this is an immersive Hands-On Arduino
course for beginners throughout this
course you'll dive deep into the world
of microcontrollers learning how to
create modify and optimize Arduino
projects from scratch by the end you'll
have the skills and confidence to bring
your innovative ideas to life using the
power and versatility of Arduino hello
my name is Matthew and I'm going to be
your instructor for this Ado course
anybody can follow along as this course
is beginner friendly so you don't need
have any prior knowledge in programming
and electronics this course comes in
full package so everything you're going
to need to learn about Arduino is fully
provided here personally when I was
learning about arino for the first time
I was jumping from course to course as
instructors to not teach me one aspect
so to prevent this almost everything
from Electronics programming and even
physics concepts are going to be fully
included in this video one final thing
when I said anyone can follow along I
mean it even the ones who don't have a
phys physical Arduino kid I highly
recommend that you get an Arduino kid as
it is more engaging but I will also be
using a physical Arduino to teach but if
you don't have one don't worry I will
show you how to follow along using a
simulator with that in mind let's start
our first
section before even working on a
physical arino the first problem that we
run into is there are thousands upon
thousands of arino kits and we do not
know where which one to use to follow
along in this course so in this course
I'm going to be using an inland starter
kit and an inland electronic parts pack
I'm going to leave uh a link in the
description of this video so you guys
can check it out for yourselves okay so
I'm going to be using an inland starter
kit and Inland electronic parts pack but
when it comes to uh these Inland starter
kits they're only mostly or mostly
they're available in what they're only
available in the US so if you're outside
of the US you can get yourself an elgo
UNO super stared kit okay you're going
to get yourself an e Lego Superstar kit
with an LED Matrix so this kit does not
have an LED a component named LED Matrix
which is very important because I'm
going to be using it in this video so
you're going to get yourself an e- Lego
Super Starter Kit and then you're going
to get it separately you're going to get
an a display matx okay so an LED Matrix
okay so one final thing is if let's say
you already have an arbino kit and you
want to know all the components that I'm
going to be using in this video I'm
going to State them on the screen right
now so you can again cross check on your
Arduino kit and on the screen right now
if you have the kit if you have the
components that are required if you
don't you can again separately Google
them and try to buy them from Amazon and
different stores so with that in mind
let's move to the next
section okay so for those of you who
don't have a physical artbo and want to
follow along using a digital artbo I'm
going to show you how to do that so what
you're going to need to do is go to your
browser and then go to Tinker
Cad and then touch the first link it's
going to be tinkercad.com let me just
zoom in so you can see it there we go
and then open
it okay so for those of you are joining
or using Tinker cat for the first time
it's going to be asking you to sign up
or log in so we going to do that I
already use Tinker cat so I'm just going
to log in directly to my account
afterwards all you need to do is go to
your designs create one and then go to
Circuit it it should be loading and once
it's done loading all you need to do is
use this tab for components so you're
going to be searching for the components
that you need right right here and then
tapping them and adding them when you do
and there is a Cod section right here so
basically you can write code to your
Arduino and then you can start the
simulation that's all you need to do to
follow along using a digital simulator
so with that in mind let's actually work
on our first Arduino project for our
first project we're going to build a
simple circuit the lights up an LED let
me turn off the light for you guys so
you guys can actually see a quite
better
okay so we're going to check the
components that make up the circuit so
we're going to check the breadboard we
have here the resistor we have here and
also the LED so we're going to check
them out separately before assembling
them into this one project so see you in
the next
section before actually talking about
bbbs
let's say I want to connect my Arduino
and build a simple circuit okay I have
my Arduino right here and before turning
it
on I'm going to connect the pin let's
say right here randomly again say I want
to connect it I'm struggling a bit right
now to hold it okay I did hold it it's a
bit of a
struggle let's say I connect uh connect
it to here it's not even comfortable
let's I connect it to
here okay then let's say I I'm going to
use a third wire I'm going to be
building a complex circuit in this case
my hands are preoccupied so I cannot
really build u a more complex circuit as
again I cannot put a third wire so this
is where breadboards come in and
actually solve the problem not only that
too but also if I turn on the Arduino
and I as I said again connected to the
pins I'm going to be Zapped I don't want
that to
happen so now let me bring my deboard
right here
so backboards come in different sizes
and different shapes so there's a
smaller one and this is the bigger one
I'm going to be using the bigger one to
explain what are breadboards and how
they work so if I go real close up here
let me just point my light towards this
so you can see it okay so if I go close
really close
actually let me zoom in I zoom in right
now and if you check this out is you see
wires that run horizontally let me
again okay there we go we can see it
right now wires that go horizontally
right here all of that you can see that
there are wires that are going
horizontally okay the same goes for this
one
too again bring it up close TOS the
light okay there we go they go
horizontally if you check them right
here if you look at these two wires
right now they go vertically okay the
one that are found on the edges they go
vertically the same with this one that
is found on this Edge goes vertically
okay so now let me zoom out right
now this is good okay so it only goes
horizontally so a up to e are connected
okay so they are connected horizontally
connected horizontally connected
horizontally connected horizontally and
connected horizontally it keeps going on
all the way to the bottom okay this same
goes from F G H I J they are connected
horizontally horizontally horizontally
horizontally and all the way to the
bottom okay so one important thing is e
and f are not connected okay there's a
gap between them as you can see right
here there's a big gap between E and F
so one thing is e and f are not
connected okay so a up to e are
connected on their own but a up to e are
not connected to f up to J
okay so they're not connected a up to e
is not connected to what f g i j
basically so they're not connected to
each other because as I said again
there's this big gap okay put that in
mind when you look at the ones that are
found on the edge as I said again if you
look at the wires again they're
connected vertically so all the way from
the bottom to the top they're connected
vertically okay from the top to the
bottom they're connected vertically so
it goes like this so go like this and
you have to go ver vertically all the
way okay all the way
vertically they're connected the same
goes for the the one that is found on
the most Edge okay so these two that are
found on the edge they're connected
vertically all the way same goes for
these ones so right now all I have to do
to conduct electricity is uh bring my
conducting wire right here put that
right here and put this right here and
if you again look up close you're
connected because there in the same row
so if I put this one right here let's
see all the way to the
bottom okay all the way to the
bottom All the Way to the Top O okay
they're connected okay they're connected
the same goes for these ones too and
these ones and these ones too okay so
the same goes for this one they're
connected again horizontally I just want
to
recap okay so let's say I want to check
this like scientifically
so I'm going to bring a device called a
multimeter you guys do not need to have
it but it's just again to check um okay
so let me just bring that right
here it's a bit of Tangled right here
okay so let me just bring this the pins
are big so it won't fit in the holes so
what I'm going to be doing is using this
conducting wires and just connecting
them with the conducting wires pins okay
so now if you look up close it's set in
the mode of cont continuity okay this
this basically means it's continuity and
continuity checks if an electric current
is going so for example let me turn this
on we turn on the
power and if I bring these two pins
together it's it starts to make this
beep sound and not only that too but
also this red bulb lights
up and so does the number change
okay okay so with that in mind we can
know that there's electrical continuity
as I said again electrical continuity
basically means that current can just
flow okay so with that in mind let's say
I bring one right here let me first go
up close and show it to you guys so let
me
bring uh connecting wi to 20 let bring
another connecting wire to 20 again
connected horizontally perfectly
horizontal let me just put that right
here and let me bring these two pins and
connect them with the
wires
can you hear that there is an omnious
beep okay that means that hey current
can flow okay with that in mind let me
just connect this vertically all the way
let me go the whole
way okay
vertically say I want to connect them
just bring this pin right
here connect that right here let me just
bring this too and
can you hear
it there we go this basically means this
hey a current can just flow through okay
because they're connected right here
they said vertically so with that in
mind let's move to the next section
where we're actually going to discuss
about uh resistors so see you in the
next
one okay so in this section we're going
to discuss about about resistors so what
are resistors resistors are electrical
components that are used to limit
current this is going to be important
because we don't want to damage other
components due to current overflow okay
so let's start from this simple diagram
okay so right here we've got the
positive terminal of the battery the
longer side is the positive terminal as
you can see here and the shorter side
right here is the negative terminal so
current always flows from the posit
positive terminal to the negative
terminal so it's going to f like this go
through this resistance right here and
then go through our LED lights up our
LED then goes back to the negative
terminal so I said again resistors are
used to limit current why is this
important so if we let's say let's
forget about the resistance existing
here for a moment so let's say we
connect it directly directly to the
current and we put our LED in this case
we're going to fry our LED because we're
we're going to be using too much current
okay so we want to limit the amount of
current that goes through because we
don't want to damage our LED that's why
we're going to be using resistors so
right now we're going to use arms slow
it's known as V equals to I * r v stands
for Vol voltage which is measured in
volts I stands for current which is
measured in ampir
and R stands for resistance which is
measured in ohm this is OHM the symbol
you see right here it's ohm oh okay so
right here to actually even give you a
better and a clear analogy let me bring
my Arduino right here and let me bring
this close close enough so that you guys
can see the 5 V that 5V means that it's
going to Output 5 volt okay so that's
why I said 5 volt right here so let me
just place it right here
then current goes and then we have our
resistor and by the way if you don't
want to know how resistors look like
they look like this moving the pack and
let me show it to you guys they look
like this sometimes you might find the
yellow one but it's okay blue or yellow
is the same thing okay so we have our
resistance right here let me place that
right
here and we have our precious LED let me
just place that right here so right here
when it comes to LEDs they have a
maximum limit of 20 milliamps so if you
go over 20 milliamps what's going to
basically happen is we're going to fry
our LED so we don't want that to happen
how do we prevent it we use this low so
right here we have five volt that is
going to be output by the Arduino so
we're going to say 5 V is equals to this
is 20 mamps is the maximum the
recommended one is 10 to 15 milliamps
okay it's 10 to 15 milliamps is
recommended but this is like the this is
like the full maximum so let's use 15
milliamps because we don't want to go
over the recommended limit and we have
our resistor right here okay so let's
divide this this becomes 5 over 15 and
we have Millie right here so it's going
to betimes 10^ of 3 and we've got our
ohm I said earlier it's measured in ohm
so in this case it's going to be
0.3 continuous * 10 the^ of
okay ohm so R is going to basically be
333 ohms this does not mean we have to
exactly give it 333 Ms but rather we
should give it a range of let's say
300 to a 400 m
range okay of resistance
for this current not to obviously
overflow and as I said again basically
firey our LED we don't want that again
to happen Okay so with that in mind how
do we you know measure how much M
resistance is so we're going to actually
check it so let me bring there are two
ways to actually do it the first one is
we bring our resistor up close okay and
what you need is a resistor color code
you can Google it if you don't have it
on your kid or you don't have an arino
but this is just a resistor color code
so right here I have it right here so
let me start from the first line the
first line is red and if you
look close enough right here first line
of red means two so let me bring my
Sharpie right here let me write two
down you got
two now let's look my let's look at my
second second band right here it's also
red you can see it it's also red second
band of red means
two so we go two right
here then I have my third one if you can
see closely it's black
so when we look at it right here when
you look at the third one it's what it's
zero okay okay then we have my fourth
line my fourth line is also black so I
go to the fourth one and it's a
multiplier so this is basically how much
I multiply two so in this case it's
black so it's times 1 M okay so when you
multiply it it's 220 amps if you look
even close enough there's a fifth band
right here that looks Brown this is just
tolerance and we're not going to get
into it because it's not really really
important surrounding this level okay so
okay with that in mind we have 220s of
resistance so you guys can check your
resistor by basically looking at the
color codes okay there's also another
way to actually do this so in this case
we're going to go back to using
multimeters so right here we have our
handy multimeter let me just untangle it
right now okay so let me bring back
those that I had here that I calculated
to be 220 right here so let's see if
it's that's actually true if I want to
be dead sure okay so let me just move
this paper right here
okay so let me turn it on and right here
what I'm going to basically do is change
it to the resistor mode as you can see
there's arm right here so we're changing
it to this resistor mode so if I go to
200 ohm right here it's going to detect
a one it's going to detect
uh 200 or less for example right now I
have 220s that I calculated if I put it
right here if I again connect it right
here let me just connect
it can you guys see it it says a0 222
let me change it to 200 amps right here
if I go 200 amps it's not going to
detect anything as you guys can see why
is that so you might be asking me well
it detects 200 amps or less okay it's
not going to detect 200 that are above
200 amps it's going to detect 200 amps
and less it's not going to detect
something that is above 200 amps in this
case this is 220 amps which is above 200
amps so it will not detect it so if I go
to two kilo okay 2
kils right
here and let me just connected right
here now we get a signal of
2242 not exactly but we get 242 let me
just bring my paper
back okay so 2
242 and as you can see here it says
kiloamps so we have to say kiloamps when
we do the math this turns out to be
242s which obviously is not 220 amps
directly but it's just very close to it
so we can use our multimeter to again
check resistance values it's not going
to give you the exact one but it's going
to give you a close one so you can use
um resistor resistor color codes right
here or again you can use your
multimeter it's up to you to decide
anyways see you in the next section
where we're going to be discussing about
LEDs
in this section we're going to discuss
the last component that we're going to
need to build our first project they're
going to be LEDs so if you open your
pack they come in this shape and they
come in all sorts of colors right here
we have red blue green yellow so before
actually working with LEDs and putting
them in our project and working with
them in the circuit what we're going to
basically do is we're going to check the
signs behind them and have a brief
understanding of how they work okay so
let me begin right here with something
quite more popular so light bulbs light
bulbs were obviously invented by Thomas
Edison and let's see how they work okay
so right here we have a battery right
here and IT supplies current so what
basically happens is current goes
through this coil and it Heats it up so
much so that it starts emitting light in
this case it is red hot when we add more
volt to this battery or a higher voltage
battery right here that we're using
we're going to supply more current
basically making this coil heat more and
it will obviously going to emit more
light so in this case it becomes white
hot so what is the problem with light
bulbs and why do we even need to replace
them well the problem is fundamentally
speaking light bulbs are not light
generating devices they are heat
generating devices because the
electrical energy that we're going to
input the current is going to be is
going to go towards heat 95% of it is
going to go towards heat while only 5%
of it goes towards light so in this case
we're going to be producing excess heat
and we're going to be wasting energy so
we don't want that to happen that's why
we have LEDs LEDs change electrical
energy directly to light energy okay so
led the long form is light emitting
diodes light emitting is
self-explanatory just as it just says
light emitting it emits light what is
the word diode let's check it out right
here so before checking out
diodes LEDs are something that we use
day-to-day we have LED TVs Led buls Led
Stripes that we put inside of our rooms
to just decorate and all that so LEDs
are something that we use every single
day okay so what are doodes diodes are
devices made from
semiconductors okay so we know
conductors and we know insulators
conductors are what conductors are
materials that can conduct electricity
for example we can take this wire it's a
conductor okay so we have insulators too
insulators are the ones that are
incapable of conducting electricity for
example let's take this pencil that is
just made of
newspaper and in the middle we have
semiconductors so they show the property
of conductors and also insulators so
let's check them
out one it comes to semiconductors they
have four valence electrons so let's
take as an example let's take silicon it
has 14 electrons when we arrange it it
becomes 2 8 4 so it has four electrons
on the outermost shell so it's obviously
four valence electrons right here so
when we align five silicon atoms we have
five silicon atoms right here okay so
when we put them in such a way they
become stable let me explain so at the
center the one with the that is marked
with red is the center molecule and it
has four valence electrons the electrons
are represented with dots as you can see
here okay so we have another silicon
atom right here another silicon atom
another silicon atom another silicon
atom okay so one important thing that we
see right here is the underlined dots
right here these ones are shared
electrons so electrons will be shared
between this silicon at and the central
atom this silicon atom and the central
atom so if we add up the electrons right
here we have one two right here three
four and we also have four that we
already have right here four valence
electrons that we have from the
beginning so when we add four + 4 it is
eight so in this case it's stable so it
doesn't want to receive or give any sort
of electrons so in this case it's not
going to conduct electricity why is that
so there will not be free electrons to
move so current cannot flow okay so it
shows the property an insulator right
here so right now we're going to use a
method called doping and this is the
method that actually changes
semiconductors and just changes the game
for semiconductors and actually makes
them behave like
conductors so let me bring this right
here so we can check it out right here
so earlier if you would actually look at
it right here earlier we had five
silicon atoms okay instead of having
five silicon atoms replace that one
silicon atom right here we're going to
replace it with an atom that has five
valence electrons so it has five dots
right here so instead of giving one like
every silicon atom right here it gives
two so we're going to have instead of
eight we're going to have nine electrons
we could even count it 1 2 3 4 5 we have
five shared electrons and we have four
valence electrons that we already have
on Silicon atoms so when we add that up
becomes nine electrons so in this case
it is negatively charged because it has
excess amount of electrons right here
and it wants to give those electrons so
it's negatively charged that's why it's
called the N Type n standing for
negative
okay so right here we're going to
conduct electricity because we have
excess amount of electricity we have
free electricity we have that one
electron that wants to what that wants
to move freely and again we want to go
back to what to eight electrons okay we
want to be stable so in this case what
do you want to do we want to give
electrons so right here it shows the
property of a
conductor we can also use another method
in this case we're going to give it
three El so we have four silicon atoms
right here the one marked with blue is
going to be the three electron element
so right here when we add all this up
we're going to have seven electrons we
have one two three electrons that are
shared and we have four electrons that
are again of silicon atom so when we add
that up it becomes seven electrons so
this will not contribute towards any
shared electrons this element right here
that has three electrons okay so in this
case we are positively charged why is
that so we have an electron deficiency
and we want to what receive electrons
because we want to achieve stability
with eight electrons okay so it's called
P type P obviously standing for positive
okay so this is what is going to
basically happen and one thing that
we're going to finally need to check is
this okay so with that in mind
right here we have n types right here
that have excess amount of electrons
electrons electrons and electrons right
here and we have the P type that have
holes so let me discuss the concept of
holes and what they are if you look
right here we have hole a hole is
basically an empty space an empty space
where an electron should have been so if
there was let's say four electrons like
earlier like we had right
here like we had right here exactly
right here
we just put the electron but right now
we have is an empty space because we
don't have an electron so basically
holes are just representation of just um
empty spaces where an electron should
have been okay so right here in the nend
type we have electrons over electrons
over electrons while in the P type in
the P type we have holes and holes and
holes and holes okay so right here we
connect the positive terminal of the
battery you can see right here with the
N type and the negative end of the
battery with the p type in this case
what basically happens is from the
electron actually going towards the
holes what's going to basically happen
is they're going to start repelling each
other so this one is negatively charged
and this one is positively charged but
they start to repel each other so in
this case current will not flow okay so
we connected the positive with the N
type and the negative with the p type
but right now when we change the
direction of the battery and we connect
the negative with the N type and the
positive with the B type what basically
happens is electron flows from the N
type to the P type so the electrons flow
from the N type to the P type so in this
case they're flowing from higher energy
level to a lower energy level okay so in
this case when they're flowing when
electrons are flowing from higher energy
level to a lower energy level they're
basically going to be releasing energy
and as you know the rule of conservation
of energy energy is neither created nor
destroyed but rather uh taken from one
form to another so when they release
that energy the electrons they release
that energy in the form of light so when
they move from higher energy level to
lower energy level they'll be losing
energy and that energy that they're
going to be releasing is going to be in
the form of FL so right now what
basically happens is we directly change
electrical energy directly to light
light energy so we don't need to have
you know excess heat and all that like
light bulbs did okay so you might be
wondering then what is the P type of uh
you know an LED look like then in real
life because it matters like what what
part of the battery that you connected
to so if you look at your LED right now
let me just bring it up
close you look at it right now let me
just
actually me get
this okay so if you look right now if
you look at your LEDs the LED legs right
here they're not even one is longer and
one is shorter okay so the longer one
the longer one if you look right here
the longer one is the positive and the
shorter one is the negative the longer
one is the P type while the shorter one
is the n type okay so if you look right
here we're going to connect the positive
end of the battery right here with the
Positive the longer side right here and
the negative part of the battery with
the negative terminal okay so we're
going to actually check um on the next
section on how to actually assemble our
components that we've learned so far so
see you in the next
section so now we're actually going to
be in the exciting section of actually
building and assembling what we've
learned so far so we have our Arduino
right here we have our resistor which is
a again recommend it to be 300 to 400
amps uh we have our LED right here we
have a connecting USB right here I'm
going to be connecting uh my Arduino to
a
laptop and I have my Arduino breadboard
right here okay and then I have my
connecting wires okay so let me Begin by
connecting the Arduino with the
breadboard if you have an Arduino uh Uno
you don't need to connect your Arduino
with the breadboard all you need to do
is a hole again so all you do is again
connect it directly to a connecting wire
okay so second thing I'm going to need
to do we're trying to build a circuit
actually so let me bring the circuit
right here okay so we've got our aduino
connected we want to connect it to the
5vt so let me go right here and let's
try to connect it to the
5vt there's the 5V connected right there
to the 5 volt okay let's say put it
around 25 okay just put it randomly on
25 then now what we want to happen is we
want to connect it to a resistor okay so
let me bring my resistor right here
bring it right here and let's let me
just try to connect it a
bit if you can see
it okay so one thing you notice is I
connected it across cross so as you
remember this row is connected this row
is connected but these two rows are not
connected to each other because they
have a gap as I told you guys earlier so
if I connected it let's say in the same
row okay horizontally in the same row
let me just make this a bit more
thin let's say connected it this way
okay if let's see the resistor is not
connected properly sometimes this
happens you have to push it in okay and
if the resistor is not connected
properly what is it going to happen is
basically this type of circuit we have
our again Arduino right here and
directly connected to what to our LED so
it's going to fry our LED with a one
that's happen again so if I connect it
abroad though if I connect it somewhere
where it's not
connected again let me just go just make
this a bit more wide it's a bit of a
hustle to even connect resistors to be
honest so you guys can see I connected
it uh abroad is current will flow like
this from the 5vt to the connecting wire
right here goes horizontally unless it's
not connected right here what's what is
going to basically happen is it's not
going to what conduct electricity so at
best at the worst case scenario if you
connect it like this is nothing happens
so the LED just not light up it's not
going to get fried but it's not going to
light up all you need to do again is
connect it properly and uh you're good
to go so we want to connect it what when
we connecting a resistors we want to
connect it across if not we can even
connect it vertically
okay because again as I said they're not
connected so we want this one one leg to
be on the connected side and one leg to
be on a side that's not connected anyway
with the again the circuit okay with
that in mind let me just bring my
LED and before actually doing that we
first need to identify let me just make
this a bit more wide uh we need to
identify which one is the positive sign
and the negative side as I've told you
guys earlier the longer side is the
positive and we want to connect it to
the positive terminal as I said again
the P the P type okay this is the P type
and we want to connect the negative side
with the negative terminal the end type
so you want the longer side to be the
direction of the positive so I have the
longer side right here and I want to
connect it right here as you guys can
see okay now
finally we connected our Arduino current
is Flowing we've connected our resistors
we've also connected our LEDs the
positive side and the negative again so
if you look right here actually this is
the positive side okay if you look at
even the diagram eally is it's positive
right here and we have the negative
right here okay so again it's going to
go all the way right here and to the
negative terminal and how do we get the
negative terminal in an adino is let me
go all the way you guys can see it
there's a sign that says G and D you can
see it right here G and d stands for
negative or ground okay so if I put G
and D right
here it basically means it's negative
there's no other meaning towards it all
right so I want to connect the negative
side of my LED so all I need to do is
push this and we're done building our
first circuit so right now let me
bring finally let me finally bring our
uh connecting USB so let me connect it
to my
laptop okay then let me connect my
Arduino there you have it we have our
first up and running LED circuit let me
turn off the lights so you guys can see
it
better so there you have it again this
is a simple circuit what is going on oh
you see resistors that I was talking
about earlier sometimes they disconnect
when we move them again and what
happened was again it turned off but our
LEDs again were not fried as I said
again because current cannot flow
through okay so with that in mind uh see
you on the next
project in our previous section we built
a simple circuit that lights up an LED
so let me bring light right here so if
you look close enough we used our
Arduino as a power source nothing more
than that something that outputs 5 volt
we only used it as something that
outputs 5 volt but also can output a
voltage a battery can so in this case we
can build the same exact project if we
have a 5vt battery okay so instead of
using an Arduino as a power source we
can use a battery right here I have a
1.5 volt battery as it's just found
commonly inside of uh the remotes and
all the all the things that we use so
I'm going to use a 1.5 volt but this
means that current is going to be less
okay so voltage is directly related to
current so I'm going to have less
current basically it's going to the
light is going to be a bit more dim so
to actually di demonstrate that let me
turn off the light maybe then you can
see it if you cannot let me just just
bring this paper right here and try to
Overlay it with the
paper maybe then you can see it can you
see
it okay there we go and let me just turn
it off and turn it on so you can see the
difference you know what it there we go
it's very dim though you can see it if
you it's actually in dark environment
but anyways this raises the question why
not use batteries instead of Arduino
because when you look at batteries they
look more reliable they're cheaper and
again they're easier far easier to just
uh move from place to place so they're
more convenient so when you when you
look at Arduino right here we have all
these things you you need to be careful
with arduinos not only that too but
they're really expensive relative
towards a battery so this raises a
question why Arduino why are we using an
Arduino so one thing you guys need to
know about Arduino is Arduino acts as a
power source but it's just definitely
more than just a power source all right
so it is a power source it acts like it
but definitely it is more than just a
power source even by looking at this
pens and looking at all these things
that we have right here we can see that
it's just definitely more than a power
source we're only talking about the 5vt
right here so when you look at all these
things that we have right here it is
definitely more than a power source so
what is the purpose of an Arduino
Arduino is used to code our electrical
components for example example let's say
I wanted to code this so that it turns
on and off every second so it's going to
turn on for a second then turn off for
another second turn on turn off doing it
in the loop okay so it's going to turn
on for one second turn off for one
second turn on for one second turn off
for one second and keeps going on in the
loop so how do I do this using a battery
I have to physically come in right here
turn it off turn it on count a second
turn it off count a second turn it on
count a second turn it off and obviously
this is not coding but with our uino we
can set this up we can set up we can set
this up so that we can actually code it
to actually make it blink so we're going
to turn it on for one second turn it off
for one second we can do this using an
Arduino so Arduino what does it do
something important that it does is lets
us code our physical components I'm sure
you use websites and applications and
they're coded digitally so what if you
wanted to code our physical components
for example let's say we're working on a
robot or some other project this is
where ardino comes in this is where uino
comes in and lets us code our physical
components so definitely
Arduino acts as a power source but it
acts as an intelligent power source all
right an intelligent power source that
we can code okay so it's definitely more
than just a power source all right with
that in mind let's check how to actually
uh code our Arduino so how to actually
put transfer code to Arduino so see you
in the next section where you're on my
screen and we actually check on how to
code using an
Arduino so far we've learned that arino
is more than just a power source and it
can do a lot more especially letting us
code our electrical components so to
start coding our arino microcontroller
we're going to need a platform to write
code on so in this case we're going to
need a code editor so it's going to be
different depending that you're going to
be using a physical arino or a digital
Arduino on a simulator for those of you
who are using a digital Arduino on a
simulator all you need to do is go to
this code right here this code section
right here and choose your preference so
if you're using blocks you can use
blocks right here you can change it to
block or if you prefer text you can use
text right here but I highly suggest
that you guys use text as I'm going to
be using text for this course
okay so for those of you who have a
physical Aro all you need to do again is
go right here follow this link and
download the uino depending on the
operating software that you have right
here so if you have a Windows you're
going to download from here if you have
a Linux from here and a Mac you're going
to download from here so for those of
you who don't have uh Linux Mac or
Windows or maybe for example you're
using a Chromebook all you can do is go
to your ardino web editor and touch the
code online and sign up and you can use
this Arduino web editor so without
downloading anything you guys can just
start coding to your Arduino that's all
you need to do start writing code to
arino so once you're done downloading
the arino code editor it looks something
like this there we go it looks something
like this it has void setup and void
loop we're going to check what these
means and not only that too but we're
also going to create This Blink project
that I mentioned earlier of the LED
earlier on the next
section
okay so now what you want to do to write
code to our adino let me go to our code
editor and one thing you need to set up
is go to our Arduino and choose our
board and our communication Port okay
how do we do it we go and select the
board that we're using for example let's
say I'm using an Arduino Uno I go to
Arduino Uno and select it obviously I'm
using an Arduino Nano so I'm going to go
back to Arduino Nano and select it so
you're going to choose the REO board
that you have right here once you're
done with that you going to check the
communication Port that you want to use
right here I only have one communication
Port so I only have one comp Port so I
don't have to stress and I can just
continue and just say okay but let's say
we have two maybe two communication
ports let's say I have another
communication Port right here underneath
and you do not know which one to use to
know which one to use all you need to do
is basically plug off your Arduino so
I'm going to plug it off and once I plug
it off it's going to turn off the
communication Port is going to be off so
you're going to know which communication
Port is tied to your Arduino okay there
we go and go back to touch okay then I'm
going to need to write code so this is a
starter code this is a code that always
exists for every sketch okay so this is
going to be a code from the complex ones
so the easiest project they're going to
contain void setup and a void Loop okay
so what is a void setup this is where we
actually put our setup code okay and
it's going to run once importantly it's
going to run once okay so we're going to
put our setup code right here and we're
going to only run it once okay when it
comes to loop we're going to put most of
our code and our main code right here
and we're going to run it repeatedly so
we're going to run it over and over and
over and over and over again okay so let
me go right here and to basically notify
that our our Arduino what pin we're
going to be using we're going to use
this builtin function called pin mode
okay we're going to use something called
pin mode all right there we go and we're
going to tell it what pin we want to use
right here I have again from two to 13 I
have digital pin 2 to 13 so I'm just
going to choose random number let me
just choose seven for now so we're going
to use pin 7 okay then once we're done
letting uh our our Doo know which pin
we're going to be using we're going to
notify it of how we're going to use it
okay so we're going to tell it if we're
going to use it as an input or we're
going to use it as an output okay so if
you want to use it as an input we want
to what we want to receive data from the
pin okay so when we want to use it as an
output what do we want to do we
basically want to send data in this case
we're going to send what electricity
okay we're going to send voltage okay so
we want to use it as an output in this
case once we're done with that for every
line when we finish a code for every
line we're going to finish it with a
semicolon okay so one thing to keep in
mind is for all of you is capitalization
does matter so you cannot write down pin
mode let's say with a small M if I did
that and let's say I want to verify the
code it's going to show me an error
message so one thing you want to keep in
mind is every time capitalization
matters and code Okay so even matters
for this output let's say I say output
right here with no capitalization with
no proper capitalization it's going to
give me an error okay so capitalization
is very important in coding and let me
just run this right now I don't see any
error okay there we go so I wrote this
down properly so what does this code do
it tells our aduino that we're going to
use pin 7even how do you want to use it
we want to use it as an output so once
we're done notifying our Arduino and
we're done setting up our pin we're
going to go to our Loop okay so how do
we uh tell ourin know if you want to
give 5 volt and Z volt we're going to
use something called digital right so
right here too again specifically
capitalization is very important so what
pen do we want to write we want to write
down pin seven that we already set up
right here there we go and once we're
done with that you want to tell it if
it's going to be high or low high
basically means
I basically I means 5 volt okay High
means 5 volt 5 volt right now you want
to keep this in mind so high just
basically means what 5 volt okay then
once we're done with that what do we
want to do when we want to make it blank
we want to what we want to write down
the same cot right here again
capitalization matters and put pin seven
and you've guessed by now we're going to
use low we're going to use low so what's
what is it going to do we're done
setting up our code once so we're GNA
let notify our do we know what pin we're
using and how we're going to be using it
then once we're done with that it's
going to run this code as a loop it's
going to run it repeatedly right here
okay so it's going to go pin seven it's
going to turn it high it's going to turn
it to what to 5 volt right here turn to
5 volt and then when we turn it to low
we basically turn it to 0 Vol or off 5
Vol or on okay that's what we're going
to do so let me just do is verify the
code right here in case we have an error
it's done compiling right here properly
and then what we do is upload it
okay and we're going to upload it to our
Arduino but one thing I forgot to do is
to set up our arino so we need to set up
our adino so one thing I need to do
right here before even setting it up and
wiring it as I told you guys before in
the precaution safety section what I
told you guys was to turn off our adreno
first we build our circuit and then we
turn it on okay okay so let me bring my
red pin right here and attach it to pin
seven wait that's pin two pin seven is
right here okay there we go put it right
here put our handy resistor right here
we want to put it at an intersection
there we go okay
then we need our LED I'm going to need
to know the big side is obviously the
positive there we go and put that right
here the positive with the positive side
and then we're going to go back to our
gnd D or negative terminal let me go to
g& d right here there we go so I want to
check again up close if I'm actually
correct or I'm making mistakes right
here so I me I'm just going to bring it
closer to myself and check it for myself
okay that's seems fine nice okay let me
check the long side again okay there we
go I'm correct all right I'm done
checking now I can turn on my
arino let me turn it
on
okay I think it's the resistor right
here okay it was the resistor so let me
just touch it again okay there we go
it's working now but can with something
it's not turning on and it's turning off
it's just not blinking we cannot see any
blinking right here here can you I
cannot so what is happening so let's
analyze our code so what we did was set
up our code everything seems fine right
here everything seems appropriate and
then what happens is basically what
happens is we digit the right and we set
it to high then we set it to low then we
set it to high and low and one thing you
notice is it's going to go at very fast
speed it's going to be really really
fast computers are really really fast so
we cannot notice this with our naked ey
so right here look at it it's going to
go high then it's going to go low really
fast then it's going to go high again
it's going to again go on a loop as I
said again so it's going to go high low
high low very very fast that we cannot
notice it so what do we need we need a
delay so we can notice it so we're going
to need a delay so we're going to do
that we're going to do is use this delay
function okay so when I say 1,000 that's
going to be 1 second so it's going to
capture it in milliseconds okay so
you're going to write down how much
seconds that you're going to delay it
when milliseconds so we want to delay it
right here and put our semicolon after
every line there we go and we want to
put the delay right here again delay of
1,000 then there we go with our
semicolon and let's run it again so let
me just verify it right
now okay then I'm going to upload it so
it's going to turn off for one second
and turn on for one second turn off for
one on off on and it keeps going on so
let me go on off on off so we basically
build this okay so one thing to keep in
mind again is that we use millisecond so
when I say 1,00 milliseconds it
basically means a second so it's going
to receive a millisecond okay there we
go so we're done we're actually building
this so actually in the next one we're
going to check so in the next section
we're actually going to check a few
things about
variables
okay so I have homework for you guys so
before moving on to the next sections
you're actually going to do these
homeworks okay so what we did right now
is obviously create This Blink again so
we used one pin and create This Blink so
what I want you guys to do is create a
traffic light so we have our green color
right now we've got our orange one and
we've got our red one okay so you used
one pin to set up everything for One LED
so how many pins are you going to be
using using for three LEDs you're going
to be using three pins okay so you're
going to be using three digital
pins so you're going to put Green in
front so instead of actually uh the red
one it's going to Green is going to be
right here then we're going to have
yellow and then we're going to have red
okay so we're basically creating a
traffic light so I want this to I want
this to do is basically okay what I want
this to do is I want this to delay for 5
Second and then turn off so it's going
to be on for 5 seconds okay then when
this one is off obviously it's going to
turn yellow for this case yellow is a
shorter one so I'm going to choose 1
second and red I want to make it the
same as the green light because that
makes sense so we're going to make this
5sec to okay so I want you to create a
traffic light a working traffic light
okay so you're going to be using three
pins creating a resistor right here
using the resistor right here then
obviously lighting up your LED then
going back to GM and D okay so they're
going to be using the same gnd D so if I
bring let's say the second wire one
thing you guys don't know is let me just
bring another wire okay there we go
another wire so let's say I have my
ground right here of the second LED of
the yellow one let's say for example and
what you're going to do is connect to
the same gnd D okay so you're going to
connect the same gnd D It's okay but
you're going to be using what different
pins though you're not going to be using
the same pin you're going to be using
three totally different pins so you
might be using D5 D7 d8 it's up to you
so yeah you're going to be building this
project for yourself so before moving on
the to the next section so pause this
video and work on it if you are not sure
of how the circuit is supposed to behave
again you guys can use a digital
simulator okay afterwards I'm actually
going to build it with you guys in case
you do not know you can refer back to
the next section where I'm actually
going to build
it okay so so now we're actually going
to work on our homework so I'm not going
to bore you guys out trying to build
this as I only need to use three
different pins and do exactly the same
thing so the necessary information that
you guys need is that green is connected
to seven so the green pin right here the
green LED sorry the green LED is
connected to what the pin the digital
pin 7even okay so it's connected to what
the digital pin 7 the same goes for
yellow it's connected to digital pin 4
while the red LED is connected to thisal
pin 9 okay that's the necessary
information that you guys need so now
let's code this so first we're going to
need to do a pin setup so we're going to
need to go to pin mode and obviously set
up our pins so we want to let our aduino
know what pins we're using so let me
just copy this right
here paste this and we're using pin 4 so
let me write down pin four right here
four we're using it as an output yes we
are let me again paste
this and we only have pin n so we're
going to use pin nine here too nice and
once we're done with that once we're
done setting it up let me just remove
this code right now CU we're not going
to be using this we're going to digital
write our pin what our pin seven for
green so we want green to light up first
so I'm going to go for pin seven then I
want to set it to high and finish it off
with a semi col it then I'm going to
copy this
again copy this then I want what I want
pin four to be high but before that
actually before actually going to four
what do I want to do I want to delay it
okay I want to delay it for how many how
many seconds 5 seconds so it's going to
be 5,000 here so I'm going to be using
milliseconds here 5,000 then I want to
do what I want to turn it off okay so I
want it to be low so let me go here and
I've got pin seven here then I want to
set it to what to low okay that's what I
want to do okay when it comes to um when
it comes towards the the yellow LED what
do I want to do I want to do is the same
thing almost but I want to change the
delay to what to one second don't I so
let me save right here and set this
delay to how many one second or 1,000
milliseconds and I want to change the
pin number again I want to change it to
four so go four and I'm going to go four
again okay this is for what let me just
write this description down or comment
yellow this one is for green so let me
write down Green right
here then I want the red one it's going
to be the same exact thing but I want to
change the PIN with the green just copy
that
again do that and I want to change the
pin number to what to nine okay all
right so I think I'm done with this one
so let's check if it's actually going to
work so let me verify this okay seems
like it's working let me connect my
ardino before uploading it so let me go
here connect my
adino and let's upload the sketch
it says done uploading so let's check it
out there we go there we go it's working
nice that's great and all but if you
look closely let me go very close on my
camera right now like really really
close forget about this paper now okay
so I want you to
very look at this let me bring bring it
up close here so if you look at it right
now can you see how much I stress the G
and D like it really looks really bad
this is by the way the gnd D all these
three wires are connected to gnd D okay
so what can I do to fix this so let me
just bring an extra wire right here okay
an extra wire let me zoom out right now
for now there we go so I have this extra
wire what I'm going to do is let me just
remove this three g& D pins for now
before actually building the circuit
what do I want to do I want to turn it
off I want to turn my adino off first
build and then we upload and then we run
it okay so got my gnd D pin right here
connect it connect the gnd D pin if you
cannot see it I'm connected to the gnd D
pin all right now what do I want to do
okay so I'm going to use this vertical
stripe can you see it points the
negative there's negative and positive
right here I'm just going to use the
negative one as this just again
convention all right so I'm connected to
this one so as I said again when it
comes to breadboards the edge ones are
connected all the way vertically so I
can basically do is what I can just
connect it to this one the vertical line
again the same for this one use this
vertical line for the g&d pins and this
one for the GMD pin I'm going to use a
vertical one there we go now it looks
more nice okay so let me just again turn
on my Arduino and run this everything
should be working normal let's check it
out
first okay so 5
Seconds there we go all right it's
working really really great okay so
let's say I have a problem I have to
wait for like 5 seconds and I just say
it's just too long for me and I just
want to reduce this to 3 seconds okay so
what what should I do I want to change
the green and red to 3 seconds I I I
like the yellow one it's one second it
feels nice but the red and yellow just
feel too long for me okay so what do I
do I go right here and change 5,000 to
3,000 not only that too I have to go
back to Red then go change it to 3,000
again okay then have to upload it so
it's going to work for three seconds
now but okay let me just let's just
check it out working okay there we go
it's working okay it's a bit faster now
just count again one 2 three and change
over okay there we go it's working
pretty fine all right but I have to go
change it at two separate places so I
have to go right here and change this to
3,000 again 3 seconds so I have to go
right here again and change this to
3,000 just think of me having lots and
lots and lots of LEDs right here let's
say I have five or six I'm going to have
to go change it what six places I don't
want that to happen so how do I do avoid
this type of mistake so we're going to
learn something called
variables all right so first before
learning about variables let's talk
about this box here so I have a box
right here okay so this box No Label on
it you do not know what is inside until
you open it when you open it you know
what's inside okay so it has no label
again it's just empty but to save us
this effort and let's say I just checked
it and labeled it right here and named
it microphone box okay so I just gave it
a label so it's going to tell me what is
inside before even opening the box so
right now by just reading this I can say
is okay this has some mic equipment
inside of here right okay this has mic
equ before even what opening it all
right so this is the nice thing about
variables so what do they do is
basically refer to things all right so
they just basically refer to our data so
we can can refer to our data without
actually changing anything about our
data our label does not change anything
about our box all right doesn't change
anything all it does is what all it does
is reference to our box what is inside
the box that just what it tells us so
how do we set of variables here and
we're actually going to see even a
second purpose of variables the first
one is to reference things we're going
to we're going to check the second the
second uh use of variables so let me go
right here let's see how you set up
variables here so all you need to do is
go right here and use the keyword let if
I correct I don't think use the keyword
let here so all you need to do is um
write down a name so let's say I want
this to be delay time so I just write
down delay time okay so I'm going to set
this to
3,000 and close this let me just verify
if this is even correct and it says no
it's not does not name a type Okay so so
right here all we need to do is go right
here and say let let delay time we do
that right
here let does not name a type so you
might be wondering for those of you who
are using JavaScript and all that we
have to tell it what type of data we're
putting inside right here we're putting
what we're putting an integer all right
so we have to let it know the type of
data that we're storing right we're
going to say is int inte teer a it's an
integer number so let me if I let me
just verify this again should be working
pretty fine now can you guys see it so
we have to tell it the type so when
you're using ardino you're going to have
to tell it the type of variable that
we're using so in this case it's an
integer I'm defining here and obviously
I'm going to give it a name so I'm going
to call this delay time again this has
nothing special on it so I can just even
call it some something else that is
unrelated to it I can just say you know
what it's green or um I can just say
phone or I can just say anything you get
me but I'm going to obviously put delay
time because that's what is the use of
variables to give us rightful
information of what this is so even
before somebody reading my code they can
understand oh they can understand before
reading this code is that oh this is
delay time this is supposed to be the
time that it's going to delay inside
obviously this again this LEDs okay so
I'm going to go say delay time and set
it to 3,000 all right so let me just set
it to 3,000 so I'm going to remove it
this delay time right here so I'm going
to be using it how do I use it I just
use it as a normal thing I'm just going
to see delay time are you defin it I can
use it multiple times all right all
right for also for red I'm going to go
right here and use Del time underscore
time all right perfect that's all I need
to do if I verify this right now I don't
get any error all right everything's
sounding great if I upload this I said
again a variable does not change a thing
about what it's referencing so I earlier
said 3,000 here and basically what it's
just doing is delay time is equal to
3,000 here so it's basically putting
3,000 the computer is manually putting
3,000 here all right instead of delay
time that's just what basically it does
so second usage of variables here is
that you know what this is a bit too
fast for me this this thing is just
really fast it's just going 3 seconds
and then 1 second uh and then 3 seconds
this is very fast for me I just want to
make it 4 seconds all right so I can
just do right here is just change it
from one spot I don't have to go
multiple spots to change it I have to
find it ones I can do is just change it
from one spot and say you know what
that's what I want let me just verify
this let me upload this I want it to be
4 seconds I wanted it to be in the
middle I don't want it to be too slow I
don't want it to be too fast all right
so look at this I upload this right now
it goes 4 seconds so let me count this
one two 3 four all right there we go so
it goes for 4 seconds all right all
right that's all you need to do when it
comes to variables that's why we use
them a lot all right so instead of using
pin 7 right here just saying
749 okay I can change it again to for
somebody who does not know um what I'm
writing down before somebody even knows
what I'm writing down right here by just
defining these variables I just save
them the time from reading the code it
can also work for yourself when you come
back to this code all right so I can
just say is you know what I can call
this
digital pin digital pin equal to let's
see again we have seven right here so
digital pin let me just see seven right
here all right let me just see digital
pin sore 7 there we go then I again I
can write this down for for
four write this down for
nine right nine here right four here
there we go and obviously replace this
digital pins right here so I'm just
repeating pin I'm repeating seven right
here on pin mode and also on digital
right I'm repeating it over and over
again can you guys see the difference
right now so let's say I'm changing a
pin I have to change it at three
separate places I don't want that to
happen so all I have to do right now is
do the exactly same thing write down
digital pin 7 it's going to out to
complete it for me and go say digital
pin 4 and then digital pin what digital
pin n okay so I'm just going to replace
this again so one thing you guys need to
know is by using control D or command D
you can just select the same number over
again so you can select the same thing
over again see I even selected seven
right now I even selected the seven from
the digital pin seven right here so you
need to be careful so okay I'm going to
do is Select this two seven right here
and I can edit them at the same time
okay edit this at the same time there we
go when it comes to four I only have two
fours right now left do is this and
again set this digital pin four and when
it comes to nine I can can use control D
select two then digital pin n there we
go it's not supposed to change anything
about our code but it should make it
what a whole lot nicer and clean all
right so let me verify this again if
it's working properly okay everything
seems fine let me upload
it let's check if everything is working
properly as it should all right nice
okay hey that's good it's working really
really nice so you guys learned about
variables so again as I said one thing
you should know about variables is as I
said again one thing you should know
about variables is what they do not
change anything all they do is what
reference again like I talked about the
Box the label on the box just basically
reference what is inside of the box but
nothing more than that all right so
that's all it comes to variables so all
they do is just refer data they just
make it easier and cleaner to to store
data all right all right with that in
mind let's move to the next
section all right so let's recap what
we've done so far so at first we began
with the 5vt right here we began with
the 5vt and we built a simple LED
circuit afterwards we use these digital
pins right here and what we did is again
build a traffic light okay so what are
these pins marked with an A and A number
next to them we're going to check them
out in the next few sections by the way
these are called analog pins so in the
next few sections we're actually going
to see the difference between analog
pins and uh digital pins not only that
too but we're going to see their purpose
and why they are important in the
Arduino world so um see you
then
all right so let me show you guys what I
did right here so what I basically did
all right is that I set up the basic 5V
LED circuit so we have a 5vt right here
connected to the red uh connecting wire
and then we have a resistor and we have
our LED and then we go back to the gnd
with the black wire that's all I did
that's what we did when we started this
course Okay so so let me go over to my
screen right now and let's start
coding so right here let me first give
this uh variable name so I'm just say a
red pin all right then let me give it a
number let's say we using pin 4 right
here analog pin 4 let's just say that
again I just took it by random and right
here what we do is again as we did for
digital pin what we did was pin mode
right then we put our what our
pin which pin it is and then how do you
want to use it do you want to use it as
an output or as an input always put a
semicolon at the end of each
line all right that's what I did right
here but there is a problem right here
so right here when we using digital pins
right here we did was only put the
number right so let's say I'm using
digital pin 4 right here let's just say
that I'm using digital pin 4 but I'm
doing that what
happens when I'm using digital pin 4
what I did was just put a number right
here and set it up like I did for an
analog pin so right here how do we
know the
difference between
digital and analog pin so how does
Arduino know that we using digital pin 4
or analog pin 4 right here and weo does
not not know okay so every time to
differentiate an an analog pin from a um
digital pin what we do is put a capital
A before it all right before the number
that we're going to use we always put a
capital A so it's going to differentiate
and it's we're going to know actually
which pin we're going to be using so
right here Arduino will not be what will
not be confused if you want to use the
digital pin or the analog pin okay so
we're going to do is what put a capital
A beforehand all right so once I'm done
setting up the pin mode right here what
I need to do is go here all right so
what did we do right here we said
digital right and we set it to what what
do we do we put the red pin right here
and then we set it to high when we were
using a digital pin so right here it
makes sense to write what analog pin
there's something called analog right
okay we do that and we see red
pin okay the pin that we're going to be
using and then we're going to put a
value so right here I'm just going to
put
255 and I'm going to come back to this
and actually explain why did we put 255
so let me just remove this right here
because obviously when not using a
digital pin right here let me just
remove this and all right so let's
verify it and let's upload it
okay let me upload it right
here and it's done compiling it's
uploading and it's done uploading all
right so let let me remove my Arduino
from the 5vt and let me move it towards
the digital pin not digital pin sorry I
said um analog pin 4 let me just do
that there we go I moved it to analog
pin 4 right here all right so right now
it's lighting up as how a 5vt lights it
up and addal a digital pin lights up the
LED so again you might be confused on
why did we use 255 right here what is
the use of it not only that too but
what's it's a very odd number you know
why not 300 why not why not 20 200 why
255 specifically okay so let's see the
science behind it to understand why it
is 255
and so the question Still Remains why
are we using in
so right here let me start from
Something That We're familiar with we
use digital WR and then we set our pin
what pin we're going to be using and
then we set it to either high or either
low obviously High means 5 volt which
basically is on low means Z volt which
basically is off it seems to be working
perfectly fine so why do we need
integers to represent this to represent
high high is represented by what high is
represented by
255 low is represented by
zero why do we need integers to
represent that because this gets the job
done perfectly right so the problem here
is when we're using high and low the
problem that arises is we only have two
options we cannot choose anything more
than high or low let's say I want to set
it to medium let's say I want to set it
to well I want it to Output 2.5 volts
literally the medium the half what
happens I basically cannot output Med
medium because I either I can set it to
high or either I can set it to what to
low so this is where integers come in
they come really really handy and they
allow us to have intermediate values so
if I wanted to set it to medium what do
I need to do all I need to do is divide
255 by what by two basically giving me
half so let me let me just bring a paper
right
here okay there we go so let's say I
want to do 255 I want to I want the half
of it 255 is what if you remember 5 volt
all right I want to Output half of 5
volt it's going to be 2.5 volt right
here all I need to do is what I need to
do try to find X right here how much I
should be writing down and then do the
math and once I do it X is going to come
approximately to
127.5 which you can round up or round
down which I'm going to round up to
almost 28 so what does integer allow us
to do integers allow us to have
intermediate values what else let's say
I want to do is what you know what I I
don't want it to be half I want it to
what I want to do 20% of what the
original high that we had I want 20% of
it I want 20% of
5vt I want to Output 20% of 5vt so let's
do the math right here what's uh 5vt 5vt
is currently
100% what is 20% all I need to do is
find the voltage do the the math right
here keep on doing the math right here
20 okay it's going to be 0 when you do
the math 0.2 * 5 is going to equal to X
when you do the math right here 0.2 * 5
all right so basically what is this five
* 2 over 10 when you do the math right
here this is going to be 2 over two so
we're going to have one there we go one
is equal to what x basically we're going
to outut one volt there we go so
basically what just allow us to do is
what we can find any value so we can
have any intermediate value between what
between high and low so we can have any
intermediate value between high and low
because obviously if I had let's say
high right here and low let's say I
write down medium for uh 2.5 volt and
then I write down another name for it
obviously you cannot name every instance
you cannot name every obviously value of
voltage so we're going to be using
integers doing the math and after doing
the math we we can do what we can find
our desired value and then output the
voltage so basically we can what we can
control the amount of voltage that's
coming in to our Arduino to coming out
of our Arduino so basically what happens
basically we can create dimmer and what
brighter light so we can create
intermediate values of light but one
thing I want you guys to keep in mind is
okay one assumption that you really
really need to know is actually how it
works is it doesn't change physically so
as I said again when we're turning it on
5 volt it's basically what it's on and Z
volt it's basically off so what happens
is let's say we're trying to write down
2.5 volt right here we're trying to what
we're trying to Output 2.5 volt what
Arduino does is all right what Arduino
does is it turns on for half the time
for half the period of time and then
right here it's Zer volt let me just
specify it the one on ground is z volt
right here so what happens is what what
happens is it turns on for half the time
time turns off for half the time turns
on for half the time turns off for half
the time it does it really really really
fast that you cannot notice it so for us
it's going to appear as what it's going
to appear as dimmer but what basically H
is happening is what it's basically
doing high and low series of highs and
lows for what doing a series of highs
and lows for again a given amount of
period of time there we go so that's how
we output how much 2.5 volt we turn on
for half the time we turn off for half
of the time turn on half the time turn
off half the time so basically we're
going to have what 2.5 volts okay so
physically the same thing is always high
and low series of 5 volts and Zer volts
but using integers allow us to do what
they allow us to what they allow us to
use intermediate
values all right so before running the
code let's do a simple recap so what we
did is what we set red pin to analog pin
and we set it as an output right here
our red pin and we use the analog right
Command right here analog right Command
right here and we set it to a maximum
value of 255 which corresponds to 5 volt
right so let me just upload it right
here and this should light up it does
okay nice so let me go right here and
let's just say I set it to a value of 40
just do notice the difference so let's
see if it goes
dmer
and when I do that you see what happens
right here you see what happens it does
not fully turn on so even uh you guys
cannot see that it's fully turned on
it's not even turned on at all all right
I can see that it's not turned on too so
there is an error on going here so one
error that um I came here to fix is that
what I did uh round was right here I
used analog pin 4 so one thing right
here let me go closer is that you're not
supposed to use this analog pins this a
pins for this purpose okay what you're
supposed to use is this digital pins
right here these digital pins that are
marked with a symbol right here so let
me go closer again for you to see it can
you see thisal pin N9 right there it has
a DOT on it a small Dot you see that
let's compare digital pin 9 to digital
uh pin 8 if you do that digital pin 9
has a a bit of a DOT on the very edge if
you look at it not only digal pin 9 has
it digal pin 10 digal pin 11 digal Pin
six digital pin five and digal pin three
have the uh DOT sign on them all right
so let me go right here and I have to
connect is this this um these digital
pins that are marked marked with a DOT
or a squiggly sign so for me it's a dot
but if you go over to my screen right
now just go over to my screen if you go
to my screen right now what happens is
there's this quickly sign I'm just
turning on an ardino an image of an
Arduino Uno and if you look closely
there's this quickly sign in front of
this digital pins so what happens again
is when you're using U um Arduino Nano
the board that I'm currently using is an
Arduino Nano we use we have is what dots
that Mark this unique digital pins I'm
going to get to using them all right but
when you use an Arduino Uno we have a
Squigly sign so it will vary the sign
will vary depending on the board you
have right so look for U if you're using
any other board is look for a a unique
mark on your digital pins okay so if you
look closely here it says it supports
something called pwm okay okay so pwm
stands for pulsewidth modulation so what
basically this means is let me just
explain it in a very very simple term
all right so before running the code let
me just let me just make sure that you
understand the signs behind it okay so
it's quite simple so what does this mean
is let's say I want to turn on my uh I
want to turn my uh my Arduino to 2.5
volts I wanted to Output 2.5 volts all
right if I wanted to Output 2.5 volts
let me just show you how you can do it
so what happens is when let's say an
Arduino outputs 2.5 volts what happens
is it goes to 5 volt half of the time
and it goes to Zer volt half of the time
it goes to to 5 volt half of the time
and it goes to um Z volt half of the
time let's say I want to turn it on to
let's say I want to turn it on let me
bring another paper let's say I want to
turn it on to uh 1 volt all right so
let's say I want to turn it on to 1 volt
let me just turn on there we go let's
say I want to turn it on to one volt
okay how do I do that all I need to do
is just again draw the graph of volt
versus time this is time right here the
time volt versus time graph so what
happens is it turns on it's 5 volts
right here and Z volts right here so
what happens is it what it turns on for
a very short period of time it turns off
for a long period of time you see that
turns on for a long short period of time
again for 5 volt for a very short period
of time turns on for a long turns off
for what for a long period of time okay
that's just a rough sketch of how one
volt will look like when it comes to 2
2.5 volt what happens is again is what
half the time it turns on half the time
turns off half the time turns on half
the time it turns off so we achieve this
voltage how do we do it we use the two
ends 5 volt and Z volt and we what we
fluctuate between them so we change
between them okay that's the science
behind it and one thing I want you guys
to know is this it it happens at very
fast speed that we can't notice it
turning on and off so we don't see it
turning off and like for like 5 volt for
half of the time and turning off for
half of the time it happens at very very
fast speat I'm talking MCS that our eyes
cannot notice the difference okay so for
us it's going to appear as a dimmer
light even though it's turning on and
off on and off at very very fast speed
so let's go to U our code and let's
write it down to actually see what
happens so let me again plug my Arenal
right
here okay so right here let me actually
actually instead of plugging it what I
should do is let me bring it closer to
you guys
so right here one thing you can notice
is we can use those quiggly signed can
you look at it those pins again with a
squiggly sign on them so in this case
digital pin 10 has a squiggly sign
digital pin n has a squiggly sign let's
just use digital pin n right here okay
so use one of those uh pins that have a
squiggly sign or a dot in front of them
so digal pin N9 have to go right
here all right so I connected it to
digal pin 9 and again a simple LED
circuit so let me connect my adrino
board right
here okay let's go back to our code let
me go back to my screen right here all
right so I'm going to say is what pin n
okay then I set pin R put as output and
Pinn 40 okay so I'm just upload it right
here
I uploaded it it's not even fully
turning on maybe might be the resistor
right here it's not the resistor am I
correct with the pin I might I think I'm
doubting that okay I got it to pin eight
now I'm correct with the pin it's pin n
is right here oh there we go we have a
dimmer light I don't know you might
notice it or not so what I'm going to do
is uh to notice it is let's go to my
screen and let's write some bit of code
so that you guys can actually notice the
difference between um a value of 40 and
a value of 255 so let me just say analog
right red pin and set it to
255 okay then we're going to set a delay
again delay function Let's us put uh
delay for the amount of millisecond so
right here I'm going to set it for 1,000
milliseconds which basically means a
second all right okay so we can see the
difference delay again
1,000 so let me just run this again so
let me verif verify this everything's
running right and smooth all right and
let me upload it okay all
right can you see it it's going brighter
and then dimmer brighter and dimmer
brighter and dimmer so what I'm going to
do is turn off the light right here so
you can see it way better okay let just
turn off both the lights on the
spot you can see it better now it's
going brighter and dimmer obviously the
brighter is 255 while the dimmer is
obviously the number 40 okay so let me
just go back to our light right
here turn off turn on both lights so so
we've seen how P pulsewidth modulation
right here works okay so I'm using what
pwm all right all right so I'm using
this pit so one confusion that happens
is uh what I see most often is all right
what are again this p pin are the analog
pins the ones that are marked with with
a d pin and then a number next to them
and that have again a DOT or Squigly
sign are they analog pin or are they U
digital pin because if you again look at
the code right here we're using analog
right so if you look at the code right
here let me just highlight it again if
you use the code right here we're using
what're using the command analog right
oh my God this is getting
annoying Jesus
just let me just go right
here there we go analog right it's going
to analog right but also one thing you
notice right here is what it's marked
with a d which makes it a digital pin so
I be wondering is this a digital pin or
an analog pin so one thing you need to
understand here is the ones that are
marked with a with a DOT or a squiggly
sign these special digital pins i' would
call them special digital pins
what um they are is they're both okay so
they're digital pins they're also analog
pins right here when we use the analog
right command we use them as what as an
analog pin okay so we use them as analog
pins and also one thing you need to keep
in mind is we can also use them as
digital pins so let me just turn off all
this code right here if I just say dig
again not changing the not changing the
pin right here I'm going to say it's
digital pin all there's to right right
here and again when we use this command
we only can say high or low We cannot
put a number here just going to say high
okay so let me just upload it right now
as it is just upload it on the spot and
again let me connect my Arduino right
here I forgot to connect my
Arduino I can't upload it because I did
not connect my arino let me just upload
it right here it's stun compiling
verified the code and done uploading can
you see that it's lighting up so one
thing you need to learn about these St
pins that are marked with a squiggly
side or a DOT is we can use them as an
analog pin and we can also use them as
what as digital pins I want you guys to
keep that in mind all right so uh see
you in the next section where we're
actually going to work we're going to
work with these a pins with these pins
that are exclusively analog pins you see
these pins they're exclusively an analog
all right so they're only analog pins so
we're going to actually check them out
and and for the first time in our lives
we're actually going to use pin mode and
set it up as an input so so far we've
used PIN mode and set it as an input as
you remember here all right so we
actually as an output so we're going to
set it up right here and use it as an
input in the next section so um see you
then right so let's continue and learn
about analog pins all right so right
here we've got these pins right here
again marked let me just unplug my right
here these pins that are marked with an
A and that respective number next to
them okay are the analog pin so let me
again Focus
here all right there we go it's focusing
let me just go a that
closer maybe even Zoom it better let's
be better there we go see those eight
pins that are marked with a number and
an a an A and A number next to them
those are called what analog pins okay
I'm just zoom out for now all right so
we're going to be working them so let me
go over to my schem right here and let
me just scr over to my screen and what
I'm going to do here open this so let's
set up our pin so right here I'm just
going to say to pin mode again then I'm
going to choose a random PIN I'm going
to choose a pin
A5 okay it's going to put this as what
as an input okay when we're using these
a penss we're going to use them as an
input so far we've worked with digital
pins and we've worked with pins that are
analog and also uh digital those ones
that are marked with a squiggly sign I
have a DOT on them all right so far
we've used them as a what as an output
but right now we're going to use them as
what for the first time we're going to
use them as an input we're going to use
some pins those pins as an input okay so
one thing I did wrong right here is I do
not use a variable again variables make
our life very easy why not use them I'm
just going to say read
pin it will make more sense when I go
further through this video all right so
I'm just going to say it's read pen okay
I'm not going to use the direct thing
I'm just going to use a variable again
I'm not going to use the direct value of
it okay so once I'm done setting it up
what do I need to do I need to use the
analog read Command right analog there's
something called analog read as you can
see right here
all right we have what an analog read
command so far we used what analog right
my time correct use analog right we also
use digital right okay so for the first
time in our lives instead of writing
we're going to use what we're going to
be using analog read okay to read okay
so what does analog read do so basically
so far what been doing was outputting
voltages if you remember so output
voltages right now what we going to do
is we're going to read voltages we're
going to read voltages all right okay so
let's just do that right here so analog
read and what you're going to put right
here on the analog read is is the pen
that you're going to be reading with
okay read pin okay all right that's what
we're going to be using to read our pin
with okay so let me just turn on my Aro
right
here plug it in right here and then
let's upload this
code favor no upload provided all right
let me go to my uh tools and then let me
go to my port right here and select the
conf port now let me upload
it it's done compiling it's done
uploading so finished uploading but how
am I supposed to see the result you know
when we were using um output pins when
using output what we did is what we used
LEDs to see the power and the voltage
that they had remember right so we've
been using LEDs to do what to see the
voltage when they turned on we said it
was what it was 5 volt if it was dimmer
we said it was a lower voltage so we
used LEDs to direct us to basically tell
us and to basically show us that what
our what our pins are outputting what
our pins are outputting U voltage okay
how do we do it when it's reversed
around so far it was an output but how
do we do it when we're using an input so
to do that actually let me just bring uh
something that is common and I think all
of you know of if you're using computers
is a mouse okay so a mouse is a what is
it an input device or an output device
it's an input device and basically what
we do is we connect it to our computer
again I'm just connect to our computer
and when we move we what we do what we
see something on our screen what is that
what is that thing that we see on our
screen it's a pointer okay so we see a
pointer so an input device what do we
expect now we expect is what to see the
results to happen on the screen that's
what we expect okay so to do that and to
actually see something on our screen
we're going to use something called
serial monitors okay so we're going to
use something called what serial
monitors so we're going to do a serial.
begin okay serial. begin and in this one
you're GNA write your B rate so you
might be wondering what is a b rate a b
rate is the the speed at
which it's basically the speed at which
information is transferred okay I want
you to think of it like that don't go
further or don't go deeper as it mostly
does not matter but to catch it just for
the sake of knowing and for the sake of
knowledge to catch it is it's what it's
just the speed out which what the speed
out which information is transferred
from your computer to other devices okay
that's just the thing you should be
thinking of BS as okay serial du begin
96,000 I said it as 96,000 as it's the
most popular B rate all right it's the
most popular one okay so I just started
my serial monitor right here and what I
need to do is quite simple I need to say
is
serial. print so I wanted to print
something for example let's say I wanted
to print the number one okay just say we
want to print the number one for now so
let me upload it right here okay all
right it's done
compiling it's done uploading and you go
to your tab right here where it says
serial monitor I'm going to touch that
okay can you see what it's going on it's
said 96,000 bot as you can see it
automatically set it up because
why I did something wrong right here
what did I do I said it says 9,600 po
right here and I used 96,000 here I'm
supposed to say
9,600 so let me upload it
again you see that I'm getting an error
message right here so for those of you
who don't know is you can't run your you
can't upload or verify your sketch
without removing the serial monitor so
you always have to turn it off before uh
uploading or moving all right verifying
your code so I have to always turn it
off and I do that and let me just upload
it right
here there we go it's done
compiling it's done uploading so always
turn off your serial monitor uh when
you're uploading your code let me just
upload it right
here can you see it it's uploading one
at very fast speed look at it one one
one one one you can see how fast it is
look at how even the pointer is moving
it's very fast okay so I just said is
print one that's all I'm going to do
it's basically like the print function
that we use on U on um python okay all
right so I wanted to print the value of
this I wanted to print the value of this
okay I just wanted to print the value of
this let me just do that set it up and
just turn off the semicolon right here
first things first what what should I do
I should what turn off the serial
monitor okay just turn it off and you
know what it's going too fast for me I'm
just going to give it a delay so I want
it to delay for what let it delay for
maybe 500 milliseconds okay so basically
half a second I just want it to delay
for half a second because it's going too
fast for me okay it's done
compiling and it's done uploading so let
me go back to my serial monitor right
here and we're
receiving that's very confusing isn't it
I mean is it is this one 50 because it
printed it out at very fast speed so is
this 50 then is a 50 here or is it 55 or
is this 5
554 are they together or what I can't
see it until it uploads it right here
okay this is very hard to keep up so
what I'm going to do here is turn off
the serial monitor right here okay I'm
just going to do that and what I'm going
to do right here is say print and add Ln
at the very end what this does is
basically it prints out everything at a
new line okay so prints it out at a new
line every print is is going to have its
own what its own single line all right
so with that in mind let me just upload
it right
here and let's see what happens to the
serial
monitor com for serial Port all right
there you go it's working actually all
right you see it it's just fluctuating
seeing
321 receiving 280
273 256 255 okay okay okay this number
does not make mostly sense does it I
don't think it does
so what I'm going to do is all right
what I'm going to do is this so let me
just try to do is well I'm just going to
read off of the 5 volt voltage all right
so what I'm going to do here is I have
an analog pin right here okay I have
this analog pin again what analog pin am
I using for this I'm going to be using
analog pin five let me just bring analog
pin five right here I'm just connecting
it right here okay analog pin five let
me just make sure that I actually
connect to analog pin 5 and that not
connect to any other pin andl pin five
okay let me just connect it here okay so
let's just again upload this code it's
already uploaded but I just I just
uploaded again so that it restarts all
right then we receive again these weird
numbers because I still do not know what
are these okay what they are I still do
not know that so I'm receiving 1023
986 all right so we have to make
something of these numbers Okay so so
what I'm going to do right here okay is
you know what this is supposed to read
the voltage again as I told you guys
it's supposed to read the voltage that
is coming from what from our arome so
let me go right here I have my A6 pin
right here can you see it I have an A6
pin I have the 5vt pin right here but I
am very very int I am very very confused
should I connect this together or should
I not I am really hesitant about the
circuit should I connect A6 with the 5vt
because if I do
am my I might short the circuit if I
short the circuit basically I might fry
my ardino you know so I'm a bit hesitant
on connecting them directly to
connecting my pin right here with the
5vt because I'm not used to doing that
we're used to what connecting the 5vt
and then going through a resistance and
then going to what to the gnd D all
right if I'm correct so how do I do that
then how do I check um you know I'm very
hesitant about this U circuit right here
I don't want to connect the A5 pin
directly to the 5vt PIN cuz I'm a short
circuit but I want to do it so that you
know the answer it gives me is 5 Vol I
want to check it so I'm a bit hesitant
on this on this U circuit so rather than
just you know doing this and hoping for
the best it's better to do what again
it's better to run a simulator so I'm
just going to go to my screen right here
turn on Chrome and go to simulator right
here okay that's what I'm going to do I
that makes my life a bit easier okay so
again let me just go right right here
and I have it right here all right let
me just open this so I can assimilate it
all
right let's just check you know what
happened here does something bad happen
Okay so I have uh my analog pin here
connected with the digital pin I want to
change that to a 5V pin I want to see
what happens with a 5V pin my 5V pin is
right here there's my 5V pin okay and I
have have my what my analog pin okay I
have my analog pin how about instead of
connecting it like this it's better how
about I just connect them directly you
know let me just turn both off and I'm
going to do is five volt pin connected
directly let's say to one of the anlock
pins this case A5 let me just start the
simulation here let's see what
happens nothing happens so far nothing
happened everything seems fine doesn't
it so far seems fine nothing is going
going on I mean let me just check my
code right here is my code good put that
right down I just did I set A5 to read I
set A3 as a read pin I just want A5 to
be a read
pin I don't need this because I'm using
the 5 volt again I don't need this I
just need my serial you know serial top
again
9,600 I already set that up all I need
to do is what um say analog I said
reader a variable reader right here set
it to analog read pin I don't need that
right now let me just copy this let me
just go back let's just write it down as
if uh the one that I already wrot down
on the uh on the Aro ID okay so that's
all I'm going to do so yeah I think
that's my code for now let's startop my
simulation right here so far nothing
there's no um warning or anything okay
all right what else could have possibly
happen all right so I want want to go to
my serial monitor right here oh there's
a Serial monitor right here all right I
keep getting this value 1023 1023 1023
1023 1023 again so so far um my uh
simulator told me that it's fine to
connect an Arduino a pin with a what
with a 5vt pin did not say it's correct
you know to put it together but like
let's see what happens if I connect an
aen while we're here let's just check
what happens if I connect
uh maybe a digal pin all right thereal
pin maybe eight you see thereal pin
eight to um to a 5V pin right here let's
just say I want to connect to a 5vt pin
what happens you what what could
possibly happen um let me just start
simulate simulation right here maybe let
me start that before doing that though
let me go on my code and let's just
let's just write it to become High all
right let me just do that okay I
received 1023 again um going to get back
to that okay but I just want to check
again what's going to happen when I
connect the digital pin with
a with a five W pin so I'm just go pin
mode and what I need to do is set up the
digital pin 8 eight and say what as an
output I want to use it as an
output what else do I want to do one
final thing I want to do is what I want
to what I want it to
be I'm just going to say is what eight
said that to what
let's see what happens let me start
simulation o what happened saying okay
this one has an error right
here okay let me start right now
now seems fine see that it seems fine
there's no error coming from my uh
simulator telling me you should not do
this or something it seems fine because
it does not make a full circuit but one
thing that's not fine that's definitely
not fine for example it's connecting the
5 volt p pin with the gnd pin let me
just connect it directly 5V in the gnd
let me just start the simulation right
here if I do that might not tell you
right here but what happens is basically
what it's basically frying your Arin
know LED so this does not tell me what
it does not tell me if it's fine or not
okay it just does not tell me that that
it's not worrying me about U connecting
it directly with u the 5vt the gnd
because it's very dangerous to do that
because again what I said is shorting is
going to happen and basically what's
going to happen it's basically going to
fry oural so you see that it's fine but
if I go to another maybe simulator if
you search for another simulator right
here it's going to say it's not right
anyways so um let's go back to actually
uh what it was so let me just go back to
control Z let me just stop the
simulation and let me just um get the
1023 right here the number 1023
okay let me just go back here okay we
connected this directly there we go let
me go back to my code let me
just okay so let's start the simulation
again what did I do right here I put a
semicolon before this all right so let
me start right
now okay seems fine let me go to my
serial monitor okay it says 1023 1023
1023 so I want to explain what this
number is it's like the number that we
used at zero and 20 255 on the analog
right command we using 255 so let me
just explain this right here let me just
bring the paper and explain this right
here okay so the same thing we did on U
we basically did on the uh 255 to zero
value when we were talking about uh the
analog L right command Okay so look we
have 1 we have 2 4 8 16 again to the
power of 0 to the power of 1 this is to
the^ of two this is to the^ of three and
to the^ 4 is 16 and keeps going on okay
we reach a point of 10 24 let just bring
it right here 1024 this is what this is
what this is 10 bits okay so we stopped
at eight bits right here this was what
256 where we basically used for the
analog right command but this extend
this and can count to what up to 1024
okay to the power of 10 that's why we
keep receiving 1023 why do we keep
receiving 1023 we're receiving 5 volt
right here because I connected uh the 5
volt with the what with the analog pin
so I I expect a 5 volt so 5 volt is what
1023 why did we say 1023 instead of 1024
because we start counting from what from
zero that's one thing you need to know
so when you start counting from zero
what happens it becomes 1023 just like
25 six right here we start counting from
zero it's going to be up to what
255 right so 1024 is what 1024 it can
store 1024 items but it can because we
start counting from zero it's going to
count to what count to 1023 okay so all
right so right here we get 1023
basically meaning what 5 volt we receive
5 volt okay so that's that's what we
basically are receiving how about if I
just um remove this 5 Vol right here
okay let me just remove this 5vt let me
start the simulation right here all
right let me just remove this
5vt I'm not going to connect the 5vt
anymore so what I'm going to do is I
remove the string between the 5 volt and
A5 right here what I'm going to do is
you know what I want it to go to gnd D I
want to connect the g&d with the A5
let's just do that okay so let me start
the simulation right here okay okay let
me start simulation let me clear this
one first let me clear the serial
monitor let me just remove it and open
it again I should be doing that I should
fully remove it stop the simulation
start it
again let me go back to the serial
monitor nothing's coming by as you can
see right
here nothing is coming by can you guys
see that nothing is coming by right
here they're trying to read the p in but
nothing is coming by here we're trying
to use E5 let me just set clear right
here just to clear it up but uh nothing
seems to be working so in this case let
me just uh reload it I think it's better
through that way and we go through these
erors of the serial monitor uh when I
was using the arino what I could have
done is you know I could have done is
what remove close the window right here
I'm just going to do is clear it and I'm
going to do is close the window right
here I can do that but sometimes when
the simulators again don't work because
they don't fully mimic the physical
world I going to have to reload it
because again it happens okay let me go
back to code right here and let's go
back to our serial monitor we keep
receiving zero when we connect to the g&
D pin we keep receiving z0 z0 and zero
like perfect pinpoint accuracy I'm
talking 0 000000 can you can see that
right when it's a 5vt we receive 1023
when it's at Z volt we receive what we
receive zero okay so 1023 corresponds
with what with 5 volt when we're reading
it when you're writing when we're using
the analog write command let me just
again for you to remember the when we're
using the analog right command 5vt
corresponds with what 5vt corresponds
with
255 the 5vt right here when we use
analog read corresponds with what 1023 I
know it might seem a bit odd that we're
using you know two different you know
bit systems here we're extending this to
to the power of 10 or we're just using
to the power of 8 uh for analog right it
might be you know it might seem weird or
stuff but it's just again convention
this is something that arduinos people
who built this uh decided upon I don't
know why they decided upon this but as
long as I'm concerned it's going to be
again 1023 for analog read and it's
going to be 255 for analog right okay
that's all you need to
know okay so uh now we've worked with
what we've worked with analog pins but
we've not worked with a physical arbino
we've been using simulators okay so
let's actually work out with a physical
arino and actually add a bit of a Twist
to it and make a good project so I'm
going to introduce a new uh electrical
equipment right here called a
potentiometer right here if you look at
it it's blue right here it's called the
potentiometer it might be different
depending on the kit you have so it
might even be black might even be long
but one thing you need to look for is
three legs right here and an adjusting
knob so you have a knob that you can use
to adjust all right so you have the knob
right here that you can turn that's the
two things you need to look for in a
potentiometer so might be different when
it comes to yours when it comes to your
kit so again check your uh check your
label all right so check the label and
check if it's a potential meter or not
okay so what is a potential meter again
before uh you know working with the
component and stuff we need to learn the
science behind it so let's check what a
potential meter is okay so we have the
simple circuit here and has a potential
meter here and then it goes back to the
negative terminal this the positive
again again this is the negative the
smaller one is the negative terminal
okay so the potentiometer you can just
think of it is what as a box that has
two resistors here let's let's call this
one R1 and R2 okay so R1 and R2 so just
think of it as what is a big box that
has two resistors okay so there's going
to be what RT let's just say it's the
total value of resistance here it's
going to be what since it's connected in
series it's going to be what we're going
to directly add them up we're going to
add them up directly so we're going to
say R1 plus what R1 + R2 because they're
connected what directly okay so that's
all we're going to do RT is what R1 plus
R2 so what does this let us do what does
a potentiometer let us do why is why is
that so that a potentiometer is very
important than a you know why why is it
different than a resistor think of it as
a variable resistor so when you adjust
the knob right here you can change the
value of curve current the the value of
volt that comes out of here okay so you
can adjust it so that what you can
adjust the resistance here so think of
it as a what as a variable resistor okay
so let's say right here I just put it
all the way to the very end to the very
left okay I'm just doing that right now
I hit the left the very end I can't move
it further than this let's say I put it
right here what's going to happen is
when I do that let me just draw it right
here when I'm with the very very left
R1 is going to have a value of what RT
RT right here the total resistance okay
and R2 is going to be what R2 is going
to be zero again when I say zero right
here I've told you guys that uh there's
nothing called as a zero resistance it's
just uh Theory okay so it's very very
small that it's close to zero but it's
definitely not zero okay I haven't told
you guys that even these connecting
wires that are not you know that don't
serve as a resistor have what resistance
so everything has a resistance even
though it's what it's very very very low
okay so in theory it's it's
zero okay so with that in mind when what
happens when I put it in the middle when
I put the knob in the middle what's
going to happen is what R1 is going to
equal to what R2 which is going to be
equal to what it's going to be equal to
half of the total resistance half of
what total resistance
okay all right then what we're going to
do is basically go to the very very
right so what's going to happen so in
this case what happens is R2 is going to
be what R2 is going to be RT it's going
to be equal to RT while R1 is going to
be what it's going to equal to what to
zero okay I just want you to keep that
in mind okay so right here let me just
turn this notification off okay there we
go so right here we have this again
voltage out again the voltage is going
to be output right here so we got these
let me just go closer right here focus
on these so you see those two these are
R1 and R2 they're connected to R1 and
what R2 these the final ones right here
okay the the first one and the last one
they're connected to what to R1 and R2
and the middle one is connected to what
the middle one is connected to V out
this is going to be the voltage out okay
so with that in mind let's just get
started so let me just put put this
potentiometer right here okay so again
when you put the potentiometer let me
just remove my uh let me unplug my arino
right here we need to what we need to
put it across we don't put it together
we don't put the wires together again we
just do it what across let me just put
that across right here okay you need to
again look like it's facing the front
Okay so with that in mind what I'm going
to do is connect it to a 5vt okay and
we're going to use our analog pins to do
what to read the voltage out of here
okay so let me just do that right here
let me just go on 5V right here connect
to to the to the 5 ft okay let me just
do that just go to the 5V right here
can't see it all right there you go I
got it right here I connected it to the
5V with the black wire and then what let
me just connect the the the third one
right here the third one the third leg
the last one right here with the what
with the G and D let me just connected
with the G and D right here boom I did
that and then finally I'm going to need
an analog voltage again the voltage that
I'm going to be reading off of I'm just
going to put it in the middle in the
middle pin right here for you to see it
in the middle pin okay I'm going to put
it at um A5 so I already have this code
written is uh I reot it earlier so what
I'm going to do is it's already uploaded
so I'm just going to run it okay you
guys can look on my screen if you guys
uh remove the code or not but I already
have
okay so let me just upload it's already
uploaded right here so let me go over to
my screen right now and let's open our
serial
monitor let me go to my serial monitor
right here let me just make this a bit
taller just all right there we go
maximize it it's 1023 it's outputting
1023 1023 1023 so let me just adjust it
right now let me just adjust it a bit
can you see it's going lower it's going
lower lower lower right now let me just
try to put it the middle roughly in the
middle all right it's going lower right
here just roughly in the middle a bit
okay it's roughly in the middle right
now I put it straight so it's roughly in
the middle and then let me just adjust
it until it goes to zero let me just
adjust it all the way down let me just
do that you see that we're changing the
what the voltage value coming out right
here can you see that we're going to
zero we don't get a true zero right here
but we get get something that's very
close to zero what is going on is is
we're getting a value it's like 0 point
something and sometimes it rounds it up
to one sometimes the rounds it down to
what to zero okay so with that in mind
something that actually can make this
more interesting is what putting on an
LED so what I'm going to do right here
to put on this led actually make things
interesting let me actually move this a
bit because this is taking too much
space let me just again move it to the
very furthest right here that's all I'm
going to do I'm not going to change
anything because this going to take a
lot of space let me just go and uh let
me just go and put this as close as I
can to the wires just takes a lot of
space okay I have one space right here
so I'm going to again connect the
positive terminal of my uh of my LED
right here to what to one of the uh to
one of the resistors R1 or R2 whatever
you want to pick I'm just going to
connect
that and then what and then I'm I'm
going to connect the negative side of it
to what to the g& D so I'm going to need
to do that let me just do that okay let
me just connect these two pins I'm not
connecting the middle pin I'm connecting
the positive the the one the the black
one and what the red one okay I'm
connecting those two let's see what
happens when I try to adjust the knob
right here let me just try to adjust the
knob all right let me just do that it
doesn't work why is that
so one thing I need you to understand
the potential meters is what RT is fixed
okay RT is always fixed what is changing
is always R1 or R2 the value of R1 or R2
is changing but RT is what it's always
fixed okay so when I'm going through the
whole resistance right here RT is what
it's always fixed in potential meter
right now my potential meter is what 10K
ohms and it's going to be written on
your uh it's going to be written on your
potential meter or at least at the label
that of how much uh resistance it has
okay so it's going to be the total
resistance minus 10,000 amps okay I want
you just to know that but it's going to
be reading for you all right so with
that in mind if I just again run this
over again it won't work so what I need
to do is what I need to go to the middle
so let me just do that how do I do that
I connect the gnd D again to what the
gnd D is the red pin if you remember is
it the g& D is what the gnd D is
connected to which pin let's just
remember that the g&d is connected the
red pin okay it's confusing me a bit
because the red pin is supposed to be
connected the 5vt uh as a standard and
like the black pen is supposed to be
connected to what the GMD that's a
standard again again does not change
anything but it's like a standard
between electrical engineers but I just
you know I rushed over it and just
changed the color so it got me a bit
confused all right so let me just
connect the positive side to what the
positive side to the middle pin so I'm
just going to connect to the middle one
and the negative side of the led to the
what to the red one so let me just do
that it's crossing over I don't want it
to touch each other that would be
bad don't want that to happen okay there
we go now let me just go tighter right
now trying try to go tighter right here
right I think this is the one all right
so now let's try to adjust it okay let's
adjust our knob can you see it it's
dimming slowly slowly slowly this looks
beautiful especially when it's going
slowly you see that we did that all
right that's beautiful
now looks nice but before finally
actually finishing uh our project what
we're going to do is what I want to look
at the serial model right now it's
outputting 231 231 some value let's just
change this to what let's just change
this something that makes more sense to
us that has some something that is what
that is a value to us again I don't want
it to show to between 0o and 1023 I
wanted to show what I wanted to show 0
to 5 volt so what I need to do right
here it's quite simple I need to do some
bit of math right here so what I'm going
to do is what I'm going to say you know
what let me just set up a value right
here it's going to say in I'm G to say
um calc value because I'm going to what
calculate it so I'm just going to say
calc value and what let me just set it
to zero for now okay Cal value and what
let me just uh let's there's a delay
right here let me just go beneath that
and I need to do is what just set up the
Cal value right here Al is set to what
I'm going to say is what it's going to
be what it's going to be 5 /
1023 you're going to divide that then
you're going to what multiply by what
I'm going to multiply by what I'm going
to multiply by the analog
read wait I got that wrong analog
read and I'm GNA
say okay just multiply right here and
I'm just going to say Cal
F okay there we go all right so what I'm
going to do is upload it right now and
let's see what happens so let me just
upload it right
now again my serial monitor is it off
right there we go is my serial monitor
off all right I turned it off right here
all right I turned it on right now just
turned it on again make sure that your
serial monitor is off every time okay I
get z0 z0 z0
0o then let adjust
it getting zeros let me just adjust it
the other
side we're getting a zero even though
this is adjusting you can see that we're
getting definitely more than zero it's
saying z0 0
z0 so the problem here is let me just
show you what I did the problem here is
what I'm using integers so right here
it's going to bring what 5 ID 1023 is
going to give us what it's going to give
us a decimal so what happens is it's
going to what it's going to value it's
going to what it's going to round it
down to zero because if you just think
of it let me just divide 5 by 1023 let
me just divide 5 by 1023 let me just
bring my calculator right here let me
just bring my calculator right here I'm
just turning out my calculator let me
just divide 5 by 1023 1023 it's almost
what it's almost zero and it's what it's
rounding it it's rounding it to what
it's rounding it to zero so any number
multiplied by zero coming from the
analog it's going to always read what
it's going to always read read zero so
what do we need to do we need to set it
as what as decimals so I go right here
and what I'm going to do is set a point
next to it all right so I'm going to set
a point next to it and you can say 5.0
or just a point next to it it doesn't
really matter it's up to you so I'm
going to set a point next to it and one
final thing I need to do is what I need
to go to calc Val right here and I'm not
going to to set it to integers I'm going
to set it to float basically float means
what basically float means um float
means uh decimals all right so you can
just set it up without actually uh
giving it a value it's up to you let me
just upload it right now okay and it
should be working okay it's done
compiling okay should be done uploading
by now let me open my serial monitor
right here all right we're starting to
receive real numbers here okay we're
receiving 4.7 4.5 right here 4.2 we're
now receiving full 5 volts you know you
might be wondering why if I remove this
led right now we're almost going to
receive 5 volts you see that as soon as
I remove the LED we get 5 volts because
we're you our LED is what our LED is
using up some of the voltage right here
that's why okay so it's using some of
the what the voltage if I remove it
right now if I remove this led right now
it's going to be what let me just remove
it for now it's going to be giving me 5
volt 5 volt 5 volt 5 volt can you see
that as soon as I put it back in though
I think this right here as soon as I put
it back in it's going to going to be
giving me 4.8 because what it's going to
be using Z what2 volt right here our LED
is using what to 0.2 volt of the value
okay so let's just adjust it again just
to check it out adjust it adjust it more
adjust it again adjust it almost off
right
now and there you have it and that's it
for uh this project so I think we build
something with a potential meter I think
it's one of this uh higher end of
projects that are actually nice
so okay so I did not change my circuit
here it's the same from the previous one
but we're going to add something called
buzzers so if you look closely right now
let bring it close enough these are
called buzzers and we're going to use
them to basically create sound so we're
just going to change electrical energy
to what to sound energy basically by
what by vibrating so again before
working with these buzzers let's go in
depth and try to understand what they do
so let's just have a rough idea of what
buzzers are okay so if you look close
enough again this are called buzzers if
you look close enough they're not the
same thing if you look at top they might
seem like the same thing but if you look
U at the bottom there's a black one
right here okay and there's a one where
you can see the circuit okay so let's
just go here and try to understand what
they are so the one marked with a black
one is a what is called an active buzzer
okay an active buzzer and the one that
does not have any board any uh bottom on
it and where you can see the uh where
you can see the components right here is
what is called a passive buzzer okay so
I want you to understand the difference
between these two so both of them are
used to create sounds but it's going to
be different for both of them so let's
go right here and let me just explain
what an active buzzer is okay just do
that so an active buzzer what it
basically does is what it needs DC
voltage it takes DC voltage and what
basically happens is there if you look
inside if you just pry it up open
there's a cone that vibrates okay
there's a cone that vibrates back and
forth back and forth okay there's a cone
that what that vibrates back and forth
and basically what creates Sound by
vibration so let's just do that so I
have my again circuit from the previous
uh lesson so what I'm going to do is I'm
not going to touch this one I'm not
going to touch any of these I'm just
going to give it a new space and one
important thing you need to understand
is this thing if you look at it it has a
plus sign okay so not only that too but
even there's a difference in what
there's a difference in their what in
the length can you see that this one is
longer the plus sign is what is longer
just like what just like when we were
using what LEDs so keep that in mind
both of them have what both of them have
a plus sign both of them have a plus
sign and the plus sign what leg is
longer okay so let's go back to our
active buzzer right here all I need to
do is put the plus sign around here and
what I'm going to do is connect it to
the 5vt so let me just go the 5V right
here there's the 5vt and I'm just going
to connect to the longer side of it or
basically the positive side that's all
I'm going to
do okay and let me bring another wire
right
here let's get another wire I sure this
is a very short wire let me get a longer
one let me get a longer wire right here
all of them are short today I have to go
closer if not all of them are short I
don't have any longer wires left I've
used all of my longer runners okay so if
I have a short one what I'm going to do
is go through this side let me just go
back to this side okay and let me just
take this 5 volt right here and take
it put it right here got the gnd D the
ground pin this going to I'm going to
connect the negative side to what the
gnd D so let me just do that that's the
gnd D right here and it starts to make
what
can you hear that starts to make what
sound directly as I plug it in so okay
that's what a an active buzzer does okay
so let me just bring this one the
passive buzzer okay when I'm using a
passive buzzer one thing that's
necessary to do is what the difference
that comes here is I need to use AC
basically I need to use what AC circuit
for this one I've just directly used
what 5vt when you look at the Arduino
5vt right here the 5vt PIN it directly
outputs 5 volt DC basically what direct
current I'm going to come back to this
and actually compare and contrast them
but it use what direct current okay so
for this one we're going to use AC
current alternative current okay so let
me just uh remove my uh active buzzer
here this is my active buzzer again the
one with the black one let me just
remove it let me just remove the wires
that I used for the active buzzer so
that it does not get too many see just
do that okay and now what I'm going to
do right here I have again my passive
buzzer let me just set it up let me just
unplug my Arduino
now let me just go back
closer so you can actually see it
there's my uh passive I'm just going to
put it right there the same spot
actually I need to I need my gnd D pin
connect it to here my gnd D cannot see
it all right there we go g& D pin
connected to the negative side for the
other leg just connected here and the
positive side I'm going to be using what
those digital pins that are marked with
a what with a squiggly sign those ones
that I said that are that behave both as
a digital pin and also as a what as an
analog pin okay so we're going to work
with those let me just put it a digital
pin n okay digital pin n because it what
it has what if you look closely again it
has what has a DOT sign wait let me just
bring it close enough so that it
focuses let me just actually zoom in
more you see that it has a DOT sign
right there so we're going to use those
pins again that I mentioned that the
ones that I used for what for analog
right right
now let me just zoom out okay zoomed out
okay so that's what I'm going to do so
let me go over to my screen right now
and actually write down some
code so let me just uh
remove this right now remove this code
because I have a need it right
now we can write it now if you need to
again okay so what I'm going to do is
what we're going to need additional pin
so I'm can say is what I'm going to need
the additional pin n so I'm going to say
what what is this
passive Buzz just going to say passive
Buzz it's G to be what I'm going to set
it thereal pin n okay all I need to do
is what after set it up going to say
passive was set it to what as an
output there we go then afterwards what
I need to do I'm going to need to do is
what use the analog right command and
again use passive again buzz and then
what then let me just set it to whatever
I want to let's just say I want to set
it to three okay so let me just set it
to three let me just upload this right
now it's don't comp compiling oh we
cannot upload it because what we have
not plugged our Arduino let me just do
that right here let me just do that let
me just remove the paper for now I'm
going to go with the explanation after
we work with it a bit okay let's just
upload
it St compiling okay it's not
uploading but we can't hear anything can
we I cannot hear
anything is everything all right let me
just again check my pins okay there's
still pin n is here there we
go let me just stop it for let me just
stop it for a second uh you might not
hear it as very uh you might not hear it
as strongest the active buzzer because I
set it to what I set it to three because
it's going to be receiving less what
less electricity it's going to be
receiving less current okay let just do
that
again
hopefully you can hear it if not let me
just again increase the value here just
put three just increase it to let's just
say 20 for now just say
20 let me just again put back what
distal pin n back again to good
spot now it's
louder now it's
louder
let's raise it to a higher
value let's just say 40 or 50 we just
set it to
50 I'm this upload it right
now it's done compiling it's done
uploading let me put it back right here
now we can hear it
louder all right so let's make it
actually do something interesting is we
do is put what a delay on it right so
we're just going to set it on and off on
and on on and off because it's going to
sound better that way so I'm me just
save delay right here analog right what
passive Buzz to set it to zero right
here and give it a delay
again okay so one thing I did not do
right here is set up what how much I
want to set it to be so let just say
again 5 milliseconds again I'm saying 5
milliseconds and let's upload
it again let me just put it back right
here a de
butt can you hear
it all right let's just set this maybe
to delay what maybe to delay uh how
about 10 just to say we want a longer
delay
all right we've experimented with the
the passive buzzer and the active buzzer
and one thing the passive buzzer you
know is capable of is what we can turn
it off and turn it on can you that can
you see that you can turn it on and off
as as we did right here we turn this to
what to zero basically what turning it
off at line 14 we basically what turn
off we did as what turn off buzzer
that's what we did right here what did
we do we turn on
buzzer but we couldn't do that using
what using an active buzzer why is that
so why is that so we can't do that using
an active buzzer why is that so so um
the big thing here is uh when using an
active buzzer is what why couldn't we do
that well it's because what 5 volt is
always what 5 volt 5 volt always outputs
what 5 volt okay so 5 volt always outut
what outputs what 5 volt that's why it
cannot you know go on and off that's why
we cannot you know turn on off turn on
off on off we cannot we cannot do it
using a five volt but we can definitely
do it using a distal pin we can
definitely do it using a St P um okay so
with that in mind let me just again
actually so with that in mind actually
what I'm going to do is going to be
working with these potential meters
before doing that we're going to have to
go again with but we we have to go
behind signs here so we're going to go
to the
signs so uh let's do that okay so why
does a passive buzzer you know require
AC circuit and why does a active buzzer
require uh why does an active buzzer
require a DC circuit a passive buzzer
requires AC circuit
and an active buzer requires a DC
circuit why is that so well why is that
so so in a passive buzzer okay we use AC
circuit let me just bring a passive
buzzer right here we use AC circuit
because what because there's something
called a vibration cone a vibration cone
what it basically does is what it
vibrates to create separate okay so the
vibration cone what in an AC circuit
what goes back and forth back and forth
so one thing I want you to think of on
AC circuit is what let bring this right
here you've I think most likely you've
heard the term AC circuit and youve most
likely know this graph it goes up and
down up and down when you look at a DC
circuit it's what it's
straight it goes what it goes one way
this goes what this goes back and forth
this goes back and forth basically what
basically vibrating just think of it
back and forth back and forth they very
fast beats basically what vibrating
basically when it vibrates what happens
it creates sound okay so when you think
of um uh uh uh direct circuit right here
a TC circuit right here you might be
wondering then how does a how does an
active buzzer work then because it
receives what it receives an active
buzzer receives what an active buzzer
receives DC circuit so when it comes
towards a DC circuit what happens is
when it comes to an active buzzer what
happens is uh the difference in
component here is that it uses something
called
electromagnetic uh electromagnetic all
right Spectrum so what I use is what EMR
so what happens is basically let me just
explain this in a simple term not get
into too much detail so what basically
happens is this okay let me just bring
the my sharp right here basically
happens is this so you see this let's
just say there's a magnet right here
okay and there's something it's
attracted to right here okay there's a
magnet here and there's something it's
attractive to so when it's on what
happens is what it goes attractive to it
it's attractive to it it goes go right
here when it's off what happens is what
this magnet is repelled okay this magnet
repels okay so you see that it goes on
and off so basically what when it goes
on and off at very fast speeds what
happens when it goes on and off and on
and off what happens even using a DC
circuit what happens what happens is it
moves what back and forth the vibration
coin moves what back and forth back and
forth back and forth okay so that's the
whole essential thing there's a
vibration cone and it's moving what back
and forth to create what vibr okay with
that in mind actually let me just go
right here I have my uh uh active buzzer
right now let me just go over to my
active buzzer what I'm going to do is
quite simple I just want to create
something that adjusts the volume so
let's just use a potential meter right
here so let me just go back to my uh
buzzer again the positive side is right
here so what I'm going to do is let me
just bring my connecting wire and and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to use
this middle pin right now the V out of
the potential meter that we mentioned
earlier I'm just going to use this as my
main terminal okay because then I can do
what I can adjust the voltage that comes
out okay I'm just going to do that and I
need the gnd D pin so obviously I'm just
going to take this gnd D pin from here
and I'm going to put it at what at the
end of the circuit let me just do
that now it's supposed to
work all
right one thing I did not do is
what uh right what did I not do the
black one is supposed to be connected to
what to 5 Vol think it's connected to 5
Vol is it connected to 5
Vol all right so one thing I did is what
I forgot about the potential meter it's
not what it has to come from one end to
the other end let me just again if uh
necessary let me just draw the potential
meter again
flip the page right now and as I told
you guys let me just try to draw the
circuit here okay we have the battery 5
volt have the potential meters is what a
box that has what two resistors
connected in what in
series and in the middle we have what
something that's going to Output our
voltage this one is like the what the
white pen in this case V
output and we have what afterwards we
have our buzzer that needs a positive
side okay a buzzer and then it has a
negative side you just put it with a
circle on top that has a negative side
and then what we connected to what the
negative side basically the what the G
and so what one thing that I not do here
is what connect the R2 the R2 is right
here I did not connect it I just jumped
it so what I need to do is right like
this so let me go back right here the V
output let it stay right here that makes
sense doesn't it so you know what I'm
just going to put the V up right here
okay then what I'm going to need another
wire to extend
it just do
that
okay all
righty about to extend
it there you go we extended so we
extended it on the what on the white pin
basically what the middle okay all right
so let me just try to adjust it a
bit I don't know if you can hear me but
let me just try to adjust it a bit okay
let me just try to adjust
it okay I connected what the white pin I
extended it to what to the red pin if
you can see right here the white pin is
the one the V out is extended to what
the positive side of the what the
positive side of the buzzer I'm using a
what an active buzzer again let me just
try to you know use it as a turning knob
basically use it as a volume
adjuster
so what happens is you can barely hear
anything at the middle or at the start
and then you can hear something at the
what at the very very very end okay when
I put it to the very end okay basically
when it's what but it's receiving the
maximum voltage basically almost 5 volt
it's receiving the maximum
voltage you see it doesn't make any
sound when I turn it all the way so
obviously for this case do we need what
we need a passive buzzer so let's just
try doing that with a passive buzzer so
instead of using what instead of using
the 5vt pin again I need to take it out
of the 5vt pin the 5vt pins connect to
what this one and I'm going to be using
digital what pin n instead okay just
going to be using distal pin nine there
we go then I'm just going to have my
passive buzzer here the positive and the
negative side again
marked okay
now we should have what we should have a
a voice adjustment so let me again what
I'm going to do is right now I'm just
going to change
it hopefully you can hear it now I'm
just going to go silent and let's see
the volume
change
can you hear it's not the smoothest it's
not the smoothest change but definitely
you can notice what the change in volume
and it just changes all right let me
just go right here and just give it More
Voltage right now I'm giving it maximum
of 50 let me just give it 255 which is
the maximum value let me just give it a
maximum value right
now okay so now let's just adjust it
again from here
here can you hear it now it's one it's
basically the potential meter is what
we're using it as an adjuster all right
so again potential meter we use it as
what as an as an adjustment basically as
a adjuster for what for the amount of
voltage that comes out basically the
current the voltage that comes out okay
so we used our buzzers right now we used
the um passive buzzer we have the active
buzzer here we're not using it we're
using the passive buzzer right now so we
made this simple project okay so now we
learned about what we learned about
these buzzers and how to make really
really good songs with really good sent
with all right so even then too if you
actually let me go to my screen right
now let's make this a bit more
interesting than it is so let me go over
to my screen right now okay I don't need
this all these wires right now let me
just remove them I don't need my
potentiometer right now let me just
remove them okay so let me just go to my
Chrome right now and if you go right
here let me just say
buzzer buzzer
Arduino sound code it'll just go for
code okay all right let's try to find a
good code sound all right so there're
going to be lots and lots of uh play
Melody using the tone function right
here let me just again let me just try
to open
this but what you can do what I'm going
to give you as a homework is what what
I'm going to give you as a homework is
try to find all right try to find these
Arduino codes again I use a buzzer you
can see that right there we're using a
buzzer right now
right now I don't know what Buzz are we
using I don't know if you're connected
to a pin or a 5vt the image is not the
best all right let me just go here okay
there we go we're connected to pin 8 and
gnd D okay all right and there's the
there's the code right here all I need
to do is what let me just copy the code
right here and it has a library I need
to include that and I'm actually going
to see how to even include libraries
right now so let me just copy all of
this
okay I'm copying all of it on
YouTube all right there we
go no me to repeat melody or whatever
just copy this right now let just put
this
again paste this fully and one thing I
need to do is what install a library
okay there's a word manager you go right
here and there's a library manager so
let me filter my search I'm just going
to say pitches
image
okay this says micro gameer just go and
try to even run the code before uh
including the varet it says what there's
nothing called
pitches. okay so let me just try to
Google it right here what a pitches.
is there are definitely lots of notes as
you can see right here let me just go to
U just.
Ed there we go yeah we're getting to it
GitHub page right
now it just. Ed and I'm trying to
include it as our
uh there we
go so I'm trying to include in our
library right now I'm trying to include
it in our library as you can see right
now trying to search
for hitch studed okay pites stedge just
do
that so again do it yourself again try
to go through problems and do it
yourself okay let me just install this
because it's the only thing that's
coming
here okay let me just install this and
let's try to verify our code even then
to if it actually works all right it
says there's nothing as in this
directory no file in this directory okay
pct. Edge there's nothing in this
directory that's what it's basically
saying so what you need to do in this
case is basically simple
okay so what I do in this case is just
go to GitHub or any other documentation
and ask them the simple question okay I
don't know how to you know include
libraries in C++ because I'm mainly used
it so all right let's just go
here my sketch cing the following error
but just do it's not enough okay
refering try to read
one leads me this link right now this
leaves me this link and and doesn't seem
to go any
further okay then how do we do it how do
we go and add the Library store Arduino
because I used to know this but over
time I think I forgot about it all right
pit still age does not seem to be
working all right so let's try to use
something that does not have any library
but one thing I'm going to go over this
again how to use libraries and stuff in
the future
all right how to install pitches. edge
audio let's just go
here there's an Arduino form and how to
install
it there's an Arduino documentation of
what installing libraries right here
pleas start Ed is a part of all right Z
to and sign
up all right so it's telling me to do
what
this part of what a sketch not a library
an example of this is official 0.2
digital sketch that comes with the what
with the rwo
ID all
right it's leading me towards this so
again I'm just we're just running to
what we're running towards the problem
again the same problem again seems that
we can't Sol it right now I'm going need
to solve it later
on okay let me just check the installing
libraries documentation again I'm trying
to U do this together with you guys is
what happens is uh with uh when it comes
to courses is it just seems easy when
somebody else does at end we don't it
doesn't seem that you're going through a
problem we are everybody does okay all
right so let me just go to again Library
manager let me just do
that so all right let me just go to
sketch include library and manage
libraries all right let just do that
sketch um there say some clode library
right now and say manage libraries right
now okay you should open the tab right
now just to get go again just to show
you to you guys um manage
libraries okay there we go just let me
do the same thing
pitches
pitch just show me so it does
not have a good documentation because if
it did it's going to show me uh
basically how to even install it you see
that at adult zip Library it can do that
so basically what I need to do is what
download this pct. Ed right now that's
what it's basically telling me to that's
to download
this you it basally this
code download this and run it so let's
just try to find something else that
actually does not require you to do what
to use this pitches thingy okay so let's
just say buzzer arino sound
code again let's just try to find it
this is part of programming but you
cannot find the things you actually
want
okay let me just say code and just say
song song code see that play parrots at
the caribbe and theme song on Arduino
there are definitely lots and lots of
great YouTube videos again to actually
make a there we go Arduino and a buzzer
songs for Arduino let's just try this
one all right there we go let's just see
the component again we have the gnd and
we connected to pin nine right here okay
that makes sense you have to include
pitches again n you have to do that you
can using this Library okay include
Library add. zip Library all
right all right there we go add a zip
library but we do we do what we
definitely need pictures. Edge what we
need to download it as far as I'm
concerned right now we need to what
picture. Edge I need to find the library
and download the zip I'm just go to pct.
Edge right now you find the GitHub about
it all
right there we go pictures. edge I'm
just going to download this right
now let me just do that I'm just going
to call this pitch. Edge because it
makes more
sense pites edge.
siip just call it that okay that should
be better isn't it better right now okay
so let me just do that import that let's
try
that let me just import it uh how I do
that I go back to this tab it's showing
me how how to import it so okay
importing a zip Library sketch include
library at libraries let's just do that
so let me go right here let's go
tools no actually let's go to sketch and
let's include library and then add don't
zip libraries it's not available in the
library manager it's not available in
the public library but just Edge don't
zip let me just try to do that it's
processing it and it's installed it so I
think my question should be working now
hopefully it
is okay it's done compiling so hopefully
now it's going to work let me just
upload it okay it's done compiling so
that's nice okay Melody can you see
that all right so we used our library
manager right here but one thing we
actually need is what it does not
include what pen I use for this you know
that's the problem right here the
problem I have right here is what does
not tell me what pen I'm supposed to use
does it does it even set up a pin mode I
don't think it does didn't I think in
this case we're going to be using an
active buzzer here because we're not
setting up any pin mode and all that for
uh for
uh for a passive buzzer so we're just
going to be using what I'm going to
assume we're going to be using an active
buzzer here that makes more sense so let
me just connect the 5 volt right here
connect the 5vt let just put it right
here and we have the gnd D let me just
again connect the gnd D right here it's
a bit harder when you're filming to
actually get the right pin let just go
over here g& D got
it okay I think this how it's supposed
to work let me just make sure again I
got the 5 volt and then not get the
wrong PIN I think I did get the wrong
PIN still getting the same
thing
all right so we're still getting the
same thing I could possibly probably be
right now I was trying to find another
code because this one does not make any
sense it doesn't at least we imported
what the pict just. edip so should have
been actually
better okay so this one is horrible or
maybe I did not read what I did not read
the full documentation what did it say I
have to connect it to What specifically
told me what to connect it to what pin
eight can you see that specifically told
me to connect to what to pin8 so I need
to remove this active buzzer again I
don't know read the whole thing that's
why I was rushing again to finish this
video that's my problem right now but
again it happens I just wanted to show
you
guys okay actually I did not know
anything about adding libraries towards
uh C++ or Arduino but I just wanted to
show you guys the process of learning
okay me and myself getting into bit of a
trouble right here okay so we need pin
eight it's hard to actually get the pin
eight right now when you're here's pin
eight all right I think it's this one I
think I'm supposed to be doing this pin
eight all right the gnd
d uh I uploaded right sure if I uploaded
or not just to make sure right
now okay start
compiling
can you hear
it let me just upload it
again okay that's a nice tone right now
okay how about I just want to run this
again and again and again and again it's
just running one more time have the what
if I run this in the right here and just
set it in the loop because I just want
to run it again again and again and
again that's what I want to do want to
run it on the
loop right here they'll before U Finish
here I'm just going to just get a delay
before you know writing the tone over
and over again I'm just going to get a
delay if maybe 10
seconds it's going to make it better I
don't know if it's going to ruin the
code we're just going to see it right
now
all
right all right so this was a bit of a
long one right now I don't think you can
see the buzzer right here it because
again I just moved moved it around but I
don't think it matters again I just
connected it to what to pin eight right
here okay connected this one to pin8 and
I connected this one to what the gnd D
that's all I did this is connected to
what to pin8
as in the image it's connected to what
to pin eight it's just my uh it's
because that my uh my wire isn't that
long here you go you can hear it
again there we go so I guess that's it
for uh today uh yeah so actually see you
in the next section this was a bit of a
long one and really sorry by the way
for um if you guys did not see the uh
the pins I tried to tell you guys where
I connected it to and but again this
just happened because again my wire
isn't that long and I have to pull it
really hard to actually bring it here
okay anyways uh see you in the next
section okay so in this section we're
going to discuss about uh photo
resistors and
termers okay so let's bring something
that is familiar with you guys resistors
obviously we use them to do what to
limit the amount of current that is
coming in so that it does not basically
what ruin our components okay so right
here we're going to learn about these
special type of uh resistors so let me
bring them right
here this is a photo
resistor
and a therm thermistor looks something
like
this let me bring this close enough so
that you can see see them for yourself
so when you're looking for a photo photo
resistor what you're going to be looking
for is this quickly lines right here
that goes like this like this like this
okay you're going to be looking for
those when you're looking for a photo
resistor and just put that next to its
nameee and when you're looking for a
therm resistor you're going to be
looking for these round headed again
they can be green they can come in black
but again always read your labels to
make sure uh what you have right here
okay so always make sure because they
look close to something called uh
ceramic capacitors okay so just keep
that in mind let me just put this back
to its
place okay
now let me try to explain what these are
okay so
these are as I said again they're types
of what resistors they're some sort of
type of resistors they have the ending
of ister okay so there are different
types of resistor so when it comes to a
photo resistor when it comes to the
photo resistor one thing you need to
understand is it is a type of resistor
where the resistance value changes okay
depending on light obviously the name
photo the beginning of photo indicates
something that has to do with what with
light just like how we use
photosynthesis has to do something with
what with what with the light so what
resistors are what these are types of
resistors in which the resistance value
changes according to light this happens
so that because we use um a special
material all right on the top use a
special material which changes its
resistance again corresponding to what
corresponding to light all right so one
good analogy of this would be something
we've worked with in the previous
project which is going to be uh it's
going to be a potential meter right here
let me just bring it closer the
potential meter we just worked in the
past few sections so potentiometer what
happens how do we change its resistance
it's a variable resistor as I said again
how do we change its resistance we just
change the knob just like this when it
comes to the photo resistor what do we
do we Chang the light we Chang the value
of light so we change the light again we
go dimmer and brighter and it's going to
change our what our resistance okay just
keep that in mind all
right when it comes to our therm
resistors the name thermy gives it away
it is related to what something that has
to do with what with temperature okay
something that has to do with what with
temperature so when it comes to therm
resistors basically just like how photo
resistors again change their resistance
value according to what according to
light just like a photo resist just
change their value according to
light these therm resistors let me just
go closer again these therm resistors
change their value according to what
according to temperature okay according
to what according to temperature just
keep that both in mind okay so now we
start I think uh working with our photo
resistor here let's just keep our term
resistor on the side here because
they're very familiar that's why I just
chose to teach them together but let's
work with our photo resistor first okay
so let me just get this out of the way
bring my Arduino here have my photo
resistor and what I'm going to do is
basically connect a simple 5vt circuit
so just how we used to use an LED and a
resistor instead of using a resistor
we're going to be using what we're going
to be using a photo resistor this time
okay let me just turn off my light here
let just turn it off turn off my adreno
bring the ardeno closer so we can focus
on what we're doing right now okay there
we go I'm going to connect the 5 VI
right here the 5vt connected to the 5vt
pin the red the red wire all right nice
now what am I going to do going to bring
it here move it to here okay then I'm
going to have my resistance again
here I'm going to put it across okay
when it comes to resistance again it
does not matter which leg you put it
through obviously this matters in LEDs
but when it comes to anything type of
resistance it doesn't matter which leg
you put through first okay the same
comes to poten the potential meters here
you can put what the first leg or the
last leg it doesn't really matter what
matters is the middle leg obviously it's
going to be the one with the V out so
obviously the middle leg is the
important one that you actually don't
want to mess up but you can just choose
between these two you can just put it in
the g& D or this other side on the 5vt
doesn't really matter okay let me just
put that
here
focus on it
again all right let me get my LED my
handy LED right here got my
LED now I'm going to connect one leg of
the photo resistor here to the what to
the LED let me just do
that just focus here so you can see it
better there we
go now you can see it way
better all right and then what do I need
my gnd okay I'm just bring the black
wire
here again connect this to the
gnd where's the gnd at it's right here
just connected the gnd pin or the
negative terminal let me bring this
across
here right and let's just put it back
here to the other side of the what the L
D okay we just did that okay we just did
that but there's something wrong with
this circuit I mean it seems fine when
you look at it because as far as I'm
concerned what did we do let's just
recap on it what did we do we used uino
as a 5vt output because we connected
Thea to the 5vt and then what else did
we do afterwards we went to our what let
me just bring this aside here what did
we do we brought our resistor here this
case it's a variable resistor and you
just indicated by this by this symbol
variable resistor is indicated by this
symbol basically changes what it's
resistors it's resistors value it's
resistance value changes according to a
condition okay in this case what is
going to be the condition of light all
right then we have our LED our handy
LED how do we write that
down we go like this then we go back to
our negative
terminal one thing I did wrong here is
what this is the negative terminal the
negative terminal is what the the
smallest side so I have to put a
negative here and I have to make this
the positive I have to make it the
bigger one because obviously why because
that the big one is the positive the
bigger line and the smaller line is what
negative okay let me just put that and
again let me just correct this this goes
big small and there's a small one here
just put this to
Big all right there we go I'm just
correcting this anyways what basically
happens here is what we have the 5vt
output we have our resistor we have our
LED this seems like a normal you know a
simple 5vt circuit again this should be
working and there's nothing wrong with
it as far as I'm concerned it looks
perfectly neat instead of using our
normal resistor right here we just used
some sort of resistance instead of using
our nor noral resistor that we have here
instead of using that we basically did
what instead of using our normal
resistors we basically used what a photo
resistor which we said is what it's a
type of what is a type of
resistor but the problem that lies here
is that this photo resistor the value
changes over what over light so right
here I have a bright environment all
right I have a bright
environment all right so so how am I
supposed to be sure how am I supposed to
be Reliant that the photo resistor you
know doesn't have a small resistance
value because we said the resistance
value changes how am I supposed to be
sure that the resistance value is not
very very small how am I supposed to be
sure right because one thing you need to
know about photo resistance right now is
as the light
increases okay as the light increases
the resistance
decreases and the out then the opposite
goes through too as the light
decreases the resistance on um on the
photo resistors increase okay I want you
to keep that in mind so right here I'm
in a very very bright environment I have
two lights set up just for this course
okay so how am I supposed to be sure
that you know this does not what this
basically does not have a very little
amount of resistance value that what
we're going to have too much current and
it's going to frog our LED how am I
supposed to be sure of that so to be
sure to be exactly sure in this case
we're going to have to put a backup
resistor basically in case if we have a
very very little amount of resistance in
case we have that we're going to need a
resistance that does not change okay so
what I need is what what I need is a
normal resistor again just to back me up
in this case because if this resistance
value just changes to let's say a value
of let's say resistance value goes to
what goes to very little numbers let's
even
0.002 okay let just say
0.2 ohms okay let see even it goes there
if it goes there let's just calculate
the amount of current that goes here so
current is what the voltage over
resistance the voltage is what the
voltage is five it's going to be divided
by
0.002 okay there's the current if I just
do that if I just do the simple math
here here and this is going to be zero
multiply this all both of them by
thousand okay and it's going to be over
two 50 over two is going to be 25 we're
going to be receiving
2,500 amp it might not seem you know
very big it seems like a big number but
it might not seem you know too big
because we don't we're not you know
relatively what we're not contrasting it
with uh what we know all right this is a
big number this is a very very big
number but put it to the light and to
see how big of a number it is let's just
use our normal calculation right we have
5 Vol and what is our resistance that we
use 300 what
330 if I just run this on my computer
right here let me just say 5 / by
330 it's almost the current that we
receive is almost
amp which is almost how much if you just
put this to light again how much almost
16 milliamps
milliamp can you see it 16 milliamp if
the number goes too low what happens we
receive an what an excess amount of
current basically what it's going to fry
our LED if not even our Arduino might
even fry our Arduino because of how big
of a number it is okay how big of
current we're receiving so just to make
sure again we're going to need what a
resistor that that is not variable that
doesn't change we need what a normal
resistor all right so in this case I'm
just going to put what a normal
resistance as a backup all right so let
me just unplug
this and connect my just bring this here
let me connect the other leg of the U
the sorry photo resistor right here
towards the other leg of the resistor my
normal resistor all right there we go
they're
connected
okay once I'm done connecting them what
do I need I need my LED again always
check for the positive side the longer
one the longer side of it I found it I'm
just going to put it
here all right and I'm going to need my
what my g& D pen let me just use my what
my gnd D to the other side of the LED
let me just use my gnd d right here all
right now it's ready now let me just
turn it on let's do that turn it on
right
here
okay everything seems to be working fine
let me just everything seems to be
working F right now it does again we're
not going to be coding anything on the
ardino because we just going to be using
what the 5 volt so now I want to change
what the value of this uh this photo
resistor the value of the resistance
again right now I'm using what two
bright lights right here I have one
light right here on the left I have one
right to the right so it's very bright
right now
so clearly the resistance value again
what happens let me just bring my here
if the light goes up the resistance
value goes down so in this case the
resistance goes down let's say
theoretically it goes down to very very
small number let's even say to almost
zero okay let's just say zero so what
basically happens here is what we're
going to have our 220 um resistor it's
going to be obviously regulating what
comes from um the photo resistor because
in this case we're using what we're
going to have a very very small number
almost close to what almost close to
zero okay so light up light is up right
here so the resistance values down
that's why lots of current is Flowing so
what so our LED is what our LED is what
our LED is brighter okay so let me just
try to decrease the light and see the
resistance value come up basically what
basically dimming our LED we'll just do
that so let me just go here turned off
one
light
turned off both lights it's getting
dimmer let me just go and even turned
off the curtains let me just fully turn
them
off now we are in a very dark
environment except for the LED that's
sliding up right here the Arduino
built-in LED let me just block it for
now okay by my hand you can see how dim
it just got you can barely see the red
light right here the red light right
here I just dimmed it
out okay you can see that it's what it's
very very dim let me just turn on the
light right
now both lights all right here we go you
can just see that what it was dim like a
few seconds ago and now it's bright okay
so this is one thing you need to keep in
mind when working with what with photo
resistors one thing you always keep in
mind is what photo resistors are not
always Reliant they're not what they're
not always Reliant because why because
again the resistance value always
changes by light okay so where do you
think can we use these photo resistors
one of the applications of photo
resistors would be what especially when
we're using Street lamps basically there
are going to be what there are going to
be times where again street lights again
will turn on and off automatically again
no manual configuration you you don't
need to turn it on or off it's going to
what it's going to detect the amount of
light that is coming out from the Sun
and if it's very very little what's
going to happen again the resistance
value is going to be very high it's
going to record it and then then
afterwards it's going to what turn it on
it's going to basically what it's going
to turn it on automatically so we can
use Photo resistors for what for self
for selft turning on and off lights okay
so we're going to use them for what for
smart lights okay so we worked with the
photo resistor right here let's work
with a bit on the the ther therm that we
just mentioned earlier okay let me just
unplug all of this take this
off all of it there we go there we
go
okay just did that and now let's bring
my right here my valuable barister and
let's try to do the same thing so again
let's connect it almost the same circuit
okay let's try to do
that all right I have my 5 volt right
here connected here then I've got my
thermister again I can put which leg I
want to because nobody's going to force
me again because it's not what it's not
important which leg you put it in let me
just go back here get this straight
actually put it here just put it
here let me get it closer I'm going to
tell you why in a minute just going to
put it closer to the Arduino because I'm
going to need this piece right here okay
then
afterwards what I want to do is use my
normal again my normal handy again
normal resistor why is that so because
again the temperature value is going to
decide if the resistance goes low or
high okay so it's going to be very very
important for me to use what to use this
so that I don't fry my
LED okay
I did that now what I'm going to do is
what connect it to this
Edge right
here the let just get this
straight the Arduino the normal resistor
okaya all right there we go it's
connected like this I can just unplug my
adino right
here there we go got it closer so you
can have a better look of it then I have
my gnd D there we go
connect the gnd to the gnd D pin let me
just do
that all right now what do I need to do
plug in my
uino and you can see it's lighing up a
bit can you see it so basically
temperature here is what we cannot know
yet first thing now we have to do is let
me just bring another paper right here
and try to explain what is going on
okay so let me try to explain uh what is
going on right here let just get this
out of the way for now to the edge put
my photo resistor right
here right bring my Sharpie right
here and try to explain what's going on
so when it comes to thermistors as we
said earlier what did I say I said that
it's relevant to one it's going to
depend on temperature okay so there's
something called
NTC and
PTC okay so when it came to photo
resistors what did we say we said
directly if the light is what if the
light goes up the resistance value goes
down okay if the light goes down the
resistance value goes up of the photo
resistor that's what we said for photo
resistors it was what it was quite
direct and straightforward but when it
comes towards
uh uh when it comes towards thermister
there's something called ntc's and uh
ptcs n stands for negative okay n stands
for
negative T stands for
temperature Okay C stands for what C
stands for control
coefficient right here
coefficient okay again the P stands for
positive this
makes sense right now positive
temperature this stands for again
coefficient coefficient let me just get
that okay so what does this mean so when
it comes to ntcs right one thing to keep
in mind is when it comes to ntcs is that
okay when it comes to and ptcs is what
they're both affected by temperature
okay but the difference here is that
when it comes the ptcs what happens is
resistance value it increases by what by
increasing temperature okay so the
resistance value increases by what by
the amount of the temperature right here
when it comes to PTC to the NS what it
is what it's opposite so the resistance
value What in increases per decreasing
temperature so as soon as temperature
starts to decrease the resistance value
what starts to what increase again this
is what due to the material they're made
from they're made from different
materials so again in this case the
resistance goes up while temperature
goes up in this case the distance goes
up while temperature goes down again we
can put this again we can put the
inverse of this so the resistance goes
what down when the temperature goes up
we can say for this one too the
resistance what goes down when the
temperature what when the temperature
goes down okay so in this case what the
resistance and temperature have what
somewhat of a what they're directly
proportional basically they have what a
straightforward relationship while in
enes what do they do they have an
opposite they have an opposite what they
have an
opposite an opposite relationship
there's we can say R is what indirectly
proportional to what to 1 / T we can say
R is directly proportional to T for what
her positive what temperature
coefficient so so it depends on what it
depends on the on the therm we have here
it can be NTC or it can be PTC okay so
while keeping that in mind right one
thing I wanted to do here was you know
what I want to check if the temperature
goes high or low but the problem being
here is I have to use something that has
big source of heat and I don't want to
get this what close to my Arduino
because it can what it can ruin my
Arduino I don't want that to happen
that's why I'm just going to be using
the light so I'm going to be using light
I'm going to be using a normal lamp here
and this lamp heats up especially in the
back it's heat up right
now that's a
lot holds a lot of feet here there's a
lot of feet here there's a lot of feet
here and I want to do is just get it
close here so we can see if the uh if
this one changes or not if the LED
changes or not okay let me just turn off
my light this light I'm going to need
one light only let me just remove this
for now because we don't need it and now
I'm just try to turn again with the
light on what I want to do is again get
this so close to the what the ther so
that maybe we can see a
difference the what and the
LED do you see a
difference I can't let me just do
that keep trying to but I don't see any
difference barely even see any
difference there might be a difference
but it's going to be very little that we
cannot see it in our
eyes both of us
um so one thing I want you to keep in
mind right now is okay
I want do to keep in mind let me turn on
my lights right now for now just turn
this on right here and this one on one
thing I want you to keep in mind is this
thermister does not change very easily
why is that so this one specifically
again check your label specifically this
one has 10,000 amps so what has 10,000
amps the resistance is Big so it's going
to change for what for bigger
temperature Okay so I just want you to
keep this in mind again one thing I want
you to keep in mind is not about the I
want you to keep in mind is all right
right here this has 10,000 Ohm resistor
just like how the potential meter has a
total combined of 10,000 ohms again it
has 10,000 ohms 10,000 ohms of
resistance this one has a 10,000 ohm of
resistance too again I check the what I
checked the label the label has it
written out because it just says 10,000
oh next to it okay on the label
okay on the paper that I had my what my
Arduino kit just basically say it here
10,000 on it's going to go to components
right here and all I need to do is go to
the components and be like oh there we
go they have a ther right here it has
what 10,000 ohm I have two pieces of
what 10,000 ohm therms okay so this is
what 10,000 ohms which is a very very
big number so what so we cannot change
the we have to change the temperature
very very by very big numbers I'm
talking by very big numbers for us to
see a change in what in their resistance
because again why because I said again
either they're very they're related
directly or they're related to what
indirectly okay so one thing to always
keep in mind is what what one thing to
always keep in mind is
what the resistance is either directly
related or indirectly related to
temperature so right here 10,000 ohms is
a very very big number so we're get
going to have to change it by very very
big number by very very big temperature
for us to see a difference in what in
the resistance basically we're going to
have more current so we can see the
light here so we can see the LED here
just keep that in mind that's why I'm
going to need to maybe use uh uh if I
can match and sticks or something that
is so hot so that again this can change
in value but I just don't suggest that
you guys do that if you want to do it I
highly suggest that you guys use uh a
digital again those digital arduinos or
simulators again because you don't want
to get hot stuff near to your again
electricity this is not what recommended
specifically especially for kids so uh
don't do that as far as you can don't do
that all right but one thing you need to
keep in mind is what thermost always
change in what they always change
according to what temperature just keep
that in mind all right this was a bit of
a long one so um see you in the next
section
actually so um see you
then all right so now let's discuss
about U temperature s sensors so so far
we've not discussed about any sort of
sensors in this AR course so this is
going to be our first sensor that we're
actually going to talk about so let me
just bring this closer so you can again
see it so this is a temperature sensor
specifically called the
lm35 and um you might have a different
type of sensor depending on again your
Arduino kit the Arduino kit that you
have but uh first uh we're going to see
how you're going to know what type of
sensor you have so obviously the first
and the best method to know what type of
sensor you have is always again reading
the manual okay so I'm just going to
bring my manual right here my man manual
that I got my quit K Form K from and
what I'm going to do is search for the
components right here and when you read
right here it says one one piece of what
lm35 temperature sensor okay so again
depending on the kit you have you might
have a different type of uh temperature
sensor but uh most of them uh we're
going to check uh two sensors so we're
going to see we're going to check most
of them okay so even them two I'm going
to show you guys how to actually see
what typee of sensor you have and adjust
accordingly to the sensor you have okay
so first things first what I'm going to
do is try to explain what these sensors
are okay so let me go right here the LM
right now specifically what I have is
what the LM sensors the
lm35 okay the lm35 temperature sensors
but there's also one other common sensor
which is called the dth there's like a
dth series the
dth 11 for example there's something
called the
dt22 and these are one of the most
popular sensor right here so is this one
but I think this is far more popular
okay so we're going to check how the
dted sensors and these LM sensors work
okay so if you don't have those type of
sensors I highly suggest that you guys
watch a video of the sensor you have
first know the sensor you have and then
um check a video right the sensor name
and then check the video of uh check a
YouTube video on it okay that's what I
suggest before starting this temperature
sensor uh section okay so now what I'm
going to do is bring the sensor okay let
me work with the lm35 right now and the
lm35 one thing you notice is what you
order say three legs okay so you're
going to put it where the text is
there's a just Buu right here you can
see a DOT a black dot right here not
only that too but it's rounded but we're
going to go to the flat side okay the
flat side of it where is there where
there is a text we're going to connect
it that way so the the most left leg is
going to be connected to 5vt the middle
leg is going to be connected to the
analog read volt okay some analog volt
again and the right the very right of
this is going to be connected to the gnd
D okay so let me just do that I'm just
going to put it right
here me just do that try to put it
together let me just widen this a
bit I need to make this a bit wider it's
not going to fit in across I wanted to
fit it across so let me just make the
legs a b wider let me just bend them so
that they fit okay there we go thinking
how they fit
better
okay and come on
on all right not the most even one but
at least they fit okay so what I'm going
to do is connect again the 5vt to the
most left leg on the flat side
again let me just do that the most left
leg it's going to be connected to what
it's going to be connected to
the right here going to be connected to
the 5
volt
okay let do that right
here connect the 5V and the middle one
I'm going to be connecting it to what to
one analog pen that I left my choice
again let me just do
that find an analog pen I'm going to be
using analog pin maybe one today or
maybe analog pin two actually let me ose
analog pin two it's just far a bit
closer I just don't want to stretch the
wires okay and then
afterwards what do I want to do I want
to use use my gnd pen let me just do
that let just go to my gnd right
here connect that to my
gnd the
ground let me just check if everything's
intact okay the g&d is right here yeah
this is correct okay once I'm done doing
that what I'm going to do is write down
the code so let me go over to my screen
right now and let's write a bit of code
okay
okay soly open my ardino
ad right open one of this and let's set
up our code so first things first we
need to set up what our read pin okay
read pin is what today today is analog
two now we got two now what I'm going to
do is set it up right here pin mode set
it up as read pin and then is what as an
input okay because we're going to be
what reading from it okay
reading that te's not right let me just
get that and uh afterwards what do I
need to do start the serial monitor
because this is where we're going to see
what we're going to see the temperature
serial. Begin Again with what B rate
9,600 B rate there you go afterwards I'm
just going to do a
Serial print
L I'm going to what I'm going to print a
new line right here of what maybe the
read value first things first I need to
do what I need to read I need to analog
read it so
analog
read all right so obviously this is not
making sense I'm just what trying to
read the value but what we're going to
do is first is what change the red value
to what to voltage first and then we're
going to go to check the math and how to
change it to Celsius all right so let me
go to analog read in this case it's
going to be what analog read the read
pin this is going to be what it's going
to be the read the red value it's going
to be the value you're going to be
reading said like this all right then
afterwards what then afterwards we want
to say calculat value calculative value
is what the read value
you got to divide it by what 1023 I'm
actually we're going to multiply it by
what just do a 5 point right here again
you know why I put the point you can
also put zero right here because it's
going to be a float I don't want it to
like round round up or down after it's
done calculating it because then it's
going to be a zero okay 5.0 or 1023 I
can add a zero right here or not it's up
to you okay then once I'm done with this
what I'm going to need to do do is
uh go right here okay there the Cal
value calculator value okay so the
change it degree celsius first what I'm
going to need to do is go to my browser
right here and I what what I'm going to
need you to do is those people have an
lm35 by the way are the only ones that
are going to be following me in the
section if you have uh D um DHD sensors
I'm going to come back to them and
actually show you in the next section
okay so for those who only have lm35
we're going to proceed if you don't have
a DHT or have another type of sensor
again if you have another type of sensor
again watch another YouTube video there
are lots of YouTube videos again of any
sensor that you really need you're going
to find lots and lots of resources but
if you're using a DHT hand gone wait the
skip to the next section I'm going to
show you how it's done okay so when it
comes to the lf35 temperature sensor
we're going to go to it Ste the sheet
all right I want you to search us for
what LM and the corresponding number
right now I have 35 temperature sensor
and go to data sheet all right let me
just do
that and you're going to find some sort
of PDF
around Precision Cent grade information
and support just going to go here well
actually the PDF is right here say 39
Pages here so let me go here to the
PDF all right and there's on this PDF
right now the documentation of the lm35
you're going to see is what the
description and the features it has it's
can measure to what can measure look at
it rated for f from 55° C to 150° CSUS
this is what the temperature range all
right the range of temperature is what
from 55 to 150° CS so it can go a lot
okay again this is going to be different
for the type of LM that you have I have
an lm35 okay so once you're done with
that um reading this and by the way
there are lots I'm talking 69 page of
documentation but we're not going to get
into any of these because they're
Advanced all right and we don't need
them in this case but again any
information that you're going to need
you can find it here in the
documentation in the official
documentation of what the temperature
sensor okay so one thing that you should
focus here is right here you should
focus at this one I have it highlighted
there we go this one it says linear plus
10 Mt per degree Celsius scale factor so
what does it mean it's saying that the
scale factor basically is what it's
going to what it's going to Output 10 m
per every degree celsius all right so
for every degree celsius that um it
monitors again it's going to what sense
it's going to Output what for for analog
pin in the middle the blue pin the blue
wire it's going to be outputting what 10
molts okay so it's going to be
outputting 10 molts Okay so right here
let me just bring my paper right
here paper and let me bring the Sharpie
and let's try to understand what that
means let me just put this out of here
for now okay so let me just draw a line
right here and let's focus on this line
on this bace okay so what does this
basically mean h 10 molt per degree
celsi let me just write this down it
means 10 molt per de Celsius is what the
scale factor
okay I want you to focus at this what do
we want to gate we want to Output what
we want to print the what the
temperature we want to put print the
temperature so what does this mean 10 m
volt means what Millie stands for 10
the^ of minus 3 so it means 10 * 10^
ofus 3 volt per degre celsus is the
scale factor which means if you multiply
this this becomes
0.01 volt per degree Celsius is what the
scale factor all right so what a scale
factor right here let me just bring
another paper okay let me just do that
I'm running out of paper right here just
bring another one so what does the 0.01
volt per degree Celsius mean okay you
said this is what the scale factor again
scale factor is what voltage over
temperature you can see their units what
is the unit of volt voltage so what does
this mean volt over what's the unit of
degrees Celsius what is the what do we
what is U sorry degree Celsius is the
unit of what it's the unit of
temperature okay and this means V overt
is what the scale factor it means
voltage over temperature trying to find
what temperature again keep that in mind
okay so temperature is basically what
the scale factor so let's do a
crisscross temperature times the scale
factor in this case it's going to be
what the voltage all right so we're
going to divide both sides by the scale
factor okay then temperature is going to
be V over SF again what is SF SF is what
0.01 volt per degree celius the value is
what without the unit again if we just
do the unit it's
0.01 okay that's one thing I want you to
keep in mind these two temperature is
what volt over scale factor and scale
factor is what the value of scale factor
is what
0.01 volt per degre celius why do we
need to change from Mill volt to volt
because as I said again let me go over
again to my
screen because our calc value is going
to Output in what our calc value is
going to Output in volt not in molt
that's why I have to change the standard
from Mill volt to volt all right because
our Cal value our calc value was going
to put in what in voltage in V okay so
what are we going to do right here so
we're going to need to set up what we're
going to need to set up uh the what the
scale factor so what I'm going to say is
here um int scale factor actually not
int it's a float float I'm just going to
say
scale I make this very short scale F
it's going to be what it's going to be
set to
0.01 all right and then
I'm going to need what temperature I'm
going to say temperature I'm not going
to set it up yet then we already have
calc value I do not set up calc value
and read value right here as you can see
in my code I have to set it up right
here I didn't do that so that's always
what recommended to set variables first
and then what and then assign them you
can do the opposite way again some
sometimes you might forget about what
you might forget about setting it up so
I already set up uh float and temp so
let me just go right here and set up
read value so I'm going to say
float read value do I really say float
or INT in this case read value is going
to give me what a number between 0 and
1023 it's not going to give me what a
float number so obviously in this case I
can say float or I can say int it
doesn't really matter but I can say int
right here it's again makes sense for me
to say int okay so you can say int or
float but I'm going to again say float
because I'm going to be multiplying this
and working with this so it's suggested
that you say float because you don't
have to think about it when you say
float you have to think about let's say
in this case read value outputs 1023
okay if it's an integer it's going to
Output it as 1023 okay if it's a float
it's going to Output it as what it's
going to Output it as 10.3.0 which is
exactly the same thing that is a float
it's going to Output it like that which
is exactly the same thing so when you
say float you don't have to think about
the most things you don't have to think
about them okay so you can just say
float and just not think about you know
it um it uh about it being integer or
not you can just use float for almost
everything okay so after using that what
I'm going to need to do is after I'm
done with my read value okay I'm going
to need float calc value now I need the
float value because I'm going to be
multiplying and dividing all right float
calc value let me just set that up okay
once I'm done setting that up
temperature is what as we said again
temperature is what temperature is what
temperature let me just go again Point
here voltage over what scale factor so
our voltage is what the value that we're
going to be receiving right here over
the scale factor it's going to be
salecore F okay so let's print the
temperature right
here let's print the temperature let's
just do that let me just first check if
our quote is right it's saying that I'm
not put a semicolon I have to put a sem
calling after every one after every line
code let just do
that and okay it's done compiling and
first thing I need to do is what connect
my Arduino I did not do that okay let me
just do
that let me just bring that right here
and connect my Arduino just forgot to do
that okay now I can upload hopefully let
me just check if it's
connected should be showing me my port
okay just select the port and let's
upload
it it's
uploading and it's done
uploading okay we're receiving numbers
very very fast so one thing I'm going to
do right here is give it a delay forgot
to give it a delay because it's going
very very fast I can't even read it let
me go delay and let's set it for 100
milliseconds 100 milliseconds we do
actually you know what let's do 250
because it's going to be really fast I
don't want it to just go really really
fast I'm just open my ceing right here
it's going to open it
itself okay let it clear out let me just
clear this out let just say clear output
and then it should be giving me an
output just 28 so it's saying that I
have what
28.35 degrees cus by the way for those
of you are thinking you know what why
are we getting 28.3 how am I supposed to
change this to Fahrenheit or everything
why did I why why is it specifically
degre Cel why is that so again let me go
the documentation it says what from 55°
C to 150° C and the most important part
what it's saying 10 molt per degrees C
right it's saying 10 molt per degre
celsus what scale factor so basically
what we're using the what the unit
Celsius that's why I'm exactly sure that
it's using what degrees Celsius all
right so if you want to change it to
degree F all you need to do by the way
let this be homework for you so what I
want you to do is pause this uh this
course right now pause it right now and
all I wanted you to do is change the
degrees Celsius to Fahrenheit we already
gave you the degree celsius right here
which is going to be uh it's going to be
temp TMP temp I want you to do what I
want I want you to convert it to
Fahrenheit okay so pause the video and
do it right now and I'm just going to do
it right now so pause the video
all right so I think you youve done it
because I think it's simple but if you
have not done it what you need to do is
first pain the formula what is the
formula of what
temperature
Celsius to
fahren Fahrenheit formula just find that
formula right here all right there we go
temperature degreed Fahrenheit is what
temperature in degrees celsius time 9
over5 let me just go over and first what
assign a variable for Fahrenheit all
right let me just do that let's go right
here and let's say you know what float
float what float temperature and let me
just put capital F just to say it's
Fahrenheit okay so let me go right here
say temp f is basically what what did it
just say let me just go back to my
Chrome and try to read the formula right
here it's what temperature and degre
Celsius time 99 over 5 okay that's
simple temperature and degre cus given
by H right here then we're going to
multiply by what by nine again we need
to put what because we're dividing what
do we need to do we always need to use a
Point 9.0 or again 9 point again it's up
to you 9 point and put a dot at the very
end dot there we go what else do we need
to do let me just check that out and
then we're going to add it up by what by
32 okay we need to add it up by 3 32
okay I'm then to add it up by 32 so one
thing that is confusing a bit for me is
uh am I supposed to multiply both of
them by 32 I'm sorry am I am I supposed
to multiply the whole thing by 9 over5
or am I supposed to just multiply
temperature by 9 over5 and then add 32
um so to just check that let me just go
right here actually should be giving to
giving it to me on
uh actually wait let me just go to
something that was written by hand so
let me go to
images all right there we go now I can
clearly see the temperature has to be
multiplied by 9 over5 not the whole
thing you see that it's not the whole
thing that's going to be multiplied by
what by 9 over5 only the Celsius will be
multiplied by what by 9 over five all
right I just wanted to get that on my
mind right there off my mind so what I
wanted to do right here is seral and get
printed new
line temperature
F okay seems good now let's try to
upload
it oh I forgot to do what put a semic
calling at the very end I should have
done that right let's just upload it
right now should be working it's done
compiling and I think it should be
uploading all right there we go let's go
back to our ceing monitor right here let
me just extend
it we're receiving lots of values but
obviously it's getting a bit confusing
here we do not know which one is the
degree celsius and we we do not know
which one is what which one is the
degree Fahrenheit so what we're going to
do right here is you know what for
degrees Celsius let me find degrees
Celsius right here this is temp degre
Celsius what I want to do is before this
what I want to do is basically
serial. print okay next to it a string
Celsius literally Celsius basically what
Celsius let me just say c cus c as an
indicating celsus and I'm going to need
space okay let's say c for Cal and I
need to do is what
serial. print for what for Fahrenheit
one thing that is important here to
notice is what it's not print Ln it's
print so basically what happens when you
print by the way what happens when you
print something in the serial monitor
what happens let me just go over to here
my screen let's say I'm printing 25 all
right 25 is specially the degrees
Celsius let's not forget focus on the on
the value of the serial monitor Focus
here on the writing okay so 25 let's
just say that what's going to happen
here what basically going to happen is
what first C is going to be printed out
okay C and then what it's going to be
print what what is going to be printed
next to it temperature it's going to be
printed next to it basically let's say
it's 25 right here it's going to be
printed next to it that's what I expect
again so I'm going to expect this and
I'm what what do I expect text so let's
see actually if my code is even correct
because I've never used this before so
let's see if even if it's correct I keep
forgetting those semicolons at the very
end it's my bad I'm just brushing it a
bit well because I have to go back to
the DHT sensors all right come for there
we go you see that we receiving C is 27
fahan is 83 they receiving that a very
very fast speed you guys can see it
fluctuates a bit but much of the last is
the same so let's say right now I'm just
going to read one of it let me just take
off this toggle okay the automatic
toggle let me try to read this one it's
saying what 2737 de C which is basically
what
8127 degree what Fahrenheit so again I
have another homework for you and this
is again predictable but I have a simple
homework for you which is going to be
that I want you to convert it to what to
degree Kelvin and I want you to Output
what Fahrenheit Celsius Kelvin I want
you to Output Fahrenheit Celsius Kelvin
so pause the video and do that okay so I
suppose that you did it yourself but if
you've not and you want to be you know
you want to make sure that you did it
right let me just go right here what
basically uh temperature Fahrenheit is
is basically temp K let just write that
down what basically temperature at
Kelvin is just adding
273 at temperature Celsius that's all
you need to
so let me just Define it right here temp
K is going to be what it's literally
adding 270 it's going to be like 10th
plus
270 that's all you need to do all right
that's all you need to do so all you
need to do right here is again we want
to print it so we're going to say
serial do print not Ln only print and
we're going to say k again put it a
column right here finish it with the
semicolon let's say serial. println new
line and then we're going to print what
temp K capital K let me just finish this
with a semicolon right there okay and
let's upload
it okay it's saying there's an upload
eror I don't know why let me just check
it
again can't open
device let me just try to run it again
let me just compile it okay the
compiling there's no problem in
compiling so let me try to upload it so
there's most likely a problem uploading
hopefully it's not going to happen again
okay still uploading all right all right
there we go let me just clear this
up and it should be
running there we go we can see C is what
F and then a k we see a c and an f and a
k a c and an f and a k a c and an f and
a k that looks beautiful let me just go
to the bottom again I just wanted to
toggle to the bottom and if itself but
you can see it we have what c f and K
coming simultaneously all right that's
all you need to do when it comes toward
Works temperature sensor I wish that I
could bring something colder and hoer
right here so we can see the temperature
move around but mostly when it comes to
temperature it doesn't change a lot okay
and again I don't want to bring
something that's very hot or very cold
near my already we know that's why but
again you can check it for yourself
using a digital simulator try to use a
digital simulator and again try to
toggle around mess around with these
temperature sensors it's up to you okay
you can do that or use again be careful
when you're doing whatever you're doing
so if you're using something hot or cold
be careful when you're putting it close
to the um to the to the sensor okay be
close especially with the wires okay
because they can really just block your
view right here here so you need to be
close again you need to be what you need
to be cautious of what you're doing so
if you're even thinking thinking of
bringing something cold or hold to just
again check the temperature sensor be
careful about it okay so um that's about
it for the lm35 sensor and for those of
you who have again DHD we're actually
going to see the DHD sensor so uh you
guys uh I might as well uh skip the DHT
sensor because I don't think you're
going to be using it if you have an lm35
okay so for those of you again who wish
who watch this uh section are going to
be using LM the LM series The lm35 the
LM 36 and all these series okay the ones
that use the LM obviously what I want
you to do is what I want you to skip the
next section because I'm going to be
talking about DHD sensors okay so keep
that in mind so um see you in the very
next
section
okay so now let's talk about the DSD
sensors okay so one thing I want you
guys to keep in mind when it comes to
these temperature sensors is there's a
lot of them there's the TT there's the
lm35 there are even different types of
again sensors that are again unknown
okay so one thing I want you guys to
think about is what I want you to think
of them as Samsung and iPhone so when
you look at them both of them are phones
there have a lot in common but they also
have their differences so obviously they
look different again
they have different features but they do
what basically the same thing so they
what they make us you know we can use it
to what to call for example we can take
photos with it we can use apps with it
okay so one thing I want you guys to
keep in mind when it comes to
temperature sensors is there's a lot of
them with different numbers but they
have what but they are mostly the same
all right so they have again difference
in features and again difference and
again how they look and all and how
they're hooked up again and how they
work but they're what they're
essentially nevertheless they're what
they're the same more or less the same
okay so let's bre about the DFD sensor
so you're going to be searching up again
your sensors again the equivalent sensor
you have and check and check for the
what for the connection okay right here
I'm just going to demonstrate using a
DHD sensor so I'm going to go to DHT
sensor connection okay as what one of
the most popular pits so right here as
you can see let me just take let me just
zoom out so you can see the whole thing
zoom out there we go and as you can see
right here is the most left side is
connected to a digital pin right here so
you can use any digital pins right here
okay and then the middle side is connect
to 5vt and then the very right side is
connected the gnd D so one thing I want
you guys to keep in mind is what this
thing is going to be using digital read
okay so it's going to be using a digital
pins we're going to be using digital
pins not analog pins for this one okay
for reading I think most of you again
we've been using so far what we've been
using analog pins to read okay from the
what from the sensors but in this case
we're going to be using digital pins and
I'm going to explain um in a bit while
okay so right here again to make again
our lives way easier we're going to be
using a DHT sensor Library okay so
you're going to be using a DHD sensor
library that is by what by Ada of fruit
okay so all we need to do right here to
add it is go to Arduino go right here
and go to our again let me go all right
here and then search for DH sensor and
try to install the one by eat a fruit
there's a lot of DH sensor libraries so
let me search for DHD and search for Eed
fruit there we go DHD sensor Library by
Eed fruit all I need to do is install it
right here from the library manager and
it says that there has a dependency
right here okay so it needs what it
needs this a fruit unified sensor
library to be installed so if it does
not if you don't install this the code
is not going to work so let me install
it all
there we go it's both going to install
the DHD sensor library and the E fruit
there we go e fruit unified there we go
unified sensor installed both of them
okay so right here that's what we can do
but another option is again to go to our
DHD sensor Library you again Google It
Again by eat of fruit and then you're
going to find the first link all you
need to do is Google it there we go the
HD sensor library and search the Arduino
link and then all you need to do is
download the version again that you want
so if you don't want the new version you
can download the Legacy version anyways
once you're done downloading that all
you need to do is add it to go to
Arduino and then go to sketches and uh
go to include library and add it as zip
as a zip Library okay so with that in
mind we're going to be using eater fruit
so once we're done doing that we say we
go to sketches again and we go to
include library and then we go to eater
fruit again DHT sensor Library we're
going to be using the DHT sensor Library
so I'm going to touch that that's going
to include the code for us so it's going
to basically include it in if itself so
we don't even have to write it down
ourselves okay so again for those of you
who want to read the documentation it's
available on the ardino so again I
highly recommend that you guys read the
documentation after this video so I can
use it for uh more things that actually
is capable of so I'm just going to be
explaining just basic stuff okay so with
that in mind now what we need to do is
actually use this set up this library
and try to use it okay so right here
you're going to be using Define hash
Define and then type okay
DHT what DHT right here DHT 11 so you're
going to be writing down type and then
writing down the DHT specific DHT model
that you have so just like how we have
Samsung s20 S21 when it comes to iPhone
they have iPhone 11 iPhone 12 and all of
that we're going to be writing down the
specific model of the dhp the DHD pin we
have right here okay
so once I'm done doing that I'm going to
be defining what pin we're going to be
using for sensing it all right so right
here let me look to my connection let me
just search for the connection right
here and it's digital pin two that we're
using right here so let me write down
digital pin two so it's going to be
equals to what two basically and then we
write down DHT HT and then we're going
to basically what we're going to give it
the sense pin okay sense pin and then
it's going to give it giving it the type
of pen that we're going to be using Okay
so we're telling our DHD Library what
we're telling it what type of pen we're
using and then what we're telling it
what the sense spin right here is going
to be digital pin to that we're going to
be using it and then the type of what
the type of DHT sensor that we have okay
so once we're done doing that one thing
the DHD sensor is capable of is it can
also sense humidity so we're going to
actually use humidity too so we're going
to be setting up humidity right here I'm
going to be setting them as again float
because they come out in decimals so
when you hear again in degrees celsius
we say 29.6 de celsus and everything so
it's going to be again in float okay so
set it up and float and then we're going
to write down everything we're going to
be writing them down with the three what
with the temperature in Fahrenheit and
Kelvin we're going to be writing them
down in three forms all right okay so
that's it humidity temperature Celsius
Fahrenheit and Kelvin once we're done
doing that we're going to need to set up
our serial monitor because that's where
we're going to be reading our again our
degrees okay so we're going to be
reading using our serial monitor so
9,600 as usual set it up and then we're
going to begin so we're going to be
telling what we're going to be telling
our uh uh DHD sensor library to begin
okay then once we're done doing that
we're go to our Loop code right here
okay and then we're going to set up
again the the values that we just want
that we set right here so we're going to
be again uh assigning them the ones that
we just set here so let me go to
humidity and set it to we're going to
say HD that we already began right here
okay that we began right here we're
going to be say hd. read humidity okay
read
humidity and we're going to go for
temperature Celsius and we're going to
say HT what read temperature okay read
temperature you can predict this since
it's read humidity and now it's
obviously going to be read temperature
okay that's what we're going to be
basically doing when it comes to the
temperature Fahrenheit and kin what do
we do we convert temperature Celsius to
what to Fahrenheit how do we do that
obviously we use the formula so let me
search for a formula right here Celsius
to Fahrenheit formula there we go
Celsius to Fahrenheit formula is what uh
Fahrenheit is what degre Celsius * 9
over 5 +
32 okay so I go to my code right here
and then what I go to temperature
Fahrenheit and say oh I want to do is
what I want to use temperature Celsius I
want to multiply by 9 over
5 plus added with what 32 so right here
I did what I did two mistakes right here
so you guys can actually see it what is
the first mistake right here the first
mistake is what we're not using decimals
when we're defining what do we want to
do we want to use floats so we need to
put what a point or a point L okay
that's what we need to do we did not do
that that's the first mistake that I did
right here obviously if I said 9 over 5
it's going to be what I actually did 9
over five right here what is the value 9
over five it's 1.8 and it's going to
round it to what to an integer right
here it's going to be rounding it to
what to an integer so it's going to be
rounding it to an integer I don't want
it to do that I want to use it as a
float so I want it to what I want to I
want to what set it to float 9 over five
there we go what other problem do I have
here the other problem that you might
notice you might not notice right now is
that what right here ardino does not
know what are we supposed to what are we
supposed to do this first this
multiplication first or addition first
it does not know what to do okay so
we're running into another problem right
here should it do the addition or the
multiplication first if it does the
multiplication first what happens
temperature Celsius is going to be
multiplied by 9 over5 and then finally
it's going to be added by 32 but if we
add if we do the addition first what are
we saying we're saying oh 9 over 5 we're
going to add it to what we're going to
add it to 32 and then after adding it to
32 what do we do we multiply it to the
temperature Celsius okay so right here
there're going to be some confusion what
do we want to do right here let me just
again look at our code let me just look
at our formula right here it's better
that way where's our formula let me just
go back there we go can you see
it we wanted what we want to multiply it
first and then add it up okay we want to
multiply it first right here you can
even see it right here we want to
multiply it first and then we want to
add it up how do we tell our we know to
do that obviously we need to do is what
we need to put a parenthesis okay so let
me just put a parenthesis right here the
parenthesis there we go put a
parenthesis all of this so I want uino
to do what I wanted to do it together I
wanted to divide it first and then I
wanted to what I wanted to add 32 as a
whole okay then how do we go to
temperature Kelvin when it comes to
temperature Kelvin what do we need to do
all we need to do is add
273 from temperature Celsius that's all
we need to do when it to Kelvin it's
very very easy okay once we're done
doing that actually it's better to use
what again it's better to use float
numbers again we're using a float number
here so it's technically best to use
float numbers here too okay instead of
using integers okay then what do we need
to do that's all we need to do that's
all we need to do so we found the
temperature Celsius Fahrenheit and
Kelvin we extracted those information
already okay so right here what we need
to do is what all we need to do is print
it out how do we print it out we see
temperature Celsius why are we writing
temperature Celsius you might be asking
me why are we writing it down well we're
going to be receiving three values
simultaneously so we do not know which
one's which so it's going to act as our
like it's going to act as if it's an
indicator okay so temperature Celsius
the string of temperature Celsius that's
written down as temperature Celsius is
going to what it's going to tell what
it's going to be written next to what
our what it's going to be written to
next to uh temperature the temperature
Celsius value right here so we're going
to know which one's which okay so when
we read uh the value right here we're
going to have three values coming in at
once so we're going to know which one's
which okay so I wanted to print
temperature
Celsius so I put again U an end right
here because they're written down I put
a I put a a space right here why is that
that I put a space right here I put a
space right here because I I'm using
what serial.print okay what happens when
to use serial. print they're going to be
written down in a what in a in a one
line and it's going to be written down
next to each other okay so temperature
SE is going to be here and the value
after the space is going to be what the
value is going to be displayed but right
here one thing I want to do is what I
want to add it in a new line afterwards
okay I want to add it in what in a new
line after it's done doing that I want
it to be in a new line and then I want
it to print again Fahrenheit and then
Kelvin so let me just do that print and
then set temperature Kelvin that's all I
need to do it's almost copying code
right now temperature Kelvin actually
wait let me do temperature Fahrenheit
first because I set it up like that so
be more fair to do it this way and then
write down temperature
Fahrenheit what do I need to do
afterwards uh temperature
Kelvin and and then print it a new line
again temperature what the Kelvin
temperature and then it's best to give
it what a delay after reading it so you
can again give it a delay and set up a
delay time right here let me set up a
delay time let's say U integer delay
time let me set it up right here and set
it to let's say uh for us to read it
let's say 300 milliseconds so we can
read it properly and put a delay of 300
milliseconds okay that's all we need to
do so right here again all of this code
again is pre-written for us and it's
already what the library covers
everything for us so all we need to do
is not even understand how even the the
DHD sensors work so let me go back to uh
that's all we need to do actually let me
just upload this let's see if it if it
compiles
properly expected what expected
uh what what is this
saying it's saying expected oh um
parenthesis before these tokens oh yeah
I'm not using anything here did I do
anything wrong saying that I should use
a maybe it's saying that I should use a
semicolon at the end but I don't think
that makes sense it's going to even give
me an error right here and it just going
through an error right now because I
don't have my Arduino but for those of
you again who have your Arduino and you
hooked it up and all it's going to be
perfectly working fine all right so just
keep that in mind okay so one thing I
want you guys to keep in mind is right
now it's going to be working perfectly
fine for you guys for those of you have
a DHT sensor one thing I want you guys
to keep in mind is when you're using DHT
sensor says let me go to my connection
right here and one thing the DHD sensor
does is it sends out signals of zeros
and ones really really fast I'm talking
zero ones zero ones it's going to be
sending out what bits of zeros and ones
it's going to be basically saying zero
means what zero means off and ones means
on so it's going to be sending that very
very fast it's going to be sending it in
milliseconds okay so it's going to be
sending um what a series of zeros and
ones zeros and on zeros and on zeros and
ones it's going to be sending that okay
it's going to be sending it through the
what through the again the the yellow
wire right here which leads to what
digital pin two so it's going to be
sending what again it's going to be
sending U zeros and ones zeros and ones
and then our Arduino is going to be
interpreting that all right it's going
to be interpreting that it's going to be
interpreting the zeros and ones okay so
it's going to either output zero and one
so it's going to be interpreting that
and then it's going to what it's going
to again write it down and print it to
our what to our serial monitor okay
obviously we cannot see uh we're using
zeros and ones how do we um read zeros
and ones in Arduino how do we do that we
use analog week right because analog
read lets us use any value from 0 to
1023 so when you're reading something we
use what we use analog read okay but
obviously we're using what we're using
Library so again it's going to be the
library is going to be the one that's
going to be doing the analog read right
here okay that's one thing I want you
guys to keep in mind so why do we use
that digital pins instead of analog pins
so let me go right here and I think
let's go with something more familiar
with you guys so let me go all the way
here and let me try to explain uh this
right here here so when it comes to if
you remember digital right what values
did it give us what was the outcome of
digital right it was either High which
basically meant what it basically meant
5 Vol or on right when it came when the
other option is what the other option
was what the other option was write it
down properly it was low what did it
mean just the write low meant what it
meant Zero Volt or basically what off
basically meant off so there's like two
outcomes to what to distal
similarly as we have digital right and U
we have digital right right here have
digital right and then we have analog
right we have analog right okay we do
have both of them and we also have as we
have analog read to we're familiar with
analog read we also have something
called digital read okay so what does
digital read do digital re what it
basically does is you can read the
documentation for yourself but it's
going to what it's going to give us what
information right here so this what does
is what it tells us if it's either what
if it's either zero or one it's going to
be telling us if it's either zero or one
what does this mean it's going to it's
going to be telling us if it's zero it
means off or if it's on when it's one
okay so it's going to be telling us that
so it's going to be telling us if it's
on or off on or off that's what
basically digital read does when it
comes to the analog read one thing that
again why you shouldn't be using analog
pin is we have 10 bits of information
that is being transferred 10 bits is a
what it's a bigger number it's more
options again it's useful again but
right here it's not because as I said
again our again our we know our U there
we go our DHD sensor always send zeros
and ones bunch of zeros and ones really
really fast okay so it's going to be
either zero or one that's going to be
sending but it's going to be sending it
very very fast and then the Arduino is
going to be interpreting that okay so
the number of zeros and ones again
inside of again the full information is
going to be affecting uh again it's
going to be tell telling us uh our
temperature so right here it's going to
be sending out 10 bits of information so
what happens here is there's what it
gives us value between 0 and 1023 gives
us lots of options but what happens here
the limitation right here is what
basically what happens is what we only
want zero and one we only want what zero
and one because again as I said again
our what our DHD sensors are only going
to be using zero and one they're also
they're always going to be outputting
what zero or one on or off okay so
they're not going to using this rest of
the value right here from 1023 anything
from what they're not going to be using
anything from 2 to 1023 okay so it's
going to be 10 bits of information
always being sent out to what to the
Arduino 10 bits of information being set
out to the Arduino what is zero and 10
bits zero and 10 bits is what you have
to write it down 10 times it's basically
what 0 0 000000 0 0 write it down 10
times what is one in 10 bits one is what
one one one one one one one one write
down 10 times I have to write it down 10
times I don't think I down 10 times but
the important thing is it's going to be
written down in 10 bits okay so when it
comes to the digital read right here we
only need what we only receive zero or
one so it's going to be sending it in
one information when we have one bit
what is the one bit of zero it's zero
and if itself what is the one bit of one
it's one what's the one bit of two it
doesn't exist it can only count up to
what it can only count between zero and
one okay so that's one thing I want you
guys to keep in mind so right here it's
more efficient because it only sends out
what it sends out little bits of
information it sends out one bit
compared to the what compare to the
analog so right here the analog is going
to be sending out 10 bits again and it's
going to compound okay so it's going to
be sending out 0 0 z0 again one one one
so one thing I want you guys to think
about when it comes to bits is like how
we have conversations okay so 10 bits
what can it do when it comes 10 bits 10
bits again allow us to what to access
different amount of numbers lots of
numbers numbers just like just think of
me saying hey how are you and just think
of it as being 10 bit okay hey how are
you is what 10 bit and think of high
it's what it's just think of it as one
bit okay which one is faster to say high
is faster to say why is that so we're
transferring a smaller amount of
information okay we're we're
transferring what smaller amount of
information right here so it's faster so
the problem here is what the problem
with analog readers it transfers 10 bit
okay it transfers 10 bit and it's going
to be what it's going to be slower when
it when it's compared to the what to the
digital read that's why it's preferred
to what to use digital uh digital pins
when it comes to this again dstd sensors
I want you guys to keep that in mind yes
you can use analog pins but it's going
to be what less accurate and then also
you risk what you also risk it being
slower but when it comes to the digital
pins we only transfer again one bit of
information so it's going to be really
really fast because the again RDH sensor
is going to be sending out zero zos and
ones and digital read is going to be
very very fast again when it comes to
what when it comes to the digital pins
so just keep that in mind anyways with
that in mind uh everything should be
working perfectly fine for you guys for
those of you who have it it's going to
work perfectly fine and you can upload
the code and you can work with it
anyways with that in mind uh let's move
on to the next
section in this section we're going to
discuss about switches so this is going
to be a very quick and a very short
section but it's going to be an
important section because we're going to
be discussing one of the most important
parts and one of the most common
components that we use in an Arduino not
only in Arduino but in our lives okay so
today we're going to be discussing about
switches okay so switches they look
something like this they have a button
right here that you can push okay and we
have four legs they come in different
sizes this is a big switch the same type
of switch and this is the same type of
switch but it's obvious obvously smaller
we need to do a side by-side comparison
okay so one thing we need to understand
about switches is they're fundamentally
very very easy they're fundamentally
speaking they're very very simple okay
so before discussing about you know all
these switches and stuff I'm going to
get back to this we're doing that I
think it's best if I discuss about
current right here because it makes
sense to do
so because switches are used to do what
switches are used to uh to turn on or
turn off something so turn on and turn
off a circuit all right so let me go
right here and let's just again create a
simple
circuit okay do
that this is what almost a complete
circuit why is that so why is this a
complete circuit because the positive
terminal goes and it touches what the
negative terminal it's a complete
circuit How about if it was like
this what happens if it was like
this what happens if there is an opening
between what the circuit right here
between the circuit what's going to
happen in this case obviously what's
going to happen current is going to Flow
by the way don't corre connect it direct
don't connect your obviously positive
towards the negative because we have no
resistor here so going to FR Ado but
again this is just for concept so
current is going to
flow all else is going to happen
electrons will flow too if current is
Flowing electrons are flowing again
currents flow from what position to what
position they flow from the positive to
the negative what about electrons they
flow from the negative to the positive
they have what opposite directions they
flow in opposite directions okay so
obviously you know by now that electron
flow is what generates current
I just want you to understand that just
keep that in mind okay but what happens
here let's say electrons are again
moving from the negative terminal
electrons are moving they're moving
they're moving they're moving here
they're moving and they stop here
because they cannot cross this boundary
then what happens here electron cannot
move the whole way so basically what's
going to happen there will be no current
flow so current will not flow because
what happens because the electron cannot
flow from what from the negative
terminal to the positive terminal so
basically no current flow because of why
because electron can't flow because
electron can flow in this circuit okay
so this basically the same concept that
we're going to be using in switches so
switches when we turn them on they make
it so that we can again flow electricity
can flow can you see it electricity can
flow but when we turn it off what do we
expect we make it so that electrons
cannot flow indirectly will not have
what and will not have any current okay
so right here let me just move
this so let me just bring the switch
right here and one thing you want to
look in these switches is again let me
just focus on the switch right now okay
there we go one thing you want to focus
on the switches is there are closed
sites can you see this there are close
sights here there are close sits here
too and there are ones that are what
they're connected to even par they're
connected in this direction okay they're
connected in this direction so one thing
I always want you to keep in mind is the
ones that are U the ones that are facing
opposite the ones that are parallel to
each other are always connected I want
you to keep this in mind they're con
they're always connected either when you
either when you push it or don't they're
always connected okay they're always
what they're always connected okay when
it comes towards um these these ones
that are connected Ed by what they're on
the same side so I want you to see the
pins that are attached to what the same
side when it comes to those pins what
happens is there are what there are I'm
just going to put this here there is a
wire okay so there's a wire that's going
to move it's a wire that is what that
moves okay so right here when you push
down okay when it comes to these buttons
when you push down what happens is want
you do again pay attention is when you
push down what happens is these wi
attach basically when they attach what
happens current What flows okay
basically when you don't touch it
anymore by the way when you just leave
it like this what's going to happen it's
going to be open can you see this so
electricity cannot flow from here to
here but as soon as you push it down
what's going to happen as soon as you
push it down the wi is going to go down
you're going to push the wire down right
here basically what creating what
creating a complete circuit this case
current will flow okay so that's all you
need to know to start with these but one
thing I want you to keep in mind is this
okay when you look at the smaller uh uh
push buttons when you look at them
spring them here when you look at them
it's really hard to distinguish it's
really hard to distinguish which side is
which am I supposed to put it like this
like in this way let me just actually
Focus this way better let me actually
put it like this it's better that way
way all right there we go am I supposed
to put this like this you know how am I
supposed to know which one is connected
like this which one have this type of
connection and which one has this type
of connection because it's really hard
because they're symmetric when you look
at them they're symmetric from both
directions they're at the very edge and
you don't know which one's which so
always what you need to look for is what
you need to look for a side that have
two pins let me just let me Focus right
here you always want to look for a side
that has what
a side that has two pins that are
connected so we're going to look at one
single side here and they're what
they're connected to the what to the
same what to the same side all right so
these two pins are connected to what the
same side so you want to look at these
these ones are the ones that where the
switching is going to occur I want you
to keep that in mind these sides are
what the ones where switching occurs
when you look at these side when you
compare this one with this one we just
bring it open here
wait it's not focusing my bad okay there
we go when we bring this one and this
one okay these ones they're parallel I
want you to keep that in mind because
why they're opposite they're not
connected to the same side okay so the
ones that are not connected to the same
side what happens though the ones that
are not connected to the same side the
focus is really
bad oh my this is really bad Focus all
right what happens to the ones that have
um that are connected to the opposite
side okay I want you to look at the
parallel sides so this side is right
here there's a parallel side right here
so the ones that are connected to
parallel sides are connected in this way
they're always connected okay either you
push up or push down they're always
connected okay so so when it comes to
the ones that are attached to the same
side what is what happens they're
connected in the in the matter for is is
connected in a condition if you push the
button it's connected if you don't push
the button it's not connected the ones
that are facing the same side okay the
same goes for this one to so I want you
guys to again to use the side metaphor
instead of uh using the ones that are
far apart because in this one everything
is when you look at the small one I'm
sping the small switch when it comes to
the small switch everything is what
everything is equally distant okay it's
a square side has a square shape so
everything is going to be what
equivalently distant so again look at
the side so the ones that are connected
to what the ones that are on the same
side the same the pen that are on the
same side have what they're going to be
the ones where switching is going to
occur the ones that are connected parall
in the opposite side basically and
parallel sides are going to be what are
going to be the ones that are always
connected either you push up or push
down they're always connected I think
it's going to make more sense when I
just bring my Arenal right here
okay so let me just bring this right
here
okay and let me just unplug my adreno
for now
let's just put this to the side so that
you guys could actually reference it
just put this to the very edge okay so
let me bring my ardina right here how am
I supposed to connect this I'm supposed
to connect the ones that have the same
side again the pins that are on the same
side okay the pins that are on the same
side how do I want to connect them I
want to connect them across I don't want
them to be together if that if they are
together obviously what switching cannot
occur so I want them to be in what
opposite what in opposite obviously in
opposite rows right here I want them to
be in different rows okay so I'm just
going to push it in as much as I can I'm
going to put this across too because it
makes more sense uh to put it across I'm
just going to try
to right there we go least a bit of a
push all right there we go now it's uh
now it's plugged in all right so right
here let me just bring
my my red pin and connect it to a 5vt
what I'm going to do is build a simple
LED circuit but in this time what's
going to happen I'm going to be using a
switch to turn the LED on and off okay
so I'm again I'm going to put this on
the first what on the first one on the
first leg did that now I'm going to need
a
resistor where am I going to connect the
resistor because I want switching to
occur I'm going to connect it to the
what to the second leg right here second
legs right here we have to disconnected
just do that oh
righty okay there we go the second leg
is connected to the resistor and then I
have my obviously LED light let me just
bring
that just bring my LED light there we go
LED light is connected right here to the
what to the leg of resistor right here
you can see it and then obviously I'm
going to need my g& D my what my ground
pin let me just get it right here and
connect it to the gnd D let me just make
sure that I'm connected to the gnd D I
don't want to get it
wrong there we go to the g&d okay so now
what I have to do is what plug in my
arino let me just do
that all
right seems to be
working okay thir window knows
on uh let me just check my resistor if
it's okay okay let me just push on the
button right now and let's see if it's
going to turn on or off
okay there we go it's turning on as you
can see it it's turning on but as soon
as I let go look at what happens I just
I just touched it once let me just touch
it once as soon as I let it go it turns
off so one thing you need to understand
here
is these buttons that I have right now
they're called where's my Sharpie right
here there we go there's my Sharpie all
right they're
called push
buttons push buttons okay push switches
basically they're switches that what
they're push buttons or switches how
about the one that we use mostly we use
is called a
toggle toggle
switch
okay so right here when it comes to push
buttons the name gives you a push button
I just want you to think of it as a push
door okay as soon as you like go of a
push door what happen happens it goes
back to what to its original position
okay as soon as you let go all right
when it comes towards uh the doors we
have at home and stuff if you don't
again put excess amount of force what
happens is if you just put it in the
middle it's going to stay in the middle
if you just leave it there if you just
again push it and then you leave it at a
position it's going to stay there it's
not going to move in of itself it's not
going to what close by itself just like
how again push uh push doors do
okay so I want you to keep that in mind
when it comes to push buttons you always
have to push okay for it to what for it
to right here let me bring my
paper for it to always what for it to
always connect you always have to push
to what for it to always put down this
wire right here okay this connecting
wire right here so that what it switches
switches on okay so you always have to
push when it comes to toggle switches
the ones that we have at home what you
have to do is what you only touch it
once and you turn it on that's it that's
all you need to do but again touch it
again and what it's going to turn off
those are what toggle switches so right
here we're going to be using what push
switches or push buttons here okay so we
have push buttons so as long as soon as
you let go of again as soon as you let
go of the switch or the button what
happens it turns off okay there we go so
let me just bring this here and let me
try to connect it to the one that is
parallel right here let me just try to
do that so let me bring my resistor
right here just pull it out you've seen
that it works the switching works when
we're using what when we're using the
pins that are on the what the legs that
are on the same side let me just try to
connecting try to connect the ones that
are parallel okay let me just do
that again let me just unplug my ardino
because again it's better to what to
always unplug your ardino work on your
again physical project and then plug it
back in okay let me just do do that let
me connect my led to the leg of the
resistor
okay and I need to connect my what my
gnd okay everything seems to be good and
everything should be running by now let
me plug
it okay my resistant is is the one that
is causing the problem let me just go
here push it okay this leg is not pushed
let me just push it to push it really
hard oh okay I have to push it really
hard okay wait let me just get my
resistor let me let me fix my resistor
right
here think the resistor that's causing
the problem I think it is as soon as I
push it back in it's going to work you
just go over
here push my resistor Jesus keeps
bending the leg keeps
bending wait I need to straighten this
out first let me straight it out all
right connect it right here come
on is the resistor connected
properly uh yeah I think it is but okay
the resistor is a bit coiled I'm going
have to fix this let me just get another
resistor let we just do that okay there
we go makes our life way way easier okay
I got another resistor right here let me
just plug it back
in plug it here plug the other one here
and there we go I'm not touching it I'm
not pushing it switching is not working
here because why as I said again they're
always what they're always connected
they're always connected even either I
push down right here it doesn't change
the result see I'm pushing on the Buton
right now I'm pushing on the switch but
it doesn't change the result okay so one
thing you always need to keep in mind is
what the ones that are parallel again
the ones that are facing parallel to
each other are always connected
regardless of them being pushed or not
okay but when it comes to the again the
ones that are on the same side what
happens is again again we have to push
to what to basically connect them so
this is where the switching occurs all
right let's just do this um using the
smaller pen right here let me just do
smaller one I have not used that but
before doing that actually I have a
really really a good question okay let
me just unplug this right now what I
want you to do
is I'm going to put this all right as
you can see I'm going to put this this
at this third leg right now they're not
parallel they're more of diagonal I'm
just going to put this one connect it to
this okay I'm going to keep connecting
it to what to this one the one that is
right here to the leg that is right here
what do you suppose is going to
happen let me just go right
here what do you suppose is going to
happen right here I mean I'm connecting
this one to what to this connect the
first one to this one they're more of
diagonal all right let me I have to
adjust my aduino again because I touched
the resistor there we go the g&d is back
here let's see what
happens what do you think is going to
happen though it's the real question
okay so I'm just connecting my arino so
let me just show you what happens right
now you might be wondering why is this
working as a switch we just said that
you know the ones that are on the same
side are the only ones that work as of
what the where the switching occurs so
you might be wondering what is going on
well the simple answer is what as I said
again these the first one and the second
one let me just again bring my adino
closer right here so that I can explain
it let me point at it using maybe a pen
okay these arinos are what these sides
are connected as we said again the first
let me just bring my just take out the
wire for now let me just push it right
here the first two are always connected
as I said again the first two are always
what they're always connected as I said
again they're always what they're always
connected all right so they're always
connected so this side is always
connected to this side so this side and
this side is going to be what directly
connected and what did I say this side
and this side basically this side and
this side this side and this side
basically this and this the ones that
are that are on the same side are what
they're connected if you what if you
push down again this is where the
switching occurs so they're connected
when you push down so what happens here
this is always directly connected and
then when you push down this also
becomes connected so you see it moves
the electricity moves from here to here
which is always connected just again
pull the wires right here it's always
connected from here to here and then
what happens and then when you switch
down this and this is connected so
indirectly what happens this and the
resistor the 5V the red wire again this
and this become what indirectly
connected so again I just want you to
keep that in mind all right so one final
thing is before moving on um on this
section is this is a bit confusing for
people again as I said I don't want them
to be confused so let me just unplug
everything switch is really hard to get
off right there we go took me a while
okay it's a bit confusing for people and
had even had to do a lot of research
before even making this course because
it's a bit confusing okay so one thing
again as I said is what we're going to
always look for sides okay so the same
side we're going to be looking wait let
me just focus here the same side we're
going to be looking for the same side so
they're always what they're always
connected to what they're always
connected let me just focus again
they're always connected to what in the
condition that we push this is where the
switching occurs again so I have to
connect them in what I have to put them
in a way where the same sides are what
they're in opposite what they're
opposite rows they're in what in
different rows okay let me just do that
let just put this in the middle around
here connect that push it again you have
to push by the way these buttons they
take a lot of effort and you have to
push them just make sure that you don't
break them okay there we go just do it
gently okay now I can do is what connect
my
arino what is the all right let me just
go here actually connect the 5V right
here right now what do I need to do my
resistor let me bring my handy resistor
here and I need to do is put it what
across again I'm going to put it right
here across and what do I need to check
that you know obviously the current is
moving or not LEDs we're going to be
using our handy LEDs and then we're
going to be obviously using the gnd D
we're going to be connecting to the what
to the gnd D right here here so I need
to do connect this to the what to the G
and
D okay so now switching should
occur there we go as soon as we push
again what happens as soon as we push it
starts to turn on but as soon as we let
go it turns off this is where again
where what happens the switching occurs
so the same goes for this one too it's
EX the same thing all right the switches
are exactly the same push button
switches but the only difference is what
their size and again their leg placement
okay so if you always look for the sides
again don't look for the ones that are
far again far and uh closer don't use
that reference because this one does not
work here because this one is a square
okay so there's nothing called far or uh
close because they're equally distanced
all right so you always have to look for
what for the pins that are on the same
side when they're on the same side this
is where the switching occurs and when
they're what where when they're on the
parallel side what this is what they're
always what they're always connected
either even you push it up or don't push
so just keep that in mind before uh
moving on all right that's all when it
comes to switches so um see you in the
next
section okay so in this section we're
going to discuss about LEDs we worked
with LEDs we've put lots of LEDs in our
project
but we're going to be discussing about a
special type of LED so we've worked with
u the the red LED the most but we also
worked with what with the green LED and
also the yellow LED we working on the
traffic light project as you
remember right here the important thing
I want you guys to know is all right
let's say we have a green LED right here
I have a green LED right here all right
that's good what if I want a pink LED
what if I want a purple LED I have to
specifically buy what an LED that is
purple I have to specifically buy an LED
that is pink if I want the pink LED that
creates what a problem okay so how do I
get any color that I want in an LED this
is where RGB LEDs come to place okay
they are called RGB LEDs and if you want
to find them in your kit one thing you
have to look for is that they have four
legs okay they have four legs let me
just focus here they have four legs not
only that too but even the third leg
right here the third leg is a bit longer
okay I'm going to get to why it's longer
but there's a third leg right here that
is longer so we have to look for
something that has four legs and looks
like an LED it has to be clear okay
doesn't have any color just like how
these LEDs used to it's going to be
clear okay so what are these RGB LEDs
before getting into that I really want
you to understand the science between
color right so we have to understand we
have to understand the basics of colors
so that we understand how does this RGB
LED work okay how does this r GB LED
work okay so to do that let's discuss
about something very very uh very very
basic okay so I think most of us by now
have learned that um the the three
primary colors are what red yellow and
blue if I'm correct we've learned that
the three primary colors are what red
yellow and blue all right right here
though we're not going to be using red
yellow and blue so basically obviously
what does this mean these three primary
colors they can combine to create any
color that you want want any color that
you think of yellow and blue together
gives us green red and yellow together
gives us uh it gives us orange red and
blue gives us what red and blue gives us
um purple and even you know even putting
less red and putting more blue is going
to give us more per bluish looking type
of purple you know and it keeps going on
so the list keeps going on so we can
find any color that we want from black
to white to purple to any color that
you're thinking of can be made from what
from the combination of what these three
primary colors okay but we can also do
it using another color instead of yellow
instead of yellow we can also do the
same thing by using green by using red
green and blue we can literally create
the same thing when we connect red and
green what do you think
happens when we connect red and green to
be honest I really do not know when it
comes to red and blue obviously what
happens is it's uh it's again purple
when it comes to green and BL uh it
becomes sent I don't know what happens
when you connect red and green I don't
remember I really don't remember but
anyways the main thing is it exactly
does the exact same thing that we just
mentioned here it can create any type of
color can create any type of color that
you're thinking of again with red green
and blue they can be what primary colors
so you might be
wondering okay which one are we going to
use when we're working with this LED and
even with computer
so let me just go over right here they
are known this red yellow blue are known
as subtractive subtractive colors why is
that so so I want you go I'm just going
to go over to my screen and try to
explain it in a simple way okay so I
think most of us know what a prism is
okay so what does a prism do it
basically what it basically converts the
sunlight again right here that comes
from the left side to what to a rainbow
okay so what does it do it separates
light it separates it into different
wavelengths or different colors so that
you can see each individual each
individual what each individual uh color
that makes what that makes the sunlight
right here the sun okay so one thing I
want you to understand here is that it's
called subtractive for a reason what
happens is what it is created by what by
subtracting so what basically happens
what it's created by what by subtracting
wavelength of light so basically what
it's basically created from what by
splitting light okay by splitting light
that's what happens when we're using a
prison basically our day-to-day life
when it comes to our day-to-day life
obviously we gain light from what from
the Sun so almost everything that we're
going to be using is what it's going to
be red yellow and blue made from these
three all right because again it's going
to be separated and then what happens
and then when it's separated again we
can see colors all right different types
of colors okay then when it comes to the
Computer World though there is a problem
we use something called RGB even the
name of this led right here it's known
as RGB LED it's known as what RGB LED
let me get to why we use RGB instead of
R YB and what in our computers so the
problem here is instead of separating
light okay when it comes towards
subtractive uh sorry subtractive colors
they have to first gain light and they
set separated so they gain light from
the Sun what do they do they separate it
okay they separate into different
wavelengths or basically different
colors of light okay when it comes to
additive though why do we use additive
in computers is we don't use the
sunlight that's the problem our
computers do not use sunlight where do
they harvest energy they harvest energy
from what from electricity basically
when we charge our phone when we charge
our computer when we charge obviously
our devices so right here we're changing
elect energy to what electrical energy
into what into light energy this is very
very important so we're not what we're
not we're not going to be using a a
light and then separating it we're not
going to be gaining light from somewhere
and then separating it obviously when it
comes to our devices they don't what we
don't use uh we don't use sunlight
obviously to charge our devices that's
why we don't use subtractive subtractive
color obviously so right here we're
going to be using additive colors
additive colors is literally the
opposite of what I said subtractive when
I said subtractive what do you do we
split so basically when it comes to RGB
what do we do we combine you see that we
combine these W legs of light to create
any light we want so we're going to what
we're going to combine them that's the
very very important thing we're going to
combine them and when we combine them
what what happens we're going to be
creating every color that we want again
so we can find again R YB and RGB the
fundamental difference between them is
what is again this separating and this
one what adding light okay this what
blending light okay and it's very very
again important what in computers we're
going to be using RGB okay all right so
with that in mind we have to first uh
try to actually work with the LED first
so let's try to understand this led
right now and we're going to go and
understand how the inner parts work okay
so when you look at the Led it has four
legs as I said again one leg is always
what the third leg is always longer than
the three legs so the fourth leg right
here let me just bring it right here
think let me just focus it all right let
it Focus the fourth leg as we can see
right here let me start from the first
one the first the what the most left leg
basically the first one is what it's
going to be blue okay and the second one
is going to be green the third one is
going to be connected to the gnd D pen
and the fourth one is going to be
connected to what it's basically the R
light okay that's what I want you to
think of them okay so one thing you also
need to keep in mind is okay this is
going to be let's say a light
compartment right here there's a blue
light compartment and there's a green
light compartment right here okay so
basically what happens I said again when
the red turns on for example the red is
on and the blue is on what happens we
get a purple okay because it's again an
additive we have to add up together we
add up lights okay when you add red and
blue what happens we get purple right
here so let's say it's it's just
basically what turning on red LED and
the blue LED what blue LED when you turn
it them on it's purple so I want you to
think of them as combining three LEDs
combining red green blue LEDs into one
LED okay just think of them as combining
three LEDs into one LED and fitting them
in this spce okay that's what I want you
to think of them okay so it's going to
be interesting is actually let me just
put this again
across it's going to be more
interesting if we learn as we go it's
better that way so you guys can actually
retain the information okay let me just
open this I need to pry it a bit open
because it's not going to fit across if
I don't do that all right that's better
right I have to just keep track of it
the third leg let me just again focus on
this one I'm just going to keep it like
this the third leg is going to be here
here the G and D you need to make sure
which leg you're putting okay this is
the first one is what the blue the the
most left one the second one is green
the third one is gnd D and the fourth
one is what the fourth one is R all
right that's how I set it up right now
so you might be wondering okay what is
is all this RGB how am I supposed to you
know find yellow because right now I've
only talked about purple maybe creating
a Canan right here but I've not talked
about you know finding any color so let
me go over to my screen right now let
just do that and what I want you to
Google is say color code or color pick
say Color
Picker and even Google has this so all
you need to do is basically choose any
color you want in this case let me just
choose green for example let me just say
the the most green thing let me just go
to the most green one just choose
that this is not the mo screen this
looks the more screen almost we cannot
see the difference right here
okay okay this is the most screen one
because it only has green right here the
green one is the only one that's on this
one is all off as you can see this is
off and this is the red one is off
anyway so you can just choose any Color
Picker right here and find the value
here and you can understand the value so
you guys do not need to you know
memorize anything so you might be
wondering instead of why are we supposed
to you know call them RGB why not just
say you know we can just say you know if
you want pink why not use the keyword
pink if you want you know purple why not
use the keyword purple you know doesn't
that make more sense you know because
it's going to be easier it's more easier
and you would have to create a whole new
system for naming what for naming lights
you know doesn't that make more sense I
mean it looks like it makes more sense
right but the problem arises here the
problem arises is we have different
combinations of colors I'm talking
Millions to Millions combination of
colors that even provides Us in what
when it comes to the amount of colors we
can even see so for example let's say I
want the shade of uh the shade of pink I
just I just say I call it let's say I
call it pink 55 okay I just called it
pink 55 all right I just give it a name
Pink 55 then let's say I move it a bit
and I want it to be a bit darker okay I
have to call this pink 56 let me just
say okay let me just call this pink 56
all right let me go right here pink 57
uh Pink 58 you can see that when we keep
naming it and naming it and naming it
it's going to be what it's a lot you can
see that right you can see that we
cannot name millions of what Millions
upon millions of color combinations
because why it's going to be infinite
the possibilities are what the
possibilities are a lot so it's better
to what to have a system and basically
what direct ourselves it's like uh I
just want you to think of just just
using a simple analogy let me just
create a paper right here okay let me
just get a paper right here and let me
just explain to you why RGB is important
why having a system of what using naming
colors is important let's just say you
know what you have to hold 1 + 1 is what
two okay you have to remember this all
you do is remember this you're not going
to go through the math or anything 1
plus one is what is true we have to
catch this in our mind okay two 2+ 1 is
what three uh okay 4 + uh five is what
let let's just say nine
um what 10 + 10 is what 20 all right
just keeps going 50 plus 50 is what
100 okay and let me just say 1+ 3 is
what 4 1 + 5 is what 6 1 + 7 is what
eight so the problem is here what let's
say I want to understand how to add up
to a million let's just say I want to
know how to even add up to 100 let's
just say that all right I want to catch
all the numbers up to 100 let's say 1+ 1
is you know two okay 2+ 1 is three I
have to hold what almost 100 digits to
even what to even count up to 100 okay
but if I learn the basics of addition if
I learn the basics of addition I can
even add millions of numbers right here
one 2 3 four five six seven I can just
add this up just takes a bit of more
time but I can just technically add it
up I want to add it with 1 million right
here instead of memorizing it what do I
need to do all I need to do is add it up
the answer is going to be
2,234 obviously 5 6
7 so basically what mathematics 2 is
also what is a system as you can see
right here instead of memorizing it what
do we do we create a system so basically
once we create a system it makes what we
can count almost infinitely almost
infinitely as in you know obviously we
can't count to Infinity but we can do
what we can do almost anything that's
why instead of you know naming it just
think of naming Millions upon millions
of again color combination okay just
think of naming over millions of
millions of color combination we're
going to do is what we're going to
create a system of naming it and then
what do we need to do all we need to do
is go to our Color Picker and then what
we can choose our specific color you see
that right so we can just think of even
thousands upon thousands shades of pink
right here so right here let me just go
right here okay what I'm going to do is
move it right here it's right here moved
all right let me just wait my my
it's glitching out it's glitching out
what happened to my computer oh Jesus I
don't want it to glitch out all right
come on let me just close this
tab what is wrong with it okay my my
computer is glitching out for some
reason let me just turn off
CH it just takes a lot upon lot of
uh okay come
on okay it's opening other stuff oh my
God what's going
on let me just ignore my computer for
now and let me just go over to uh let me
just go over to this again so that's why
it's very very important to do what it's
very very important to have a system of
what naming colors because there's going
to be Millions upon millions of
combinations okay so with that in mind
we're going to be using one of the most
popular naming methods all right one of
the most popular what color system
methods okay the color methods and this
one are RGB there is something else
called heximal and I think uh some
people might know it if you're familiar
with coding and stuff but we're going to
be using RGB today okay in case it makes
sense because this is again as I said
the LED is an RGB LED it makes sense for
me to obviously talk about rgbs okay so
now what I'm going to do is right here I
want you to think of it is as I said
again I want you to think of it as if
we're connecting let me just go put the
red right here the blue on the blue let
me put the red on the red
just put the blue right here and put the
green right here and the red right here
so remember us uh oh wait just let me
just put it back here all right remember
us doing obviously the traffic light LED
what did we do it if you again I would
really be I would really be appreciative
if you just again go back and check it
for yourself go back that section and
check it but what we did is what we
connected one resistor to the what to
the red and then what connected to the
what and then we finished and then we
continue to what we continue to the
green and then connected a a resistor
for itself again a resistor for itself
and then we connected another resistor
for what for blue and then we did what
we finally connected it to the gnd D
that's what we basically did so one
thing I want you guys to keep in mind is
just because it's just one LED don't
think that we have to what we have to
use only one resistor all right I just I
just told you guys I want you to think
of what I want you to think of just us
mashing up these three LEDs these three
LEDs into one okay just think of mashing
up these three LEDs into one and having
a for leg right here for gnd D that's
all I think what you guys redid All
right so just think of mashing up again
what this RGB LED just mashing it up
together so we're going to need three
resistors here I want you to keep that
in mind again mashing up the red green
and blue so right here don't use one
resistor I think this is something that
uh a common mistake that happens so
please prevent that so
again always what use three resist
because we're going to be what lighting
up red green and blue I just like as I
as I said again just think of it as what
as three mashed up resistors okay so as
three matched up what LEDs okay so let
me have to put this back again have to
find the longer side
again which is a bit of a
hustle o it's actually a bit hard oh I
found it all right there we go it's like
this the longest side is obviously the
ground pin where the ground pin goes so
let's start working with our
LED now is the right time I think to
work with our LEDs I have to widen this
a bit again I have to widen it so that
it goes
across to push it a bit there we
go all
right come
on okay come on come on there we go got
it okay so let me just go back to my PC
hopefully
okay for some reason it's glitching
out
okay so sorry uh my computer just
crashed but uh let's continue where we
left off so as I said again I just want
you to think of the RGB LED as what as
three LEDs separate LEDs what combined
into one okay that's what I just said
obviously it's going to be very similar
to the one that we just did to the uh
traffic light uh course but instead of
using green sorry instead of using
yellow we're going to use what green
here okay so what did we do in the
traffic light we separately did what
again we separately what connected three
digital pins three resistors and then
connected it so what we're going to do
right now is going to set up what three
again digital pins for each color so
we're going to be setting up one digital
pin for red one digital pin for green
and one digital pin for what for blue
okay so let's just do
that okay forget about the com the
comment that I have here okay I'm just
going to get back to this I just want to
remind myself to uh teach about this
along the way so we're going to get back
to this but right now I want you to
focus what we're going to be creating
three digital pins so it's going to be
red pin right here we going to start
with red pin I'm just going to set it up
to one digital pin I'm just going to say
four today again you can choose whatever
you want in then I'm going to choose the
green pin what is it going to be again
five eight any number you like I'm just
going to choose five I'm just going to
try to make it consecutive and then
we're going to go to blueprint
and set it to
six all
right then afterwards what do I need to
do I need to go to pin mode then set it
up to
look I need to go to pin mode say red
pin this case and set it as what output
once I'm done with that obviously what I
have to do is copy it so to do this in
an easier way what I'm going to use is a
shortcut alternate shift and then point
downwards I'm going to be using
alternate shift holding it it then I'm
going to point downwards so I can copy
it again see it I'm going to copy it
three times then now what I have to do
is what change the pen right here I just
changed my language Let me just change
it back to
English there we go set it a green pen
and then set this to a blue pin all
right then afterwards what do I need to
do as always I need to what I need to
use digital right because I'm working
with a what with a digital pin then I'm
going to saying red pin and set it to
what to a value of high all right again
use alternate shift and again click down
because again as as I said again it's
going to make things easier than copy
pasting them fting them from scratch so
all I need to do right here is what
change this to Green pin and then what
do I need to change this to I need to
change this to Blue pin all right so
we're done uh setting up the code so
let's start working with our components
okay so let me just get this out of the
way actually I should let it stay here
to be honest because it's a bit of a
harder concept so I want it to stay here
so again you guys can reference this all
you need to focus is not on the
subtractive focus on the additive and
again these three things all right just
want you focus on these two things okay
so what I'm going to do right here is
I'm going to be using the red one for
the red right here the red is at the
fourth the green one the green I'm going
to be using a green wire for what for
green a blue wire for what for the blue
color that's what I'm going to be doing
green blue here green here and the red
here that's what I'm going to do and I'm
obviously going to use the gnd for the
GN I'm going to use what a black wire
okay so let's just do that so let me
start with the blue one which is going
to be the one at the very most left so
let me just connect it let me get this
closer and let me connect it now let it
Focus now let me connect it there we go
then what am I going to do right here
I'm going to be connecting it to pin
what again let me pin it's pin number
six okay pin number six for me pin
number six there we
go then I am going to connect the green
one let's just do that let's connect the
green one with the what with the green
wire so let's go to the green one right
here it's going to be next to the blue
one there we go let me just show you
guys there there we go got it and then
where are we going to put it just put
this right here we're going to put it to
the digital pin five okay so where's
thisal pin five it's around
here let me again make sure that you
guys can actually see it Focus here
digital pin five hopefully Focus there
we go now you can see it there we go
digital pin what connect the digital pin
six and then digital pin five now the
one that is left is what gnd D okay let
me bring my black wire right here let's
get my black wire and let me connect to
gnd D there we go as you can see
connected to the g& D and then now I'm
going to connect it to the third to the
third leg there we go Third Leg
connected all right then now the fourth
one I'm going to be connecting with what
I'm going to be connecting it to the red
so the red pin is what it is pin four so
digital pin 4 let me go to digital pin 4
just did that just do that so let me
just focus so you can actually see it I
connect to digital pin for which leg the
fourth leg there we go focus it right
here the digital pin what digital pin 4
all right now I could just what I could
just run so all I need to do is upload
it let me connect my ardino let me just
plug in my uino right here all right now
I can just run it so let me upload
it what I need to do is verify the code
say snowboard selected oh let just
select my board says unknown let me
select it again sometimes this happens
all I have to say is r no Nano there we
go got my con 4 serial Port there we
go and now we should be should be able
to
verify and it's done compiling now let's
upload
it
okay so let me just turn off the lights
so you can see way way better let me
just do that because it looks like a
greenish type of light right now let me
just turn off the light right here both
lights actually just turn this off
too so you can actually see it it's too
bright right now let me just try to
focus it
here it's a very very bright light you
cannot you can barely see it it's trying
to giveing me
can you see green sometimes you can see
red mostly you can see green but let me
go over to this direction it's really
hard to actually get a luck of this but
it looks somewhat like what somewhat
like white okay somewhat like what
somewhat like white whsh type of color
but when you put it here when you look
at it on the screen it looks like green
but genuinely what I'm getting is what
I'm getting a white light right here by
the way I can look at it white light
somewhat looks like green on the screen
right here can you see it we can see
dynamic range of what colors right here
I can see a red right now can you see a
red right now can you see we have red
green and blue when we combine them
looks like somewhat like what somewhat
like white
so one thing I did not do right here is
what by the way one thing I did not do
right here is what use resistors I want
you guys to keep it in mind I did not
use a resistor well specifically
speaking right here you don't have to
use a resistor all right again
specifically speaking you don't have to
what use a resistor but it's not really
stable when you look at it it just looks
like it's changing color every time by
the way it's not what is happening is
what there's a red one the green and the
blue are lighting up and when the camera
focuses it Focus only on one color you
get me right so when I change it right
here it looks like a reddish when I
change it a bit to another angle can you
see it you can get a blue greenish
thingy then when I change an angle again
it renders it as other color but
generally what I can see is what mostly
what I can see is white but if you look
close enough you can see red green and
blue those red green and blue are turned
on okay okay so let's just keep that in
mind so if you go to my screen again
right here and let's go to our Color
Picker let's do that have to Google it
again because I just said again my
computer
crashed Color Picker and if you go here
through the very most white it is what
it's
255 255 255 basically it's turned on to
its maximum and maximum and maximum even
if you go right here and say the RGB
model just say the RGB model and you
Google it if you look at
it the intersection of the red green and
blue the intersection of all of them is
what it's white when we turn all of them
what happens it turns to what it turns
to White okay so inter the intersection
of all is what it's one okay so let's
just get this in mind okay so one thing
again we've worked with let me again
familiarize RV for you guys we actually
did what we actually turned on all of
this it's
beautiful let me just bring a paper
right here and let's go to the m math
side of it as I said again there going
to be what a math side towards it just
like how we again use math to again
systematically what add and all instead
of what memorizing we're going to have
this involves a bit of what this
involves a bit of numbers okay so let me
just remove this Pap right here and if
you guys remember something you guys are
getting familiar with let me start with
something you guys are familiar with if
you guys remember when we're using the
analog I want you to focus here
analog right
command what did we do we sted the we
stated the pen P right here what pin we
we using and then we see a value from
what from 0 to
255 if you
remember wait let me get Pap right here
from zero to what a number from zero to
255 an integer from 0 to 255
so one thing you need to know about RGB
is literally what it basically means
okay when it's written in this format is
okay the first the first the first one
represents present red the first value
represents the amount of red and it's
going to be from zero to what to
255 see that it's going to be the green
one is also going to be zero to
255 the third value is going to be a
blue which going to be 0 to
255 okay so if we have let's say a color
for example that is written as RGB let's
say
78 uh
241 and let's see this one is set to
even zero right here the 78 is what the
78 is the value of what the value of red
24 is the value of what it's the value
so 241 is the value of what it's the
value of green okay I want you to keep
that in mind and zero is the value of
what the value of blue okay so the first
value is going to be what the value of
red the green is going to be what the
second value and zero is going to be
what sorry uh blue is going to be what
the third value okay we just keep that
in mind so let me go over to my screen
right now and when we see something as
255 2255 255 what does this mean it
basically means it's turned on to
maximum it's turned on to maximum when
we turn on everything to the maximum
what does it give us the color white so
again when we analyze the code let's
just analyze the code right here we just
did what additional bite High what does
the just write high mean High means what
high corresponds with what high
corresponds with 255 as we learned again
what does low correspond with zero
corresponds to what to zero basically
255 means what 255 means 5 volt while
low corresponds to zero which means Z
volt Okay so we've just what created
only white light right here what we've
created is what white light but we can
create Many Many Lights by using what by
using the analog right command because
why we can set it from a value to zero
to 25 what we did is what set only zero
to 255 that's all we could have done we
only can set it to zero or 255 but now
we can set it to any number between 0
and 255 so when we use analog right
we're going to be what we're going to be
unlocking new possibilities okay so what
we're going to do right now is we're
going to first change the p that we used
again the digital pins we're going to be
finding those squiggly lined pins again
that look like what they're marked with
a d and have a what a squiggly sign on
them I told you guys that this pins are
what both analog pins and they both
function as analog pins and as digital
pins so let's try to find those squiggly
signed pins and try to use analog right
command on them okay so let's just do
that so let me just remove all of it
except for the G and D the G and D
always stays the same so I'm just going
to keep it there I'm just going to keep
the wires here because I'm going to get
back to them again let me just take off
this paper for now and what I'm going to
do is go to my screen right here and we
have to remove four or let's remove four
five then six we're going to set them to
what to the digital pins that have what
squiggly sign so let's look at one that
we have right here so let me unplug my
Arduino right here because it makes no
sense to plug it right now okay so let's
try to find mine is an greo Nano so
we're going to look for what for a DOT
on the what on the digital pins so let's
look closer and you can see one on
digital pin 11 we can see one on digital
pin 10 and we can see one on digital pin
9 so let's connect these three okay so
digital pin 10 sorry there's still pin
11 10 and N are going to be the ones
that I'm going to be using so let just
do
that actually I'm I'm not supposed to be
plugging my arino I'm going plug it and
let's start working with actually let's
first assemble it and then we can go and
write the code okay so digital pin 10
I'm going to be setting it to digital
pin 11 is going to be set to Red I'm
just going to do
that I said again let me just bring this
here so you guys can again remember it
the red is what at the very very what at
the very last so I'm going to be setting
it to digital pin instead of digital pin
11 it's better to set it as digital pin
n because it's going to be closer okay
so I'm just going to set this to what
digital pin N9 I'm going to change my
mind and change change it uh and change
it to what to digital pin 9 let me just
set it to digal pin 9 right here set
this to digital pin 9 where am I
supposed to connect it next to the g& D
pen to the very right so let me just do
that there we go connected it nice now
what do I need to do I need to set up
green let me get my green wire right
here let's find my green wire and uh put
it right
here I need to go to digital pin 10 I'm
going to go for digital pin 10 for green
okay then I'm going to go for the blue
one which is going to be the most left
one there we go and I'm going to set it
up for what digital pin
11 oh SP is the space is very tight let
me just do that there we go you guys can
see it right now let me just do that let
me just make sure that you guys can
actually see everything every setup and
there you have it okay so now what I'm
going to do is let's go over to my
screen and let's start writing the code
okay so the red pen is what set set to
what digital pin 9 while the green pen
is set to digital pin 10 if I'm correct
digital pin 10 there we go and blue pin
is set to digital pin 11 there we go now
what do I need to do right here I'm
going to be using them as an output so
this is all correct I'm not going to
change anything here what else am I
going to change here I'm going to be
using what analog right instead of
digital right so I'm just going to do
that down analog
right and I'm going to set the what the
first one let me just set the red pin to
what to some sort of value I'm not going
to do that right now well I'm going to
do set it up so let me again copy
this set up green pin I'm going to set a
value later and we have the blue pin
there we go so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to go to My Color Picker
right here okay so as you can see we
have the value right here written down
on RGB you can also see other values
such as cmk HSV hsl we're not going to
get into them because we're not going to
need them right now but we're going to
focus on RGB because this is going to be
one of the most popular type of what
color naming systems all right now a
color what a color system all right so I
just want to for something more of
yellowish today I just feel like
something yellowish let me just go for
something
yellow okay there we go I I like this
color I want it to be a bit brighter
though just make it a bit brighter
actually but that that looks good I want
it to be somewhat greenish though let me
just go to The Greener Side of it okay
that looks nice I like it so what I need
to do right here is again the RGB says
that I'm supposed to set it what 132 for
red 20 55 for green and zero for what
for blue so let me just do that let me
go over to my ardino IDE supposed to be
right here I have to set 132 for the red
pen 132 for the green pen I'm going to
set it to what 255 and for the blue pen
I can just set it to zero okay so all I
need to do is what upload
this everything should be working no
upload Port is provided why is that so I
do not plug in my adino let me just do
that
forgot to plug my arino right here all
right now let me try to upload
it okay done
uploading so let me just turn off the
light so you guys can see it way
better again turn off the
lights it's really hard actually when
there's when there's uh actually turn on
the light actually it's way better with
the light at least it's not going to be
too bright that you cannot see it it
gives me the yellowish you cannot see it
again because of the screen again it's
going to focus on only one light but if
you look at it it looks like somewhat
yellowish type of uh green it doesn't
look like the one that looks on the
screen like perfectly but it looks
somewhat somewhat yellowish type of what
type of green right here some yellowish
type of green if I rotate it to another
degree it looks like yellow you can see
that right if I wrot it to a degree it
looks like a yellow when I wrot it back
to another degree it looks like green
there we go there like a green right
here
okay so right here let me just try to
make something of a distinct color let
me just again and turn on the light let
me try to make somewhat of a very
distinct color that we don't have we
already have a yellow pin so let's try
to find something that we don't have
maybe a cutor that we don't have maybe
something like cyan because we don't
have a cyan type of uh a cyan type of uh
color right here can is one of my
favorite colors I actually like it so
much okay okay so the value of Canan is
what almost what 238 255 but if you go
to the closer side actually it's going
to be 255 right here the most Canan
color is going to be
255 there we go 255 this is cyan if you
if you want to find for example by the
way if you want to find a specific color
okay if you want to find any specific
color the RGB value of any specific
color all you have to do is what all you
have to do is Google it so right here
you're going to goes right here and say
um let's say I want the color pink okay
so I'm going to say is pink what I'm
going to say is pink
RGB value or RGB code this RGB code or
value when you just do that a pink is
going to be right here the RGB code is
what 255 192 and 203 all you need to do
is go right
here okay so I'm going to set the red to
255 let me just do that set it to
255 and this one to
192 well I need to do set it up to 192
if I'm correct let me just look over
192 and this one to
203 there we go all I need to do is what
upload it right now let me just do that
it's done
compiling and now it's uploading it's
done
uploading as you can see right here let
me just turn off the light if it helps
you it looks somewhat like white right
now let me just turn off the light so
that it can help
let me just do
that okay so again it's was really a
hustle you can see that the color is
changing a lot it's changing from green
to right now a red when I tilt it again
and now to a blue but I at the right
direction right here doesn't look
doesn't look like pink right here looks
like a pink right here can you see it a
pinkish color I can see it right here it
looks somewhat like pinkish by the way
you cannot see it that much because
again we're using camera but you can see
what somewhat of a pink when I tilt it
when I tilt it to the right degree you
can see somewhat of a pink there we go
somewhat of a pink right here there we
go we got a pink that is beautiful let's
just do that can you see it it's a
beautiful one all right so um again you
guys can choose any color you want
Google it again any color you know maybe
Indigo s any color you like Google it
obviously and yeah all you have to do is
search for the RGB value and you can
again do what you can use your RGB LED
and what and try to create that light
for yourself all right I think this is
it for the next section of for this
section of the course but we're going to
be working with RGB LEDs and adding up
we're going to take them to the next
level by uh working with the serial
monitor on the next section of the
project so um see you
then okay so let's up this part project
as I said again up a notch so everything
here is going to be the same the
components here are going to be the same
so is going to be the code so we're
going to continue what where we left off
okay so right here what I want to do to
up this project is use our serial
monitor right here okay and what do I
want to do this let me actually upload
this code right here first because uh I
was working on the pseudo code I was
working on the code previously and I
don't want to to interfere with this
one okay I think the serial monitor
should be printed now put my serial
monitor should be like new all right
there we go and what do I want to do
right here is okay what do I want to do
right here is I want to enter a message
to what our serial monitor okay so as
you can see right here there's a black
bar that says message enter to send
message to Arduino Nano so basically we
can use our serial monitor not not only
to read not to only what listen or read
from uino Nano but we can use it to
write messages to what to send messages
to our Arduino Nano basically to our
Arduino okay so how do we do that let's
write down a message right here let's
say I said red right here I can send it
to what to the ardino obviously right
now it makes no sense because obviously
we have to what we have to create a
system on which how we're going to
receive the message and what Arduino
should do when it receives the message
okay we have to set that code up anyways
we can set what messages though just
like how we have uh I want you to think
of this just like how we have digital
just write it down properly digital
write and digital
read just like how we have that when we
can write a message to again using our
digital pin and we can read message
using our digital pin too the same goes
for analog too we had what analog right
and analog
read now we're going to have is what now
we're going to have a Serial what we've
been using what serial read we're
reading what using our what a Serial
Monitor and now we're going to be using
what serial kind of something like what
a Serial a Serial right type of thinking
because we're going to be what we're
going to be sending a message by using
our what our serial monitor okay so
what's the idea here the idea here is
that we're going to set a color name
right here let's say red and what I
wanted to do is I wanted to change this
led the RGB LED as I said again capable
of almost any color to what to give me
the equivalent color so when I say red I
want it to turn to red when I say blue
when I enter blue I want it to change to
Blue when I say pink I wanted to change
to pink when I say purple I wanted to
change to purple again I wanted to
change to what to the color I already
what that I set right here on the
message okay that's the idea of FL we
going to be doing so the question is how
do we even first receive the message
from AR and how do we even code it so
that what so that again it gives me the
equivalent color on the
rgbled okay so I'm just remove my serial
monitor right now and we're going to be
working a bit on the uh serial monitor
so one thing we need to do before
working with any type of Serial monitor
is what we're going to have to always
what start our serial monitor so we have
to say serial. begin and set it to what
to 9,600 right now and then we're going
to be using right here serial. read
string we're going to be using something
called what serial. readstring okay so
what I'm going to do right here we
already started our serial monitor right
here okay serial. what. read string let
me just copy
it okay serial. readstring there it is
so what does this do let's just go to
the documentation to check it for
ourselves so what does the serial do
read read string does for us so let me
just go to
serial. read
string and there we go we have the arino
documentation of it there we go so it
says serial. read string reads
characters from the serial buffer into a
string the function terminates if it
times out see time out so basically what
does it do from a technical point they
say what a Serial buffer into a straight
so basically what does it do is what it
reads the characters that are what are
going to be outputed right here so it's
going to be reading the characters that
are going to be what that are going to
be written on the message right here can
you see this the message part right here
this is the serial buffer and it's going
to be what it's going to be what reading
the messages that are coming from here
so we're going to be using what serial.
readstring to what to read messages that
are coming from what that are coming
from our message bar right here or our
serial buffer okay so right here what
we're going to do right here is we're
going to need a new value a new variable
we want to what once we get the value
let's say right here I have red I put
red right here let's say put red right
here I want to what I want to store it
because we're going to be using it in
our code so what so I'm going to be
using it later in our code so what I
want to store it in a what in a variable
okay so let me just do that so what do I
need right here I need a variable so
what is it going to be right here what
type of variable is it going to be am I
going to say integer and say you know
what this is going to be the curent what
set color let me just say set color
right here the set color is it going to
be integer is it going to be integer
when I set it
up no what is it going to be a string
okay a string might correct even how to
write it down I think it's string let me
just again to always check that uh
everything is correct right here let me
just try to compile
it saying that it expected a what oh it
expected a semic colum let me just
compile
it okay the capital S is the right one
if I put the small s well let's see what
happens if I put the small s right
here okay there we go it says an error I
have to say capital S capital S is the
right way of writing it okay there we
go so you might be wondering what is a
string uh let me just go over this so
that it becomes what a simple as
possible okay so a string is right here
I'm not going to use my people actually
I think it's better to use my screen so
right here what does a string mean okay
a string means a normal text okay for
example this is a normal text right here
it says put your setup code here to run
whats okay but right here pin mode is
what pin mode is a what let's let's go
right here let's use an example of pin
mode what is pin mode right here let me
just go to pin mode what is pin mode pin
mode is a what it's a command it's a
what it's a code okay it's a code to be
what executed so one thing it wants to
identify is what it wants to
differentiate between a normal text and
a what and a what and a normal what and
a normal code so wants to differentiate
between what code and text which one is
text and which one is code because if we
don't do that we're going to get into
what we're going to get into lots of
troubles because if I just say right
here instead of let's say I'm just say
hello world it's going to expect let me
just say hello world right here okay let
me say hello world okay let me just try
to compile this let me verify this look
what happens hello was just not declared
in the scope it's trying to find what
it's trying to find a command a code
named hello world okay trying to find
what a code named hello world obviously
there's nothing called hello world in
the AR Rino obviously that makes no
sense so what it basically means is what
it does not understand that's a normal
text or a Cod so to differentiate that
we use what symbol we use right here
what do you to call
it a quotation mark you see that a
quotation mark so we use quotation marks
right here to what to identify a a one
that is what code and a string so in
strings we say double Mark right here
and let's say
hello right here hello
world if I say that it's going to what
render it as text it's going to treat it
as a what as a normal text so it's not
going to be giving me in so let's see
what happens I just say you know what
there's a strength name just say hello
world okay always finish it with
semicolon right here how about if I
upload it right now let's see what
happens it's done compiling see that
it's done compiling it's not giving me
an error it's saying is what this is
just a normal text don't get into what
don't get into detail just write what
render it as a normal text okay don't do
anything further than that it's not a
command it's just basically what it's
telling it so what it's a normal text so
right here basically what are they
called they're called strings okay so
keep that in mind because why because I
said again we're going to be working
with what with what with letters right
here and I wanted to render it as what
it's not going to be rendering what it's
not going to be searching for the what
for the command or for the code red it's
going to be searching for what it's
going to be searching for what the
string red it's going to make more sense
as I go okay so right here I wanted to
what to read the string how do we set
this once it reachs the string I want to
set it to what to a variable again
because why I want to what I want to use
it for what for later purposes so how do
I do that what I do is I go right here
sa color let say sa color let just go
right here see set color set to what set
color is equal to the string red value
so once the value is red right here as
soon as Arduino reads a value as soon as
let's say I enter a value right here and
it reads it it's going to set it to what
it's going to set it to red right here
okay it's going to set it to a value
this the string that we just what that
we just read right here okay so what
does this mean so for example if I said
red right here I just say red and enter
it what is going to happen set color set
color is going to be what go right here
set color is going to be what set color
is going to be equal to what it's going
to be equal to the string red again what
is one thing we have to uh
uh sorry acknowledge what is it what is
one thing that we have to acknowledge
this is what a string there's what the
quotation mark is right here okay keep
that in mind okay so with that in mind
now what we want to do is we know we
said the color Okay so let's try to
print what we just wrot right here so to
actually see if it's working or not
let's just print it okay we just say
print Ln and say set color I just want
to print it so that let's even see if
it's what if it's rendering the right
thing okay so let me just upload this
but before doing what should I do turn
off my serial monitor do that and now I
can
upload
it's done compiling and it should be
done
uploading okay so let's go back to our
serial monitor right here let me extend
it a bit so you can see it better and
let's try to say red right here does it
print red there we go it printed what
printed red can you see that it's
printed red and you can see that it's
printing out empty stuff can you see
that it's putting out empty what is what
is going on you might be wondering what
is going on okay what is going on you
might be wondering why are we printing
out after red we're printing out
something something what are we printing
some empty spaces some empty stuffs why
is that so let's see what happens again
one thing again you have to keep in mind
is what one thing you have to keep in
mind is what it's going in a loop so
it's going to read it one time and it's
going to be you know setting the analog
right to again all these values
afterwards what does it do it reads the
string in this case it was red I already
wrote down red and then it's going to
set the color as I said again it's going
to what set the color so basically what
sorry I said set color it's going to
print it out it's going to print the
what the variable set color and then
what happens and then it runs it again
but this time I have to write it what I
did not write it this time so it's going
to start from again it's going to start
from again as I said it's going to start
again because this goes in a loop again
it's very void Loop so it's going to
start again do the same thing but right
here what happens here on the read
string and this case what did I do I did
not write down red again I have to write
down red at very very fast speed for me
to what to match up to what to match up
to the Arduino right here what's going
on the read string is what it's an empty
set because I did nothing it's basically
what it's basically empty because I do
not enter anything so it's going to be
giving me those empty spaces right here
it's printing it out you can see that
it's printing out what empty spaces okay
so I just want you to keep that in mind
okay so right here it's going to be
printing out this we're going to fix
this and by using something called
serial. available I'm going to get to it
but now let's focus on just optimizing
the read string we're going to go back
and fix this later okay so right here
let me just get forget about the
printing it works but obviously what
happens again the problem here is what
it's going to print out those empty
characters we're going to fix that on
the next one okay so one thing what we
want to do afterwards after we store our
set color is what our set color is what
we want to compare it okay so how do we
do that so right here let me write down
an if condition there's the keyword
called
if
okay we have a curly brackets right here
our condition is written inside here
okay right condition and then our code
is going to be written inside of the
curly brackets okay so when it comes
towards um when it comes towards these
if things if you write them down let me
just write them down right here if I say
if it has what a special color okay it's
a code as I said again we're going to
write down our condition what in those
curly brackets and then we're going to
have our code in the middle of those
what in the on in the middle of this
what curvy brackets again okay so this
what the squiggly brackets right here
okay so in the middle of the sorry the
what in the middle of the uh curly
brackets sorry I keep saying curly
brackets for this one this is called a
parenthesis okay in the middle of this
is going to be the condition I I got
that wrong when I said it but in the
middle of the curly bracket is going to
be our our code it's going to be written
here okay so one thing I want you guys
to keep in mind is let's use a very very
simple analogy so you guys understand
this so I think most of us have
obviously uh had this English lesson
about what if condition tenses condition
tenses if you remember so when we
learned about condition tenses what did
we say what did we say there's a
condition there's if and there's a
condition and then there's what and
there's what and there's the result of
the condition so it's like cause and
effect so one good example would be if
okay if it doesn't
rain if it doesn't
rain going to say I will
go
outside uh to play
basketball basketball let's start to
analyze this so if it doesn't rain I
will go outside to play basketball what
is the condition here the condition is
what it doesn't rain is what the
condition this is what our condition
okay this is our
condition and the result of the
condition again the consequence of the
condition will be what what I will what
go outside to play what basketball this
is what this is going to be our action
basically
action so there are two things to this
uh condition again there are going to be
what two cases to this condition what is
that what are the two cases in this case
one case is what it doesn't rain so what
I can just go outside and play
basketball but there's another condition
too when this condition is false
basically when it's it's what it's
raining when this condition is not
satisfied it's raining outside basically
right now what is going to happen I'm
not going to go outside to play
basketball I'm not going to go outside
to play basketball because I don't want
to get wet okay I just want you guys to
keep that in mind so when this condition
is what can be set to true or what it
can be false okay both of them will have
what when it's true it's going to have
what when the when it's true it's going
to have what I'm going to go and what
play basketball and it's false in this
case what it's rains what am I going to
do I'm not going to go and play
basketball so it's going to have what
two scenarios when it's what when it's
true or false when the condition is what
true or false false so it's going to
have what two again cases as I said
again okay so it's going to what affect
our what our action again it's going to
affect our action this condition is
going to affect our action the condition
coming true is going to affect our
action and the condition coming false is
going to have what another effect in our
action that's one thing I want you guys
to keep it up so it's going to be the
same thing too when it comes to
computers okay so what there's an if
right here and there is a condition we
have a specific what we have a specific
condition and then what when that
condition is satisfied what's going to
happen it's going to specifically what
it's going to what it's going to execute
the code that's here okay when the
condition is not satisfied it's going to
what it's going to skip it it's going to
skip what the whole what the whole
bracket to the very end it's going to
skip it the whole what the whole code
right here you can write hundreds of
codes in the middle of this brackets but
it's going to what it's going to skip it
as long as what the condition is what
not satisfied if it's satisfied it's
going to what it's going to run it so I
just want you guys to keep that in mind
so why what are we going to do with this
if Loop right here what are we going to
do right here so let me go over right
here
okay to my screen the condition here is
what if red right here if the set color
is what if it's equal to Red okay if
it's equal to Red here equal to it's
equal to Red what does what do I want to
do right here when it's equal to Red
what do I want to do you guys know RGB
so we want to get the most red color how
do we get the most red color we do what
we do this analog rights so let me copy
the analog rights and I'm going to
adjust the value
again let me just remove this and let's
just print this again and we have again
analog what red pin 255 and unlock right
Gren pin for what set we're going to set
this to zero and the blue pen we're
going to set it to zero because we only
want what we only want red to be
lighting up because what we want the
color is what it's red so again we can
again use our color Color Picker right
here if you want to we can just go to
Color Picker and say color sorry color
RGB value RGB value of what value of red
when we do that the RGB value of red is
what
255 0 there we go so that's what we
basically did 2055 0 0 I wanted to do it
analog right for it 2055 0 Z right am I
correct that's what I wanted to do what
if it's not red
so right here when it's not red when we
want to set another condition okay now
let me go back to my paper actually let
me add another paper to be honest
because this paper is not enough there
we go so how do we set another condition
okay we're going to be using something
called else okay we're going to say if
right here we going to say if and we
have our
condition okay and it's going to beun
running the code if this is true
okay okay then we have something called
else okay else else as in what it's the
second option else is what is more of
what the second option so if this
condition for example is satisfied what
is going to happen it's going to run the
code as I said but what if this
condition is not satisfied if this
condition is not satisfied I wanted to
run let's say a specific code right here
if I wanted to run specific code right
here okay instead of just you know
skipping as traditionally what did it do
it had a condition and a code if it
again this condition is not satisfied
what did it do it just skipped it but
let's say I want to you know if in this
case this condition is not satisfied
okay in this case this condition is not
what it's not satisfied if in this case
it's not satisfied what I wanted to do
is write another what another type of
code right here we have code number two
right here and code number one I wanted
to write code number one if this what
this condition satisfied but if it's not
I wanted to wrun another code okay
instead of just skipping it I wanted to
what write another code that's why we're
going to be using something called else
so what I want you to think of them is
like this okay we had this again
sentence right here which was what if it
doesn't rain I will go outside to play
basketball okay but something else can
happen to other than raining let's say
it gets too hot I'm talking really
really hot so if it gets too hot what
happens if it gets too hot what happens
I will not go outside and what play
basketball so instead of just about
we're only talking about raining here we
again it has a what a wider context
because let's say it's what it's there's
a tornado let's say outside if it's if
there's a tornado or hurricane outside
what I will not go outside and play
basketball obviously I will not go
outside and what play basketball so I
just want you to keep that in mind so
when you're working with else what are
you doing we're just adding another
condition we're just adding another
condition just adding what another
condition basically what we're saying is
basically oh if this what if this code
is not run it's condition is not
satisfied I'm going to give you another
option which is going to be you're
writing down the second code okay so I
just want you to think of it is that so
if this what if this condition is not
satisfied I wanted to do something else
okay instead of just not playing
basketball I wanted to do something else
one of it would be what playing maybe
board games okay so if let's say if it
rains okay if it rains in this case what
it's going to get be our condition is
going to be what false if it rains
instead of just not playing basketball
what else am I going to do what also I'm
going to do is what I'm also going to be
let's say playing board games inside the
house okay with my
let's just say that okay so with that in
mind okay you can say what else okay
else and what I wanted to do is I wanted
to tell our user right here I wanted to
print out and tell our user right let me
just go to serial
do
print and tell it hey color not
recognized I wanted to tell it that we
do not recognize what color it set right
here okay I just wanted to tell it oh I
don't recognize the color that you're
just saying right here okay all right
that's what I want to do okay so one
final thing that we need to learn about
if and else is to be exactly fully done
is something
called so we learned about if right here
just recap we learned about if and then
we learned about if and else combining
them together and then we're going to
learn about something called if right
here let me start it's going to start
like if just going to add up to it and
there's our
condition let me just give this separate
this condition obviously we have our
code in the middle of the brackets it's
going to be code one then we have
something called if
else all right if else and we have a
condition again we can write down
another
condition okay we're going to be using
code two again right here and we can
even set it up with what with else right
here again right here else is what it's
the final straw okay so here we go so
what does this mean so this means is oh
we have our code three right here when
you see else we have our code three a
third code there we go okay so what does
this mean so this means is what if there
is a condition what's going to happen
it's going to be running the first code
if this condition is not satisfied it's
going to go to the second one we're
going to give it another condition okay
so we're going to give it another
condition and it's going to be what
running code two and what the third one
is going to be what it's going to be
running the final straw it's basically
what the final straw it's like the final
you know like the final thing that you
do when you have any don't anything else
you don't do right you don't do anything
when you don't have anything else to do
when you don't have uh anything else to
do it's like the final straw okay it's
going to be running what our final straw
right here so I want you to keep that in
mind so there's if again condition with
the code one and there's if else
condition and our code two and then what
else and then our code the third code so
I want you to keep that in mind okay so
right here let me just bring
my again our simple example right here I
think it's going to make it way easier
so what does an if else fit right here
so basically thinking of it as I said
again if it doesn't rain I will go
outside to play basketball ball all
right so in this case let's say it rains
okay when this code is not satisfied
it's going to jump this one and what's
going to happen is if else it's going to
go to the if else right here the second
option it's going to be the second
option it's going to go to our second
option and say okay it's raining what
else can I do what else can I do okay I
will not go out I'll what I will not go
outside to play basketball that is true
I I will not go outside to play
basketball but what else can I do I can
be on my phone let's say okay let's say
what I can be on my phone I just want
you to think of it as what I will be
inside of my house and be on my phone
okay all right then let's say again
there's another condition where this one
cannot be true basically let's say
there's no light and my battery is dead
okay let's say my phone battery is dead
in this case let's say my phone battery
is dead as a final straw what do I do I
play board games because I have no
nothing else to do that's what I want
you to think of okay so when this
condition is not satisfied there's what
there's what when this condition is not
satisfied have another condition that
we're going to do but when that
condition is again not satisfied we have
a final straw again to do what to do our
last thing okay so let's say even we
don't have board games well let's say
this is going to be another if else okay
we don't have a board game what are we
going to do okay we're what we're going
to do is maybe sleep because what we
have we don't have any bird game we have
we don't have anything to do basically
we don't have anything to do we're just
going to go to sleep okay just going to
take a nap all right so that's what I
want you to think of them okay so one
thing you always need to keep in mind
when working with these is what what it
goes from up to top one thing you want
to keep in mind is what it goes from up
to top so again from up to bottom up to
bottom so it's going to be reading the F
right here so let's say it reads this
one and this is true if this is true
what's going to happen it's not going to
read the else one okay it's not going to
read it it's not going to read it it's
going to skip it it's going to what it's
going to skip it no matter what thing
you're write in it it's going to what
it's going to skip it okay keep that in
mind when it comes to this one too
what's going to happen is it's going to
read the first condition if the first
condition is satisfied what are we going
to do let's say in this condition for
example if what it doesn't rain what do
I do I just go outside and play
basketball I'm not going to be on my
phone I'm not going to be using board
games or anything I'm going to be what
I'm going to be what playing out I'm
going to be outside and what playing
basketball so I want you to keep that in
mind so when this condition is what set
to true it's not even going to read the
last options okay so it's going to pick
from like these options and the first
option is obviously this if it if it
reads this and this is true it's going
to skip all of this this okay so one
final thing that you need to keep in
mind is you can write down if let me
Spring this here you can write down if
and then you can write down what our
condition again the
condition then our code is going to be
written down if we obviously what we we
obviously write it down right here then
we have if
else okay then again it's going to have
its own condition here and it's going to
have its own code it's going to be code
two then we can also add another if
else the same thing it's going to run
another code with another condition it
has another different condition right
here code
three if else you can you can keep
adding it to what till Infinity okay you
can keep adding this to what to Infinity
right here it's like adding let's say
okay I don't have you know my phone is
not here with me okay I'm going to be
reading a book you know what instead of
reading a book I'm going to be cooking
some cooking dinner or something so what
there's like infinite possibilities okay
so you can keep writing down if else at
what infinitely and then at the end what
you do is always finish it with the last
option it's going to be an else right
here an else option and you finish it
with a code so this is what our code for
it's going to be our code five so one
thing I want to again as I said is what
always one if it is going to get picked
so going to happen again when this is
picked if the the first condition is
picked what's going to happen if the
first condition is picked what what's
going to happen is basically what it's
not even going to read all these if this
is true it's not going to read any of
these from else all of it till else
everything it's not going to read
anything it's not going to read all of
it all right what if the second
condition is
true if the second condition is true
what's going to happen Okay first reads
the first condition and this one is
false and second condition let's say
treats it and it's true in this case
what's going to happen anything beneath
it is not going to be red it's going to
be what it's going to be skipped
anything beneath it it's going to what
it's going to be skipped okay it's going
to be keep going on like that so I just
want you to keep that in mind we're
working with um if conditions so I think
it has been a very longer section of the
course because we're learning about new
uh uh programming again functionalities
and all so it's going to be a bit uh it
is a bit longer one so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to stop this right now
right here and then we're going to see
uh we're going to take a break and then
see you in the next
section okay so in the previous section
we discussed about e flops and uh now
we're actually going to utilize them in
our project so we're going to fully
utilize them okay so let me go to my
screen right here and what does this
mean this means is what if the set color
is red what happens the analog right
command just go here the analog right
command it's going to set the red p 255
obviously other ones are going to be set
to zero basically giving us what the
color red so let's see what happens when
I just do that so let me just upload it
right
now let
uploading and there's a problem right
here can you see I do not write down
anything on the what on the Arduino I
not write down anything but what
happened here what happened was it
turned down to red which is a bad thing
because I'm supposed to what I'm
supposed to go to my serial monitor
right here and then I'm supposed to type
red and then when I enter it when I send
it to the Rino then it should have been
turning to Red not when I again just did
not do anything right here okay so I did
nothing and what happened was let me
tell you guys what happened was I said
the color is equals to what to red right
here I said the color is equals to what
serial. read string all right then
afterwards what did I say if set colors
equal to the red I set it to what I set
it to read to Red so how do we compare
things so how do we you know know the
difference between setting up stuff you
know just as in like this let me just
bring this here to bring a paper and I
think I'm going to use a math analogy
again because to make things way way
simpler for you guys so I'm bring a
paper here
okay so if you remember if you guys
learned about
expressions and then
equations what is the difference right
here when it came to Expressions what we
have to say is what 5x + 7 is like an
expression what is an equation an
equation has the equal sign let's say 5x
is 7 is equals to maybe here four okay
so right here what does this do this
means means to solve what does this mean
when when we set the equals to here this
means what solve for x in this
case what if I said 4 equals
5 4 equals 5 if I say that this is going
to be what this is a
statement and what is the statement is
it true or false this is definitely what
this is definitely a false
statement okay so we use the same sign
right here to do what to solve for X and
what to even what to see and compare and
contrast so basically what we see what
the statement to see the statement but
when it come to computers I said that
what computers are what computers take
you literally and I think all of you
know that that computers what they take
you literally so they need to understand
the difference between you are solving
for x basically they need to understand
the difference when it comes to
computers right now they need to
understand the difference when you're
assigning a v a variable assigning ing a
variable assigning value right here to a
what to a variable they need to know the
difference between you assigning a value
and then you
comparing a value with another comparing
values comparing two values so how does
a computer know when you're assigning a
value and when you're comparing values
because when we go to line 23 here what
are we trying to do we're trying to
compare the set color value iable with
what with the string red if the string
is equal to Red if the answer is equal
to Red what are we saying if it's equal
to Red we wanted to what you wanted to
write what this code it wants to run
this code you want it to run this code
between line 24 and uh 26 okay that's
what we're basically saying but it
cannot know that so when it comes to
assigning values one thing you need to
keep in mind is when it comes to
assigning values you're going to be
using the equal sign just like how we're
using again the equal sign at line 21 to
what to set the color right here we say
set color is equals to what serial.
rring to assign variables you only what
use what you use an equal side but when
we were comparing values what do we do
is we use two equal signs okay an equal
sign next to an equal sign when we do
that our ouro knows that we're comparing
values okay so we're not assigning
values we're comparing values okay
that's one thing I want you to know okay
so let me just move it right here and
let me fix this properly after what
right now I'm what in line 23 I'm I I'm
doing what I'm literally comparing what
I'm literally comparing so what should I
be using I should be using
double there we go I'm going to be using
double equal signs here and then let's
upload
it okay I forgot to again close my
sering monitor it happens often all
right let me go
again should be
uploading okay it's done uploading there
we go now everything is fine there we go
it's not lit up right here okay so now
what do we think should do right now
when I say red we want it to turn to
what we want it to turn to Red so let me
just do that right
here actually I keep getting color not
recognize color not recognized color not
recognized over and over again let's see
why is this happening first okay so
obviously this is going in a loop right
here right here it's a loop the void
Loop so it's going to check for the set
color in this case I have not set
anything so it's going to be an empty
string or almost zero a zero or an empty
string some somewhat like that because I
don't not put anything right now let's
see what happens and then it's going to
be checking for the set color is equals
to Red obviously it's not equal to Red
in this case and then it's going to go
what to what okay this is not true so
let me go to this one let me go to the
else one let me go to the else one it's
going to say let me go to else one and
do what and run this code again and then
I'm going to start the cycle again
because we're in what in Loop so that's
the problem here so let me remove the
else for now because it's quite quite
distracting for now so let's remove else
for now at least so let me just turn off
the serial monitor right here and try to
upload
it okay it's done compiling
and it should be uploading all right
it's done uploading so let's see if
we're even going to run to errors right
now okay so right now when I say red
when I enter red right now I expect this
led to turn to what to Red so let me try
to do that I'm just going to touch the
ENT key right
now and uh we can't see nothing let me
try to doing it
again you still can't see
anything so in this case let me try to
debug it all right so one way to debug
it is what let me go to my uh serial
right here and say serial. print it
let's try to print the set color if
there's even a problem with it so let me
just check if the set color is correct
so let me just upload this but before
doing that again turn off my serial
monitor let me just upload this right
here it's done
compiling okay it's done uploading all
right now let's try to go to my serial
Monitor and now let me try to go to my
monitor right here and set the value to
Red okay let me just try to do
that okay it's not setting to red as you
can see right here what is the problem
again what happens it's just printing
out I think an empty character there we
go it's emptying out look at it it's
going down and down if you look at the
pointer but it's emptying out what
printing out empty characters why is
that so I don't put anything inside of
the message again I didn't put anything
inside of the message for an instance I
only put what red for an instance and
then keeps running and running and
running again so I need to put it where
I need to put this the print one I need
to print put it right here I want it to
print as soon as what it turns to Red I
think it's better that way but it might
not even print it because why is this a
bad idea again m because if obviously
this is true it would have run this so
it always skipped this this basically
means it always skips it it's saying
that set color is not equal to Red for
some reason and I need to figure it out
myself so let me try to do is let me try
to do is just go over here it's be
before the uh before the color right
here what I want to do is I wanted to
read the string and then okay let's try
it again I think it's better that way
let's try to see it because it's really
hard to work from here okay let me just
do
that okay it's done uploading so let me
try to go right here let me just say
red okay there we go there's an instance
of red right here before I get it runs
through it let me forget about the no
line ending right here let me focus on
the red right here there we go can you
see it the red has a what right here it
has a space can you see this it's like
writing it as what the problem here is
like it's right equalent of writing it
as what as a red and then maybe you're
putting a a new line right here you're
giving it a space like it looks like
this because it has what they said again
has a space next to it so obviously this
red is not equal to what it's not equal
to not equal to what to the red we have
again on the code right here the red we
have here it's not equal to that what
also could be happening is it could be
doing this it could be saying is you
know what it prints red in a new line
all right it prints red in a new line it
prints red in a new line either it's a
space or it's a new line because I
cannot extract that information right
now can be a red or it can be a what a
new line right here at the end at the
very end there's a new line it's
creating a new line here okay so let's
see if it is a new line or just a space
so that we can adjust it to what we can
adjust uh our red right here the string
that we have to again compare it to so
what I'm going to do right here it's
going to be uh you know what if it's a
new line I should print next to it I
should be printing something next to it
so let me just print something next to
it uh print not a new line let me just
take off the new line right here let me
just take off the new line for both
codes and if it's a new line should
basically what this one should be on its
separate line again so let me just print
out maybe then say
hello okay hello all right hello there
we go finish that so basically what
should happen right now if it's know if
it doesn't have any new line or space
What Happens let's see what's going to
happen the two scenarios the first
scenario is what the set color what
doesn't have any string so basically
it's going to appear as what is Red by
the way for those of you who have a
legacy version it's going to appear it's
going to work for you guys okay I'm
going to get back to you guys so right
here red okay it's going to here is red
or we're going to be receiving what
we're going to be receiving red with a
space as we saw on the seral monitor it
had a space when I selected on it and
then or it might be a what it might be a
red and it has a new line at the very
end it tries to make a what a new line
right here write that a new line okay
that's what it's trying to make so how
do I know if it's a new line or a space
I received the one that had what again a
space right here how do I know it's a
space or a new line obviously what I do
is again put a hello next to it so if it
if it doesn't have a new line what's
going to happen there's a space right
here what it should it give me it should
give me like red right here say after
the space say hello okay but if it has a
new line on on a new line on another
line we're supposed to be receiving what
hello on a new line on a totally new
line so let's see what happens here let
me just upload this again so again we
might need to what we might need to
adjust again this makes no sense as I
said again it makes no sense why arino
is doing this but again we just have to
adjust
okay all right there we go keep saying
hello hello hello now let me try to say
red right
here look what happens there's a red
right here and at the very end look what
happens right now when I even go go to
the very edge there's no space right
here but it pushes this to a new line so
what does this mean this means that what
we're having a red that is attached to a
new line so basically what does this
mean is one thing that we have to know
is what when we're using serial do sorry
serial. print sorry what was it called
read string read
string okay when we're using serial.
read string one thing you always need to
keep in mind is what it prints out
strings prints out strings okay and it
prints it out in what prints it out in a
new line okay all right that's one
that's are the two things you want to
know okay print it out in a in a string
and prints it out in what in a new line
one other thing too and prints it out in
the string so one other thing I really
want to show you guys is all right let
me just remove this hello right here so
that it comes becomes really easy to
teach you guys this
one when I mean that it prints out
everything in a string I'm actually
going to show you why what I mean by
that okay so right here let me just
right here okay if I write down 10 and
if I print it out what's going to happen
is it's going to give me a version of
this so what I have right here what I
gave Arduino Arduino is what the number
what did I give it the number 10 I gave
it the number it's a number 10 wait let
me just let me go back here give it the
number 10 what did Arduino give me what
Arduino printed again what Arduino again
set serial sorry there we go what set
what color right here what was my
variable darino set color again what did
it set the variable again two is listen
let set it to a stringed 10 okay a 10
inside of a what inside of a string so
what does this basically mean okay one
thing I want you to understand here is
it it looks quite the same don't you
look at it doesn't look quite the same
but it does not behave the same why is
that so because if I said right here if
I said uh 10 right here let me say 10 +
5 and just you know write it down and
let me just compile it okay I'm not
going to upload it compile it right here
I'm not I'm not going to have any sort
of error but if I just do a string
version 10 right here okay a string 10
and try to add it up with
five if I add it up in five it doesn't
seem like there's a problem but if I
print it right here okay let me just
print it print this and a new line I
should be printing it in a new
line let me just print this in a new
line let's see what happens let me just
verify it and then let's upload it let's
see what happens when I add up the
string 10 with five okay so as soon as I
open my serial monitor it says comare is
already connected okay let me just get
back
here let me try to unplug my
Arduino and then let me unplug it back
in
okay now I think should be working let
me just try to upload
it okay so done compiling and I think
should be uploading by
now
okay so when I go to my serial monitor I
should be getting what I want to see
what happens when we add up 10 and then
five so let's see what happens when we
add up 10 and
five it's not printing
anything
let me just see if if it's even capable
of printing something let me just say
hello world okay let's just say that let
me try to upload it take off my serial
Monitor and it's done uploading
okay it's not okay there we go give us
her Hello World there we go so what I'm
going to do is you know what I think
it's not g to add it up just say 10
right here and I think it's capable of
adding it up let just go right here I'm
let just verify
it this okay St compiling let me just
upload
it hopefully we don't go into an
error all right nice now let's see what
happens we still not receiving anything
can you see it you're not receiving
anything but basically what happens is
we cannot add what we cannot add can you
see we cannot add strings to what to
numbers have you ever thought of adding
up a number to a text I don't think it's
even physically possible you know we
cannot even do it theoretically it's not
possible obviously it's what it this
sorry uh does not obey the law of math
obviously we cannot do what we cannot
add a text to what to a number so
basically we cannot add a string to what
to a number but if I say 10 plus 5 right
here 10 + 5 and let me try to verify it
and let me just try to upload
it there we go how about now try to
upload it it's done
compiling and it's uploading all right
it's done
uploading there you go it starts to give
me what the number 15 the number 15 the
number 15 10 + 5 is what 15 so that's
one thing I want you guys to keep in
mind okay so when you're working with
the when you're working with again those
serial
R strings what do they do their name
even gives us away what do they do they
always convert anything they print out
strings every time what they do they
always what when they store values they
what they put them in strings and what
they do they print it out in a what in a
new line okay all right so one thing you
need to know before actually you know
working with this before actually uh
finishing up is what we need to make it
we need to create a new line character
we need a new line character so that it
matches what this one right here right
because right here set color is what set
color is not only what we said it's a
string what does it also have it has a
new line it has a new line okay so it's
not going to be equal to it's not going
to be exactly equal to what to red again
if it was a human being it would have
understood obviously would have
understood that these things are equal
but when it comes to computers again
they take it what they take it literally
so it has to be literally equal if it's
not literally equal it's not going to
take it if I said red like this with a
space is equal to Red it's going to say
it's going to give me the output of what
it's going to give me the output of
false okay it's going to say it's false
it's not true but obviously if it was a
human what would they say say it is true
obviously as we can what we can account
for mistakes but computers to get they
take it what too literally so with that
in mind how do we represent the new line
characters is the big question this one
represents a space then how do we
represent a new line well if you go and
Google
right here just Google it right here if
you go to sln okay
sln uino new line do we know new line it
literally starts with a what with a back
slash n can you see it it says slash n
there we go slash n slash n okay that's
one thing I want you guys to understand
slash n so what you're going to be using
is a backs slash so it's going to be uh
B beneath your backspace or above your
Enter key so there's a back slash and
there's a forward slash okay don't use
the one that is what a forward slash use
the one that is what back slash okay so
even though you let's say you do not
have that character even on a keyboard
let's say for example using an old
keyboard and you don't have that
character what you're going to do is
just say backs slash say
backslash if you just find the backslash
all you have to do is copy it from here
there we go we can do is what copy it
from here again you guys can see right
here the back slash is right around here
okay so even if you cannot find it all
you have to do is what copy this and
paste it okay anyways so you represent
it with a backslash and an N okay n
stands for what for new line okay so let
me go over here and let's try to upload
it finally let's try to upload it and
now I hope everything should be working
because we went through lots of eras in
this section so okay let's go to our
serial monitor right now and let's see
and let's write down
red and finally it lights up what it
finally lights up as what it's finally
lights up as red there we go it finally
lights up as red
okay so that's one thing that's a very
very complicated thing but let me
explain to you guys why this is the case
okay so let me go over right here so for
those of you who are using an Arduino
version older version by the way but an
older version those leg Legacy verion
that are 1.8 you're not going to go
through this error it's going to work
for you perfectly fine okay so if you
just say red set color equals the red
it's going to perfectly work okay but
after um the ones that are using the
neard weo right now at the current time
of filming I'm using an Arduino uh let
me just go right here the verion is is
at the very top I'm using 2.1 there we
go 2.1.0 so if you're using something uh
around the two Series right here the
ardino 2 2 point something series okay
what's going to happen is what you're
going to have to use the new line okay
you're going to have to use the what the
new line character okay so for those of
you had uh again an older version The
Legacy version which is 1.8 you guys all
you need to do is what you guys only
need to write it down as a normal string
but for those of you there is what
there's the addition of what there's the
addition of new line every time so what
does this mean by the way one other
analogy we can use is actually a good
example would be print serial. print and
serial do what
serial.println all right print Ln what
did we do when we were using
serial.print this basically means what
it prints it out and it's next to each
other that's what happened when it comes
to print Ln what it did what it did was
it just printed the serial first it was
just a combination of what it was a
combination of basically serial what do
print and we added what at the very end
we added the character what with the
back slash right here again back slashes
are important the forward slash back sln
with the what with the new line
character that's basically it serial
print Ln was what serial print added
with what with the what with the back
slash and what character basically
meaning a what a new line okay that's
all I want you guys to keep in mind all
right so right here we just only added
red so let's add few more colors I think
this is going to be the most exciting
section of the course because uh we went
through a lot of Errors before even
getting close to here so let me just
remove all these codes that are
unnecessary all right there we
go let's just improve our code right
here okay so what else can I use right
here what can I say if
else or else if again let me go right
here what I say we used if else if else
if else if else again all right so how
do we write down that in our doino let
me just check that
out say else if
Aro let me just go over to an arino
again you always have to what you always
have to read documentation there's if
there's else and there's what else if
okay so the naming is different when it
comes towards what type of language
we're using but it's an if else or you
can call it an else if it's again
preference you can call it if else or
else if but you have to write it down as
else if when it comes to what tardo
there we go we have to write it down as
what else if I teach this as if else
because I was using a different I use a
different language to code and it's
written down as if else in another
language okay another coding language
but right here we have to write it down
as elsf all right so what I have to do
is right here is say okay this is not
red what I want it to be is what it's
all right I wanted it to what let's use
let's set up uh let's say this time
let's set up um Canan actually I want to
set up Canan I really want to set up C
obviously give it a new line right here
and then after giving a condition
obviously what do I want to do now I
want to do the analog right red pin
version I don't know what it is I have
to first I have to first what Google it
so let me say Canan
RGB
value the RGB value of Canan is what red
of zero green of 100 and a blue of 100
okay so let's just do that so let me go
right here red of what zero a green of
what 100 just go analog right green pin
and give it a 100 value and then what
analog
right of what
green sorry red blue blue of what 100
right here and let's set it up okay so I
want upload it let me just turn off my
serial monitor right here and I think
this good all right it's good let's go
to our Ser monitor right
here okay we're going to upload it right
now and should be working good let me
just try to say right now let me just
say red for now there we go have a
s there we go changes to S hopefully you
guys can see it let me just see if you
can see it it's somewhat what greenish
type of blue again if you can see it
looks beautiful then you can add more
colors too you can again add pink you
can add what purple it's up to you again
add your favorite colors this is going
to be a project add uh three or four of
your favorite colors and then fully
create what I just did right here okay I
just want you to do that that's not
that's all you have to do okay so
anyways uh this was a bit of a longer
section a big a bit of a bigger project
uh we finished it it was success so
anyways uh see you in the next
section okay so let's go to the section
so right now what we're going to be
discussing about today is Led displays
so the seven segment LED displays so
this is going to be our first time in
this course working with some sort of
display okay so this this display I
think you're familiar with it as in we
use it in digital watches not only
digital watches but calculators and even
when it comes to let's say we're going
to a gas station to again fuel up our
car we can see what we can see the price
per gallon stated by these type of
displays and even the total price being
what displayed on what by using uh these
type of displays so we see them very
very lot
often so what are their use their use is
we use them when we want to what when we
want to only get numbers or Alpha
numerals these are capable of what only
displaying Alpha numerals and numbers so
for example we have LCD screen when it
comes towards our laptops our uh devices
and all that they have a dedicated
display but what if you need a very
cheap display that is supposed to only
you know indicate number or sometimes
letter so so in this case the effective
solution is going to be what having
these cheap LED displays again they are
very very little not only that too but
they're very very cheap okay so when
we're using again when we don't want
these smart L LCD displays again to
again use them uh on devices that are
unnecessary when they're unnecessary we
use what we use LED displays so right
here we're going to be using it so right
here one thing you need to understand is
when it comes to LED
displays right here when you go over
there is a specific number associated
with your specific what with your
specific manufacturer basically the one
the type of what the type of LED display
seven segment LED display so before
doing anything what you first must do is
literally go here Google the name right
here say right now mine is 5611 as okay
you have to go to my let me just go over
to my screen right now so before running
anything first thing we need to do is
Google
5611 this again my number you you Google
your own number seven segment display
data sheet okay once you do that go
towards the link that has PDF or you can
go over and get the website check it for
yourself okay so I'm right here and one
of the things you can see what the size
you can see the emitting col it's going
to be red some of them are blue but most
of them are red and it has a common
cathode I'm going to get to this and
it's obviously single digit and it gives
me all the information I need on what on
this what on this LED display the seven
segment LED display okay so right here
you might be wondering what it why why
do we call it a seven segment LED
display so let me just go over right
here and when you just read this when
you just look at the seven components
right here let me just focus on the L 7
segment LED display when you look at
this when you count this let me just
actually use a pointer get my Sharp you
right here when you look at this when
you count this it has seven segments
count it if you count it there's one two
3 4 let just focus my again my camera on
the LED display five 6 7 there are seven
okay and it also has a decimal point my
one has a decimal point yours might not
have a decimal point included but most
of them do okay so it's going to vary as
I said from kit to Kit so again know
your number and read your sheet okay so
before moving forward I just want to
declare something called common capod
and common anode so they come in two
again they might seem the same as I said
looks can be very deceptive they seem
exactly the same but they function again
entirely differently okay so there are
going to be two types of what led seven
segment displays so this are going to be
common cathodes and then common anodes
okay so right here as again let me just
go to my documentation to my
screen when I do that it says that it's
a what it's a common cathode mine is a
common cathode so what does this mean so
let me go right here and try to explain
it for you guys with this image okay a
common cathode means is that there are
different as you can see all the
segments the seven segments are right
here there are seven segments and then
the decimal point right here and what
basically happens is what they are
connected to what to a single common
cathode okay they're connected to a
single what cathode so you can see
they're individually right here they
have their own individual pins as you
can see let me just go over to just go
over right here and show you in my
camera they have their own what just
focus on the there we go they have their
own pins as you can see right here here
they have their own pins okay and then
what happens is inside they're connected
to what they're connected to a common
cathode that's why they're called what
common cathode seven segment LED
displays okay when it comes to the
common an exactly it's exactly the same
thing okay it's exactly the same thing
what happens is what it's connected to a
what it's connected to a common anode
okay this time you might not know what
anode and cathode means but cathode
Bally means negatively charged anode
means what positively charged so to
actually give you guys a a meaningful
sentence what I'm going to do is draw a
simple circuit as we usually do let me
just do that the longer side is the
positive as we know the shortest side is
the
negative and let me just draw
that okay then once I'm done drawing it
there's a positive side and there's the
negative side side the positive side is
what the 5
Vol keep attention and the negative side
is what negative side is where the G and
D okay so when we say we have a common
cathode what do we mean we have a common
G and D pin okay so for example my case
it's a common cathode I'm going to have
what I'm going to need only one g& D
because why they have it all in common
so it's connected together so again
they're connected together at the very
end and they have what one common what
one common g& D pin when it comes to the
anode it's going to have what one
connected 5vt pin okay so I'm going to
try to go over both of them both common
anode and both common cathode so we
don't have to go through any other
videos you can just follow along this
course okay so let's get started so let
me just bring this right here let me
just put it and what I'm going to need
you to Google is right here go to seven
segment LED display write it down seven
segment LED
display right here once you do that go
to your Google images okay and they show
you the equivalent one the equivalent
pin so let me just go over to this one
this one looks better this one provides
a more detailed image there we go so
what can you see right here it say GF a
b basically indicating which segment
it's going to it's going to what it's
going to light up okay so G indicates
what this one so the first one that is
at the very very left right here at the
very very left is what the very very
left is what it's G then the next one is
f and the ones that are marked with
again an underscore a Hy you can see
right here are the common grounds okay
they're the ones that are going to be
what those are going to be G and D if
it's a common cathode and 5 volt if it's
a common anode okay I just want you to
keep that in mind and a and b and
there's e d c and also d right here okay
so with that in mind let me just try to
light up my common cathode uh LED let me
just do that let me just bring my LED
right here what do I need I need
resistance right here by the way it's
recommended that you use 500 to 1,000
ohms of resistance okay so 500 to 1,000
ohms of resistance the resistance is
going to be applied to who the is going
to be applied to every individual pin
okay except for the what for the common
anode or for the common C Cod okay
except for the common cathode and common
anode we're not going to apply the as I
said again we're not going to apply the
resistance but where we're going to
apply it is we're going to be applying
it to every individual what segment okay
let's just keep that in mind okay so let
me just do that and bring this oh just
threw a
resistor I'll try to find it later
anyways um so right here when I go to my
the screen again it's going to be my
guide okay the G is located at the the
very very what at the very very left let
me just again unplug my adino so I can
get it
closer and all I need to do is what
connect the G right here let just go
over right here so you can see it I'm
going to connect the
G and then I have a wire let me just get
a wire right here okay I have a wire
right
here okay but first let me connect the
common one what do I have I'm using what
a common cathode so it's going to have
what when I'm using a common cathode it
has what it has a common gnd D let me
just connect that the gnd D is found in
third leg so let me just do that so let
me bring a black pin for the gnd D let
me bring a black pin right here count
one two three and here we
go there we go connect this to the gnd
let me just do do that and what I'm
going to connect it to is a what I'm
going to be connecting it to a pin right
here let me just connect it to 5 volt
for now just to show you how it works
but I'm going to be connecting it to a
pin when we're working with a project so
just to show you how it works let me
just connect it to a 5vt there we go
connected it to a 5vt and now what do I
expect the G the G to to light them the
G's found in the middle it's the middle
segment it's the middle segment so I
expect this to light up okay the
resistor should be intact I'm using a
1,000 Ohm
resistor you guys can use anything
between 500 and 1,000
Ms and this should be working
hopefully okay can you see
that can you see that what's happened
the common the common uh sorry the
common capod is right but what happened
was what did I do wrong I got the
decimal point light up up instead of
what instead of the the G what did I do
wrong what did I did was I flipped it
okay what I did was what I flipped it I
was supposed to put it like this
supposed to flip this like this the
decimal should be here and then put it
down like this first let me unplug my
adreno because again I don't want to get
the Pence
wrong right I think there we go that
should be
it
excuse me all right so now let me just
plug back the
ardino there we go now it's working let
me just turn off the light so you can
see it better there we go the middle
what the middle segment is lighting up
nice so now let's just go to the ones
who have common anode let's see how you
guys can actually do it let me just
check that and in the next section we're
actually going to build the project with
it so let me just go over to my screen
again because I don't have specifically
I don't have uh my own I don't have a
just go to my Tinker C right here
specifically I don't have a I don't have
an anode a common anode seven segment
LED display so I'm going to have to use
a digital
Ardo just creade
that it's going good now what I'm going
to need is an ardino get an ardino
there we
go what else do I need a
breadboard breadboard I can get a small
one for now I'm just trying to light up
what a single display then we're going
to go to our project okay and then what
do I need I need uh a seven segment let
just write it down seven segment there
you go seven
segment not getting anything just seven
segment there we go seven segment
display okay so I'm going to set it to
what a common anode right here so you
guys can actually see how it's done so
as I said again a common anode what do
we have let me just bring back the paper
I'm not going to need this anymore let
me just bring back the paper common
anode we can have a common 5vt pin okay
so let me just connect the common one
right here so I I said again we have one
thing to always keep in mind by the way
let me just go to the
image do we have the image okay there we
go all we have to do is connect one of
these again common PS okay one of these
we going have to connect both of them
okay we don't have to connect one 5V and
another 5vt all we have to do is connect
one of them okay all you need to do is
what connect one5 Volt or one 15 volt
when it comes to a common anode when it
comes to a common cathode what you need
to do is what connect what um one common
what gnd D not like two G&S all right so
you can choose either one and just
connect it
okay all right so with that in mind all
you need to do is I'm going to connect
the 5 volt right here to the third leg
third one is here the comment there you
go once I'm done doing that I'm going to
use a resistance on the gnd D let me
just get a
resistance let just get a resistor
resistor there we go got a resistor what
value 1 kilohm basically meaning 1,000
ohm let me just roll
it let me just rotate it so that it fits
me let me try to light up a different
segment here let me try to light up this
one I don't know what what this one is
it's B which one is B let me just see
which one is B okay so I'm going to be
lighting up this part I'm going to be
lighting what the right one the right
the right upper one the right upper one
okay so let me just go here and I'm
going to need my I'm going to be using
what I'm not going to be using g& D
don't get that WR wrong okay I'm not
going to be using gnd D I'm going to be
using distal pins yes I can use a gnd d
for
now let me just try to use a gnd d for
now let's see what happens never used
the gnd with
that yeah let me just just land it on
gnd D see what happens
actually I think it should light up
there we go it lights up as you can see
it it lights up so we're going to do
again uh so right now what we did is can
light up a common anode and a common
cathode so for those of you again who're
going to follow along with a common
anode I'm also going to again provide
you with the course right here so you
guys do not need to again go to another
uh YouTube video or another another
documentation to understand because I'm
going to be covering both common anode
and common cathode okay so in the next
section we're actually going to build a
project so um see you
then
okay so what do I want to do for this
project what I want to do for this
project is build somewhat of a simple
timer so I wanted to count from nine all
the way up to zero so I wanted to go 9 8
7 6 5 4 3 2 one and end it at zero okay
so we're just want to build somewhat of
a what personal timer okay so first how
we do that so first what do we need to
do we need to plug all the components
here
obviously we did not plug any components
and then we're going to go over to code
so let's first plug our components okay
so again as I said the third one the
third one is what the third one is the
common ground here for me it's a common
cathode so I'm going to be what using
what a common what a common G and D okay
that's all we said all right so let me
just get this over with and just bring
this there we go so instead of using
normal wires what I'm going to be using
is strapped on wires wires that are
strapped to each other so when you look
at them they're strapped to each other
it makes things way easier for me as all
I need to do is what connect connect it
continuously and then what and then all
I have to do is connect it continuously
here too so it's going to be way easier
than using again normal wires okay than
using normal wires but if you don't have
any of these strapped uh these strapped
type of uh wires the normal wires are
perfectly fine they don't make any
difference in terms of conductivity or
anything only the only reason I'm using
them is I want to introduce new
components too I only that too but it
makes it way easier because once I put
them right here let's say I set up the
five pins that I'm supposed to be
connecting here once I set up the five
pins right here all I need to do is what
see it relatively from here so I go
Brown is first okay Brown is here and
you know and go right here Brown is here
and then relatively tell what the
distance from here I don't have to go
the whole way back here just to tell
which pin is connected to which pin so
it makes it way easier especially when
connecting what when when connecting
wires that are closely to each other
right here I have five pins to connect
to just check it right here five pins
right I've got five pins to connect to
right here and five pins from here too
okay so let me just get started so let
me just arrange this so that it matches
the color there we
go right seems to okay purple needs to
be in the middle right here all right
there we go simple Arrangement now let
get started so let me just start with
brown right
here all
right what what did I do wrong right
here I forgot to put my resistors first
resistors do what they come first okay
so obviously I have to connect my
resistors first and then I'm going to be
connecting my wires so let me bring my
resistors right here again I'm using
1,00 ohm resistors okay I have a
collection of them 1,000 ohm resistors
but again you can you guys can obviously
use anything between 500 to 1,000 okay
so it doesn't directly have to be 1,000
okay so let me just put this
here what I'm going to do is I'm going
to move the resistors across okay that's
what I'm going to try to do right here
there we
go try to move it across now let's
connect the first one right here just
focus here there we go it's connected
now I keep on bringing res resistors
first let me connect all the resistors
and then I'm going to continue and
connect it to the
wires let me just do that okay you see
what I did right here I connected a
different the second pin but obviously
they ended up in the same row so all I
need to do is again widen it a bit and
there we go aim for it okay I pushed it
a bit there we go come on it's a bit of
a hustle to actually connect them when
you have a little amount of space
okay so it did
connect yep did connect right here all
right nice now I'm going to bring
another resistor let me try to find the
one that is wider let me just widen it
up
myself all
right now the third one what am I going
to do to the third pin as we said again
when you look at the diagram we have two
common pins all right we have two common
pins this is the third pin right here
it's going to be the common one the
third pin right here just point it using
my resistor it's going to be what the
common the same goes here too it's going
to be the common so again when it comes
to the common I'm not going to use any
resistance I'm going to be only using
resistance for what for the separate
segments here all the segments so let me
skip the third
one I'm go to the fourth
one okay you need to be really careful
not to connect the wrong PIN the WR
resistor to the wrong place everything
can go wrong once you plug it once you
plug your Arduino if you don't be
careful
okay wait
slowly let me let me weiten this a
bit all right there we go now let me
just check it okay when you look at here
I connected one two I skip the third now
the fourth is connected and the fifth is
connected and all of them are not in the
similar not in the same row I just want
to keep that there I don't want them to
be in the same
row okay all right they're not in the
same row now I can start using again
these pins so let me just do
that we just go here it's a bit a hard
one when you're picking it the
breadboard up it's really hard all right
there we go connecting to the first
resistor here
and then the next color is white let me
go get
white okay I need to go
here all right the third color is
silver let me get
silver okay let me just see that you
guys can actually see it there we
go can you guys see it there we go
connect the third one and the fourth
resistor the fourth and the final
resistor from this
side right connect this one obviously
what did I not do right now I did not
connect my g& D pins so let me go over
right here okay let me go over where's
my gnd D pen let me just bring a
separate wire for gnd D okay I'm just
going to bring a separate wire it'll be
preferred if I again bring a black one
because we use black wires to connect
gnd D just to maintain the code if I can
I have a long black wire trying to look
for one okay there are no black long
black wires so I'm just going to use
blue I cannot find it or I did I think
this one is this one is long okay there
we go found a black long wire so I'm
going to connect the G and D let me just
do
that it's supposed to be one two it's
supposed to be right
here okay it's a bit of a hustle again
let me connect this to the GM
D we have a common ground pin just
connect it to
it all right there we go connected it to
gnd all right now obviously we have a wi
from other side now I don't have enough
space here as you can see I only have
one row of space right here I have one
column of space because I said again
this LEDs this led is Big so what I'm
going to be doing is creatively I think
a creative idea is to use use a smaller
breadboard so I'm going to be connecting
it what with the resistor across here
and then I'm going to be using a smaller
breadboard and connecting it here it's
better that way so let me just do that
so let me forget about these wires right
now just put them right
here uh let me just make sure that I
have the numbers intact it has numbers
on it so I'm going to be referencing the
numbers right here on the breadboard let
me just bring it Clos so you can see it
there you go they have numbers 1 two 3
and I want to again reference this one
okay so let me just do that just take
off this one for a moment it's a bit of
a hard
one okay connected our first
resistor then our second
resistor we're not going to be using the
common as I said again we're going to be
using one of the common pins so as I
said again we have two common pins and
we have two common pins but we're going
to be using only one okay so you either
can use this one or you either can use
this one you don't use both of them so
right here I'm going to skip it I'm not
going to touch any of it okay I already
connected the g&d from this side so I
don't need to connect it from this side
so the third pin is going to be skipped
totally okay now let me go to the fourth
one the four line right
here all right have to push it a
bit they're a bit hard resistors to put
in just let me first just
straighten now myself okay just make it
straight focus on the resistor for now
let me bring it closer and actually
focus on the
resistor there we go you know what I'm
going to do is straight on out once I'm
done studying it out I'm just going to
do is bend it okay there we go bend
it there we go now let's focus on
the on putting it back in because this
said again the resistors they do not fit
in properly sometimes and it can be a
big of a
problem this did not fit the
best I think it's going to cause me
problems but I think it fits actually I
think it fits but might cause me
problems in the after a bit while so let
me just bring my final resistor connect
it
okay I'm going to connect the Fifth
Line into the fifth
pin there we go can you see it I connect
the fifth one I cannot pick it up as I
said again because there is side going
to fall apart so I'm just going to move
it very very slowly to the middle so you
guys can see the frame right there we go
just need to be very careful with it
okay now I'm going to be connecting this
blue wires
as you can see I don't have enough what
enough length to go here so what I'm
going to do is just going to move this
totally so what I'm going to do is from
purple to Blue there's what there's a
difference in so I have to change my
Direction so what I'm going to do is
wrap it more can you see this I'm just
going to separate it can be separated
there we go
slowly can you see me I'm separating it
I don't want to separate it completely
if I do that then it's going to be
useless there we go so it has more space
I want to move a bit of the resistors I
don't want them to move that
much there we go we got our
first then we need our second what comes
after blue green all right let just use
the
green there we go third one is going to
be orange
or actually yellow yellow's the next one
not orange I can see it for I can see
the colors from here so it has to be
after green has to be orange sorry
yellow so I'm going to bring yellow not
orange see that well that's why it's
very
useful it helps me again okay I'm going
to skip the third pin and go to the
fourth one it's very useful because I
can just reference it from here they're
attached so when I'm using a lot of pins
I can just when when they're put next to
each other I can use this type of wires
because they make wiring way much easier
because if I just wired them with this
normal again wires I'm going to come
back here check everything track back
everything like this and then see where
they're connected and it's going to be a
bit of a hustle okay so I connected
these four I skipped the third one and I
connected the fourth all right good I
don't want to move it too
much it's moving a lot I don't like
that not a big fan of it moving
the resist don't seem to be holding them
in place because they're
weak wait seems to be moving a lot okay
so what I'm going to do is separate the
wires again I think the wires are just
having a lot of tension on them but
actually I can keep it like this to be
honest because yeah I can keep it like
this if everything is intact let me just
check it everything seems to be intact
so I can keep it like this actually but
I just need to be careful when I move
the wires again when I flip this we just
slowly flip it
ooh it's moving a
lot all right I'm just going to try to
flip
it all right let me just connect to some
random PIN so that it holds together I'm
going to come back and solve this I'm
just going to connect it to some random
pins again obviously don't turn your
arrina while you're doing this it's
dangerous can just short the circuit
right here I just connected it so that
again it just moves okay I just
connected it randomly all right just
make sure that your aring is not turned
on when you do that okay so right here
let me just think of the pins that I'm
going to be using I'm going to be using
digital pins okay because I said again
I'm going to be using digital right
right here I'm going to be using digital
right so I'm going to be using digital
pit so I'm going to to use this side
this is where my digital pins are so I'm
going to be using the digital pins so
again
slowly doesn't seem to be holding the
best wait
wait let me just put these right here so
that it doesn't move a lot I'm not going
to be using them but again just so that
it doesn't move a lot and holds it in
place okay there we go all right so let
me go over to the other
side it's a bit of a
hustle let's go over to the other side
and now try to use these spins so I
connected what purple pin so I need to
get my purple pin first purple pins
black pin all of these that are here I
need to First them up hold this
together okay so let me start with the
black pen I'm just going to start from
digital pen three okay you might be
wondering why I'm using digital pin 3
instead of digital pin one why not start
with digital pin one might be wondering
well the thing is they're still pin one
and they're still pin U zero they're
also used in binary so as most case as
possible I try to leave them alone okay
I don't I don't try to touch them as
much as I can but obviously you can use
them for digital pins but they're also
used for binary so I always again
reserve them so I just don't touch them
okay because just think of me filling up
digital pin zero and one and let's say I
want to use binary then I'm I'm have to
arrange the whole thing again okay so I
just leave them alone most of the time
but they work as a normal dish to pin
okay so again you guys can actually use
them but it's just again not a practice
as much as you can don't use them if you
have to though you can use them they're
perfectly fine to be
used let me start with digital pin
two digital pin three sorry I said
digital pin three this hard to even see
it three there we go after black what
comes after black
white ifal pin B then what comes after
white gray I'm trying to get the
gray there we go and then after gray
comes
[Music]
purple there we
go then afterwards after after uh purple
comes blue which is right
here let me go get
it
then after purple comes
green let me just make sure that I not
skip anything there we go got
yellow then at the final one I have what
I have
brown obviously discluding the uh again
the gnd D or the common pins I have what
pins how many pins to connect I had 10
pins to connect and again discarding dis
disregarding two common pins it's going
to be eight pins so let me just count
this if I'm correct one 2 3 4 5 6 7
eight so I connected eight bins let me
just make sure the white is the yellow's
connected properly there we
go and now everything is
connected again I just need to be more
careful okay again I'm using this again
as a support they're not connected to
anything just keep that in
mind don't want to move them bit I have
to move them a bit right I'm not going
to touch it afterwards there we go let
me just bring my ardino
wire hold there we go I'm just get my
ardino wire let me wire up my adino just
bring the wire let me just keep it here
okay it was a bit of hustle to again
even connected okay so now let's start
writing down the pins let's start giving
them names okay let's begin so go right
here and give start giving them names
okay so the first pin that we're going
to be giving out name to is pin three
first things first again we need to
understand what part is going to be
lighting up okay so be first I'm going
to need what I'm going to need the
diagram just get the diagram I say seven
segment LED
display let's go to
images and should find a diagram that
has there we go we find a diagram that
has what their namings okay so let me
start from here the very most left from
here from this side it's going to be
what the very most left side is what
it's going to be the black one the black
wire the black wire is connected to what
to pin number three okay it's connect to
pin number three what is it decimal
point so what I'm going to say here is
integer
DP what is it it's pin number three
integer what else is there and keep
comparing them so what I'm going to do
is going actually there we go divide
them into two right here so you guys can
actually see them let me just get the
image let just get the image the full
image let just open the image open the
image UT tab let's get the whole image
there we go all right so now what
iConnect the decimal point then
afterwards is white pin white is
connected to what to pin number four
which is what is it it's C so all you
need to do is what C is of course to pin
number four then integer again keep
saying that then we skipped it and then
we went to what we went to the silver
one which is going to be D so D's set to
what pin five it's going to be easy
after e set to what pin six because
they're set to what to next each other
okay then afterwards what I need to do
is we're done with this row so I need to
go to the other one we need to go this
side so we're going to need to check
this one too okay so the blue starts at
the very left the blue starts from here
as you can see the blue starts from here
it's connected to the very left okay the
next after uh purple is what is blue so
it's going to go after six it's going to
be seven so this one is going to be
seven okay so the very left again you
need to keep referencing what the
decimal point is how you're going to be
referencing it okay so let's look at the
image so is it going to be what it's
going to be pin what segment what
segment B it's going to be segment B
what do it said to pin
seven keep going on and then a set to
what
eight then afterwards again we skip the
third one the common pin and then we go
to F which is going to be set to pin
nine and again the final one G set to
what it's set to pin 10 so let's even
see if it ends on pin 10 and starts at
Pin three
let me just look at
it it's a bit of a hard
one if you cannot move your Arduino it's
really hard to actually look at
it okay back pin 12
okay it's really hard to actually get a
hold of these let me just look at it so
again let's see if I made a mistake or
not let me just move it slowly
see that I stopped at Pin nine not pin
10 might have made a mistake here we
connected four pins here and four pins
here how much should it add up to I'm
supposed to be using what eight pins
okay how many integers did I set up
eight integers I'm correct on this one
did I start from three or two maybe I
might have started from two
let me just check
it it is connected to pin it's connected
to pin 3 or pin two it's connected to
pin 3 I'm checking it and it's connected
to pin three
pin four five 6 7 8 n and then it
doesn't seem to be connected to pin 10
did I forget about let me just check the
number of pins that I connected here
okay so I think I made a mistake right
here because supposed to be extending to
pin 10 and it's not touching pin 10 so
let me just count the number of pins
here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 I'm supposed to be
connecting eight pins so I did a mistake
right here I made a mistake right here H
what could it
I made a simple mistake most likely so
let me just check again all I need to do
is what since they're what since as I
said again they're connected pins it's
going to be really easy when I make a
mistake so let me just check it right
here so I
connected I don't not connect the green
pen because I'm sure I connected okay
there we go I connected green pen but I
connect green pen so what did I do I
connected Brown pin here instead of
Green ooh just so wrong
again
let me just all I need to do is check it
so let me just check the colors I
connected black and then white and then
gray which makes sense and then purple
if I'm correct there we go connected
purple and then blue and then yellow
blue and then yellow but I forgot about
Green in the middle right here I'm not
conect I'm not supposed to be what
connecting green right here I'm supposed
to be connecting green not yellow oh I
made a mistake right here that
happens we just try to solve
it
there we go made a simple mistake but it
was easy to solve why is that so I'm
using attached pins that's why they're
very very important as things get
complicated it's going to be really
really hard to fix them it would have
taken me at least 10 minutes to even
find the problem if I was using normal
pins but with just using this pins I
just made it really really
easy okay and then what after green
comes
yellow now am I correct again did I make
a simp another
mistake okay now it's connected what how
many pins one two
three three four five 6 7 and then I
have an orange pin did I connect an
orange pin here yes I did but I
connected it to
what ooh instead of connecting this one
see what I did wrong here instead of
connecting an orange pin I connected a
brown pin here the brown is the very
very edge I'm not supposed to do that
again so I made a mistake here let me
just solve that remove the brown and
what is next to Yellow it's orange I'm
supposed to be connecting orange I made
a mistake my
bad and there we go now I fix it and now
I also connect the orange from this
side okay now everything seems to go
okay everything seems to be right all
right let me just again connect these
two pin so that they hold the small
breadboard together just going to kind
of here so that it does not move a lot
again they have no purpose of than
holding the breadboard the red and the
brown pin okay so now I think the wiring
is right and now I set up what
everything the name is Right extends to
what to 10 from 2 to 10 so everything
seems to be correct from so I said two I
me three 3 to 10 so everything seems to
be right so now let me go over to my
code and now let me just go to p P mode
and set everything up pin
mode and set everything up so we have
decimal point set it to what set it to
Output all right keep copying this
alternate shift down keep copying it and
then I can do what I can change the
names so I'm going to start with
CDE let just go
C and then there's
d
and then there's what there's
[Music]
e and then there's B just go to
B and then there's what and then there's
a and then there's
F and then there's
G okay let me just remove the final one
let me just count the pins there're
supposed to be eight one let just count
it one two 3 4 five six seven eight
they're eight pins okay good now what I
need to do just to light up everything
I'm going to need to do is what use
digital write okay and send my pen right
here let me just start again decimal pin
and set it to
high once I'm done with that for to
light every component right now what do
I need to do again I'm going to need to
write the disal right I'm I'm going need
to copy it it's going to be second two 3
4 five 6 7even eight okay now where do I
go now let me write them down CDE e
c
d
e and then after e there's ba a b
a
f and then finally
G there we go so now let's just upload
it well before I need to upload it
though what do I need to do I need to
wire up my Adeno so I'm going to move
this again slowly
it's going to be a bit of a hustle
because if things go wrong right now and
the resistors go wrong it's going to be
really really
sad because the amount of what wiring it
took going to attach both and slowly
move it
again need to be gentle very very gentle
because this resistors again can just
pop out really just push it a bit okay
now let's just try to turn on our
adrino okay now let's just verify our
sketch let's do that verify my sketch
hopefully everything's good okay it's
good now what now I can compile it's
compiling and now it's done uploading
okay can you see it it's not fully
leading up uh just need to move this a
bit
okay just going to move it a bit so you
can see it the wires there we go let me
just focus on them let me just turn off
the one light right here so you can
focus at it not everything is turned on
why is that so it's the resistors again
let me just if I touch one resistor
right here look at it if I just touch
one resistor lights up it's because the
resistors are not what connected
properly okay so let me just again push
the resist a
bit there we go push this one in this
one is pushed
improperly everything seems to be intact
here all right okay let me just check
the other resistors right
now oh there we go can you see
it the second resistor is not connected
properly slowly we need to go
slow just push it
okay there we go how about this one the
gpin I think it's the very left one
because I put it at the very
edge it's not lighting
up okay this pit right there we
go
let's push this it's a bit of a
hustle let me try to push in this one
and what what is not lighting up what
segment is not lighting up right now
okay this this segment is because of
this resistor this resistor seems to be
working fine how about this
resistor okay both of them okay I see so
again wiring it up is a big problem if
itself especially with this resistors
they don't
hold and place and I find it really hard
can you see
that okay so they're not holding in plus
two so what I'm going to do is again fix
the resistors this resistor let me just
see if this is even correct because not
all of them are on just again so you can
see that not all of them are
on so for those of you are using a
digital art we know it's going to be
really easy for you guys it's going to
be way easier than
here again due to the limitation we have
again and components we going to have to
find a way to work around it okay
everything seems to be working fine but
the middle pin right here let me just
check what is even the name of the pen
let just check the name of the pen okay
so let me go to my Chrome the middle pen
is the gpin okay where is the
gpin which one is connected to the
middle pin how am I supposed to know
that uh let me again check the image G
is supposed to be around here okay G is
around here at the very edge the very
edge but the res at the very edge is not
working
basically let me just check if it even
if it's wired up
correctly I'm just need to remove this
it's not doing much of a thing
slowly okay let me just again straighten
out the
resistor hopefully you can see it let
just bring my light out
make a focus on the
resistor the focus is bad I'm just going
to straighten out my
resistor just focused on the LED right
now okay straight it and out there we
go now I'm going to have to carefully
put it back in just again a hustle just
do
that
oh I see the problem here too I do not
push it in let me just push in my L just
push it in first there we go now it's
pushed in our LED is pushed in only what
only one line is
not only one line is missed right here
can turn off my light so you can see it
better only one line is not is not
appearing what is it it's the line F
which is going to be next to what next
to G so the res next to G is not
lighting up properly let me just check
why it's not lighting up properly I'm
just turn on my light right
here it's a bit of hustle as I said
again oo I's see what the problem
is there we go push it in and then
slowly let go slowly let go let me just
turn off both the light so we can see
what we did right here it looks
beautiful okay turn it
off and turn it off for let me just turn
off the other one there we go now
everything is lighting up including the
what the decimal point all right nice
okay let me just go right here and do
exactly what I just did I'm going to
light up two three pins on the common
anode I'm using a common cathode so I'm
going to show you guys how to do it in a
common anode just in case you do not
know okay so let me just go right here
this is a common an that I said just
turn this off let me just take this off
let me delete this first where's the
delete button there we
go just let me just first bre it and
then there we
go delete this delete the
resistor so basically what do you do is
what we have a common what we have a
common this is a common anode so what do
we do we have a common what I have a
common 5 volt so what I'm going to do
right here is connect the 5V right here
the common 5 volt to the third pin again
I can use the one that is at the bottom
right here or I can use the one at the
top it's up to me there we go now once
I'm done connecting the 5 volt just give
it a color right here so that it's
easier to track again okay and just
change the color right here to Red there
we go the 5 Vol and now I'm going to
start connecting what I'm going to start
connecting using resistors so I'm just
connect uh one let me just light up one
two three segments and then I'm sure
that you can do the rest of it okay I'm
sure that you can light up the rest of
it so I'm me just go right here it has a
resistance of 1 kils okay basically
1,000s and now let me just rotate
it just rotate it right now
okay so you might be wondering how to
turn it on using a digital pin all we
did was what there's the five volt in
the ground pin so I'm just going to show
you guys how to use a digital pin and
just light it up okay another resistor
here let me slide up this part
too okay just rotate
it
right there we go let me start writing
code for this so uh before doing that
actually I need to what I need to
connect the wires so I'm going to
connect this wire right here to digital
pin three let me start from pin three
just give this another color let me
start with orange go and let's give this
another color too First Connect this to
digal pin 4 there we go give it another
color so you can see way better I'm just
going to zoom in so you can see the
circuit way better okay there you go
that's the circuit that I'm going to be
using you can pause the video and check
it for yourself okay all right now let
me just go to the code so what you need
to do is basically the opposite when it
comes to what when it comes to the
common what the common cathode okay so
I'm go text and use text so what I'm
going to do is let me just again set up
variables I want you to do it yourself
for those who have common anode I'm sure
you guys can do it just have to follow
the same step but there's going to be a
difference I'm just going to show you
the difference here okay that's
basically what you need to do um let me
just bring the seven segment where is it
the seven segment image I'm going to be
connecting B right
here just see it it's going to be let me
just take off the code for now I'm going
to be connecting B and and from
underneath here I'm going to be
connecting what I'm going to be
connecting the decimal point okay let me
connect the decimal point and B very is
b b is around here so I'm going to be
lighting this and this up okay so let me
go to our
code then what let me just turn off all
this code right here I don't want
that so I'm going to say B what what
what pin is it it's pin three let's
connect digital pin three and what do we
have decimal point it's going to be
connected to what to what the digital
pin 4 then what I need you to do is what
right here set it up as we did normally
set it up pin mode set be to what the
output just get the capitalization right
pin mode set the decimal point two to
what to
Output output there we go and all you
need to do right here is instead of
using Dish right again you're going to
be using digital right and setting it to
high what you're going to be setting it
to is
low okay we're going to be setting it to
what to low basically almost acting like
a what it's going to act like a g& d pin
okay so I'm going to do decimal point
and setting it to low I set again so let
me just start the simulation right
here and let's just move our code and
there you go B and decimal point is what
they're activated so what I want you to
do again to light up everything is what
again connect all these components
yourself just like how I did using my
common cathode again connected and then
write every code obviously for Tom and
Anna you're going to be using what
you're going to be setting it to low
okay that's all you need to do instead
of high you're going to be setting it to
what to low okay so just keep that in
mind so now what I did is what what I
did is set it up to what to light up
everything so to even make a timer right
now let me go over to my arino IDE
let me go to my IDE there we go so now
what do I need to do I want to set it to
what I want it to count from nine then
go to eight then go to 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 and
then finally going to what to zero okay
that's what I wanted to do so again I
turned all of this just to check that
everything is connected I turned out
everything to high just to see that
they're connected and now they're
successfully connected because
everything's on I just wanted to check
if everything is on so that does not
give me does not cause me problems later
on
okay oh I just turned off the pin mode
sorry I was supposed to uh Delete the
high ones accidentally I accidentally
cut this sorry I just put it back uh I
want to do is what take off the digital
rights not the pin mode pin mode I
needed it's a bit of
hard there we
go
there we go now for n what do we need to
light up for n we need to light up what
so let me start from here I just copied
this okay okay I want you to do is what
before cutting this okay I want you to
copy it again that I set it all of it to
high I want you to copy it and going
turn it off right here what I want you
to do is for night what segments do we
want to light up so we go over right
here we want to light up what we want to
light up where is nine there we go for
nine we're going to need to light up
what a b g c and d a b g c andd so what
I'm going to do right here is bring a
paper I think it's going to make it way
easier let's first write it down I think
it's better that way so I'm just bring a
paper right
here BR some
paper just go get it there we
go all right there we go found the paper
right here let me go get my
Sharpie the Sharpie there you go found
my Sharpie I don't want to push this a
lot so I'm just slowly move it because I
need that space Oh my God it's very very
very very
hard just moved it a bit and the pin B
just turned off there we go just push it
back in okay there we go okay so for
nine what do I need
what do I need to turn on for nine let
me just keep writing this for nine what
do I need to turn on I need to turn on a
b g c d so I need to turn on
a b g c and d let me just make sure
again a b g c d all right for eight what
do I need to turn on for eight I need to
turn on everything everything from what
from
a to G I'm going to need to turn on all
of it I can add the decimal point but I
don't need to all right so for um seven
right here what do I need to turn on I
need to turn on a b
c a b c yeah a b c for uh seven then six
let me write the numbers down for it's
easier that way one then end it to zero
okay for for six what do I need to turn
on a f g let me first go a f j a f g and
then e c
d e c d basically turn on everything
except for B then go to number five what
do I need to turn on I need to turn on
afg
afg AF FG and then CD just write that
down CD for number four what do I need
to turn on for number four I need to
turn on uh
fgb just write that down FG B and then I
need to turn on what C that's what I
need to turn on C then for number three
I did not write down number three
properly there we go for number three
what do I need to turn on a b
g a b g and then C and
D let me just check it again a b g c and
d yeah C and D for number two what do I
need to turn on I need to turn on a b g
e a b basically G and then an
e a b g e and then a finally a d okay
for number one what do I need to turn on
I think number one is the easiest one I
can either turn on BC or Fe I'm just
going to go to BC I'm going to choose
BC there you go and then finally for
number zero what do I need to turn on
everything except for G we just write
that down
everything everything except for except
for
G okay there we
go okay so that's all I need to turn on
so let me start turning this on
okay so let's go back again to our
Domino
code our doino ID and now let's start
let me just right here number what
number nine for number nine what do I
need to turn on again I'm going to cop
paste this again what I'm going to need
to turn on is
what the decimal point I can remove the
decimal point I don't need to turn it
off on I can moove the decimal point
okay what do I need to turn on a b g and
C and D so I'm going to leave C I'm
going to leave D I'm going to leave I'm
not going to leave
e I'm going to leave b and a that's it
that's all I need to turn on except for
what G okay there we go so I'm going to
remove f and g there we go so this is
for what for number nine how about for
number eight just write down number
eight number eight for number eight what
do I need to turn on again paste this
first and then I'm going to need to
remove decimal point and then I'm going
to turn on everything from a to G so I'm
not going to touch anything everything's
from a to G is already written there we
go and then for
number seven okay what do I need to turn
on for number seven a b and then C okay
A B and then C for number seven let me
just let me go to my clipboard right
here control
Z just go here and just say windows and
V just go to my
clipboard I forgot about this I
accidentally just
uh I accidentally there you go again
copy this again and just turn it off I
can paste it there we go so now what I'm
going to turn off decimal point and then
what do I need turn off everything
except for ABC okay so I'm going to turn
this off turn this off turn this off and
this off so let me just check how code
goes until until here let me just check
it so let's just try and upload it it's
compiling and then it's done
uploading what did I do wrong right here
doesn't even look like any number right
here it doesn't even look like a number
looks like a six an inverted nine from
my perspective for you guys it most like
looks like six which is way wrong so
wrong right here h there is a problem
now
okay so what I need to do right
here is what give it a delay I forgot a
delay oh so let me just give a variable
right here let me say delay time time
I'm going to set it to uh second I want
it every second so I want it to decrease
every second so I'm I'm going to give
give it a delay between every number
that's what I need to do so let's see
how it progress so
delay
time just give
that keep writing delay time for every
number delay I'm going to give it a
delay of what delay time delay time
there we go anded semic call in at the
very end put a
semicolon and then finally give this to
a delay time delay for a
delay time delay time there we go delay
time and then let's set it up
okay now let's see what
happens I gave all of them a delay T
let's just see what happens again let me
just try to go
again that seems so wrong doesn't it it
seems so
wrong what could we have possibly done
wrong let me try to again turn on
everything first okay so let me just try
to go right here and then at the very
end I want to do is turn on everything
let just try to do
that so what did I do wrong here I do
not know let's turn this off well what
did I do wrong I forgot the curly
bracket right here at the very end of
our Loop code uh what did I do wrong let
me just turn off this one just put it
down here what did I do
wrong I think everything seems fine so
let me just see everything's even coiled
up properly so if everything is even
what it's even the resistors might be a
problem so let me just check the
resistors out the problem
here let me try to find
my there we go finally I'm going to set
it to all if it to high so we can
actually see it ourselves is it the
resistors that are making a problem
right here again or are they the are is
it or is it our code
let me just
check I be
resistors let me just turn off the light
so you can see way better okay when I
finally turned it to what all it to high
everything seems fine what could we have
done wrong
then H okay we don't even see nine at
first did we see nine first number nine
did we see nine properly so we got C D B
A and G let me give the delay time even
let's give it a more time let me just
see 3 seconds every 3 seconds why is
that so because I want to see where the
error arises okay where the error starts
so let me look here even the nine is not
correct and then it change the number
okay so what could have done wrong here
is what what I believe we could have
done wrong here is naming it while we're
naming the variables so again I made a
mistake it happens as I said again but
right now I can again check it what
relatively that's the best part of it
you can check it what relatively so let
me go over here and let me bring my
diagram again I went through the another
mistake again it happens but right here
there's a black wire the black is
connected to what to pin two what does
the black indicate the black indicates
what decimal point right yeah the black
is the one that's connect the closest
one if I'm correct yes the resistor goes
here and then it's connected to this one
so it's connect the closest one so the
Black Goes what to the what to the
decimal point am I correct it goes to
the what to the decimal point all right
it's connect decimal point what did I
give it it's pin what it's pin what it's
the first pin it's pin what we start
from pin three so this should be correct
okay this should be correct and then
let's go to the white one the white one
seems to be connected to the other one
let me just again keep checking on the
wires just going to keep on doing
that okay I see the problem I think I
see the problem right here okay no
actually I don't everything seems
correct oh right oh yeah everything
seems to be
correct the first is connected to here
the second is there the third is there
the the silver one the silver is next to
the purple which makes sense uh did I
get anything wrong let me just put it
side by side again just put the side by
side okay okay that's all I need to do
I'm going to need to set it up side by
side and there's pin e and there's pin
D H what could be our problem okay set
pin e to what set it up by number
decimal point and then C and then D and
then e and
then wait after E I said to e okay there
we go I'm correct I set it to e and then
I start to the other side what could be
the problem right
here what could be the problem
H so I want this to finally light up as
what as a
nine so one problem that I did one
problem there is let me just show you
one problem there is right here is what
one problem that there is is that I keep
forgetting to do what I keep to give it
low right here what happens is look CN D
already set to high okay when we're
going to number nine c d b are set to
high as I said they going to be set to
high and then when it comes to number
seven and again G set to high too okay
wait is G supposed to be set to high
it's not I forgot about G right here let
me fix G up so we fix G up and then C
okay all of it are set to high Okay C DB
a are set to high and then what happens
here is what you only want a to G set to
be set to high no problem okay
everything what is set to high that
makes sense but the problem starts here
what is the problem right here can you
see the problem C and then B and then a
can you see it c b are the only ones
that are supposed to be set to high but
we already set everything up to high can
you see it we set everything to what to
high this is where the problem starts
okay so we set everything already up to
high and then we only want to set this
to what to high so we have to what
technically what do we have to do we
have to turn everything low before what
moving into the next one because right
here I set everything from a to G to
what to high already and then when I go
right here from c b and a I only want
them to be set to high other ones
they're going to be set to what to low
what I want right here is what what
happens what quite the opposite okay so
what happens is quite the opposite so
everything's already set to high and
when I try to set this high again it
doesn't make any difference that's
what's happened okay so I need to do is
what I need to go over to my code right
here again hopefully I have everything
intact let me just get this
right hey this oh let me go to my
clipboard
again there we go got everything right
instead of removing them what I'm going
to be doing is what I'm going to be
setting them to what to low okay the
ones that I don't want I'm going to be
setting them to what to low a b g c d so
we need c we need D we need what we need
what we need e we don't need e so what
do I do I set it to low
okay because it's going to affect the
next number that we're going to what
we're going to be touch it so we're
going to set this again to high or low
we cannot just remove it okay so this
was already set to high okay a is
supposed to be set to high we're not
going to be using F so we're going to be
setting it to low and then how about G
Okay g is supposed to be set to high too
all right so we're not going to touch it
so let's try to upload it right now
let's even see if you can even see nine
as a as a number so let's just try to
open
it you cannot see
what okay you see that for the first for
the first
seconds what happens is what you don't
see the whole thing light up we see 1 2
3 four four LED segments light up how
many LED segments should be lighting up
1 2 3 four five let me just check my
code again five segments should be set
to high 1 2 3 4 and five what could be
the
problem I generally don't know what the
problem is so I think what I'm going to
do right here is inste
uh wasting wasting time is I'm going to
try to figure the problem out myself and
then I'm going to come back here and try
to solve it okay so I was about to
rerecord the whole section but uh I made
what what I made was a very very simple
I made two very simple mistakes the
first one being is that the resistors
right here are touching so let me just
move my move it right here and these two
resistors were touching each other all
right so basically what happened was
when these two resistors touch each
other they started to what they started
basically to fuse as if they were just
acting as a one resistor so basically it
was not working on its own okay these
two resistors that was the problem that
I just made so there's a good chance
that the the code is working for you um
so right here that's the first mistake
right here okay and the second mistake
here is when we're using nine okay we
need to also turn on
F okay we also need to turn on what F
all right that's just one thing you have
to keep in mind let me just show you
guys where f is there we go we need to
turn on F which is supposed to be around
here okay so with that in mind what I
should be doing right here is what set
this to high that's our first mistake
solved it I untangled the the resistor
right here I untangled it myself okay so
it should be working properly right now
I just separated them and one thing we
need to finally do is what we need to
finally write down the whole code of
this obviously I not do that for this
one let me just do that me go here here
let me just copy actually number eight
because all of it is set to high it's
going to be
easy we need to copy the whole thing not
just part by part let just do that copy
that just paste it here wait I oh I I
took it off I deleted number eight let
me just leave it there copy that and
then I'm going to paste it here just
going to supposed to remove number seven
here all right there we
go this should be paste there we go
number seven paste let me just give a
space right here just you can again have
more space there we go now what I need
to do is uh right here is what what is
supposed to be set to high ABC so other
than ABC everything is supposed to be
set to low just keep on doing that let
me turn on cap lock and there we go low
EC supposed to be set to high so I'm
going to leave this one and this one to
low and then finally G to low so now
let's just check and upload
it okay should be
compiling and it's working perfectly
fine now
okay and it's working perfectly fine it
counts to seven that's good it goes back
to 9 87 let me just change your angle so
you guys can actually see it from the
right spot let me just do
that there we go let me just put it
right here there we go let me turn off
homeone light so you can see it way
better now you can see it from a good
Angle now it's going 9 8
7 okay the delay time is Big so let me
just change it to it set to uh let me
just check it 3,000 millisecs basically
3 seconds I'm going to set it to what
1,000 milliseconds basically what a
second okay so what we're going to do
right now is write down the whole number
so let me just write down we're on
number what number six number six what
do we need to do for number six again
I'm just going to paste this code right
here for number six afg e CD need to be
turned on so basically B needs to be
turned off what else
um yeah basically B needs to be turned
off that's I think all that is supposed
to be turned off there we go so B needs
to be what turned off so B set to low
for number six all right now once we're
done with that just going to set this up
to what
number number five paste the code again
so for this case one needs to be turned
off B and then e b and e needs to be
turned off low and then for E2 it's
going to go low let me just check it
again AB okay A a okay B is going to be
turned off because it's not here then
there's C there's d e needs to be turned
off and then F and then there's G so I'm
not going to touch that so let's just
check it out right now actually let
upload
it right till that time let me just
write down number four okay it's going 7
5 okay okay let's write down there we go
okay it went to number five now let's
write down number four that's all we
need to do let me write down number four
all right go to digal oh I just need to
do is paste the code again one needs to
be turned off right now and needs to be
turned off let me just turn off a first
turn off a no I need to turn on cap
stock there we go turn a off how about b
b needs to be turned on C needs to be
turned on D needs to be turned off let's
go to D and turn it
off okay how about e in this case e
needs to be turned off too let's go to E
how about f f needs to be turned on and
then G needs to be turned on so I'm
going to leave it like that okay and
then again keep on doing this for number
three paste that and what need to be
turned on for a
C okay a b g and C D okay so basically e
needs to be turned off okay D is turned
on E and F needs to be turned off so
let's go to E and F and turn them off
low and F to
low okay afterwards let me go to number
two number two paste that for number two
what needs to be turned off C and then
what uh D needs to be turned on so e
then F okay so basically what what C and
F needs to be turned off so let's go to
C and F and turn them off let me turn
them to what to
low
okay F needs to be turned low again for
those of you are using a cathod pin
you're going to be exactly doing what
the opposite of what I'm doing if you
want to turn off something obviously
what you're going to do is what you're
going to set it to high when you want to
turn off something when you want to turn
on something you set it to what to
I think you guys know that all right let
me just keep that in mind and let's move
to number one number one let's number
two right here number one paste that and
what do I need to do for number one only
B and C need to be turned on so most of
it is going to be S to low okay B and C
need to be turned on just go here how
about e
low B and C I'm going to leave B GNA go
to a turn that low
and
f
and g what is left only Zero's left so
let me write down number zero number
zero and paste that what needs to be
turned off for number zero everything is
on except for what except for G so only
G is going to be what set to low one
final thing I want to do on number zero
is I want to add uh I want to add the
decimal point because we've not been
using it so I want to add the decimal
points and what I'm going to do is say
decimal point and set it to what to high
okay so if I'm send setting this to high
what do I need to do as soon as this is
set to high after it goes to one round
it's got to kept it high because I've
never mentioned decimal point here so
what do I need to go do I think I wrote
it down myself but what you need to do
is what you need to set it to low okay
you need to set what the decimal point
to low I just do don't do that right
here and let me just upload it just
removed it for now let's see what
happens okay so 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 zero
okay the decimal point you see that the
decimal point after another round once I
set it to high again on number zero when
it when it reaches number zero I set the
decimal point to high it's going to what
continue on being high as long as I
don't write the code to what to keep it
on low so I have to write down the code
to keep it on low I cannot just what
neglect it okay so let me just do that
and let's upload it right
now
okay nine 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 zero the
decimal point and then decimal point
turns off there we go now we created our
own timer okay so this is as far as we
go on the LED I think we're done with
this one so um see you in the next
section
okay so in this section we're going to
discuss about 4digit seven segment LED
displays so far we've worked with u
normal s segment LED display but now
we're going to work with one that has a
four digits okay so one thing that you
notice right here that is off the bit is
when you look at the four digit 7
segment LED display is that it only
has as you can see right here it has six
pins right here it has six pins so
totally it has only 12 pins okay when
you look at here when we think of seven
segments again how many pits do we have
for each segment right here we had
almost what we have eight segments so we
have eight again eight pins for segments
and then we have two pins for the common
as you can see right here we have five
pins and five pins so totally we have 10
pins so how much pins do we expect right
here we expected at least we expected
how many pins we had eight pins again
eight segments here so we're going to be
expecting how many pins we're going to
be expecting 8 * 4 which is going to be
32 and then we expected two common pins
which is going to add it up to a total
of what
34 but obviously our Arduino only has
how many digal pins let me just unplug
my Arduino so you can see it closely if
you look at my adino Nano right here it
has around 13 dis pins it goes to
digital pin number 12 right here and
then there's digital pin number 13 at
the very edge can you see that even
let's say we're trying to use our analog
pins we only have how many pins we only
have seven analog pins here okay so
right here even if you add it up we're
not going to have anal space for 34 P so
right here they use a very very simple
yet a very genius way of of us of making
it of Designing it in such a way that um
it only needs 12 pins basically two more
than just our normal basically two more
than just our normal seven segment LED
display so let's see how this works okay
let me just plug my again seven segment
LED display it's very familiar to the
elite display we have here okay the
four-digit one is very very familiar to
this one let me put it actually in the
other
side so it can actually be better there
we
go the focus isn't good wait let me fix
up the focus let me get around here
there we go now it's better
so now the question is what are these
what are these pins again what are these
pins what do they represent so let me go
over to my screen right now so you can
see it for yourselves and when you look
right here there is what there is D4 AF
F D3 D2 b e d DP c g and D1 so one thing
that again you're familiar with is are
those a to G Pin so you're familiar with
the segments a f b e d DP C and G but
you're not familiar with these ones that
are marked with the green the D1 the D2
the D3 and the D4 so D1 D2 D3 D4
basically means is right I want you to
keep this in mind is D1 represents digit
one D2 represents digit 2 and obviously
digit D3 represents digit 3 and D4
represents digit 4
okay so the question is what are these
these are I want you to think of them
this deepens again this digit pins I
want you to think of them is as the
common pins okay I want you to think of
them as what as the common pins okay so
again right here uh if it's a common
anode and common Capote they exist here
too we obviously had a common anode and
common gape when it came to the what
when it came to seven segment L display
they are also exist here too so they
they can be a common anode when it comes
to four-digit one they can be common
anode or common cathode okay so when it
comes to D again depends they act as a
what as a common pin so what you want to
turn on something what basically happens
is what let's say we want to turn on a
on digit four if you want to turn on a
on digit four what do we do is we do
what we turn a for example let's say I'm
using a common cathode for now I'm using
a common cathode my pin is a common
cathode okay my four digit U LED segment
display is common Capal so I'm going to
be using common Capal as an example so
what should I do right here a needs to
be turned on to what a needs to be
turned on to high okay the pin that is
connected to it's going to be turned to
high and then D4 is going to be what
connected to the what it's going to be
connected to low basically acting as a
what as a ground basically it's going to
act as a 5 volt and then there's a
resistor right here on the segment as as
every time we did um using the seven
segment LED display the on digigit seven
segment LED display what we did was what
we always connected the resistors to the
what to the segment we're still going to
carry this roomle okay so we're going to
be connecting the resistor to the Ain
and then what we going to do is what
we're going to turn on again we're going
to use the D4 as a what as a gnd d as a
gnd d Comon bin and what happens is what
we're going to turn on a where is a
supposed to be let me just Google the
seven segment LED display there's an
image of where a should
be okay there we go the a is right here
the a is right here at the top so
basically we're going to turn on this
part this part that is what we're going
to turn on this segment it's going to be
at the digit four and what it's going to
be a okay so let's try to first things
first let's try to understand you know
how to connect these things okay so let
me just try to exactly do what I did
right here
okay so right here mine is a bit
different again with the number okay you
always going to check the number right
here let me just unplug it for now
you're always going to check the number
and then search for the data sheet okay
you're going to search the number right
here you're going to write the number
and then say LED Matrix and then what
and then search the data sheet again to
just see this layout of how yours is
going to be because it's going to be
different from again from U uh the
display to another so from kit to kit
it's going to be different so again
always keep that in mind okay so right
here I already made myself a
documentation right here okay I'm going
to show you guys how to actually make it
if you guys do not find the data sheet
on online sometimes there might be cases
where you don't find the data sheet
online I try to Google mine I put my
number right here I put my number right
here and Googled for it and then I could
not find it so what I basically had to
do was write a documentation a data
sheet myself so I'm going to show you
how it's done but for now let's try to
again focus on how uh these again four
segment LED displays work okay so right
here let me just get it as close as
possible to the we know just put it
right
here okay so let me bring two bring one
resistor here let's bring a resistor
let's bring another wire right here mine
is a common cathode so what is the
common pin right here the common pin for
me is what the common pin is going to be
those D pins let's say I want to light
up digital pin number one here I want to
light up this little pin number one okay
what do I do I go to the very edge again
I kind of forgot to put the dot here I
only put 888 here let me put the Dots
here forgot the decimal
point there we go fixed it up right now
okay so what do I do I literally put
right here this is going to turn on
digital pin one as you can see sorry I
said uh it's going to turn on the digit
number one the first digit basically and
I want to turn on a this one so let me
just go right here but before connecting
to a segment what do I do I always use
my resistor let me just get my resistor
right here a 1,000 Ohm resistor we're
going to be using the same resistance
when we were using in u the seven
segment and the Seven segment LED
displays basically this ones that have
one digit okay so let me just do
that just try to turn on a this should
be
easy okay there we go moved it across
let me just bring it closer so you can
see it I again I connected this one
right here oh I think I jumped one oh
jumped one actually I'm not correct
there we go now it should be at a as you
can see I connected it to
a all right everything seems to be
working nice now and then I connect this
one to the red so obviously what do I
connect this one to I'm going to be
connecting this one to what to the 5vt
while I'm going to be connecting my
common pin because it's a cathode again
it's a cathode since it's a common
cathode what am I going to be connecting
it to I'm going to be connecting it to
g& D let me just do
that okay seems to be have been
connected let me just push it in just
need to push it in a bit and now let's
try to light up
ouro with
that let's see what happens
here okay let me just touch my resistors
I'm not sure if the resistors is causing
the problem right here it's not lighting
up let me just try to push it the whole
way
in it's nothing is lighting up right now
going through an error let's just see
what happened right here again let me
just check my pins let unplug my adrenal
first let's check our pins we been
connected the 5 volt all right I connect
the 5 volt to this one all right nice
the gnd D I connected the G and D to
this one which is good let me just make
sure this is what digit one as you can
see right here this is digit one let me
just check if I connected it to the
first
digit yes that makes sense I connected
to what to a gnd d can you see it I
connected it to gnd D and then
afterwards what did I do and then okay
connected the resistor right here to an
a connected the resistor right here to
what to an a the a pin so basically what
should have been lighting up this one
should be lighting up this segment
should be lighting up this one right
here should be lighting up okay so
everything I think should be working
fine
oh there we go everything is fine now
it's lighting up let me just turn off
one light so we can see it
better
okay lower the light a bit let me give
it a different color right here there we
go and now I think you can see it way
better I'm just trying to focus at it
there we go now it's lighting up okay so
we just did that but right now the big
problem again being here is okay I turn
this one on let's say I want to turn on
digit number two I want to work with
digit number two now I just wanted this
to be on and I want to work with digit
number two okay digit number two is what
again is I'm using what a common code
it's going to be connected to the gnd D
all right where's the digit number two
right here digit number two is after a
I'm going to have to jump okay a step
and F and then go to D2 let me just do
that so all I need to do is what go to
D2 right here what else I should do is
what I should be connecting it to what
to resistor or not I shouldn't be why is
that so I'm working with a what with a
common pin when it when it comes to
Common pins we don't connect it to
resistors but when it comes to
individual segments we connected to what
we connected to again resistors so okay
let me just Skip One and go right here
just did
that can you see it let me just focus
here there we go skipped it and now
where do I go I go through the gnd D
basically I'm going to share this gnd D
with this
okay there we go this as soon as I do
that can you see that just try to there
we go get my resistor can you see
it one thing you notice is okay seems to
be working fine now let let me just try
to connect the you know I want to turn
on F2 I just want to turn on F okay
there's a problem that's occurring but
let's just again go and let's connect it
to F right now and then we're going to
talk about the problem of doing this let
me just connect it to an F right now
okay how do I connect it to an F I'm
going to need again a resistor right now
because I'm lighting up what an
individual segment all right so I'm
going to what I'm going to need to
connect it to an F so where is it it's
around the middle have to go between
these
two yep it's just going to be a bit of a
hard
one it's going to be a bit of a hardship
to do actually
all right there we go connected it to an
f and then I'm going to need a
wire I'm going to need a long wire
actually this time I'm going to get the
white wire it's very long there we go
what am I going to be connecting it to
to 5vt because I'm using a common
cathode again the individual segments
will be connected to what they'll be
connected to the 5 Vol let me just do
that they should be connected to the 5vt
just the resistors let me just check
both the resist
SS all right there we
go just touch the resistance right
here can you see a problem with carrying
it's not consistent as you can see it
it's not really consistent what is the
problem here the first problem is okay
the first problem being let just take
off this one just take it off for now so
you can see it the first problem was
there's not what there's not enough
power to turn off to turn on all these
displays okay that is the first problem
okay so as I said again these again when
we were when we were putting our
resistors they were intended to what
they were intended to for what for one
segment LED displays they were intended
for one segment what led displays so
basically we turned on at maximum we
turned on eight segments here remember
maximum we turned on eight segments just
think of them lighting up what eight
LEDs here but right now we have how many
segments we have around eight right here
88 8 basically we have 32 segments how
are we going to light up 32 segments
because it's going to require a lot of
power it's going to require More Voltage
than 5 volt okay so one thing we could
have seen right here is when I put the
fpin right here when I connected try to
connect the fpin everything what
everything blacked out what happened
basically was it did not have enough
power to light up all of them okay did
not have enough power to light up what
all of these segments again okay that's
one thing just want you to keep in mind
they had no enough power to what to
light up again two again two different
digits okay so right now another problem
is it starts copying the same thing can
you see it if I just put right here a
right here it's going to light up both
let's say I want to turn on one let's
say I want to turn on I want to
represent the digit one two the problem
here is what okay I need to turn on this
and this for number one and I'm going to
need to turn on another type of what
another type of segments for number two
but right here what happens is what it's
copies the same segment so when I light
it up in this manner what happens is
what it lights up what it it copies the
same thing it copies the same thing so
which is going to be what it's going to
be very very horrible you don't want it
to be exactly the same I said again
let's say I want to turn on one right
here and once I want to turn on two they
going to be a problem right here let's
say turn on two okay I'm just going to
add up these segments right here just
fine but when I want to turn on one what
happens is what I have to turn off this
one okay I have to turn off this one so
basically what happen happens is what if
I turn off this one it's going to turn
off from this one too so they start what
copying each other which is going to be
bad okay so this is where the problem
arises okay this is problem number one
the problem number one being what it
copies the same thing and the second
thing you can see is if you focus again
is the what the division of power is not
very very consistent look at it let me
just turn off the light can you see it
one is very very bright right here and
this one is very di now just thinking
just think of trying to light up 32
different segments here which is going
to be what almost impossible it just
even tapped out when we tried to connect
it to an F as you could as you could
have seen in the when I tried to connect
to F right here the F pin what happened
it just tapped out it couldn't do it
basically all of it turned off okay so
this is the second problem that we have
here okay so how are we supposed to
light it up then well one thing that you
need to keep in mind is where are always
supposed to light up just actually take
off all of this we're supposed to light
up what we're supposed to light up only
one digit at a time so we only can light
up one digit at a time so right here if
you look let me go again to the image
right here if you go to the image right
here what you can see is what a FB all
these segments are what they're common
to what they're common to the dpin the
dpin are the one that are specific right
here we have D1 we have D2 We have D3 we
have D4 they're specific while a FB
again e d decimal point C and G those
segments right here they're what they're
common they're common to all of them
okay so one thing you can do is what we
can light up everything here from a all
the segments but we can do it what we're
limited to what we're limited to what
we're limited to one digit at a time
okay we're limited to what to one digit
at a time so right here when we do that
again when we just think of again using
the on digigit LED matrix it's going to
work perfectly fine when we use using
one digit I just want you to think of
them as what is like four again these
four what these four one segment LED
displays connected together okay
systematically so that they have 12 pins
so I just want you to think of them is
what is four again four one digigit
seven segment LED displays okay so right
here again there was specific if we had
specific you know specific uh U excuse
me we had specific segments for all of
them it would be like A1 there will be
A1 it'll have a different pin for A1
we're going to have A2 we're going to
have A3 we're going to have A4 so
basically we're going to have a lot of
pits obviously we cannot work with all
these pits so another problem arises
while using this method through the
problem is okay I want you to keep this
in mind the problem is okay one digit at
a time okay one digit at a time okay it
works perfectly fine when we use one
digit at a time let me just again let me
again to prove this again let me just
connect uh let me just connect three
pins using the let's use digit number
again digit three right here let's try
to connect again just three or four uh
segments right here let me just do that
so you guys can understand it all right
let me just unplug this where's my digit
number three right here digit number
three is
here me just focus here digit number
three is here so it's going to be the
one at the very edge the one close next
to the very edge there we go just push
let me first push this one so that it
doesn't move a lot there we go but it's
still visible there we go it's a I'm
lighting up what a digit so I don't need
to use my resistor I'm just going to
connect the directly to what I'm using a
common cathode as I said again so I'm
going to be connecting it to gnd D the D
pins are going to be connected to to the
gnd D I just want you to think of the
digital pins the D pins the sorry the
the digit pins as what I just want you
to think of them as common pins again
they're marked with what they're marked
with the number of their respective
digit that light that they light up okay
there we go connected it to what
supposed to connect to gnd D there we go
connected it to the gnd right now let me
just focus here so you can see it way
better there we go and now what do I
need to do let me just light up again
one segment right here I don't care that
much so okay I'm just going to light up
B because it's close to uh it's very
close to
uh the digit number three all right
there we go now I'm just going to need
my wire let me just wire this up let get
my wire right
here then I'm going to be connecting it
to the 5vt I've got my resistance all
right my resistance is check does it
light up B I think it lights up B There
we go let me just try to light up
another one too just for the sake of it
let me bring another resistor let me
just light up someone that that
somewhere that is here just go right
here can you see
it hopefully you
can there we
go
we go should be
around here I'm going to connect this to
5 volt let me just light up to
why I think two proves the point so I
don't need to light up more than two
there we go okay I need to push in that
resistor I'm just push in this display
and the resistor can you see it let me
again turn off the light when we again
use one digit at a time what happens is
what can you see it it lights up
properly there's no what there's no div
when you see the power division of power
right there was uneven right here it's
even okay as you see it right here it's
even and then two I don't need to copy
it's not copying the same thing but it
rises again another problem the problem
with this method is using one digit at a
time because it's intended to do it's
because it's intended to be used at what
as as one digit at a time so what
happens here is the problem most people
I think think about right now another
problem is what if we use one digit at a
time it destroys the purpose of what it
Ro the purpose of having a 4digit LED
display because right here let's say we
want to turn on you know 1 2 3 4 right
here I just start the resistor okay
let's say we want to turn on 1 two 3 and
four right here we want to turn on 1 2 3
4 we can do that if you're using what
one digit one digit um for only using
one digit at a time basically what
happens is what what basically happens
is what we cannot turn on all of them at
once well one thing I want you guys to
keep in mind is okay um one thing I want
you to keep in mind is always is that
these things are very very fast I'm
talking about these LEDs are
microcontrollers computers are very very
fast okay so let's say we want to turn
on one what do we go we go to digital
pin one and then we turn on again two
segments we're going to turn on these
two segments okay we want to turn on
let's say one okay we want to turn on
that and let's say we go to digal again
we're going to go to digital 2 we're
going to turn this off after we're done
with it we're going to turn it off and
there's still pin two we're going to to
D two connect D2 right here and then
we're going to light up all these
segments again the one that marks a two
we're going to go right here and light
up all these segments right so you might
think that it's going to go really slow
we're going to see one right here and
then we're going to see two but it's
going to happen very very fast okay I'm
talking in milliseconds it's going to
happen very very fast in milliseconds
that we're not going to notice one
turning off okay we're not going to
notice one turning off and then
switching to two one turning off right
here and then and are you know going
here and lighting up two it's going to
happen so fast that we're going to what
we're going to keep seeing one and then
we're also going to keep what seeing to
right here okay for our eyes it's not
what it's not visible for us so that's
one thing I want you guys to keep in
mind we're going to be lighting up one
digit at a time but it's going to happen
very very fast that our eyes cannot what
our eyes cannot notice it okay our eyes
cannot notice it so that what so that we
can basically what turn on all of this
at once so we can turn on all of this at
once so technically speaking we're not
turning all of these at ones we're
turning this on we're turning this off
once we're done with this we go to this
one and then once we're done with this
we go this one once we're done with this
we go with this one but it happens very
very very fast that our eyes cannot
notice what this turning off okay these
turning off okay the the others turning
off it's going to happen very fast that
all of them for us it's going to appear
that all of them are what all of them
are on and they're what they're
displaying what they're displaying
numbers okay that's one thing I want you
guys to keep in mind okay so right here
one final thing before uh moving on is
again the problem here is what let me
just turn on our lights the problem I
encountered myself was okay the problem
I encountered myself was I could not
find the documentation on my specified
type of what on my specified type of
four four-digit uh seven segment LED
displays okay I could not find a
specific data sheet okay if you look at
the image right now when you look at the
image it's very very different from my
what it's very very different from the
one that I had here almost everything's
the same when it comes to segments right
here a f b e d DP C and G are the same
but the but the layout of the what the
digits is very different digit one right
here is located at the very very left
per me left top while digit four the
well in the image it's digit four so
again how do we find you know which
digit is which and how do we label them
and write this down for ourselves
because sometimes you might I find what
if you have a less popular uh less
popular type of code right here you're
not going to find what you're not going
to find your LED display D sheet there's
a lower chance of it because I do not
find it myself I've been looking around
for like a good 20 minutes 30 minutes
but I could not find any data sheet on
my specified type of um four uh digit um
semi segment LED displays so right here
what I did is first things first I
wanted to know if it's a common anode or
a common cathode okay how do I know that
let me just Again Begin from just turn
all of this off okay let me just do that
how do I know that
that how do I know that okay how do I
know that what I did is what okay I just
assumed that's what this is going to be
the digit PIN right here let me just
assume this is the digit PIN okay again
assume this is what this is going to be
a digit PIN I just started with this and
I started connecting it to it I just
assumed again you're going to you're
going to be doing it with trial and
error okay you're going to be using a
method of what trial and ER until we get
one segment okay so right here let me
just again use this as a what as a
digital
pen right here I'm going to be using it
as a dpen as a what I'm just going to
assume this a common cathode so if this
is a dpen what is it going to be it's
going to be connected to gnd D connect
to gnd D all right I'm going to assume
the other one the next that is right
there as a segment
again so you're going to keep on trying
until again you find the right one until
you find one uh one segment lights
up okay let me just again assume this is
a common let meum assume this is a
common actually you know what this is a
common code but let me just assume this
is a common anode for now so to make
things very easier for other people who
have a common anode so let me just show
them right here I'm going to be
connecting this to the what if it's a
common anode I'm going to be connecting
5 Vol let me just do that and let me
bring another pin again I have my
resister I'm just assuming this is what
this is a segment next to it it's a
segment I'm just assuming that again
this is assumption until we find until
we basically what until we find when
it's right always one thing you have to
always keep in mind is what we always
have to light up again or what we always
have to use resistors because if we try
to connect one without any resistor
what's going to happen is when we're
trying to find out which one's which
we're going to basically what fry our
LEDs our segments right here we don't
want to do that again okay so just keep
that in mind okay it doesn't turn on
Okay what I'm going to do is I'm going
to be moving I'm going to start moving
okay I'm going to be starting to move my
resistor to the other pins I'm not going
to change the commment pin again I'm
just going to keep it like that for now
I'm just assuming this is a dpin okay
I'm just going to keep doing
it let me go with the other one right
here let me Focus actually here there we
go I'm just going to keep doing it it's
not lighting up again pushed it let me
just push it
again just push it so they can even see
it there we go it's not lighting up I'm
just going to keep on moving the
resistor again one one at a time to the
next spin try to connect to the other
one it's not lighting up okay let me try
the other one
let me try a whole row before actually
concluding okay so let me try at least
one of these six spins before actually
concluding so okay let me just try to
connect this one to the resistor is
supposed to be here okay it's not
lighting up so what could I possibly say
right here either I did not connect it
to a right digital pin right here so
okay I do not know if I connected it to
what to a normal dpin I'm just going to
assume again a segment again just going
to keep doing this until we find what
correct answer so let me just keep
touching this again changing it keep
changing it okay I reached the resistor
point so I'm not going to touch that
again there is a probability of finding
it let me go to the other side right
now now we have to find again one of
those digital pins are supposed to be
here one of them is supposed to be what
digital pins right here just keep doing
it keep doing it it's not lighting up
nothing is lighting up right here keep
doing it all I reached my end of this
side so basically what could happen is
what I reversed it basically it's so
what it could be a common what common
cathode instead of what a common anode
right here I tried it as a what as a
common anode okay it's not a common what
it's not a common anode so let me try a
common cathode so let me just reverse it
so right here what do I need to do is
again set the the deepend are supposed
to be set to what they're supposed to be
set to G and D let me just do that again
this I'm going to be assuming this is
what going to be assuming let me start
actually from right
here keep on let me just start from here
because I know this is the the deepen I
don't want to start from here I just
want to show you guys how we do it right
now since I already wrote it down again
I wrote down the
documentation all right let me again go
here right here let me just again put a
segment right here and let me connect it
to a what to the 5vt segment to the 5vt
segment to the 5vt okay let me again
push it push it a bit in so we can see
it there we go nothing is like lighting
up okay maybe I have to move this again
here let's see if it lights up where's
the 5V did I get the gnd D right I think
I got the g&d
right
wait right there we
go oh I did not even connect this one to
the proper resistor I'm supposed to
connect the same the same R there we go
can you see
it oh now it's lighting up if I put it
right here it doesn't light up but if I
just put it here it lights up okay let's
say to not find this one again let me
just go over right here and let's try to
find it
again let me just try to find let me
just try to what my objective here is to
at least try to find what try to light
up one segment that's that's my only
objective here as soon as I do that it's
going to be
easy what did I do wrong here let's keep
on pushing it again I'm just going to
make sure the resistance is again intact
oo now it's lighting up so let me say
okay this this light up let me just say
Okay this lit up so how do I extract the
information right here okay this one
that is right here okay there's
something right here I'm just going to
again check it it's the one at the very
very left okay I'm just going to draw
this diagram right here before lab
labeling it okay let's just say I'm
labeling it right now okay let me just
hide this for now let just hide this for
now there we go let me just draw this
diagram again that looks like this and
shows the pins so right here it's
lighing up at what it's lighing up at
the the what at the fourth digit so what
does this mean this is the one at the
very very again at the very very right
so this one is supposed to be what this
is supposed to be digital what sorry I
said digital I meant digit number what
it's going to be digit number four it's
the fourth digit okay it's digit four
all right so this is what this is going
to be D4 that is right here it's going
to be what I hooked it up to here it's
D4 what other information can we also
extract it's a common anode or a common
cathode it's a common cathode because
why the D pins are what they're
connected to what to the G and D okay so
they're what they're basically what
they're basically uh common what common
cathodes okay we extracted this
information what else can we extract
here can you see the segment right here
let me go over to my image right here to
my screen and when you look right here a
is at the very top so what does this
mean the segment we connected right here
okay the segment we connected right here
is what the segment we connected right
here is what it's going to be what it's
a so this is what if if you let's say go
here let me just go over here there we
go the one that we connected right here
is a when you look at the resistance
right here the leg of the resistance is
touching a can you see it it's touching
a there we go a oh I just moved the
resistance again that's the resistance
that uh oh there we go I moved the
resistance there we go a so I also
discovered a pin right here just little
pin let me just go over to it h so
around here I think
so it's around
here there we go now what is this this
is what now we can just again look where
it's located right here what will we
connected right here and then we can say
what is this again let me just move this
to the top can you see it it's the one
at the very very what at the very edge
what is this then it's appearing on
digit one so basically it's what it's D1
right here when it comes to White one
again the white um wire it's going to be
connected to what to D1 okay what is
this again a so we can keep finding them
again by doing what by lighting up other
segments that's all you need to do so
let's say we're trying to find another
segment what do we do right here we're
going to move our resistance right here
and what does when it does not light up
what does it mean when it does not light
up it's it's probably what it's probably
a what a dpen so we're not going to
touch that so we're going to leave it
again we're going to light up all the
segments so basically let's just trial
and error until you find one segment as
soon as you find as as soon as one
segment lights up you can extract lots
of information from here I can extract
what this is a okay this is a from here
from the red wire I can say this the pin
right here is a what else is it it's on
the first digit so it's what so it's
going to be what the digit number one is
going to be here what else can I extract
right here I can say it's a common anode
or a common cathode so again you keep
doing that and find all the pins okay
and name all of them that's all you need
to do so with that in mind we're going
to actually work on a project in the
next section and we're actually going to
wire up all of this which is going to be
a lot of it so we're going to wire up 12
so anyways we're going to see you um see
you in the next section we're actually
going to work on a project with this
one okay so we're going to build as a
timer okay just like how we did using
the one segment LED display right here
one seven segment LED display with the
one that has one digit just like how we
did that we're going to be building a
timer and it's also going to be
including a buzzer okay it's going to
have a buzzer right here an active
buzzer and it's going to actually ring
after what the timer hits zero okay so
just to save you guys time I did all the
wiring up that was necessary again so I
did every wiring up and Drew down all of
the all of them as variables so let me
just again get this closer so you can
have a good look at it and what which
where where it's going so let me just
just make a simple again let me just
explain it simply these are a andf the
let me just again bring this closer how
am I supposed to do that let me it's
actually hard let me just bring the
camera down this time it makes more
sense to do
that there we go let just bring it way
closer here all right so these two as
you can see the black and the silver
again when you look at them they're
connected to what to a and F they're
connected to resistors right here one
resistor leading to a and the second
resistor leading to what leading to F
okay that's all I did then afterwards
what I did was okay what I did was I put
this again as you can see it right here
can you see this the silver one the
silver one is supposed to be D1 okay
it's D1 and afterwards these two colors
right here the purple and the blue
respectively are D2 and D3 and finally I
set a resistor for again B because it's
a segment again and then use the going
color okay then afterwards what I did
was okay I went to the other side
because I did not have space in this
side too as you can see I don't have
space on this side so I just used
another small breadboard just to go
through it just like how I did using the
1digit 7even segment LED display so what
I did was again connect again these pins
again these pins in order right here we
start from yellow again the next color
is yellow as you can see on the stripe
and then connected them respectively so
yellow represent res e then orange
represents D obviously then red
represents DP and then the brown
represents C and then right here because
I run out of wires right here again uh
we're connecting lots of pins because I
run out of wires what I did was I used a
single white wire right here
specifically a single what white wire
right here as you can see it and this is
connected to it is connected to G okay
and one final thing is obviously we have
D4 right here that not use let me go
back right here obviously I don't have
to put a resistor on this so I put it
right here and connected it to what pin
13 okay can you see pin 13 is the very
very other side let me just
again just give this let me change the
color a
better change it to there we go I think
this is better there we go
D13 all right D13 is right here then
there's stillin with 13 again you can
see it from another angle there we go
there's still inin 13
so that's what I did I connected them
and separately I run out of digital pins
right here okay so one thing I want you
to keep in mind let me just put this in
its normal
angle okay there we go so one thing I
did right here as what after I was done
with setting up the four LED again
four-digit LED Matrix uh LED U segments
right here what I did was what I set up
a different circuit a big black one I
used an analog pin because I ran out of
a digital pin right here I used an
analog pin okay I used what I used an
analog pin and then I used a diode okay
a diode again as I said supposed to
change what supposed to change AC
circuit to DC circuit all right and then
I used my active buzzer active buzzer as
I always told you guys it it what it
needs five volt DC it receives what 5V
DC direct current and basically what
again what does uh let me just explain
the science before we go behind it uh
what does a diode do it basically can
convert AC to DC let me just show you
how it
does let me just bring the
paper right here let's go over the signs
before you know we keep walking and
focus on the again this the four-digit
uh the 4G dis four-digit display because
it's going to be the main one right here
it's the main component
here basically when we use a diode if
you remember remember AC circuit goes
both sides it goes both sides okay when
it comes to DC circuit it only goes what
one way okay it's straight it goes one
way when it comes to a diode if you
remember I told you guys even when we
using these LEDs let me just bring an
LED right here I think an LED would be a
great example because they're diodes too
they're literally what light emitting
diodes they're diodes but they what they
emit light that's their like special
property but they're just dios they're
the same thing okay so when it came
towards um these again diodes they were
represent like this if you remember and
then we again presented them in the
circuit so this is what the positive
side and this was what the negative side
okay is it the positive and the negative
I think I actually switched it up there
we go it's this side it's positive and
negative here anyways the main thing
here is what the main thing here is if
we connect it to the positive again we
connect the positive to the 5vt and the
negative to the g& D it worked but if we
switch the the direction what happened
it did not work so basically what
happens in diodes in diodes currents
only flow in what currents only flow in
One Direction as I told you guys
currents only flow in what in Only One
Direction so that's basically what is
it's doing when we receive again inputs
from analog pins and digital pins
they're always what as I said again
they're always AC so to just change it
to 5vt DC what does a diode do diode
only receives what half of what the AC
is sending it's going to be receiving
half of it so basically it's going in
both directions it's going to receive
only the One Direction and it's going to
what it's not going to receive the other
one it's going to be dull and then keep
on doing this so basically over time it
looks something like this if we just
again Lower it down let's just say we
tune it down it's going to be almost as
if we're getting what we're getting DC
circuit okay just as if we're getting DC
circuit that's one thing I want you guys
to keep in mind okay when we working
with this a diode let me just show you
guys what a diode looks like this is
called a rectifier diode again read your
labels and try to find some sort of
diode okay this is a rectifier diode
right here okay basically does what
changes what it's used for what
basically to change AC circuit to what
to DC circuit okay again the side again
you have to understand the side okay how
you set it up is again important because
s if I just again change the direction
right here and put it like this if I put
the there we go if I put the again
silver mark right here with the with the
positive sign okay with the positive
sign what's going to happen is what it's
going to basically what it's not going
to connect it's basically going to be
silent but if I was to change the
direction right now I change the
direction it's supposed to be like this
if I change the direction like this it's
going to work perfectly fine okay just
keep that in mind let me just put it
back to its spot
though don't want to
ruin ruin
it oh I think I bended it a bit I don't
think it's in the positive side of the
okay there we go the positive is
here all
right there we go connected it obviously
if I don't hear anything I just set it
up wrong again we can know from just
again listening to it if you don't
receive anything then basically what I
did is what what I did is change the
direction okay let me get this out of
the way and the gnd D if you can see
right here the gnd D let me just make
sure you can see it the gnd D is again
extended by this it goes the whole way
here and then what happens goes what to
this side and then it goes to the other
side of the what the active buzzer okay
so now let's focus back on the again
four segment LED display so everything
before obviously we start what you want
to do is what we want to check if
everything's hooked up properly
especially the resistors again there
might be cases where again the resistors
are not connected properly basically we
have to push them in so let's just see
if if they're connected properly so let
me go over here to my
code let me just do
that
I have another code I want not this one
I think it's this
one no it's definitely not this one how
about this one I think it's this one
there we go okay let me just remove this
code I don't need this I'm gonna go back
to this we're going to be including
Library so we're going to get back to
this but we want to do is check
everything so again I just set up the
pins again gave them the name and then
connected them to their what to their
again the pins that um we had to use
again to the respective pins uh one
thing you notice here is I again
recommend that you don't use digital pin
one and pin two because again they're
used for what for binary but this time I
was using digital pin one why is that so
because I don't have any space as you
can see I did not have any space I
finished what until 13 I used every pin
until 13 I only have up to 13 and I used
every digital pin that I had okay so
that's why I used two again you can use
them but most case when you don't need
to don't use them okay so again we're
going to start here and then again I set
up everything D1 D2 D3 D4 and then I set
up a delay time set it to 100
milliseconds we're going to get to it
and then obviously I have to set
everything to what to an output just
like how we did in the for in the on
digigit uh seven segment LED display
just did the exactly same thing and I
set every segment to high so we can see
it including the decimal point and then
obviously what do we do we're going to
again using a common cathode so in this
case we want the g& d so the one we want
to light up right now we're going to set
it to what as a g&d we're going to set
it to low so we want we want it to act
like a g& d so we're going to set this
to what to low basically to have what to
make a complete circuit soon as we turn
this all of it to high and then we turn
this to low we basically me what we
create a 5 volt to ground type of
circuit a a complete circuit okay now
I'm going to set every other to what to
high let's see if I don't set this to
high let's see what happens if I don't
set this to high let me
just comment this out let's comment
actually the second digit too let's
let's comment everything and let's just
focus on this one let me just do that
let me just comment everything and focus
on the first one okay and I'm going to
get back to them comment it
out commented out now only this one
should be working then I say what I said
this below but let's just say I forgot
about writing these again I just only
focused on D1 right here and forgot
about these let's see what
happens okay should be done compiling
and now should be uploading can you see
it one all of them are lighting up as
you can see but obviously there's a
problem right now the problem is it's
not consistent I mean let me just turn
off the light so you can see it way
better some of them again what light up
bright and the other ones are just Dim
when you look at them other ones are
just dim I don't think you might notice
it in the camera but when you look at it
in real life it's just the for example
the four digigit right here is very very
dim okay and obviously they represent
what the same character over and over
again right now I just wrote down eight
uh I wanted to write down eight and they
represent the same character I want it
to have this this is not lighting up
okay this is not lighting up I have to
think it's this one there we go let me
add that
segment the G which which one's not
lighting up right now right now the
middle is not lighting up let's just see
what even segment here is the segment is
G what pin is it uh pin 12 G is attached
to pin 12 where is G G's here okay G's
right here so should be around here okay
there we
go it's a bit of hustle to to even
connect them there's a lot of pain even
in connecting these okay there we go now
now everything's lighting up but as you
can see everything lights up so
obviously what should we do right here
should set everything what everything by
default is what everything by default is
set to low or as we know it every pen by
default to set to low we want to set
them to high so that they don't what
they basically don't what they basically
don't display right here let me just set
that to
high now only the first digit should be
working there we go the first digit is
displaying really really bright nice
it's going nice right here so actually
for you guys to even see it let me just
change the angle again just keep on
changing the angle so you can see it
there we go I think this is better yeah
that is better you can't even see this
one too you can see the there we go
that's better now obviously let me
just put back the code that I just
commented out okay let me just put that
back there we go and now let's just
upload it so basically what happens is
what we set this to low again then we
set this to all of it to high so
basically what digital pin one only
displays and then we're going to set it
for what the delay time is set to 100
milliseconds after 100 milliseconds
what's going to happen is what we're
going to set this again all of it to
high the other digital pins I'm not
going to write the same thing over again
because I already set it to high and I
want to keep it that way okay because I
want to check what everything is working
perfectly fine that's that's why I'm not
going to you know write this again
because I'm going to be setting all of
these to high so they're already set to
high so I'm not going to touch them
that's what I want okay obviously if I
want to write down something and stuff
I'm going to turn it off but now I'm
just using it for testing purposes okay
so set this to low for the second digit
and other them set it to what to high
and give it a delay time and then do the
same thing except for digital what
digital sorry digital digit three again
digit three we're going to do that for
low we're going to set it to low and
then obviously give it a delay Tye and
then all of it to high and then finally
we got to put what digit four to low
basically turning on digit four okay and
then having a delay time right here let
me just upload this and let's see what
happens all right can you see it it's
scanning can you see it's going
8888888 I gave it a delay of 100
milliseconds okay that's how it's
working let me just set this to again to
a very small number let's say five
milliseconds right now and let me just
upload it when I do that let's see what
happens when I do five look at it it
goes so fast it scans so fast it just
switches from one digit to another digit
so fast that we cannot see it so we can
just see is what we can see is that all
LEDs are what turned on for us for for
our eyes what we can see is what all
LEDs are what turned on obviously that's
not the case what it's doing is scanning
it really really really fast just like
how we did when when we put it 200
milliseconds you can just see the effect
you can see the effect when you put it
200 milliseconds scanning it really
really really fast look at it look at
how it does it really fast really fast
really fast let me just put it to 20 so
you can see it even let's go let Let It
Go even faster than it is let's go even
one five times faster and look at it
it's flickering can you see it how fast
it's going it's just flickering we
cannot see it we can see it it's going
so fast but when we set it to five right
now when we just set it to again five
which is four times faster than 20 when
we just do that look what happens right
here
we don't see any Interruption we just
see all of them light up for our eyes we
only see what it's all of it is lighting
up because again our eyes cannot what
they cannot comprehend that type of
speed okay that's all that there is so
everything is hooked up properly and as
it should be okay with that in mind
right now what we're going to do is to
make this project interesting is we're
going to be using a library not only
that too if you remember when you were
working with the let me just turn on the
light when we were working with the
Again One digigit 7 second LED display
just focus on the focus on it when we
working with it what we basically did
was what if you remember what we
basically did was what we just used 9 8
7 6 5 4 3 2 1 to just set a timer to
just basically make a timer we just did
was what count up to nine obviously this
led segment can count up to what it can
only count up to nine but when we go to
the four-digit one obviously it can
count up to what it can count up to
99,999 so just think of writing down and
setting up all these numbers just think
of setting up 9,999 going to
9,998 just think of even setting up all
of that you know it's a lot obviously so
in this case it's just way easier to use
what libraries so they make our lives
way way way easier okay so let me just
go over to my screen again and what I'm
going to do is let me just go over to my
code I already wrote the code so again
we don't waste time and we can focus on
actually reading the code understanding
the code okay so again I don't want to
waste time by typing it okay there we go
there's the code all right there's the
code so one library that we're going to
be using is you're going to go to your
library manager and search for surf SE
okay surf SE this literally the surf SE
SEC is literally the library that we're
going to be using okay it's not showing
it oh sa s sorry I misspelled it SA sick
there we go install it right here you
can install it again if you cannot even
if you don't find it on the library
manager again you can go to what you can
say seeg library and then afterwards
searching for seeg look at it go to
arduo page and then you can install it
as a zip right here you can install it
as a zip and then you can again add it
to it you can add it to your sketch
basically I think you guys know how to
do it because I've shown you guys but
even if you don't after you um uh after
you're done doing that what you do after
installing it is you say include
libraries and add don't zip Library okay
that's all you need to do but again you
can just Again download it from here
it's going to be easy let me just remove
it for now so that I can install it as
you can see all you have to do is just
tap the install button
and when once you're done there you go
we're just done that's all we need to do
there we go okay so the saf Library just
helps us again work with LED matrices
all right so it's going to help us as
what it's going to be working with LED
segments right here so it's going to
make our lives way way way easier oh I
think it's displaying 999 I'm just going
to fix that up there we go okay it's
going to make our lives way easier as I
said again using libraries we're just
going to what we're going to focus on
actually work on a project and actually
understanding lots and lots of Concepts
because they're going to be lots of
Concepts here okay so what I did again
is here and my code let actually I can
turn off the light uh no let me just
keep it on it's just
reflecting am let me just put it down
there we go okay so when it comes to the
code all I did is again set up the every
segment right here with its respective
pin and then again put again the digital
again the sorry the digits right here
set it up and I set up a delay time of
five five milliseconds that's all I did
right here what do we set up okay wa
this is not supposed to be the this is
not the oh this is the one that I turned
on the all of the segments where where
is that that other one there we go I
want the other one I want this one there
we go there we go all I did is again set
up what I set up every digit again and
again gave it its variable gave it a
variable name and then what I did here
is user input basically what this
program does let me show you let me just
show you the program ring let me just
upload it first so you can see how the
program works okay so it compiles my
sketch okay it's done compiling now it
should be done
uploading okay so let me show you what
happens again once you're done building
the course what is supposed to happen so
again we can set a timer for seconds
maximum is what
9,999
9,99 so again we're going to set a timer
in what in seconds okay so let me just
set a timer for let's say 10 seconds I'm
going to enter it okay after I'm done
entering it it starts counting to 10
goes 8 7 6 and you can see five it's
going for 3 2
and the buzzer should be ringing the
buzzer isn't that loud let me try it
again let me try one minut one second
again did I flip it maybe I should flip
it should flip my diode because you
cannot hear
anything maybe I again put the wrong
direction on the diode because it can
happen as I
said let me just get the
positive get the positive with this
all
right the positive there we go that's
the positive I think I think it's the
opposite direction so we're not hearing
anything from the buzzer let me just say
two seconds now two
milliseconds we're totally not going to
hear
anything okay I'm using an active buzzer
okay there we go and let me just check
the polarity of the again the active
buzzer the positive is supposed to be
here let me just
put the change the direction here too I
think it's the
direction
right the positive is here the negative
should
be right around
here okay the positive is connected the
negative it's connected the negative
terminal basically the G and D okay and
then this is going to be connected to
analog pin 4 I set it up as analog pin 4
let me just check it out bus pin set to
as you can see unlock pin for let me try
to upload this code again may it should
be the uploading let me turn off my
serial monitor first though let me first
turn off my serial monitor before
uploading it okay it's done
compiling okay it should be uploading
all right there we go let me just again
set up for three three seconds counts
three 2
one
okay I think the problem is let me just
go over to my try to find analog
right okay let me just set this to 5
milliseconds this one to 255 yes
basically 5 volt 255 5 volt yeah and it
turns off after 5 Seconds of what 5
Seconds of playing a timer let me just
do that going turn off my serial monitor
fast before it it's done uploading there
we go let me go back this code let me go
up now let me go to my serial monitor
let Set it
three should be working come
on Can You Hear
It
O I think you can hear something but
it's not the best okay I think it's
because this one is not connected
properly I think one of them is not
connected properly you know what so what
I'm going to do right here is again
search for analog right command let me
just turn off this analog right let me
just when it turns it off this is
basically turning off your what it's
basically going to turn this off after 5
seconds it's going to turn off what our
uh our um our buzzer so let me just turn
that off and let me try to wire up wire
it up properly I think it's the wiring
that's causing the problem let me upload
this code first and then let's try to
again use the timer let's just do that
done compiling uploading and it should
be done uploading okay let me set this
to
three
okay now we can hear it
continuously just correcting the analog
pin
for you can hear something can't you
can you hear it so what happened again
what did I say right here I said that
when we're using what when we're using
diodes what happens is what we hear it
half the time musically okay we hear it
half the time because again when it
comes to each circuit it goes back and
forth so going to only work what in One
Direction let's say the back one works
okay let's say the back one works the
fourth one doesn't work okay so
basically we're going to hear it for
what we half the time okay so we're
basically hearing it is what can you
hear it it's not like the normal active
buzzer sound but it's creating a sound
why is that just think of it as if
you're using uh a delay of what five uh
milliseconds and then what giving it an
off okay just turning it off on off on
off keeping off doing it what for over
what half of the period of tie okay just
think of doing that it's basically that
okay because it's turned off for what
for half the tie as I said again when it
goes to the other direction when the
current revers in other direction it's
not going to go to what to the buzzer
why is that
so because we have a what we have a
diode
okay let me just focus here there we go
it is working okay so now let's focus on
something else let me just turn off the
serial let me just actually upload it
again let me first turn this on so that
turns it off after 5 Seconds basically
like how a timer just turns off after a
while it's going to turn off after 5
Seconds okay that's the code right here
let me just go all the way up and let's
start actually analyzing the code
because it it does work okay I know it
might seem a lot of code but I'm just
going to explain to you what I just did
most of it is copy paste so don't get
intimidated by the like the amount of
code that there is here okay so user
input is what user input is basically
the amount that we're going to be
receiving from what from a user right
here I'm going to save it so for example
the number we're going to be receiving
here if it's a 30 it's going to be what
user input is going to be what set to
what the 30 right here okay it's
basically that okay this code is useless
right here so I just removed it and
there's bus pin right here which going
to be set to A4
again I'm going to be using this
obviously for my what for my buzzer
makes sense and then I'm going to set
there a delay time of 5 milliseconds
okay then I'm going to what I'm going to
include the sefc library right now the
one that I again what installed in the
library manager I'm just going to
include it right here and right here it
says is what SE seg SE seg right here
again again the capitalization matters
okay again you can read the
documentation for yourself you can just
say you can Google it yourself say SEF
seg uh documentation right here let me
just I already Googled it sa SE Library
documentation and you can go to your to
the GitHub right here and actually read
what the SE seg is capable of okay so
you can read it for yourself but I
already read the documentation myself
and I'm going to be what I'm just going
to be uh using it for this purpose all
right I just want you guys to know that
let me just go to the there we go so
it's basically what it's basically
asking SE SEC right here to set up an
object or a list called sefc okay it's
going to be creating a seeg called list
and we're going to be using this a lot
like look at here I'm going to be using
se. begin se. SE brightness SE seg do a
lot there's even se. refresh right here
set number refresh display so basically
it's going to contain the commands of
our of what of the SEF seg what library
okay it's basically like how Arduino
sets up you know how Arduino is like hey
Arduino be like Arduino sets up what
serial monitor okay it sets up the
object called cereal right here a cal
just like how we obviously this is
automatic by the way just like how we
use Cal and say do begin we say
serial.println right here Arduino is
basically what it's like Arduino what
setting it to what serial I just want
you to think of it it's like that
equivalent all right but obviously
Arduino does it what Arduino does it
automatically we going have to touch
anything but when it comes to libraries
we have to do it ourselves okay we have
to do it manually okay we're just
setting up what saf s uh just think of
it as a folder named SE SEC and it has a
lot of files again okay lots of files
right now okay I just want you to think
of it like that okay so again we're
going to see this as a what as a bite
again as you remember we were talking
about bytes when we were changing it to
Binary saying eight bit 10 bit and we
were checking that so basically a bite
is literally what a single bite is eight
bits okay so basically it's like eight
bits of what information and we also saw
how eight bits of information literally
correspond with you know when we're
working with with Zer up to 255 for what
when we're using what analog again
analog right command if for remember
okay so we're using a bite okay so we're
going to be setting this to a bite again
okay and we're going to tell this and
and we're going to set this is what
number of digits basically what for
example in our case we have four digits
okay we have four digits it's going to
be corresponding to what to one and
eight if you go to your documentation
right here it just tells you right
here should be around where is it I
actually saw there we go supports up to
what 1 to8 digit displays okay I want
you to understand that so basically what
I did is what the number of digits that
is on my what on my seven segment LED
display in this case I'm using what I'm
using a four digit seven segment LED
display that's why I'm going to set it
to what to four and then afterwards what
I'm going to do is what write this down
again digit pins and then what do I do I
set it in order okay I say the digit
pins what are the digit pins they're D1
I already defined them here they're D1
D2 D3 and D4 okay one thing I want you
guys to understand here is order matters
okay you're going to first put D1 and
then you're going to put D2 and then D3
and then D4 okay you cannot jumble it up
and then expect the library to
understand which one's which okay it's
not it's never going to understand that
so again one thing I want you guys to
understand is what D1 D2 and D3 and D4
are supposed to be set with in an order
okay the same goes for segments right
here when we said segment pins okay it's
going to be set in an order why is that
so it's important to be in order as I
said again there are lots and lots of
models of what seven segment LED
displays okay there are lots of models
of them right here mine has a different
number which is 420 something and I
didn't even find the what I didn't even
find the documentation regarding my type
okay so they're going to be lots of them
that are manufactured by different again
different companies okay they're going
to be different where the pins are the
pin placements are going to be what
they're going to be different from pin
from seg mment to segment okay that's
why it needs to know which is which is
which okay so you need to figure it out
yourself as I said again You're going to
figure it out yourself and then you're
going to what Define it here and then
you're going to put it in an order okay
you're going to put an order of what a b
CDE e f g in alphabetical order and then
finally put your decimal point all right
then afterwards there is again we're
going to put the type of again um um the
type of data we're going to store in
this variable in this case Say Bo I'm
going to I'm going to teach you guys
what that means okay then it says
resistors on segments are we using
resistors on our segments yes we are so
we set it to true true basically meaning
what yes we are okay what does a bullion
mean so a bullion basically means true
or false okay it holds two values true
or false so true basically means I want
you to think of them as being asked as a
question when you asked a question for
example are you hungry you're going to
say yes or no it's a yes or no question
okay you're going to say yes if you're
hungry you're going to say yes and if
you're not hungry you're going going to
say what no if you're fully going to say
what you're you're going to say what no
okay that's basically it but obviously
different in what in computers basically
you're asking our computer do you have
resistors on your segment that's
literally what SE is asking us and we're
setting it to what we're saying yes we
do we're setting it to what to True okay
so this is basically booleans okay so
even if you Google it for yourselves and
say bullying
values this is again basic computer and
I think that most of you do not know
don't have prior programming knowledge
okay so right here represents a truth
value that is obviously true or false
okay that's literally what it is so to
express booleans again they're data
types just like how we have numbers and
you know strings and all that there's
something called booleans again they're
data types okay I want you to get into
detail right here they're data types and
then we're going to represent it by what
by using the word Bol okay that's one
thing you should keep in mind all right
then afterwards we tell up the hardware
configuration ation is yours common
cathode or is yours common anode
obviously for those of you have a common
anode you're going to be what you're
going to remove this and say common
anode there we go it's going to finish
it by itself it has aut ofil so you can
just finish it by yourself again
capitalization everywhere matters so
again make sure that you write it down
in capital lers let me just put this
back to Common cathode because mine is
common cathode again if you have a
common anode it's going to set it up to
what common anode okay then as soon as
what we're done doing that what we do is
we set our what we begin just like how
we begin our serial monitor we're going
to begin giving our SE SEC the
information we just set it right here
what did what did we do right here we
just set up the information in what in
variables that's all we did right now
what what are we going to do we're going
to what we're going to give this
information we're going to hand it over
to what to se okay we're going to give
it its Hardware configuration right here
which is going to be common cathode
we're going to give it the number of
digits again which is literally four for
our case and we're going to set our
digit pins again we're going to give it
our digit pins the list of Digit pins
right here okay segment pins to and then
resistors on segments one thing I want
you guys to keep in mind right here is
what when we put these again squared
again squared uh uh brids right here
okay when we put them okay one thing I
want you to understand is we're just
saying is we have a list okay this means
is what we have a list we're going to be
setting up a list okay so we're
basically doing what we're just setting
up a list we're just setting up a list
of what a list of Digit pins right here
so basically this does what it just
tells Arduino hey we're about to what
we're about to use lists in our code
okay that's all it's basically telling
you okay and afterwards once we're done
again giving this information handing
this information to sepc what do we do
we set the brightness right here okay
and I read the documentation and it
should be around 0 to 200 okay it turns
it lights up from 0 to 200 the value is
going to be 0 to 200 right here but when
it comes to 200 we're going to see
something like flickering all right just
like how when we're using uh when we
were using uh let me just bring this
right here and we set this to 20 when we
set the delay time to 20 and we try to
turn on everything and this to 20 and
just like how we turn on everything
we're going to see some flickering don't
we I'm just to compile and just upload
it okay I have the seral monitor open on
this one that's why there we go now it
should be
working okay it's compiling and now it
should be uploading it's like how when
we're trying to do that it flickers a
lot can you see it it's flickering a lot
you see it right it flickers a lot
basically that's what's happening right
here basically it's telling us right
here to use a brightness between I want
you to do right here is listen um right
here when we set it from 0o to 100 it's
going to be perfectly bright but when we
set it to something above 100 for
example between 100 200 flickering again
might occur okay so to prevent this I'm
just going to set it to a value between
zero and 100 right now just set it to 90
you can set it to 100 if you want to but
again most cases don't use 100 to 200
value okay okay because it flickers a
lot from my experience not only that too
but it's also written in the
documentation okay then afterwards we
finally what start our serial monitor
right here start our serial monitor okay
then after we're done setting up our
code right now what do we do now we're
going to ask the question hey set a
timer for what set a timer for seconds
and the maximum is what let me actually
set right here should put a comma right
here makes more sense to put a comma uh
set a timer for seconds the maximum is
what the maximum is what
99,99 obviously the maximum is what
9,99 I'm just saying that okay let's
just say again a user wants to use our
again our Domino and set a timer let's
just say that we're just again creating
a product that is like the timer or
something for again users a simple
digital timer let's just say we're
creating that for a user okay so we're
going to ask set a timer for seconds the
maximum is what the maximum is
9,99 okay I'm again printing the string
out and then look what happens here
there's a wild code right here there's a
code right here that you guys don't
understand so what I'm going to do right
here okay just to make again our lives
way simpler let me just get out of the
sketch right here and try to explain it
let me just open a new sketch and try to
explain it inside of a new sketch I
think it's going to make it way way
easier let this
load this some time okay it's taking a
bit while there we go it's loading and
let me just show you what I mean by what
this Loop does right here what does even
this code mean okay so first things
first is we're going to be setting up
our serial monitor okay serial. begin I
just want you to follow along I don't
want you to code this okay I just want
you to follow and just give me your
attention Okay then afterwards what I
want you to do right here is we're going
to write down while and then me go here
and then right here set something called
we're going to be using the serial again
and we're going to saying available okay
and we're going to set this to zero
we're not going to set this to zero
we're going to compare it to zero right
here and let me just try to explain this
code for you but before that let me try
to print something without it so let me
just comment this out basically let me
just leave this out for now let me just
try to print something let's see the
problem that there is and let's see the
problem it solves for us okay let's see
what this Cod what this code solves for
us okay so let me just again try to
print what let's say uh let me just try
to ask it a question right here Hi how
are you okay I'm just trying to ask it a
question right here let me set a
semicolon right now and let's see what
happens okay let me upload
this and it should be done uploading
it's compiling and it should be done
uploading by now okay it's done
uploading so let's see what happens
here so let me turn on the serial
Monitor and just go close to it and you
see that it's printing out the same
thing Hi how are you multiple times
again and again and again can you see it
just printing it out again infinitely so
it's just going through a loop again
printing it again printing it again
printing it so just think of just being
in a conversation and some somebody asks
you a question what do you do you what
you go silent and what wait for a
response don't you you go silent and you
wait for a response basically Arduino is
what Arduino is basically asking us the
question over and over again and just
think of somebody doing that in real
life that would be really really awkward
and really weird really so anyways how
do we stop ardino you know from telling
us you know from um from again how do we
tell Arduino to to again to tell it to
shut up right now just hey Arduino I
just want you to shut up until I give
you a response
how do we do that so obviously we're
going to be using the while loop right
here okay and we're going to be saying
serial. available okay there we go equal
to what equal to zero and then when we
set it to here again what does it show
right here basically now it's going to
ask me one time right here okay so I'm
just again remove the serial monitor
when uploading it there we go ask me it
asks the same thing there we go still
uploading so right now what does it do
stops asking me the question it just
basically stops asking the question just
asks once and then waits for my response
can you see that it waits for me to
enter a message right here let's say I'm
doing fine doing fine and just send it
over okay so waits for me until what
until I'm done giving it a response
right here okay that's what it does so
again serial. available checks what
checks the amount of information that is
coming here through here so basically
the amount of information that is being
sent by our serial monitor right here in
this case we're if we're not sending
anything it's going to be equal to what
it's going to be equal to what it's
going to be equal to zero if you don't
send anything it's going to be equal to
zero when I when as soon as I send
something though it's not going to be
equal to zero right here let me just do
that soon as I do that this will no
longer be true so this while loop is no
longer going to be true
okay there we go now it keeps asking me
the same question why is that so because
it's no longer what equal to zero again
the amount of information that I'm being
sent by the message again by the serial
monitor is what is no longer to zero I'm
sending some sort of information
specifically right now I'm sending what
I'm sending a string okay so right here
what does it do a wild Loop does again
wild Loop does is again while is
basically as I said again while
hungry we can use this metaphor
again while hungry eat okay so I want
you to think of them as what while loop
I just want you to think of them as what
it going to it's going to keep on
running this same thing and same thing
the same thing over and over again until
what this condition is false the
condition that is here is what is set to
false okay so let's say while we're
hungry what do we do we keep on eating
we keep on eating we keep on eating but
as soon as we not we're no longer hungry
basically we're full what happens we
stopped eating okay so we stop this
specifically what in this case what
doesn't mean we're going to skip the
code that is in between the curly
brackets right here the curly braces
right here so we're going to be what
we're going to be skipping the code
between it until what until that
condition the condition that we set here
is what it's false so so in this case it
is true until what until I give it a
message right here as soon as I give it
a message though it's false right here
there's nothing here so basically what
am I telling it is basically wait wait
for my response don't run any code just
wait for my response and it's is going
to keep on what running this on a loop
on a loop again and again and again
waiting for what for my response okay so
it's was going to be waiting for my
response and as soon as I respond to it
it starts to what it starts to actually
uh give me what starts to actually what
starts to actually run the code that is
below here okay so run the code that is
found below the Ser what the while again
the while loop okay the while loop is
going to keep running over and over
again it's not going to read the the
code that's beneath it okay it's not
going to be reading the code that's
beneath it what is it going to do it's
going to be reading again the while loop
over and over and over again until what
until I get a response as soon as I do
it's going to go beneath and read the
code that I wrote down beneath the W
Loop okay so once you just keep that in
mind let just go to our Arduino right
here there we go let's go back to our
actually go back to our code right here
to our W Loop code okay just go here
where is it there we go okay afterwards
what do we do we take the user input
right here and then it's set to what
serial. parse int so what does serial.
parse in mean so let me start from
something you guys know and you guys
learned about u in the previous few
sections so one thing you guys learned
about is what we learned about again
setting up strings right here so we set
up a string right here and then what did
we do let me just give it a name user
feed okay for now just give it a name
let me set it up and then what did it do
right here I'm going to do is I'm going
to say user feed. what user feed I'm
going to say user feed I'm going to set
it to sorry I have to set it to
something it's a variable I have to set
it to something I'm going to set it to
re serial. read string right read string
basically what does this mean basically
what it's going to read what the value
that is going to come from here what do
I expect to be I expect it to be what a
string it's written right here I want it
to be a string so if I display a value
right here let me just say um I am fine
to the serial monitor but before doing
that I have to upload it let just
actually upload it first let me upload
it and then I can just run it okay it's
done compiling and it should be
uploading now okay it's done uploading
there we go now let's go to our serial
monitor there we go and what do I say I
am fine okay let me just say I am fine
right here here there we go if you just
let let me just print out user feed
right now it's better to print out user
feed so we can see it ourselves let just
say print Ln and say I want to print out
the user feed after what after we set it
up okay there we go let me just upload
it let me close my seral mon till that
time all right everything should be
going good now it's not uploading now
let's check what happens here okay let
me just say I am
fine okay it prints out out I am fine
there we go prints out what I am fine
nice so what does this mean again this
is again used for what for Strings
reading strings so if you remember what
did it do it always made what created a
new line always at the very end it
created a new line for what for our
responses if you remember create a new
line so I can just say serial.print and
again it's going to print it out in a
new line if you remember not only that
too but importantly right now what does
it do it also sets it to what to a
strength so even if I let's say give a
value of 10 right here if I say 10 and
just enter it over here it's going to
give me what even though it looks the
same thing right here it seems like the
same thing it's giving me what it's
giving me this what it's what Arduino is
outputting is what it's outputting 10
what I want is what the number 10 it's
giving me the text 10 right here okay
you might not see from the serial
monitor I mean for Ser from the serial
monitor you just assume that oh it's
just 10 no difference here but obviously
what is it doing it's giving me the what
the string 10 okay it's not giving you
what the number 10 obviously with that
case we cannot what we cannot you know
multiply strings we cannot add up
strings they don't have the properties
of what numbers okay it's going to treat
it as a what as a text our green is
going to treat our 10 as a what as a
text when we put it inside of a string
it's going to be thinking of it as what
as a text containing What as the text
containing number 10 so it's not going
to be able to multiply it to add it and
this property is very very important
because we're going to go here let me
just go show you guys right here even in
our sketch right here we're going to be
using something called set number from
what from our SE Library okay so we're
going to be using set number so again
when set number obviously the name
self-explanatory we expect a what we're
going to be setting a number right here
okay so we're going to be expecting what
a number if you put a string right here
we're going to be what we're going to be
confusing our SE Sego Library okay we're
going to be getting a bunch of Errors
okay so right here just to make sure
that you know we're receiving number 10
and we want to even give out numbers is
how do we tell Arduino that we're going
to give it numbers instead of strings
how how we're going to tell it that
we're going to be giving it numbers is
literally using parse int okay parse in
it contains the the what the the the
name int the integers it indicates what
integers okay so we're telling our we
know what we're going to be giving it
integers okay in the message board we're
going to be giving it what we're going
to be giving it integers and most
importantly I want you to store it as
what I want you to store it in the
variable as a what as an integer I want
you to store it as a string I want you
to store it as what as want you to store
it as a number okay that's what we're
telling Arduino so it expects a number
not only does it expect a number but
also what it also is going to be
outputting it in again setting our
variable to a what to a number okay so
right here let me just say right here
and parent I'm just going to say 10
right here and then it's going to give
give me can you see it I just give it 10
right here just gave me 10 obviously I
just said print right here not print Ln
I said print right here uh so it's give
me 10 and then ask the question again
because obviously what because again
it's running on Loop so it's going to be
asking me the same question once it's
done going through the loop okay so the
main important thing here is what when
it comes to parseint it's what we're
going to be receiving integers on the
message board that's where we're telling
what uino okay so we're going to be
telling ardino we're going to be
receiving 10 not only that too but what
we're going to store it at what as a
number I want it specifically store it
as what as a number I don't want you to
store it as a string that's where we're
telling ouro or obviously there's
something called parse end and there's
something else called parse float
basically parse float is literally the
same thing as parse ENT except for what
it's for float numbers basically what
decimals okay so let me just go back to
parent that's one thing I want you guys
to know okay so even actually we said
that we Ed the while serial. available
again this Loop right here we Ed it
again to what for R you know not to asks
the same question but it's actually
important too in another aspect okay let
me just remove the question right now
again let me let me just show you why
it's important too just go right here
let me just dice it out again let me
just take it out right now and let's see
let me just upload it let me just try to
set up a variable right here okay let's
see what happens okay okay it's should
be done uploading by now there we go and
when we put on the serial monitor let me
just again if you cannot see it right
now but it keeps on outputting z0 z0 0
can you see it but let me just again
give it a value right here let me just
say 22 okay it's going to Output 22 and
then it's going to go back to 0 0 0 0
what's going on you might be wondering
obviously the problem here is what the
problem here is what uino starts reading
this code and for now what did we set uh
in our in our message bar we did not set
anything when we don't set anything what
happens it's equal to what it's equal to
zero so basically what it's going to
Output zero can you see it it's going to
be outputting zero and it's going to be
printing it you see that right so what
do what does it prevent to this wild.
serial. available again code prevents to
it's going to wait for for us to what
for our message before what setting up
our variable so it's important not only
in asking the question for the question
not to be repeated again and again and
again but it's also important in what
it's also important for us to what to
set up our variables okay so it's just
going to set it up to what it's going to
be setting our variable before we give
it a response it's going to prevent that
okay so just keep that in mind okay so
let me just go over uh go over back to
our main code right here and let's try
to read the other part of it so right
here I'm asking it is is user input is
what less than or equal to
99,999 because we cannot display
anything beyond what four digits as I
said again and and this symbol right
here and then what it tells us is what
user input must be greater than zero as
you remember what it goes down it goes
let's say if we have 20 right here we
start our timer from 20 it's going to go
20 19 18 it's going to go all the way to
what let's say it goes to 5 4 3 2 1 zero
it's going to keep on decreasing so -1
-2 I don't want it to go to what I don't
want it to go to negative numbers and
zero because obviously time obviously
cannot be negative okay so I don't want
it to go to what to negative numbers
that's why I always want to check before
running any code I want to make sure
that the user input is what has to be
greater than zero because we're going to
be what we're going to be decreasing one
as soon as we go anyways one thing you
always want to make sure is what it's
less than 99,999 and then what less than
or equal to
99999 and then greater than zero okay
then okay these again this symbol right
here let me start from the symbol right
here I think you guys know obviously the
if statement the symbol right here
basically means less than equals to if
you just go over here and U let me just
go over here right now and let's go to
less than or less than or equal to the
sign if you look at the sign of it I
think most of you are familiar with this
in math we use this sign this symbol
right here but we don't have the symbol
in our keyboard okay so when we're
coding we write it down is okay how do
we write it down we write it down is
what we put our again our first again
less than or equal to whatever it is
less than or greater than we put it
first and then we put the equal sign
okay we put the equal sign at the end
okay so for something like greater than
let me just try to write down greater
than if you want to write down greater
than or equal to we just put the greater
sign right here and then we put the
equal sign at the very end okay just
want you guys to keep that in mind okay
and what does this mean this basically
means like the keyword end okay it just
basically means end okay so right here
what does this mean is okay if the user
input is less than equal to 999 and user
input is greater than zero it's going to
what it's going to run this code
basically if one of them is false what
happens if one of them is false you know
let's say the user input is less let's
say it's less than what it's less than
zero right here okay let's say it's even
zero or negative number and this is
going to be true user input is going to
be what less than negative it's going to
be less than or equal to 999 because
it's going to be a negative number okay
this going to be true but in this case
what happens in this case it's going to
be what it's going to be false it's not
greater than zero a negative number is
now what greater than zero so it's going
to check what both of them are true so
if only both of them are true it's going
to happen what it's going to what it's
going to be running this Condition it's
going to be running this code okay this
condition is going to be true if only
both of them are true when we're using
end okay that's how we express The
Logical term end we just say we put
double what we put double n signs right
here and that's it okay just want you to
keep that in mind when it comes to or
obviously or when it comes to or let me
just actually go back here when it comes
to or we use this sign okay we use this
sign it's found again above your Enter
key and you just use shift and then you
just again touch it okay so what does
this do this basically means or okay and
when it comes to or one of the
conditions are true if one of the
conditions are true it's going to be
true so it's basically asking if user
input is less than or equal to
99,999 either this is true or this is
true if one of them is true it's going
to run the code this condition is going
to be true it's this statement is going
to be what the statement is going to be
true okay I want you to keep in mind
this the statement is what going to be
what it's going to be true so it's it's
going to want want it's going to only
want one true value okay when it comes
to the end everything must be true
everything must be true for the whole
condition to be true okay all right just
keep that in mind okay now let me just
go right here and again right here we're
going to be running the while loop okay
so it's going to be going until this
Loop until what until this condition
turns out to be false so we're going to
be checking again if this is greater
than zero okay just checks for zero and
then what happens it's going to set a
number basically what it's doing is what
we're telling what we're telling seeg
hey I want you to what I want you to
what to display this number okay send
numbers basically I want you to display
this number basically what is this the
user input basically what the user just
input it okay once you're done doing
that what I want you to do is I want you
to display it okay okay so let me just
uh there's a bit of a code that is
repeated over and over again this code
is repeated over like 200 times okay
this code like this specific code right
here this two lines they're repeated
again over 200 times so you might be
wondering why did we write this over 200
times so let me just explain this to you
so right here what people would have
suggested was okay I want you is okay I
want you to do a SE seg I want you to
what I want you to refresh the display
so let me just explain what refresh
refreshing display speed refreshing
display basically means when you're
scanning again you're again if you
remember when um when we're using a four
digigit again segment display what
happens we only turn on what one digit
at a time so it's going to what it's
going to keep on scanning basically what
it's going to keep on running the same
thing again again and again and again
very very fast that we don't see it in
our what you don't see it by our Naked
Eyes okay basically that's what's going
on so we're telling what we're we're
telling SE I want you to physically what
I want you to physically refresh the
display okay I want you to do what I
want you to do exactly what refresh the
display again and again let's say for
example we put a number for example this
time is 20 how do we display 20 on the
third digit what do we do on the third
digit we put a what we put a two and
then on the four digit we put a what on
the four digit on the again on the
display we put a what we put a zero okay
so I wanted to what I wanted to
basically refresh the display I wanted
to go from two Z I want to go two Z two
Z again and again because we can again
as I said again we could only turn on
one what one digit at a time so it's
going to do it very fast so SE is going
to automatically what it's going to
again when you tell it again it's going
to what it's going to refresh it again
and again okay so most people would have
suggested just me let's forget about the
code that's beneath here okay so beneath
the comment right here so what most
people would have suggested was refresh
the display and then okay you know what
we have to set a delay for what for 1
second why is that so basically
represents what after 1 second we just
wanted to what we basically what
representing one second of delay right
here 1 second and then we're going to do
what we're going to decrease it okay
that's was basically what uh most people
would suggest right here we're going to
be telling what refresh the display and
then delay it for a second so that it
counts what it counts a second okay it
counts a second on the timer and then
what it can again we can keep on what we
can keep on decreasing the user input
value okay the problem areses here so
okay let me just let me just think that
Arduino is again reading this code so
it's going to go right here and let's
say the user input is what less than or
equal to 9,99 yes it is let's say I just
put 20 right here okay and is 20 greater
than zero yes it is so it's going to
read this code and then it's what it's
going to be set the number to what it's
going to be setting the number to 20 and
then what it's going to be refreshing
the display and the problem arises here
it's going to read this in an instance
it's going to read this in what in
milliseconds okay it's going to refresh
the display in milliseconds and then
it's going to be delaying okay
physically it's going to be delaying for
what for 1 second so it's going to turn
off the display and delay for what for a
second so let's just say this again
takes Arduino 5 milliseconds to read
let's just say it takes a definitely
less than that but let me just say it
takes it only 5 milliseconds to read
this okay how about this it's going to
be spending okay it's going to be what
it's going to be turned on for 5
milliseconds and then what happens is
what for 955 milliseconds it's just
going to be off okay it's going to be
what it's going to be delayed okay it's
going going to be delayed it's not going
to be on okay we're not going to be
refreshing the display as I said again
it's going to be just delayed it's not
going to be reading any quote for what
for one second that's what's going to be
going on okay so what is the right way
of doing things okay what's the right
way of doing things then the right way
of doing things is let me just remove
this code again the right way of doing
things is okay we're going to put our
seeg we're going to be refreshing it and
then we're going to be delaying it for 5
milliseconds because we cannot notice 5
milliseconds when I put every everything
as I said again let me just put this
right here where is it there we go when
we set the delay time here to 5 and we
again uploaded the code let me just
upload
it okay there we go it's fa failed to
upload okay I see I see why I fail to
upload let me turn off my serial monitor
right here there we go let me just
upload this forget about the errors
right
now okay I should be done compiling and
uploading if I just upload this right
now can you see it it's going to go so
fast that we cannot see what we cannot
see change from one digit to another
digit change from one digit to another
digit and another digit again we cannot
see it because it's going to what very
fast 5 milliseconds is just so fast for
our eyes okay so what I did was let me
go back to my again normal code right
here okay what I'm going to do for my
normal code right here and then what do
I do is I keep on refreshing the display
and I keep on delaying it by 5
milliseconds okay I keep on delaying it
by what by 5 milliseconds there we go so
I keep on refreshing the display and
doing it how many times 200 times okay
this code is again written over and over
again so it's written like over 200
times okay if you go all the way up to I
think line 400 or something you can see
the end of it but anyways it was written
200 times so obviously the simple
question is is what's 200 * 5 200 * 5 is
what 200 * 5 is 1,000 milliseconds
basically what basically a second okay
that's one thing I want you guys to keep
in mind so right here I just keep on
refreshing the display and then do what
do a delay of 5 Seconds refreshing the
display do it what do a delay of 5
Seconds and keep on doing this over
again 200 times so how do we do this
obviously again you write down what I
did was what I obviously wrote down this
code right here and then I started to
what copy paste it until again to the
point of where it reaches 200 again you
have to again paste it 200 times I think
you guys know how to uh you know place
this 200 times really easily obviously
what you do is what you write it down
and then you P again paste it until it's
10 and then you copy the whole 10 and
then you do what after you copy the
whole 10 you paste it how many times 20
times so basically you just count up to
20 and then it's what it's 200 okay so
you obviously you don't have to paste it
200 times okay you don't have to paste
the same to these two lines 200 times
there's an easier way to do it okay so
right now let just go here there we go
it ends here and then once I'm done
again again displaying again my what I'm
done displaying the user input for how
much for a second for a total of 1
second again this adds up to a second I
told you guys once I'm done doing that I
want to do is what I want to minus one
from the current value so right now I
said it was 20 right so it's going to
What minus 20 it's going to be 20 right
here 20 minus 1 is what it's going to be
19 and it's going to set it to what to
the user input it's going to set it to
what to the user input the new user
input is going to be what it's going to
be the old user input right here minus
one okay so it's going to be what if it
was 20 right here it would have been
what it is the the old the new user
input is going to be what it's going to
be 19 after we're done with that it's
going to what it's going to refresh the
display again all right and then what I
wanted to do again is keep on running
this wild code okay we do not finish the
wild code right here this is a quote for
another one but it's going to keep on
running this while loop again it's going
to keep on running this Loop over and
over again until we reach what until we
reach zero let me just go all the all
the way up there we go it's going to
keep on writing this over and over and
over until what until we reach zero as
soon as we reach zero it's going to be
zero is greater than zero is that a true
statement or a false statement is 0
greater than zero no it's a false
statement and as soon as it hits zero
what happens is what again all of this
code all of this that is multiple lines
again until the end of the curly bracket
is going to be what it's going to be
skipped and then as soon as we reach
zero what happens is what as soon as we
zero we're going to have what an analog
right basically what we're going to turn
on our what bus pin for 5 seconds and
then we're going to turn it off okay so
it's going to be ringing for 5 seconds
and then we're going to turn it off okay
then afterwards what happens here SE do
blank what does it do SE do blank what
what it does is basically it turns off
every what it turns off the display okay
so basically if it was displaying
anything and if you just put dot blank
at the end basically does what it's just
going to clear out the display okay it's
going to be turning off everything from
the display okay so right here we're
done with that and we're left with is
only else so it's just the F if El
statement right here okay if you want to
see by the way the end of the curly
brackets right here you have the
rectangle right here right you have to
find the other rectangle the one that is
what the one is that is highlighted by a
rectangle right here so this one is
highlighted by a rectangle let me just
find the other one that is highlighted
by rectangle right now let me just go
all the way
up and as soon as I do
that there we go can you see it it's
what it's mapped with a what it's
highlighted with a rectangle right here
so basically what it's basically the
curly bracket of what the if the if
statement right here so we're saying if
if it's 9,99 and again if it's greater
than or equal to
99,999 and if it's what if it's greater
than zero I want you to run this code
but if it's not there's the else right
here the else we just go all the way
down because it takes a long while there
we go if it's not you know if it's not
be in this range what am I going to say
I'm going to say his maximum number is
99,999 I'm going to tell the user please
try again so let me just run this code
right now let's just upload
it okay all we need to do is upload it
right now and now it should be working
like magic okay and it's done uploading
and now it should be working there we
go now let me just say um 10
seconds should be counting to 10
actually I can turn off the lights too
it's nice four goes to three two
one and there we go the buzzer rings for
what for 5 seconds and then what it
basically turns off so there you have it
this is the timer again made from what
from four segments LED displays using
the what the CF seg again Library
anyways um this is one of the final end
of the projects to be honest and this is
personally my favorite project from the
whole of the the whole course this is
one of the hardest uh sections and
actually one of the what one of the most
rewarding and one of the best again one
of the best project of section of this
uh Sor course so anyways um see you in
the next
section in this section we're going to
be discussing about Led matrices so
you're going to be looking for again
these do looking type of pins right here
that have around eight pins here okay
they have eight pins here and they have
eight pins here so we're going to be
looking for something like that okay so
one thing I want you guys to keep in
mind is while we're also working with
the with the four segment right here so
sorry the four-digit seven segment LED
display one thing that obviously we had
was the number right here so it varied
again the positions of the pins varied
again according to the number one thing
I want you guys to keep in mind is again
there's going to be a specific number
associated with your what with your LED
Matrix right here and then that number
again is going to what it's going to be
literally dictating which pin is which
pin so first on let's just see what led
metrics are even capable of so if you've
seen a l Matrix it might look like
something you've not seen before
something that is completely new but if
you again let me just go over to my
screen and I think most of you are very
very familiar with this these step type
of ads and most of us see this type of
these scrolling type of red LEDs have
you you've seen lots of these led ads
that scroll okay I think most of you
have seen again these again red
scrolling LED ads and they're basically
the same thing obviously the the ones
that are on the ads are obviously bigger
and they're more capable but they
operate on the what on the basics of
this okay this is just that it's a very
very small one okay
all right so right here why do we use
LED matrices first things first rather
than these 4digit seven segment LED
displays because we use this display
again to display what we display numbers
within any number that we wanted from 0
to 9 but obviously when you try to
display uh something other than a number
for example an alphabet we start running
through errors okay so right here let me
just try to display small a what should
I even be turning on it's impossible to
what impossible to what to turn on small
a for example here what to basically
display a small letter A okay but using
an LED Matrix what we're capable of
again we're capable of what we're
capable of displaying any type of
alphabet all right small letter capital
letter uh any number and even small
small types of images basically we
cannot display a sophisticated image
using this but we can display simple
images for example a smiley face frowny
face and other than that so we're going
to display a little bit of what Smiley
again again we can display what simple
images okay so LED mat are more capable
than what they're more capable than our
four digigit again seven segment LED
display we use this again when we want
what we want to only dis play What
numbers obviously they're no match to
obviously they're no match to our again
LCD screen that we have on our phones
and tablets and laptops but they're way
cheap and again they're going to show
you the text when you need them so so
okay so they're very cheap and again
very very useful all right so now let me
just show you how an LED Matrix works so
before even you know using it in our
project what we're going to do is check
how LED Matrix work okay so let me go
over to my presentation right here so
right here is what they're marked every
pen is marked with a what with column
one column two column three all the way
up to eight okay the same goes for rows
they're what they're marked from Row one
to row eight and one thing I want you
guys to understand is row is what from
left to right extend is from left to
right while columns extend from what
from up to down okay so if you go inside
of an LED Matrix what you're going to be
seeing is what you're going to be seeing
lots and lots of wires let me just show
you a wire right here this is basically
the inside of what led Matrix you can
see what you can see multiple lines here
the ones that again extend the wires
that extend from left to right are what
they're rows okay they're going to be
this lines again so I just want you to
think of them as a grid okay they're
going to be basically what a grid a grid
of what a grid of literally wires okay
so you can see this again they go to the
corresponding number RS go from left to
right and then there's columns Mark with
a what Mark with a black color the black
line is what columns and the red line is
rows okay so how do we turn on a
specific specific what a specific dot
basically a specific LED inside of this
led Matrix how do we do that basically
what we do is okay we turn on R5 we set
it to what we set it to high okay we're
going to be setting up let's say for
example we're going to be setting up R5
to high row five to high and then what
we're going to do is what set column 3
to low when we do that guess what
happens I want you to take a guess which
led segment lights up is it this one
specifically or even uh the the whole
row lights up here the whole row lights
up what
happens I just want you to take a guess
for those of you who guess that the
whole row will light up you're wrong
because what happens here is what the 5
volt is going to be connected for
example let's say to this led right here
the LED segment that's here but the
problem is what it's not a complete
circuit a complete circuit always has
what it has what the positive terminal
and the negative terminal okay so in
this case it has the 5 volt again but it
does not have what a negative terminal
so specific here it's not going to light
up the same goes for this one for these
ones that are here but when it comes to
the one that is again located at Row 5
and column 3 what happens is what what
happens is what it lights up because why
we have the 5 Vol coming in from row
five and we have the ground pin the
negative terminal coming from what from
the column three so specifically right
here it's going to what it's going to
light up there we go it's going to light
up okay that's one thing I want you to
keep in mind all right so let's just
move forward right here and let's try to
draw an L okay let's try to draw a
simple L um one thing I want you guys to
actually keep in mind when trying to
draw the simple else is what do we need
to turn on we need to turn on R2 okay we
need to set R3 to high we need to set R4
to high okay then we need to set R5 to
high and then when it comes to the
columns what happens we turn on C3 to
what we we turn it on to low so
basically what we create a full circuit
for these four LEDs and then we set C4
to low and then C5 to low I think most
of you would suggest me to do what to do
this to get what an L but there is a
problem here okay and this is literally
what this is the result that we expect
but what actually happens is what
actually happens is it's going to light
up like this why is that so right here
unintentionally unintentionally we lit
up what column 4 and row two Row three
and row four are already set to what
they're already set to high because of
what we're again think talking about
what column 3 but we already said column
4 to low so basically when they
intersect right here basically what
we're going to have a full circuit so
when you have full circuit what happens
in this case it's going to what it's
going to light up so these LEDs are
going to start to light up and the same
goes for what C5 so it was more of like
the problem that we had when we were
working with the Ford
for the four-digit uh seven segment LED
displays you remember we did was what we
tried to turn on everything right here
we tried to turn on four of the digits
right here when we tried to do that it
started what started copying the first
digit and the first digit started
copying the second one and the second
one copy the third one and the third one
copy the fourth one basically giving us
the same thing so for example if I let's
say turn on seven right here and try to
turn on all of this forage at once what
we what are we going to be getting we're
going to be getting s s s s okay okay
that's what that's what basically is
happening so if you look right here
again what happened is what the column 4
what started to copy column three that's
what's going on column four copied
column three and column uh column again
five copied column three can you see
that what happens is there we go it
started to copy it and basically they're
literally what they're literally the
same right now column 3 column four and
column 5 light up the same
okay so how do we prevent this we we do
exactly what we just did when it came to
what when it came to the four segment uh
sorry four digigit seven segment LED
display what did we do we only displayed
one digit at a time and then we switched
from one digit to another digit right so
for example right here I displayed eight
and then what did I do I moved to what I
moved to here and then displayed another
number for example let's say two and
then after I'm done with that I
displayed what let's say three right
here and then I'm done once I'm done
with this I displayed four but again one
thing obviously Arduino did so good is
what it was very very fast the Arduino
was very very fast at scanning and again
going turning off the first digit going
to the second digit it was so fast that
for our eyes we can see all of them is
on so basically what we cannot see
ardino physically doing what or you know
turning off the first digit and going to
the second digit it was that fast so
we're going to be doing exactly the same
thing here so what we're going to be
doing is what okay we don't want again
column four and column five to copy what
column three so do what do we do we only
turn on column three right here okay one
part of the L we're trying to again uh
write down cap capital letter L what
we're going to do is what we're going to
set up R2 up to R5 to high and then
we're going to set column 3 to low so
we're going to basically have what this
line once we do have that we're going to
what we're going to automatically what
we're going to turn off what column
three okay we're going to be what we're
going to be turning all of them off okay
so we're going to be turning this to
what we're going to be turning column 3
to high and then what row two up to row
five are going to be what row 12 to row
five are going to be set to low then
afterwards what do we do then afterwards
we what we focus on what we're going to
be turning on row five and then we're
going to be turning off what we're going
to be setting this to low and we're
going to be setting this to low column
four and column five so basically we
have what we have an L obviously we
cannot see it right now as if I'm just
doing it separately but if I even try to
use this on the presentation let me try
to actually toggle between it very fast
so you can see it okay
so you can see somewhat of an L right
here obviously I'm not doing it as fast
as the Arduino when the Arduino does it
it's going to be so seamlessly fast that
we're not going to be noticing it but
even right here you can notice a
flickering L okay you can notice a
flickering l so basically Arduino is
going to do it really really fast and
what so that we cannot notice it okay
one thing again I want you guys to uh
keep in mind right here is what the
difference in the model there were lots
of again difference in models when it
came to the four segment U LED displays
the 4digit 7 segment LED displays
obviously the pin placement is going to
be what different according to what
according to the number you have again
what I want you to do is what find the
corresponding number in your LED matx I
want you to find the corresponding
number and then do what and then Google
the data sheet if you don't have your
data sheet you're going to be doing
exactly what I just did for the what for
the four digigit seven segment LED
display we're going to keep on trying to
turn on one segment right here one light
as soon as we do we're going to be
extracting what we're going to be
extracting information right here let's
say this one lights up in this case okay
let's say this one lights up I'm going
to see this is what I'm this is going to
be what row six and it's going to be
column 3 and I'm going to be again
talking about the corresponding again
pins that I again attached and obviously
what do I need to do afterwards I can
extract information and create a data
she myself okay but one thing I want you
guys to keep in mind is okay right here
I can just say this is row and column
okay I can just flip it again and say
this is row or column I can just say
this is again this is row this is column
I can just say this is what this is row
this is column so one thing I want you
to get to always um um to always keep in
mind is okay I want you to put the one
that has a number right here it has
faded what happened to mine was it has
faded so I just put a black sign on it
okay so to just indicate which direction
is which so one thing I want you to
always keep in mind is the PIN hits are
supposed to be like this when they're on
the opposite okay and again the one that
has a number it's going to be placed
like this it's going to be again placed
what like this and then you can write
down your pins okay so I want you to
write down your pins like this so this
is going to be what when you talk about
Row one like this row two like this
you're going to be keep on talking them
like how you're going to be placing them
like this this is very very important
okay if you just do that you're going to
be interchanging if you just let's say
say not use this one where the pin heads
are like up and top top and bottom and
if you just place them left to the right
when you when you place them left and
right what happens is what the row is
like this and then what we just
interchange the row and the column they
basically what they basically switch
okay so just keep that in mind so always
keep them from top to bottom okay when
you're working with them okay so with
that being in said before um we actually
work in our first project let me just
try to uh light up one LED segment right
here okay so I get my LED again and
because the LED takes a lot of space I'm
going to be using a separate breadboard
right here to make my life way easier
let me just connect that breadboard to
the LED
first hopefully you can see it there we
go connect it in such a way and then
connect this right here around here okay
I'm going to need my resistor right here
obviously I need my resistor
I just want you to think of them as what
as LEDs if I just connected an led
directly to what 5 volt and the gnd what
happens to it it's going to what it's
going to be fried if I brought my normal
LEDs right here if I had one there we go
if I brought my normal LEDs right here
and just again connected 5vt and gnd
what happens it's going to what it's
going to be fried so I want you to think
of them as what as LEDs right here we
have 64 dots right here I just want you
to think of them as 64 LEDs okay so
right here what I'm going to do is put
our resistors resistor right here
there's a documentation right here x
indicates okay X indicates row y
indicates column this is my
documentation my version of the
documentation so I want let's say I want
to turn on X6 okay I'm going to be
connecting it to what I'm going to be
connecting it to the positive While y is
going to be connected to the negative
okay so let me just do
that X6 which one is going to be X6 X6
is going to be the one that is marked
with a what that has a number for for
you most likely has a number mine has
faded so I just put a black sign on it
so right here let me just put it back
again I just removed it so I can show it
to you guys let me put my resistance
right here let me just make sure that it
goes across because I don't want it to
touch the don't want to touch the the
other LED pins right
here and then just do
that okay that seems good enough for me
then afterwards what do I do
I need my gnd D I need to connect to one
of the columns right here let me just um
go to column wi5 right here let me just
go to wi5 why not let me just do that
let me bring two wires let me bring a
red wire let me connect the red wire let
me just focus it right here let me
connect the red wire right here the red
wire to the five
volt all
right five volt right here connected it
to 5vt and then I'm going to be
connecting my gnd D there's my gnd my
handy gnd is here there we go and I'm
going to be connecting it to the pin
next to the very very left okay I cannot
see it from this angle let me
just it's very hard to see from this
angle oh
wait when I push it in just tap the
there we go now it should be lighting
up there we go let me just turn off the
light turn off all the lights so you can
see it there we go it's lighting
up
nice there we go it's lighting up uh let
me just turn off the turn on the light
back again let me just do that there we
go and uh one thing I want you guys to
keep in mind is what is this again let's
count all the way again to rows if I
count all the way Row three row four row
five it's going to be row six again it's
connected to what to X6 which means what
x represents row as I said so basically
what X6 is what row six okay it's
connected to what column five all right
let me go to column read it from up to
bottom 1 2 3 4 and 5 basically this is
what y5 there we go so it's connected to
what column five and what row six there
we go it's sliding up but one thing I'm
going to tell you guys is all right one
thing is this is how we're
conventionally used to what lighting up
our LEDs we first put what we first put
our resistance and then put what the 5vt
and then the gnd but we can also do what
we can also do it another way we're
going to be putting our resistor instead
of placing it on the g& D right here let
me just unplug my
uino instead of what using the resistor
on the 5 volt we can use it at the gnd D
okay so let me just do
that it's really hard to focus and film
at the same time wiring it up is really
the biggest problem when it comes to
these led displays wiring it up is
literally 90% of the problem in my
experience okay there we go the resistor
should be connected to the same okay
there we go I think it is all right let
just do that and there's our handy gnd D
connected to that one and there resor is
going to be what to the g& D instead of
what instead of being to the 5V let me
put the 5vt back to its place the 5V
should be at X6 so should be at the one
at the very very start just there we go
the very start let me just go here and
now let me just plug in my
uino all
right should be working okay it's not
lighting up completely let me just make
sure the even the resistance is okay
there we go the resistance is the
problem
problem but you can also wait let me
just the resistance is keeps on it's not
put on properly let me just take it off
I guess it's not doing well let me get
another
resistor let me get another resistor
right
here does really hard to actually
connect these pins and see at the same
time it's really
hard there we go now it's even lighting
up really really good I don't think you
might see it it's lighting up even way
brighter than it used
to can you see that it's lighting up
really really good the last time I tried
to light it up what happened when I
connected the 5V when I connected oh let
me just turn on the light so you can see
better when I connected the 5 volt to
the resistor it wasn't lighting up that
good I can even see it myself it wasn't
lighting up that good the problem isn't
with the one thing I want you guys to
keep in mind is it's way preferable to
do what it's way preferable when it
comes to LED matrices it's preferable to
do what to go to what to use our 5 volt
directly and then limit the resistance
when it comes to the what to the ground
pin basically to the what basically to
the what to the colum okay that's one
thing I want you guys to just keep in
mind so again you can again wire it up
as you like you can wire it up again put
it to the what you can connect it to you
can connect the resistor to the what to
the 5vt but it's again recommended that
you connect it to the what you connect
it to uh the gnd okay because it's going
to have what it's going to have more
consistent lighting and it's going to be
more brighter especially when you're
lighting up lots of LED matrices at once
anyways this is it for the section where
we're actually going to be again
checking what led mats are and just
introducing it but we're going to work
uh on a final project before again uh
before again uh moving on from our LED
matrices so uh see you in the next
section we're actually going to work on
a project involving uh LED
matrices okay so I were I wired up the U
LED Matrix as you can see here so let me
just try to explain um what I did right
here so I just again wired it up earlier
because it takes a lot of time to wire
it up because there's like eight pin
from the top and eight pin from the
bottom so to of 16 P so it's going to be
a really really it's going to be a big
effort to do what to actually um connect
the what connect the El Matrix again to
our Arduino okay so right here again
this is my um let me just bring this bit
back so you can see it this is basically
my what this is basically my
documentation on what the documentation
I made on my uh on my LED Matrix okay so
right here is what this is row four
connected to the black one I'm just go
right here so you can see it connected
to the black one and then the white one
I keep connecting this again with the
parallel wires that are here okay I'm
just going to be connecting it the wir
that are next to each other so I keep
connecting it all the way up to here and
then connect it starting from what
digital pin uh two okay so I keep doing
that and then once I'm done with that
there's going to be two pins left here
these two pins right here these two um
wires left here and I start from here
and again what do I do I keep going on
again I keep going on obviously the wire
ends at at 10 I connected eight here
then I connected two there's a total of
10 wires here okay so what happens is
what I start using the normal wires as I
said again so I run out of it so I use
my normal wires and keep what and keep
adding it up until digital pin 13 after
digital pin 13 we run into a problem
what is that problem we have 16 pins
here okay we have 16 pins and right here
how many pins do we have right here in
the uin know digital pins we have around
how much maximum of what maximum of 13
in my adino Nano specifically in my
adino Nano there's a specifically what
there's specifically the maximum is what
13 what digital pins okay so we run into
this problem so what do I do I try to
use the analog pins afterwards so I
start to use the analog pins I think
starting from A2 let me check at
starting from A2 I start to use the
analog pins okay connected them again
it's going to be what different again
how you it up again is going to be
different from person to person
depending on the model of what the model
of LED metric you have obviously they
look the same but obviously the number
again is going to what it's going to
affect where um every other pen is going
to be so every column right here is
going to be what my column one is going
to be here right here at the very edge
but for somebody else it might be
somewhere around here or even somewhere
around here so obviously the placement
of pins and the placement of columns and
rows and the pins is going to be
different depending on the what on the
number you have the model of what the
model of the LED Matrix okay so I just
want you to keep this in mind so again
this I made is again specifically for me
how do we know that I already showed you
guys what you need to do is keep on
wiring it up until one lights up as soon
as one lights up what happens as soon as
one lights up we can extract two
information from it we can extract the
row and the column okay okay so with
that in mind okay let me go over to my
code and to even check that everything
is wired up properly what do we do we're
going to need to turn on every LED
Matrix right here we're going to need to
turn on every column and every row just
to see that everything is wired up
sometimes again what happens is what the
resistors again they might be attached
together sometimes they're not put in
properly and sometimes we run into what
physical errors so sometimes it might
confuse us where the errors occurring so
your code might run perfectly and then
again you might have a problem when
you're working with the LED Matrix it
happened to me when I was working with
the uh four what four digigit seven
segment LED display okay so with that in
mind how do I turn on everything so let
me first again there's I defined them
earlier right here so I don't waste your
time trying to do that so I Define them
right here basically when you use the
keyword hasht Define it's basically like
using variables instead of here they're
going to be what they're going to be set
to constants variables are what they
change from time to time again you can
add them up you can what you can change
them but when it comes to what when it
comes to constants they're always
constant I just want you to think let's
say the constant of gravity is what
we're going to say hash to Define okay
I'm say hash to Define for uh the work
anywhere hash to Define we're going to
be saying gravity gravity is a constant
what is it it's 9.8 9.8 m/ second so
we're going to be defining constants
okay so it's exactly going to do the
same thing as what the same thing as
variables but it's going to be what it's
going to be set to constant it's not
going to be what you cannot change the
value once you set it
okay all right so I just set this up
again I Define the row one up to eight
and what again pin they're connected to
and then column to what column one to
eight I just what I just rolled them
down okay so right here what do I need
to do is what I need to go to pin mode
and then what
start giving them output say they're
output I want to use them as what as
output okay let me just keep doing that
let me keep on pasting it until and then
go to row two and then Row three row
four row five row six seven and then
finally eight I'm going to be doing the
same thing when it comes towards what
when it comes
towards oh wait I'm not correct here
when it comes the same to the what to
when it comes to the columns too we set
all of them to what to Output that's
what I want to do I'm going to be using
all of them as an output okay so let me
paste this again keep on pasting it and
I think this should be eight let me go
two right here 3 4 5 6 7 and then eight
there we go now afterwards what do I
want to do turn all of them on as you
remember we're going to be setting what
the rows to high and the columns to low
to light up what to light up even a
segment of the LED Matrix if you
remember so to even light up everything
I need to set all rows to high but one
thing I want you guys to again pay
attention here is we used analog pins
and also what we also used digital pins
so depending on the pin that I have I'm
supposed to say I'm supposed to be
saying what a analog right for analog
pins and for those who have again a
digital pen I'm going to be saying what
digital right okay so I just want you to
keep that in mind so let me just say dig
the right right here oh it's changed my
language Let me just there we go uh let
me just turn this caps lock off there we
go digital right then let's just check
which rows receive digital right so all
of them seems to be receiving digital
right except for row five and row eight
so except for row five and row eight I'm
going to be saying this to right I'm
going to be starting from Row one row
one and setting this to high and let's
keep just pasting it a bit there we go
and now for Row one we're going to say
row two 3 four we're going to skip five
we're going to be using analog right for
five then we're going to go six seven
we're not going to be even writing down
what eight eight is going to be using
analog right so let me go here and say
analog
right and then if I set this let say set
it to row five right here and then I
cannot use high when I use analog right
I'm supposed to be writing down a value
which is going to be an integer between
0 and 255 obviously High means what 255
so I'm just going to be setting it to
255 right now and then once I'm done
doing that what do I do I'm going to be
also copying the same thing for row
eight row eight said that
high obviously right now oh I'm supposed
to say 255 I said High instead of 255 my
bad um so after this obviously our job
is not done now we should set what the
columns to what we should be setting
them to low or basically G and D okay so
column uh most of them seem to be using
yeah yeah only two of them don't use it
and this time they're what column 3 and
column five okay so okay for columns
what am I going to say they's still
right most of them going to be using
digital pins again it's because I run
out of them that we're going to be using
analog wrs so if you if you guys have an
analog pin did again you're Arduino
again your type of model that has more
than 16 pins I suggest that you use only
digital pins okay mine does not have it
so I'm going to be using analog pins too
because mine is a bit small okay so let
me just set column one
to
low we set that to low let me focus on
the numbers here one number okay there
we go column one two okay column 3 and
five are not going to be what they're
going to be using analog analog right so
except for them three and five I'm going
to be using everything so let me go to
column right now let me go column
two three is not going to be using it so
I'm going to be skipping three and going
into four and also five we're not going
to be what we're going to be using
analog analog right and then seven and
then eight let me just remove this code
all right there we go now I'm going to
be writing down analog
let me turn off caps lock analog right
column we're going to be starting from
column three and then setting it to what
to zero zero corresponds with what with
low all right and then copy this and
then do the same thing for what column
five there we go and now I think
everything should light up let's just
upload the code right
now it's done compiling and it should be
done uploading can you see it almost
everything's lighting up let me just
turn off the light for you guys so you
can even see it better and change the
angle here it's not the best of angles
there we go let just move it a bit there
we go you can see that um row what a
column what column 1 2 3 column 5 is not
lighting up so basically I've touched
the resistor or something most of the
case again resistors uh they're not put
in properly so let me just check my
documentation right here to understand
which one is causing me some problem
right
here okay so column column five should
be around uh should be around it's not
here okay it's here there we go column
five is here so the resistor that is at
the very front right here let me just
turn on the light so you can see it
there's a resistor at the very very
beginning there we go at the very very
beginning let me just turn that off
there we go to just touch it a bit don't
touch the other ones there we go just
touched it a bit let me turn off the
lights so you can see it better now now
everything is lit up
there we go everything is lit up okay so
everything seems to be what connected
properly so every column and every row
was connected properly okay that's good
now let's try to again do something
interesting with it so obviously let's
try to do what a project with it so
right here what we're going to do is
okay I'm going to be having uh I've
tried to actually U search for libraries
okay I've searched for U um LED Matrix
Li liaries just like how we had the safe
seg library for uh the segment LED
displays the seven segment LED displays
I Tred to find LED Matrix libraries and
when I did that what I found was most of
them required something called a Max
72xx chip basically it's not going to be
your typical what your typical LED
matrix it's going to have some like some
add up to it all right so it's not going
to be exactly the LED Matrix that we're
using right here okay so it's limited to
to what to the again the models that are
what the models that are popular mine is
a bit of a less known model okay not
only that too but it's going to include
its own chip so it's not going to what
it's not going to include the
traditional LED Matrix when I look at
most of the what most of the libraries
okay so what I did was let me just go
over to the code right here let me go
over to the code right here there's a
code right here that is preset okay I
don't want you to focus too much on this
uh what all of this is but there's a
preset code right here that I'm going to
be leaving down in the link below in the
link below in the description below so
again you guys can see it and you guys
again can use it for yourself so you can
again get the sketch for yourself okay
so let's just analyze the code though
we're not going to be just giving you
I'm not going to be just giving you the
code okay I'm just going to let you
analyze too what you need to analyze
okay so let me Focus right here so let's
start with it's going to be defining
again your row so again with your
corresponding Row for example it's at
Pin five right here if you set it to pin
five you're going to say pin five mine
is set to pin six so I'm not going to
touch it you're going to be defining
your rows and columns and what pin
they're connected to okay okay then
afterwards what you're going to be doing
is defining the rows and this one again
is going to be written itself it's going
to be preset again when you again look
uh when you check for when you check the
code in the link below so don't Focus
too much on this but what this does is
basically it's an object okay I just
want to go over it so this an object
that's again contains what this is a
list that contains what it's a list that
contains what row one row two Row three
row four row five row six row seven and
row eight at what at a list at a single
list okay so it's just listing what what
rows we have here basically the ones
that are right here okay all right the
variables that are right here let me
just skip this right now I'm going to
get back to this okay and right here
what is very very important for you guys
is okay what is very very important
right here is again we're going to be
setting the pin mode to what to all of
them to Output what all of them to what
to an output that's one thing I want you
guys to do okay then afterwards okay I
don't want you to focus on these two
codes okay they're going to be
pre-written again on the code I don't
want you to focus on them they're been
more complicated again so don't focus on
them okay just leave them alone as they
as they are okay we're just going to be
using them as a library okay when we use
libraries again we don't look at what
most in most cases we don't look at what
the behind code of like how the library
works okay we don't do that what what we
do is what we use the what the library
what it provides us okay so like that
again we didn't play in the library so
what I did is is again this is all set
up for you guys so again don't focus on
these okay they're again beyond your
scope okay don't focus on these they're
going to be written down for you guys
but I want you to focus is uh right here
I want you to focus on this this uh to
understand this what we're first going
to do I think for you guys to better
understand this is let me go right here
and I want you guys to search for an LED
Matrix matx okay LED Matrix right here
and I want you to search when you come
to LED Matrix editor Okay add editor and
search for it and then go to the link
right
here and then you have your own what
digital LED Matrix okay so what I want
you to do is right here okay what I want
you to do is what it's way better to
draw it right here so let's say I'm
trying to draw L like we did last time
so I just showed you guys the science of
drawing an L so let's say we want let's
say we want to draw an L so the problem
here Aris this is what we're going to
have to what we're going to have to
first what we're going to have to first
turn it on before what visualizing okay
so even to CNL right here what should I
do I should visualize it myself before
what before actually what before
actually turning it on myself all right
so the problem here is what the problem
here is what we cannot visualize it we
cannot visualize the what how to draw
this in dots okay we cannot visualize
how to draw this in dots before what
before putting it in our what in our
physical again LED Matrix so what this
allows is what we can visualize how an L
is supposed to look like so we can first
do is okay so what I need to do is like
this then I can know what okay I need to
turn on column three and uh what row
three again and I'm going to turn on row
four row five row six and then after I'm
done with that what I'm going to be
doing is okay I'm going to turning this
off I'm going to be giving it a delay
time maybe a 5 Second 5 milliseconds
okay not 5 Second 5 milliseconds and
then I'm going to be running this code
right here okay so I'm going to turn on
row what row six and then I'm going to
be turn turning what uh column 5 and
column four and column 5 to what to low
okay so I can visualize it so before
even writing it down again in dots you
it allows you to what to visualize it
and the best part about this is what the
best part about this is that once you
let's say okay I wrote down L okay let
me just write down l or something let me
write down capital L let just write it
down the best part about this is okay
what you're going to be saying is insert
inserting it after you insert it okay
after you insert the code right here and
you can see it right here okay and after
you insert it what you need to do I'm
just actually delete this I don't need
this one just delete this one there we
go once you have again this uh L again
what the best part is as soon as you
just go right here the code is written
for you obviously you cannot understand
what this is but as soon as you just
touch as bite Ray it's going to change
it for bytes for bits of data okay as a
bite once you do that you can get this
code right here so I can just copy this
and then what you can just basically do
is paste it okay to your code basically
directly without without yourself doing
it again without yourself saying okay I
have to turn on three and then what two
to low and then keep on doing this and
this and this is going to what involve a
series of steps okay just not to do that
what you need to do is what what you
need to do is only use this in what in
bits so first things first let me try to
show you guys what this means so let me
just analyze one of these codes for you
guys so I think it's better that way
okay so right here let me start right
here let me start all the way to the top
okay there we go we have a right here
can you see a can you see a okay let me
start with b actually a is a bit of a
the code is not right because I was
messing around with it I remember that
so I'm going to fix it though on the on
the description code I'm going to be
fixing it on the on the final code but
right here let's see B right here okay I
think B is something interesting to
analyze so what does it do it says b
okay bite it said to bite a bite is what
a bite is basically eight bits just like
how we were using again uh the number
from 0 to 1024 if you remember numbers
from 1024 basically these numbers from 0
to 1024 they were what they were eight
bits okay so basically for example 1024
in 8 Bits or in a bite it's basically
what one one one one one written down
eight times okay when it comes to zero
what was it it was Zero written down
eight times and obviously 10 0 to 1024
again the values again are going to be
converted okay that's basically what it
is okay so again we' we've discussed
earlier we've discussed about a binary
so this is basically binary okay okay so
what you do is B and what do they have
is right here is a b they use a b or a
small B right here to Define what we're
telling our adrenal we're not just
setting down random numbers we're
setting down what we're sending
information in what we're sending
information in bytes okay we're sending
our information in bytes I want our wein
know to know that so you can use what
zero B with a small b or you can use
capital B right here okay then what do
you do right here this this defines
every column okay this defines every
column so this is going to be for Row
one okay this is the first one in our
list this is the first one in our list
so it's going to be what row one okay
this is going to be row row two this is
going to be Row three row four row five
row six row s and then finally row eight
okay so right here what we're telling is
okay I want you to turn on what I want
you to turn on Row one I want I want I
want you to turn off what row one I
don't want to use what when you set it
to zero it's basically off I don't want
to use what row sorry column one I I
don't want to use column one for Row one
we're setting this up okay this is again
the whole thing is what the whole code
right here again the whole thing is for
Row one okay I want you to keep that in
mind so every bits of zeros and ones is
what every bits of zero and one is what
every bits of zero and one is columns
okay so right here I'm saying is for Row
one I want you to do for Row one is I
want you to what I want you to turn off
what column one basically what basically
I don't want it to light up okay I don't
want it to light up okay when it comes
to what column 2 column 3 column 4 and
column 5 I want you to turn it on okay
basically what it's going to light up I
want you to light up what column three
column four sorry column two column 3
column four and column 5 when it comes
to column six seven and eight I want you
to turn it what to turn it off basically
what I don't want you to light it up
okay that's what it's basically saying
okay so right here I want you to do to
do is what I want you to turn on what I
want you to turn on column two 3 4 5
let's try to do that ourselves right
here on the editor so we can see it
ourselves so let's try to turn on let me
just clear this let's try to turn on
column 2 3 4 and 5 okay for Row one so
let's go back to our code right here so
that we can understand what this is okay
there we go we again Define 2 3 four and
five all right then afterwards for row
two what I want you to do is I want you
to turn off what column one and then
turn on what column two let's turn on
column two right
here column two is turned on on row two
we're going to be turning on column two
let's visualize what's going to happen
let me go back to my we know right here
no it's the other code let me go back to
the other code there we go and then I
want you to turn on turn off what column
this is column 3 four I want you to turn
it off and then finally I want you to
turn on column what column five let me
just count it let me just see if I'm
correct one 2 3 4 yes so I want you to
turn on column five let's just do that
let's go back here and turn on column
five There is five and then let's go
back to our Adeno code we're just going
to analyze it again just to see how it
works and then I want you to turn on
what column two and column uh column 5
column two and column 5 the same thing
as we did right here I want you to turn
on column two and column 5 okay for Row
three I want you to turn on column two
and column 5 all right I just did that
right there let's go back to
ouro then afterwards for row four I want
you to do is what I want you to turn on
column 2 3 4 okay column 2 3 4 let's
just keep that in our head two 2 3 4 2 3
4 there we go and then what do I want
you to do right here let me read it okay
we we read what row one row two Row
three row four we're on row five right
now let me just check it
again yes we're on row five there we go
row five is
here okay now what I want you to turn on
column two and then what column two and
column five again okay I'm turn on
column two and column five just like how
we did for row two and Row three okay so
let me just do that column two and
column five column two supposed to be
here and column five is here there we go
and let's go back here then afterwards
what do I want you to do column two and
column what column is it column six we
count it column two 3 4 five and then
yeah column six so I want you to turn on
what column two and column 6 okay let's
just do that right here column 2 and
column 6 for row six column two and
column 6
all right looking something like an R
right now let's finish it up so
hopefully it's going to appear as B
there we go I want you to do is what the
same thing if I'm correct it looks
exactly the same let me just check it
yep I want you to do the same thing let
me just check it again column two this
is column two and this is column six so
I want you to turn on column two and
column six okay I'm just go to column
two and column six column two column 6
there we go and then when it comes to
the row eight let me go to the row eight
right here the final row I want you to
do what I want you to turn on column 2 3
4 5 6 so I'm just do that I want you to
turn column 2 3 4 2 3 4 5 6 and there we
go we have what we have somewhat of a b
right here this is basically what's
going to draw if I tell it if I tell it
to draw B so what you need to do again
to draw something is okay we have the
information again preset for you I have
the information preset for you I have B
right here here c d everything from A to
Z from a to capital Z I have it written
for you guys okay from a to capital Z is
written for you guys okay then what I
want you to do right here okay is you're
going to say draw screen and then you
tell it I want to draw a b let's see
what happens right here let me just
upload this it's compiling and it should
be done uploading that's all you need to
do I want you to do is what use the
function draw screen and put what again
what you want to draw right here as soon
as you set it at bytes right here once
you set it to a bite what I want you to
do is use it okay there we go draw
screen B can you see it let me just
check if you can see it let me turn off
the light for you guys let me bring this
closer actually bring this closer I
don't want to touch the wires they're
very very fragile I was about to push
them away for you guys but they're very
fragile because I can just ruin the
whole thing and I don't want to again
connect 16 pins it's going to be a lot
of work let me just go from this angle
so you can see
it there we go I want you to focus on
this there we go drawing out the be that
we just drew on the water on The Matrix
editor basically on our what digital
Matrix so let me just zoom this back
okay that's good all right so right here
we draw B and I already said this said
this for you guys so again you can write
draw what d e anything let me just
upload d right here let me just I want
to draw D let draw a d right here there
we go we have D drawn out for you guys
so almost every letter is again I
already preset it so what I want to do
here is again we can use this to do what
we can use this to again set up what not
only letters we can also use it to even
do what simple drawing so what I'm going
to be doing is I'm going to be drawing a
simple face right here I'm going to be
trying to draw at least at least I'm
going to be trying to draw a a face
right here let me go to L right here let
me delete it I don't need it
anymore I don't need it let me just
delete it and let me just reset
everything once I'm done doing that let
me just try to draw a smiley face not
the best drawer
but okay let me just go right here and
let me start like this I think it's
better that
way let me just keep on trying all right
let me go like this and then let me just
try to do exactly the same thing here
it's bit of a struggle because I don't
know how to uh I'm not the best draw
right here okay I mean it's not bad it
looks like a good Circle not the best
one but I think it gets the job done
okay let me put two
right here eyes and then let me just try
to draw a smiley face on it let me just
try to do
that there we go we have what a smiley
what we have a smiley face right here we
have a smiley face so let me do is
insert it right here okay once you just
insert it the code is already written
for you guys so again lighting up all of
these individual what individual again
um individual what individual uh bits of
dots would be really hard because you're
going to have to do what a lot of what a
lot of work just to even light this up
just to know which one's which and if
you mess up a one spot you have to go
back check everything again you have to
do almost how many we used around let's
say half a fit right here we used let's
say roughly I would say uh maybe uh two
two5 of the 64 again dots that we have
here 64 bits of what bits of again
lights that we have here and basically
if we just again try to do it physically
again set this to high set it to low and
doing all of that it would be a lot
foric okay so we're just going to be
using this and you're going to be
extracting this information right here
okay that's all you need to do once I
insert it the information that's out
going to be right here it's already
going to give me the code right here
again make sure it's written down in
bytes and bite erases this is again
selected just make sure that this is
selected let me just copy that let me
just again let me only get the code
right here copy
that okay let just copy that and uh let
me go right here oh not this one one let
me go right here there we go and what I
need to do is what I add it as as a bite
okay as a bite of information so I'm
just going to say bite and I'm going to
say let me call it smiley because it's
smiley face so let me just call it
smiley and then again I'm going to need
to again use again what my what my
brackets right here just to indicate
it's a list and then afterwards I can
paste it there we go let me just again I
don't want it to be spaced out so let me
just give it space right here let me
just make sure that again it can take up
a whole line This is valid but again
from an aesthetic point of view every
every what every what every row right
here is taking what a line up so it
doesn't look that good let me just again
without touching anything just remove
the extra bits of the extra bits of
again spaces right here let me just
remove them okay I think this is good
okay I have to remove this one that is
here remove the extra bits of again
there we go the extra bits of spaces
that we had here now this looks better
and let me just upload it right here let
me just upload the
code oh I forgot to do I forgot to give
it a what the suic callon at the end I
defin it right here smiley it should be
working it's done compiling and now what
it should be done uploading okay let me
go to draw screen and I want to draw
what smiley smiley let me try to draw
smiley right here it's done
compiling okay now we should be
uploading and there we go we have smiley
face can you see it let me just turn off
the the other light not the best
lighting but I just want to make sure
that you see it for yourselves let me
bring it closer so you can see
it there we go we have a smiley face
right here so again it's up to what it's
up to your imagination again to do these
things so you basically can do what you
basically can do obviously you cannot do
everything but you can do lots and lots
of things it opens possibilities that
were no longer possible in what that
were not possible using a seven segment
LED display so what I'm going to be
giving you guys to do is what right here
again I have the preset code what I want
you to do right here is okay I did not
add every alphabet I added every
alphabet like every capital letter from
A to Z as you can see right here added
up and just set it up right here for you
guys but one thing I did not do is I did
not finish there we go where is it I did
not finish writing down every small
letter okay I have a right here but I
did not finish writing down everything
we have a b c d e and I stopped at
stopped at J okay what I want you to do
is add up to it okay I want you to add
it up all the way up to Small Z okay I
want you to add up all the way up to
Small Z and one important thing I want
you guys to do is okay again one thing I
want you guys to do is don't Focus too
much on this code but what I want you to
do is write down a word with it how do
we do that how do we write down a word
uh if you again what I want you to do is
we want to write down a word how we
display a word okay how do we display a
word I want you to think of it so again
I want you to pause this video think of
it for like at least a minute or two and
then come back this video where I'm just
going to show you again how we just do
it because we've learned this so far and
it's going to be very very simple okay
so I'm just going to be waiting
and hopefully now you have again resumed
the video and then hopefully you got it
right obviously to to write down words
they're what they're just a bunch of
what they're just a bunch of letters so
what do we need to do let's say I want
to say the word Arduino okay how do I do
that I say draw
screen draw screen a and then I give it
what a delay time a delay time of what a
few seconds right here 20 maybe 200
milliseconds I want to draw it for a and
then what I want to give it a delay of
what maybe a delay of a bit while and
then give it some delay right here and
then what live a delay of some some bit
right here let me say 20 milliseconds
and then I want you to draw screen d d
right here draw screen and then B I
already wrot down capital B so I can see
oh I said b instead of r r after a is R
let me give it a let me actually give it
a draw screen of what a draw screen of
uh B okay let me set this B right here
no sorry draw screen I said draw screen
again I meant the delay time sorry delay
time of what a delay time of plus 20
milliseconds what what is better if I do
it right here if I give it a variable
say delay time and give it a variable so
let me just select both of them and just
say delay time delay time what also did
I do wrong right here the code right
here is not supposed to be set to delay
time it's supposed to be set to delay I
said delay time instead of delay my bad
there we go now let me just Define this
here let me just Define it maybe down
here let me just Define it right here
here say integer integer delay time
let's set it to 100 MCS and let's try to
upload this see what happens let me just
try to upload these two again sentences
right here this two letters it goes too
fast for me okay let me just give it a
bigger delay time let's say one second
okay let's say one
second see what happens St
compiling can you see what's going on
it's basically turning on it's doing the
draw screen thingy and then what it's
going to be delaying physically for what
for a second and then it's going to be
drawing again R for for a very very
short while and then again it's going to
have a delay of what one second where
it's going to be what when it's on the
delay it's going to be what turned off
okay so what I want you to do again I'm
not going to do it myself but your
homework is going to be okay to find a
way to delay it in such a way that again
you don't do what you don't uh you don't
do what it does doesn't what it doesn't
turn off okay how do we delay it in such
a way that it doesn't turn off so I want
it to turn off for what for at least
what for maybe a second okay I want I
want it to be on for a second then I
want it to switch to R not obviously
again it appears for a second right here
it appears for like uh millisecond right
here and then what it turns off for a
second and then it goes to the other R
and then it turns off for a second so I
don't want that to happen so I just want
it to be on until we switch to a what
until we switch to a to a to a delay so
this is going to be your homework for
this uh section so again I'm going to go
to the next section and fix it myself
but I want you again to try to do it
yourself so before you guys again check
out how I do it I want you to try again
I want you to try hard and then to do
what to and try to again solve it for
yourselves
okay okay so now let's analyze our code
right here draw screen and then it does
it again at for milliseconds and then it
delays physically where it's going to be
turned off it's going to be delayed for
a second right here and then basically
what it's physically turned off and then
the draw screens are and then it's
physically turned off for a second so
best thing actually to do right now is
let me just remove all of this code
because it's not working let me just
remove it let's go back where we were
just drawing a specific ladder what
happened here for example right now I'm
draw screening what a what happens it
draw screens a but it goes inside of a
what remember the loop function in the
ardino what happens it keeps running
over and over and over again it's
basically a loop just how it says it's
going to be going over and over again
again if you remember our setup code is
here what setup ones when we go to our
setup right here our void setup okay
when it comes to void setup what do we
do we only have what we only run out one
time okay when it comes to the loop we
keep running it multiple multiple times
that's why when we draw screen let's say
for example only a no delay time on it
we can see a just being drawn right here
there we go a is literally what is drawn
on the screen again it's going to do
what it's going to draw screen a for an
instance and then it's going to keep on
doing it inside of the loop again and
again and again and again and again so
obviously it's going to be too fast for
our eyes okay so now the pro the
question is going to be what the
question is going to be how do we create
our own Loop because when it's inside of
a Loop it does what it literally what
lights up so how do we create our own
Loop how do we do it we use the while
keyword okay so what I'm going to be
doing right now is I'm going to be
trying to maneuver it in a different way
a bit of a different way but what I'm
going to be doing is I'm going to be
setting up an integer right here integer
and call it I okay let's set it up and I
want to set it to zero okay then what I
want we know to do right here is I
wanted to do is as long as I is less
than 300 I want you to continuously what
draw a that's what I'm saying as long as
I is less than 300 I want you to do what
I want you to draw it okay I want you to
put what draw screen a keep on doing
that okay that's what I'm telling
mardino to do okay then what should I do
right here it's going to be an infin
Loop if I do this what is going to
happen I is always going to be less than
300 if if if you remember because I set
it to what I set it to zero so I want
this to end at some point how do I do
that then I'm going to say I keep adding
one okay keep adding one every time
while I does what while I keep adding
one on I every time that's what I want
them to do at the end of the loop okay
then it's going to what it's going to
end after what running this Loop 300
times it's going to run the loop around
actually 299 times not 300 299 if I
wanted to run 300 times I'm just going
to set it equal to right here and then
now it's going to run through the stop
300 times okay before what it's going to
be drawing screen a 300 times before
what before uh moving on to the other
code so let me just try to even upload
this okay we're running into an error
okay I see I see where the error is
occurring so right here I said integer
to I and then right here too what did I
do I used I as a bite I already said it
as a BT again so the problem is why do
we have two I variables are unique
they're supposed to be unique that's
what Arduino is telling me so let me
again set I maybe to let me call it
counter because we're going to be using
it to count so counter seems like a good
name let me go right here and set every
ey to
counter
okay there we
go and let's check it out
now
all right can you see it it turns on for
like a bit while we can see it visibly
and then it fully turns off so let's see
what's going on here okay so what's
going on here is it reads the counter
and then again runs through this code
300 times so basically drill screens a
300 times so it gives us enough time to
what to see it obviously we can see it
but afterwards what happens counter
keeps adding up to 300 once it reaches
300 what happens again what happens once
it reaches 300 H what happens is
basically counter let's print counter at
the end so let's see what counter is
going to be at the end so let me go to
serial.print Ln and let me just say
counter at the very end because I want
to see what counter is going to be up to
all right I think this is good now what
are we going to do uh obviously we have
to what we have to start our serial
monitor let me just do that let go to my
setup code right here at the very end
start our serial monitor at the bot rate
of
9,600 give it a semic colum at the end
and let's run this let's upload it right
now it's done compiling and it should be
uploading by now all right now let's
open our seral Monitor and it's finally
going to open it for us all right come
on 301 can you see it the value that's
coming out here saying what 301 301
printing out 301 so what happens is what
301 is what less than or equal to 300 so
what it's not going to run this code
another time can you see that it's going
to be what it's going to be counter 300
what's going to happen is when it
reaches 300 when it reaches 300 here
okay let's go right here when counter is
set to 300 this is going to be true and
then what is it going to do it's going
to draw screen a as usual and then it's
going to be counter is equals to 300 + 1
what is that going to be it's going to
be setting it to 301 now when it comes
back and tries to do the loop again 301
is less than or equal to 300 that's a
what that's a false statement so it's
going to be skipping this at all it's
not going to touch it again anymore and
then what's going to happen is what it's
going to keep printing the counter right
now it's the value of the counter 301
okay all right so right here it's very
important at the very end of the code
that we what the very end of the code we
set it to what we set the counter back
to what back to zero to to its initial
value okay we only printed a so what
what's better is let's create a loop
again counter is less than or equal to
what what are we going to put right here
as soon as it passes through 300 the
value is going to be what 301 so I want
it to be less than or equal to 600 right
here that makes more sense to do then I
want to do basically the same
thing cross screen draw screen what for
me R I wanted to draw screen R and then
I wanted to counter to keep adding up
again so that it's not stuck in a what
an infinite loop I don't want it to be
stuck in an infinite Loop what it keeps
running R again infinite amount of time
because it's always going to be true in
that case as long as we don't add what
counter is equals to counter plus what
okay and then finally what we want to do
we want to set it back to zero okay as
soon as it runs through this what is
going to be the value as soon as it's
done running through this Loop the
counter is going to be what 600 as soon
as let's say it goes 600 right now it's
going to be what 600 is less than or
equal to 600 it's going to be true it's
going to be drawing R and then six what
the counter is going to be set to 600 +
1 what is 600 + 1 it's going to be set
to 601 so again we want to set it back
to zero so that loop again keeps going
on so let's check it out there's an it
should be an A and then an R it should
be going between A and R there we go
it's going between A and R A there we go
and then it's going going to R nice now
let's keep adding on again the other uh
letters for Arduino we need D so let me
just keep on copying this is better that
way let me copy the white Loop ones let
me the counters equal to zero at the
very end so I don't touch it paste it
and then now I'm going to go to
900 and now I'm going to go for what for
our uh there we go D say capital D and
the counter counter plus one I'm not
going to touch that and then and keep on
pasting this code just keep on pasting
it it was 900 let me add 300 on 900 it
be
1,200 and then I want to draw screen
what after d i want to draw
u u okay there we go seems
nice let me paste that again and 1,00
it's going to be
1,500 do we then I have an i for the
Arduino
and paste that
again um 1,500 and add 300 on it it's
going to be
1,800 and then it's going to be are we
okay come on there we go I hate the
documentation sometimes can't touch it
by using your pointer anyways and and
then and then we have an
O Arduino
okay I to said this to what value 1,00
not 1,00 actually
2,100 there we go let's let's check what
happens and we have again it's going to
set this back to zero at the end that's
good now should we just playing
Arduino there we
go and
there you have it obviously uh one thing
I want you guys to keep in mind is just
going to keep doing it on Loop that's ni
but one thing I want you guys to keep in
mind is uh again this is what we're not
using time directly we're not using
delay time we're not using any type of
what time we're indirectly using what
what I want you to analyze is one thing
we're using is what we're using ardino
processing speed okay again it's going
to be running through this code how many
times 300 times so let's say we have a
very very fast arbino mine is an Arduino
Nano let's say we have a faster Arduino
I'm talking a significantly faster one
it's going to be running through this
code really really fast so basically
it's going to feel like how we just saw
it for like again a bip and then it
turns off okay so that's what's going to
happen so again it's going to be very
inal with on the adrenal model have and
how fast it is okay so I want you to
again adjust it using what as it's
slower or faster I want you to adjust it
for what for the number right here how
do we make this way EAS easier then for
ourselves give it a variable right it's
better to give it a what a variable what
I'm going to need to do right here is
say Okay delay time I'm saying delay
time right here you know what I can use
this because I'm no longer using delay
time here so I'm going to be setting
delay time and what I'm going to be
doing is I want to set it to 300 you
know what let me set it to 200 because I
feel like 300 is very long let me just
set this 200 and again what I'm going to
be doing is okay delayed I'm going to
say delay time right here nice then I'm
going to be saying delay time times what
times two that's basically what it is
delay
time times
three again this was again I just set it
to 200 right now because I want it to go
shorter okay that's what I wanted to do
but obviously let me set it back to 300
so you can understand it delay time
times uh it's delay time is what 300 and
delay time * 200 is what 600 there we go
that we put earlier 600 right here and
then delay time * 3 is what 900 we
literally put 900 right here delay time
* 4 is literally 12 what 1200 okay so
it's 1,200 so that's what I'm going to
keep on doing so it's just times you can
again use a variable instead of because
we're going to be using this in multiple
places it's going to be easier to do
what it's going to be easier to use a
variable so that again if you want to
change anything we can change it only at
one place and it's going to affect the
whole thing let me see delay time
times s right here and then we have
delay time times eight there we go and
we set the counter to zero and one thing
I want to do right now is I want to set
the delay time right here to
what to 200 so that it goes faster okay
I don't want to throw in the code 300
times I want it to go 200 times let's
see if it goes faster
now okay there we go it's better right
now it's
better or do
we could the use a bit longer and oh
there we go let's see set it to faster
you know what let me just set this to
50 set it to 500 sorry 50 there we go
let's upload it let's see what happens
now there we go now it goes really
fast r no there we go nice so again one
thing I want you guys to keep in mind is
we're not using delay time directly
we're using what we're relying on our
processing speed okay we're relying on
arduino's processing speed we're just
saying that you know take 50 it's going
to take a long time right here so that
we can see it so we can see what we can
see a being drawn but let's say arduinos
again like every computer like every
what phone from here to here they get
what they get faster they get better
they get upgraded and all so maybe this
might take again a while to write down
for now for this model of Arduino but in
the very future what's going to happen
it's going to be so fast then it's going
to be running it so so fast for example
right here it's going to be almost as if
you're running it uh giving it the delay
time of let's say 5 milliseconds okay
that's how fast it's going to be it's
going to be like running this at 5
milliseconds because again the
processing speed is going to improve
it's going to be basically like that see
that it's going to be so fast that
obviously right now we cannot read this
because again it's very very fast for us
okay so that's one thing I want you guys
to keep in mind so for example let's say
we're using this for uh let's say
producing something okay we're using
this for production or something for a
production basis obviously it's not
going to be reliable it's not future
proof because as I said again it's going
to be running to problems but obviously
this is just again a home project so it
doesn't really matter that much but
again I just want you guys to keep that
in mind okay so anyways with that in
mind let's finish this section
well there you have it you've completed
this sardino course and I hope you've
enjoyed the journey as much as I have
Before We Say Goodbye remember that
finishing this course is just the
beginning of your arino adventure the
world of uino is fast and there are
countless number of components projects
and problems waiting for you to be
solved with the skills you've gained
here if you find this video helpful and
inspiring please consider giving it a
thumbs up that's a way of boosting the
content so it can reach more learners
like you and don't forget to subscribe
to free Cod Camp to join a community of
fellow programming enthusiasts plus it
really helps the YouTube algorithm with
that in mind if you want to check more
courses made by me you can check my
personal channel in the link below I
don't want to keep you for too long
thank you for tuning in and I hope to
see you again
soon